Let's go this direction.
Come on. Faster. Just a little bit of
energy. I want to try something better
right now. I guess the people
and see what things
but not for long. You'll get
jinxed.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
Heat up here.
men, I ask you, will you follow me
tonight to break their spine and reclaim
what once was mine?
Those crorous backstab me, deceive me,
never shall tolerate their crimes again.
Now let the hunt begin.
Yeah.
7,000 souls scared and daunted in such a
terrifying
to
live forever.
Now the regime I'm going to unleash
eternal power
lead us to
the
Yeah.
I am the light ringer.
Now listen, f warriors, I ask you,
should my campaign come to an end?
There's way more to avenge.
Wow.
15 million souls living in this realm
without much hope. Not too long ago,
this kingdom was a golden stone.
Yeah.
to bring hope and pieces for you to live
forever.
Yeah.
Bring down the machine
to unleash eternal power.
We have
I am
Heat. Heat.
Cool down the reening. Bring back hope
and peace. Restore our glor
to live forever.
Call down the reckoning to bring back
peace. Restore our glory
to live forever.
Bring down your regime
to unleash eternal power.
us to order. I am the hungry
Here
we go.
Here we go.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
goat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hey.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey, Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Show me all your might.
>> Time is not on your side.
>> Welcome back to Le. This is day two of
the rebound regional and now there's no
room for mistakes. Day one was a
battlefield, but today only the
strongest are still standings. This is
where legends are made. Every decision
matters more and every single player is
here for one thing, the title. The
stakes are higher than ever and the path
to the crown starts now.
Welcome everybody to day two of RQ Le
James and Lothar to take you through the
beginning of the day and get ready to
determine the second European RQ
champion.
>> Yeah, and I'm super excited to see what
we're going to see in the broadcast
because we're going to have a lot of
people. This is also the first time in
the regional when we have the most
amount of legends in day two from all
the regions so far. So very big variety.
Yeah, we we have a lot to track
throughout the day. Lots of things
happening. Lots of Riftbound still to
play.
We had eight rounds of Swiss yesterday,
Loi. It was it was a long day. It was a
long day. I know you you at home stuck
with us. So, thank you very much for
joining us and thank you for for joining
us early today as well. Uh today we have
even more even more Swiss and then a top
eight. So, when we take a look at our
format for the day, it's going to be
five rounds of Swiss followed by a top
eight bracket. And that's where we
determine who's going to win.
>> Gruelling tournament. I'll tell you
this, eight rounds, 13 rounds of Swiss.
Like, when you think about it, when you
go to a local skimmish, you're going to
play like what, five rounds maybe, maybe
six maximum. It's like going to three
essentially of those tournaments at
once. If you're in top eight, there's
like four tournaments in one sitting.
that I mean not one sitting, two
sittings, right? But it's actually
really grueling.
>> Yeah, you have just enough time, you
know, grab some sleep, grab some
breakfast, get back to the venue and and
off you go again. Um, so yeah, a lot of
a lot on the line today. A lot from uh
the player perspective of where they
have to perform these first five rounds.
You have to make it through to the top
eight. So let's take a look at our
players that are in the running for that
top eight for now. When we look at our
standings, of course, we've been
tracking some featured players
throughout the weekend. Um, quite a few
of them have been doing well overall.
You can see Allan has uh as expected
71 actually not the best best performing
uh Ezreal in the field so far, but that
can still change for day two. Kasanova,
our fellow caster doing really well with
his Lucian, six and two, still alive in
day two. And also look at the end. And
we were following Yamato's cannon
journey. He was at 1.12
and1 if I'm not mistaken. And now he's
finishing at two 52 and one. Not a bad
showing for the first tournament.
>> Yeah, it's respectable. It's
respectable. You're right there on the
cusp of day two. So impressive. I I was
speaking to Kasanova earlier. Still in
the running for best evolution. So, uh,
you know, we'll we'll keep an eye on
that throughout and see how that goes.
Uh looking at our overall standings for
the event, I think this is the players
that we're looking um in a in a wider
pool of who is making the top eight. So
uh a number of players undefeated so
far. 10 players at this point in time.
Of course, you saw Animation Module on
on stream yesterday. We still Pedro
Squirtle on stream as well. So some
names we do of course recognize all the
way down the list, but a good variance
of legends being played.
>> Yeah. When you when you look at the
legends over here, you see that Draven
is in the first place right now out of
the 10 undefeated. Well, actually 12
undefeated, but 10 people with 8 Z.
Draven is the first one, but then it's
only one Draven in the top 16 so far. So
quite a bit of a change from the last
regional
though, they skyrocketed in population
over here, right? We have four again,
five maybe even, but overall the variety
is really incredible. you see so many
different decks and even if you look at
for example Rexside there are still
different variants of the deck. The same
goes for uh Ezreal if I'm not mistaken
there should be for sure different
builds and I just see the name Yahosera
over here which is a fellow competitor
in other card games that I know for
really unique deck building and so if we
ever going to get him on stream it's
going to be 100% a unique build.
>> Well see the Ezreal there as well. I
think I have to mention we we don't yet
have many teams in Riftbound of note,
but Challenger TCG holding it down with
their players already vying for that top
eight. I saw three players there on the
second page. Uh, of course, that's just
the fact that there are so many players
at 8 or 7 and one that we have two pages
for you. So, everyone there doing very
very well so far. It has been um such a
good showcase of competitive Riftbound.
Um, but not everybody's competitive
journey is at this level. Not everybody
has been joining us so far at our Q
level. You want to start your own
journey there. You want to make your
path to pro play. And the place you can
do that, begin your journey at your
Nexus Knights uh in your local game
store. That's where you want to get
involved. I know yours is a a really
really cool environment to uh to get uh
you know that experience in. And then so
many people come over from their
summoner skirmish winning that buy
round, come to the RQ and play against
some of the best players in Europe.
>> I can only say this, go to your Nexus
night, go to your LGS, play in those
tournaments that will give you
experience. It's an awesome just fun
event. Like I go weekly to one of my
local gaming stores in my hometown. It's
always a good time. It's nice to be
socializing with people, you know,
that's one of the most most important
aspects of playing card games. And you
can see here in regional as well, so
many people are just making memories,
you know, and that's what I love about
those really big events. It's quite a
different from like a normal typical
esports event when you have like
>> more isolated groups. Here you have like
a big gathering and it's like
>> a unique experience. I would say
>> it's so funny. I've introduced some of
my esports friends to my local game
store friends uh and now they're just
like one group and I'm like, "Wow, hang
on a second. That's really cool." But
also like wow, worlds collide in that
regard. Um, and one thing to know, um,
we don't have a graphic for this. I'm
just going to going to riff with it. Um,
I know as we come towards Unleashed,
>> the local game stores, many of them will
get copies of the Flash promo. Correct.
>> Um, and that'll be given out at the
discretion of local game stores
basically for being a good community
member is is the thought process of
these promos. It's like, hey, you do
cool things. You bring people into the
game. You you you know, share a good
experience, you may very well be able to
get that uh flash promo. super cool cuz
it it's a card that so many people are
trying to get their hands on and you
know that's another way to get it just
being a really cool person within the
community.
>> Yeah, it's a nice incentive to like be a
part of a community, bring maybe someone
new to the community, right? And also if
I'm not mistaken should be a foil, but I
might be wrong about that. So maybe I
should not speak about it.
>> The the promo foiling in general is
gorgeous of of the the Nexus Knight
promo packs. We've seen so many players
here. Uh we were speaking of course to
like Azia players and that who like oh
that that foiling I've got to get it for
my equipment from Forge Nexus Knights
promo. Okay we've done a little bit of
like how you can get involved. Um we've
talked a little bit about the the
players that are in today's rounds of
Swiss. Let's talk about the tournament a
little bit wider. Um what have we seen
coming from like the bands hitting the
meta? How do you feel about day one meta
here at Arculion? Um, I can say one word
and that's like variety. That's
something I already said two times in
the in this intro, but uh I think it's
the best word to describe the entire
tournament right now. We had seen I know
that the uh featured matches that we
have are not exactly like an
encapsulation of the entire metag game
that we have. It's 2,000 people that
were competing almost 2,000 people that
are competing here, right? So there's no
way that we can show like maybe 16 20
people on the broadcast. But in general
the pool is really wide and we have seen
the population not be also like top end
heavy right we have seen the most
populated deck be 15% that was then 13%
Draven and when you when it goes like to
the trickle down effect you can see that
it's actually very healthy looking like
it's really looking healthy when it
comes to the metag game. And there's
this is the day two metag game, James.
>> Yes. So, some really interesting things
here. Of course, Urelia and Draven and
Kaiser were our most played decks coming
here, so you would expect them to be
right there up at the top. Uh, very
similar to our day one breakdown where
Mari, Victor, and Rexai come next. And
then we have a a sprinkling of other
decks, but there is a Jinx down there at
the bottom. Um, has been performing in a
surprisingly strong fashion for a few
players.
>> I hope we get to see the Jinx on the
broadcast. It's going to be an
interesting feature because I don't know
what the what type of deck this is. Is
this like just a mid-range build that
just plays Jinx to, you know, just hunt
for that metal foil uh play the legend
or is that something else? Is it more
unique? But overall, I wanted to say
that it is expected that the best three
decks are going to be overperforming
because they're the best decks. At least
they are perceived as the best decks for
a reason, right?
>> Yeah. And a lot of that comes from
consistency, right? of just like being
able to draw the decent cards at the
right point in the game allows you to
come through uh more rounds with a win
and that is exactly what happens here.
But I will say that there's a slightly
different flavor on some of these decks.
There are uh quite a few changes that
came from the bands that make Urelia a
little bit less potent and Draven a
little bit less potent to some of the
fringe matchups. We've seen it a couple
of times, but in general they're still
still very very strong. Yeah, Draven is
incredibly strong and overall I would
say that because the meta game shifted
so much, the Dravens are adapting as
well, but you will see that many many
actually matchups are not that easy for
the Draven like you know from the get-
go. We have seen Azir really perform
well yesterday and it's one of those
decks that can outperform a Draven
because of the final potential pushes
with like the death grips that were very
efficient like super high amount of
might. Um the juggling of the equipment
is something that Dven can also do but
not to the same extent as some other
decks like the Azir like the Rex eye or
for example the Ezreal which are but now
that two builds so we we have to
approach it differently a little bit but
the tempo Ezra is also pretty neat.
>> Now I think this is a really important
thing we always look at day two
conversion. This is this is the
calculation of of the percentage of
players that played this legend how many
of them made it to day two. You can see
this is in the order of the number of
decks, but the conversion rate when you
look down the line, you start seeing a
couple of outliers. Annie there at 26%
of Annie players made it through to day
two.
>> Yeah. Essentially, if there's like 25%
conversion means that one out of four
players playing this deck is in the day
two. But what is also very interesting,
for example, Urelia, there's 70 Urelas
alive in day two, which is 28%
conversion rate. But when you think
about the population of the day, there
was 15% of the population on day one
that was irrelia. But in day two, it's
going to be 22% of the day, which means
that there's when you compare it, the
the population day one and day two,
there's more on day two than there were
in day one.
>> I I see what you mean. I see what you
mean with that. is uh you know it's
always really interesting to see which
which decks perform at a rate that uh
you know
>> more easily or at least more
consistently I think is the right way of
putting it securely too because I think
no one really has an easy route here
the players across the table from you
still have to beat them regardless of
the matchup right that is that is one of
the things in car games is a bad matchup
doesn't necessarily mean you lose every
single time but interesting conversion
rates there coming into day two and I
think I think some people were looking
for sweeping change from the bands. For
me as as a viewer, as somebody who is,
you know, taking people through the
action, I think there has been enough of
a change to to make a really interesting
meta right now. There are a few things
that are the same as the previous meta,
specifically like Draven being there,
being there, but I do think that that is
slightly more interesting perhaps than
the slightly I would say. I I I think
the game became much more robust in this
meta game. It's less flimsy when it
comes to the decision-m as well. And
that's what also what you mentioned
fight or flight was such a big influence
in how the game was resolving in the
final moments that it sometimes it was
just hard to say oh I will make a
calculated decision here. Fight or
flight was such an unknown factor in
many games you had to just say oh one of
my units is just not fighting this turn
right and if this is the last turn that
means that my biggest unit is not a
factor. And in case of lack of the fight
or flight, we don't really have that
many reaction speed like uh uh um
influence for the for the combat, which
makes Riftbound more interesting to
watch in my opinion, but also to play.
>> So, uh people are going to clip out me
being like, "Hey, it changed some stuff.
It's interesting." And then this is the
top cards for day two of like present.
So, I will say it's a lot of chaos and
fury.
>> Yes. So, this is also interesting
because I remember the stats from from
yesterday and Rebuke had 41%. Yeah,
>> which means that the population of the
purple collar is up from day one to day
two and also population from Ferris
Verona is also up because it was 38%
from what I remember and now it's 46%.
>> Does make sense because when we're
looking at the the top set of decks you
are looking at, you know, Urelia leans
into chaos. You've got Draven and Kaiser
both share Fury and Draven of course has
Chaos there as well as as as top three
>> deck. When you go to Rexai, it includes
some of the red cards like where you're
looking at uh whether it's Brin here or
Ferris 4runner. Like it does make sense
where the domains break down across the
top deck. Only Victor really there is
trying to like drag things and Azia to
to a different way.
>> Victor slightly unperformed
when it comes to his day one as well
because from from what I see on the
stats that I written here, he was 7%
population on day one,
>> but for day two, he's actually 5.3% of
the population. So, a little bit like
let's say some of the victors left, you
know.
>> Yeah. I I think that's the interesting
thing. We were talking to some of our
Victor players yesterday. They were
saying that um it's it can be
inconsistent like you can just draw the
the the wrong cards at the wrong time
where a lot of decks like Kaiser and and
to some extent Draven and and Aelia,
they see more cards. You you more
actively see things whereas if you
>> Well, definitely Draven.
>> Exactly. If you if you don't see hidden
blade in in Azia, oh well, you might not
be able to to get quite as many cards or
the shears. Exactly. Like lots of things
that that that stop him from seeing as
many. So, not surprised to see Victor,
sorry, Azir struggle, but it is a deck
that I think when piloted well, when you
do have a little bit of luck on your
side with uh the way the cards come out,
we've seen strong performances. I
>> I think minmaxing in Azir is is one of
those very important factors. When when
you watch the feature players from
yesterday, you can see that they are
taking nonobvious actions in many many
times or like are forced to do something
and find a solution on the spot and it's
a very cool deck to watch because of
that factor like the board state doesn't
look great for them and then suddenly
just one decision and it clicks in your
brain and you see like ah that's how you
get out of the sticky situation. and you
start juggling the equipment, the death
grip is transferring the might to the
other battlefield. The Azir that now
moves the units with him and finishes up
the game. It's a incredibly cool deck to
watch.
>> It is. It is. But it it's it's big brain
for me anyway in in a similar way. And
that's one of the things that that some
of those decks really do require you to
to calculate out ahead. And being able
to do that in time is is a very like
innate skill in uh in card games where
that's why we're watching the best
players. That's why we're watching the
uh the top performers throughout the
day. Of course, we will track as many of
the unorthodox legends that are still
performing. Hopefully, we'll get the the
jinx that we were talking about on
stream at um cuz we're tracking for the
best of cards throughout the day. We
talked a little bit about um the format
and things like that. But that's the
other thing that now we lock right into.
I believe I don't have the stats fully
in in my head, but I think it's three
bests are likely to have been determined
already because there are a few
champions that have not made it to date.
>> Correct. Ranata on
>> I think it might be Garen maybe
>> maybe but this is the first tournament
where we have uh so many legends in day
two so it's really cool that we've see
this progress as well uh and on already
three legends being distributed when it
comes to metal foil I think that's
pretty cool that there are still in
contestion like the other order other
order other order other order other
order legends are still being um let's
say waiting for the results
>> yeah still to be determined as we are
getting closer and closer to round nine.
Day two math is always difficult cuz I
want to say it's like the first one of
the day, but it's actually we're going
into round nine of Swiss. So, we got a
couple more minutes now before we get
there. Of course, players are filtering
into the venue. We've got to get
everybody set up. Got to get everybody
like started at the same time at the
beginning of the day. So, uh that that's
why you're with us here to begin with on
a on a Sunday morning. Uh thank you for
those of you that are joining us. You
can use the hashtag RQ Leal in order to
get in the conversation on social media
as well. Um, it's been such a cool
event. I I wish we even had some more
time to like go crack packs in the booth
down there. I know we did what we did
one with uh
>> we did Friday.
>> Yeah, definitely wasn't a
pre-constructed pack to say welcome to
Le.
>> It had a double altar of madness and
what was the other one?
>> Uh, I can't remember because if we were
stacking packs, it wouldn't be like
that.
>> It wouldn't.
>> If it was Bleven, it would definitely
would have been different.
>> I know, right? Always the case. Somehow,
somehow maybe we just get Blevens to
open all of these packs on stage.
>> There's a box here. We can crack it now.
>> Speaking of Blevens, I know that he is
standing by with Amy to get us into our
first games of the day.
>> Hey, thank you, James. We're here, as
they said. I'm Blevens. That's Amy. We
are here for a nice long day of
riftbound action here at Regional
Qualifier. Leo and Amy, I'm really
excited. We are day two championship
Sunday. I'm so excited.
>> Honestly, I could not be more buzzed.
The amount of variety, as they were
saying in the intro there, is
phenomenal. Most legends made it through
to at least a day two. And I can say
there's going to be a variety that are
coming our way, even ever so soon in our
first feature match of the day.
Hopefully, our players have rested well
because it's going to be a long one.
We've got that unttimed top eight. So,
we've got that
>> all to play for. You've got as much time
as you need
>> and we're going to see some fantastic
games unfold.
>> Absolutely. It is really awesome to to
see all this. There's, like you said, so
much variety. Almost every legend made
day two, which means there's going to be
a lot of people playing for top eight. A
lot of different decks vying for top
eight. Yes, we I mean, we saw Aurelia,
Draven, Kaisa. We knew that was going to
happen, but we have seen a ton of other
stuff that is in contention for top
eight. This may be the most diverse top
eight for any major event that we've
seen, which is really crazy. But we
actually have some deck list for our
first match of the day. It is going to
be Urelia on the one side. Of course,
this is a deck we've seen quite a bit.
It is right now the the most represented
deck in the event right now. Of course,
trying to, as you so eloquently put,
Amy, protect the princess, build up all
of those gears, get an Aurelia out, and
maybe draw some cards with Stellorn
Herder.
>> Yeah, we saw a lot of Stellorn Herder
shenanigans yesterday, and I imagine
we'll see many more today. And there'll
be a lot of Stellicorns flying around
the venue today as they draw many cards
for their Blade Dancers. Now, this deck
has shown that it's consistent. It has a
lot of power when it comes to preventing
your opponent from doing what they want
to do. So, not only putting barriers in
front of their game plan, but also
progressing your own at an ample pace.
>> Yeah. And having more of that early game
action as well. We see Desert's Call,
Lonely Porro. Desert Call is a great
card as you can play it early, but also
play it as a bigger spell. But wow,
we're seeing a Volibear right off the
bat. Let's start it off with the big
bear himself, dazzling Aurora Volibear.
>> What an exceptional match this is going
to be. We've got the ferocity of
Volibear. Will Aurelia be able to
protect her units well enough when
you've got such an aggressive deck
coming up against you? We've got this
amazing dazzling Aurora build. You're
going to want to try and get into that
as soon as possible. Then you've got
Deadling Predator. We've got all sorts
of We've got all sorts of kind of tricks
and cards in there that are going to
make it difficult for an Aurelia build.
>> Yeah. And there's a lot of there's a lot
of cards in that Volibear deck. You
know, we saw Volibear Aurora early on in
Origins meta and then it kind of fell
off a little bit. I think people went
for more of the Misfortune or Civer
Aurora with Spirit Forge. Now Volibear
is here and I think people remember that
you can put other cards in the deck. It
doesn't just need to be dead bloom
predators. We've got oh I don't know
Ferris 4runner. You just get to play
that card.
>> Oh god, not again.
The memories from yesterday.
>> It's one of the few decks that actually
gets to play Yona which is a card that
I'm I mean I'm a big fan of uh I don't
know if you know I opened the first
signature Yona. Uh you know James said I
was lucky. I don't know what he's
talking about. Uh, but so it is a card
there that and both of those cards are
actually very good against well Yona is
very good against cuz you try to hide
that Yon or you try to hide the Aurelia
in the backline. Well, Yona says, "I'm
going to conquer an open battlefield and
I'm going to hit the Aurelia in the
backline."
>> Yep.
>> And I don't care.
>> Yeah. Also gets to play Minotaur Recker,
which says, "Yeah, I know you want to I
know you want to get this Aurelia out of
here. Uh, can't move back to base." No,
it's like File Mos layer on a giant
Minotaur. Yeah, we've got things like
Brin here thunderstorm which going to
make a really big impact in a kind of
over over combat strong deck. You're
thinking, "Oh, okay. How am I going to
prevent my opponent from coming back at
me?" Well, uh I can just not allow you
to play cards.
>> Yeah, it's uh it is a way you can have
all the interaction that you want in the
world, but uh Bin here says, "No, no,
no, no, no, not not today. Not today."
But, you know, taking a step back, I
mean, I think it is it's just an awesome
experience to be able to have a day two
and not really be sure what we're going
to see. I mean, we see a volley bear
here. There's a ton of Azir,
>> Rexi, uh, Jinx. I mean, Jinx. I I heard
the statement Jinx is completely
unplayable now that Miracle is gone. I I
heard people say it,
>> so I'm curious. What are what are these
Jinx decks? What are they What are they
running? I really want to see.
>> I think we should line those people up
and make them eat their words.
Make them eat all of their Jinx cards.
>> No, then there's less Jinx in rotation.
We want more Jinx.
>> That's That's true. We want more Jinx.
We need to make them make more Jinx
cards. There we go.
>> They have to play Jinx now.
>> They have to keep opening packs until
they open uh Super Mega Death Rockets
and give them to prospective Jinx
players. There we go. That's the
community service.
>> That's it. Yep. Perfect. We figured it
all out.
>> But I mean Jinx I mean we saw Annie.
Annie's one that I think kind of very
slowly went under the radar. Same with
Master E. It was like, "Oh, Spear Forge
is out. That means that we can't play
Proven Grounds champions anymore,
right?"
>> Uh, that's kind of kind of crazy, right?
>> Those two were the two of the best decks
in Origins and they just
>> went away and now they're back.
>> Yeah,
>> now they're back. I wouldn't be
surprised if we saw either one in top
eight.
>> No. No. Honestly, I wouldn't either. And
I think that's the thing when someone
begins to underestimate a deck when
you're no longer thinking about it. When
you're deck building, you're thinking
about multiple things obviously, but one
of the main considerations with deck
building is what am I building this to
achieve, right?
>> How am I getting my points?
>> And how am I going to stop decks A, B,
and C from doing what they need to do
before I can do what I need to do? And
realistically, you're going to be
thinking about the top decks in that
scenario. Well, just because it was a
top deck in Origins, not Spirit Forge,
doesn't mean it's still not a very
strong deck and should not be forgotten
and should be considered. And Annie is
one of these decks that can just keep
fighting back because of that fantastic
ability where you do get to reutilize
your runes over and over again.
>> I'm secretly hoping that it's a downwell
loop, Annie, because that was a deck
that I saw as a meme. Shout outs to Gail
Winds for uh pointing that deck out to
me. Uh, and it's a deck that can
constantly play downwell. Bring back the
Annie chosen champion, bring back the
down well, and just keep bouncing over
and over again. Is it good? Probably
not. Is it one of the day two decks? I
hope so. And I hope that we put it on uh
camera if we have it. But it's it's
unlikely.
>> That would be absolutely phenomenal to
be able to see something like that come
out of the out of the bushes and such.
But honestly, we've already seen
innovation like that. Yesterday we saw
that Kaisa mech deck which was something
that was anticipated when
>> Spirit Forge came out. I remember
proxying that deck before the cards were
out and having a play with it, but I
couldn't quite get it consistent enough.
And the players have cooked, they've
worked with their teams and they've come
out kicking and shown that actually this
deck is very viable.
>> Yeah, that's you bring up a really good
point about the regional qualifier
events specifically. You go to your next
night, you go to your skirmish, you see
even online tournaments, people are
playing, they're playing level one
decks. I mean, some decks, you know, are
better than others are playing it. This
is people say, "This is the meta. This
is what you need to play."
>> Well, you know, you're playing an online
tournament for fun. You're not
necessarily showing all your tricks,
right? You're holding them for the
regional qualifier. This is where you
want to win the most. So, we're seeing
all everyone come out of the woodwork.
We're seeing the optimized mecha. where
fingers crossed seeing the down well
loop any deck that's optimized and is
going to take down this tournament maybe
um but that like this is the type of
event where you will actually see those
decks come to light you know people
thought ye master ye wasn't good but
someone knew that they were good well
yeah no yeah it's really bad everyone
don't play it
>> and then I'm going to bring it day two
and maybe even top eight this event
>> and that's what it's all about to make
sure that you just let everyone
underestimate you just and then uh
here's a first runner in Kaiser and
another one and another one and here's
some here's rumble and they're like
sorry what I thought we were playing
Kaiser I'm so confused
>> I literally made that face yesterday
when we were watching the match
backstage I saw the rumble and I'm like
oh they got a rumble on like
>> what wait this is this is Kai'Sa why
what I did that rumble come from why is
there a rumble in play right now just
just you know just in play as Kai'Sa
because it's Matt Kai'Sa Yeah, you can
make that. You can make it work. There
are so many utilizations of mechs.
>> Mhm.
>> Why are we not using them?
>> Rumble is not the only one who can
utilize mech mechanics, right?
>> We put those in other decks.
>> Yeah, we absolutely can. I mean, and I
think again, we're we're planting the
seeds in the early sets of Riftbound.
And you know, I'm an old man. I've been
playing card games for a long time. I
know foreshadowing when I see it. I see.
I can look into the future and see
future sets and go, "Oh, every time a
mech comes out, huh, wonder how that
works in Rumble and I wonder how that
works in Rumble." And then maybe in a
few sets we have a new whole mech set
and all of a sudden Rumble looks way
crazier. These are the types of things
that I think I'm I'm here for a long
time. This is what these are the things
I look I look into uh to to keep my eye
out for for things in the future for
Riftbound. And it's all very exciting to
me. And we're even just seeing craziness
right now. There's only two sets out.
>> I know. And that's the thing, and
there's so much to look forward to with
these utilizations of certain mechanics,
certain triggers, and certain key words.
You've got to really assess the
potential of a card when you see it.
Okay, you think, "Oh gosh, I've opened
so many of those." Well,
>> okay, that's great, but have you read
the card? Because it might not be great
right now, but when something comes out
that combos with that in one, two sets
time, like Vendetta, you just don't know
what's going to come out. So you think,
well,
>> actually, these common and uncommon
cards I've got could suddenly become the
strongest thing. Everyone's fishing
around for them because people have
counted them out.
>> What's really funny? Did you know that
Brin here thundersong was a legal card
in Origins?
>> What?
>> No, no one played it.
>> No one really played. I mean, there's a
few Okay. Yes, I know there were some
Kai'Sa decks that played it in the
sideboard. I know. Highle Kai'Sa. You
know, I I know. I know. But I also know
that we've got a match here. Uh it is a
new match actually. We were talking
about Master Yi. We still have an
Aurelia. We've also got a Master Yi
here. We're going to be the battle of
the calm decks. It is protect the uh the
president versus protect the princess.
There we go.
>> There we are. And that's exactly what
we're going to be trying to do. Uh
honestly, I'm excited to see a master.
We haven't been able to commentate one
yet, but this will be exciting. Uh,
Aurelia we've seen go from strength to
strength in this event, but also we've
seen her crumble. So yeah, will this be
her time? Will she keep on dancing or
will the bladesman rather than the blade
dancer take the crown?
>> Yeah, and this is an interesting matchup
here because it could be multiple
different types of mastery. There's a
mid-range version. There's of course
Aurora version. And you really don't
know what it's going to be until it may
be too late. But here we go. We are
getting into the mulligans here for both
players. I see that fabled monster, that
absolute behemoth Stellicorn Herder.
>> Oh no. Again,
>> this is the battle of Stellicorn Herder
decks. Both of these decks are actually
able to run Stellacicorn Herder. There's
>> Oh. And there's three.
>> Oh, we're going to have a whole herd of
tele herders.
>> Wow. The herd of herders.
>> What What do you call a herd of herders?
Is this just still called a herd?
>> I think it is just I mean it's a plur
it's pluralized already. It's just a
herd. Um but it could get a little bit
wild drawing cards left, right, and
center. But which one of our players
will be able to craft that meticulous
hand and make it through? Okay, we've
got booties. Booties of swiftness. We
love that. We love a bit of uh equippage
for some ganking and extra might.
>> Mhm.
>> And our first Stellicorn Herder joins
the fry.
>> Yep. Stellicorn Herder. I said it
yesterday, I'll say it again. No man
scares me, but but that thing,
it strikes fear into the heart of any
deck because any deck can be okay or can
be better or worse against another. When
one deck has a full deck of cards in
their hand, it is hard to deal with
regardless.
>> It really is. And even just the the fear
that you strike into your opponent with
a hand so large, you've got energy
remaining. You've got to think about all
the possibilities. And these calm decks
have such potential for that. So, we do
have to bear in mind there's a lot that
can transpire when you've got a lot of
cards in hand and the energy to utilize
them.
>> Y I want to point something out here. We
see the turn happen from they play tide
turner there. They actually took quite a
bit of time thinking about that play.
You may go well player two drop past the
turn. It is not that easy. There is so
much to think about with this Aurelia
deck. And we have seen I mean obviously
this player is 8 and0 right now in the
tournament they are making sure that
they are taking the necessary time to
actually plan out their turn plan out
their next turn. Thinking about not just
what I'm doing right now but what is my
game plan right now. So even little
decisions like that are very important
at this point in the game.
>> Oh going straight in with Aurelia
getting played. I know, I know. Box
played Aurelia, not Gozer,
but again, we're running that calm
domain. So, we can go ahead and also
utilize Aurelia in Master Yi, which is
one of the things that also brings
Mastery into the limelight, makes it
strong, makes it powerful because
Aurelia does want to defend alone a lot
of the time. So, you're getting that
extra might buff
>> quite consistently.
Yep, you absolutely are. We are seeing
the equip here from the tide turner.
That is going to be four into five here.
We're seeing
the defiant dance played out.
That's going to buff that tie turner
considerably and debuff the Stellorn
herder. So once again seeing one of our
strongest spells right now showing its
stuff giving quite a considerable amount
of might to our tie turner giving that
the extra and taking Stellacorn Herder
down to some depths I got to say down to
one which is quite scary and then we go
in and win with that six might.
>> Yep. Take it down. Get rid of that
Cicorn Herder. It's definitely
one of the scariest things that can be
out on the side of your opponent, but of
course that Aurelia on the side of
Master Yi. Now, normally Aurelia very
strong in Aurelia also as you said very
very strong in Master Y and especially
when there's that Vile layer on the
other side on that other battlefield.
This is not a this is this battlefield
is way worse for Aurelia than it is for
Mastery. Mastery says, "Oh, yeah. No,
I'll just park. I'll just park here.
I'll I'll sit here forever. Uh Aurelia
wants to obviously dance around and
Bomos layer says, "Yeah, that's not
going to be so easy to do."
>> No, I'm going to make that a lot
tougher. So, this was a great choice,
especially for our game one, making it
really difficult for the pure Ireelia
build rather than our kind of Master Yi
with a sprinkle of Aurelia on top.
Showing that we've got our Aurelia
showdown right now as both are now in
play. And now it's just the
consideration of where to spend this
energy. Do we try and get another
Stellicorn Herder out? Of course, we're
both fighting over Zorn Warren right now
to try and get that early game card draw
to push us into the driver's seat of
this game.
>> It's just a Master Yi cosplaying Is
Aurelia and that's uh we we love the
cosplay here at the RQ and uh of course
Master Y cosplaying Iselia. That's Hey,
we'll accept that as well.
>> I'd love to see it.
>> Yep. Just going over quick judge call
here. Making sure everything is up to
snuff here. But I mean right now we're
seeing the early game posturing. We
already saw a Stellicorn Herder get
taken out. There's Aurelia on both
sides. How are you feeling about this
game right now?
>> I feel like we're very we're taking it
slow and steady,
>> but I appreciate the aggression on the
Stellicorn Herder being really key to
this because you can see why they're
both fighting over Zoran right now. It
is so imperative to both of these
players that they draw lots of cards at
the beginning because then you know not
only have the knowledge of what's
available to you, but you can plan turns
ahead. You can say, "Okay, right, if I
sequence this properly with all of this
information that I have and all of these
cards, then I can pull off a win." But
the fewer cards you have in hand, the
less you can plan ahead. And that's what
this is about. It's this matchup
especially is going to be a huge game of
mental chess.
>> Yeah, absolutely. You're able to really
take advantage of the fact that Master
Yi
>> wants to but also kind of has to leave
their units parked on a battlefield.
Yeah.
>> Well, Aurelia does not have to. And if
you are sitting if you're a sitting duck
well or a Stellicorn, he can move in.
You've got a lot of combat tricks. Yes,
Mastery may have been able to fight over
that uh that battle there, but uh when
Aurelia has a bunch of cards in hand and
a lot of energy up, you really do not
want to be taking uh combat trick fights
with Aurelia on a battlefield.
>> No. And that's exactly it. Both of these
decks can use a lot of combat tricks.
They've got them up their sleeve, but
arguably Aurelia has more. We have those
Defiant Dance especially which I think
notably are going to be the turning
factor when it comes to these larger
combats.
>> Yep. Okay, looks like the dust is
settled. We've got an Urelia coming in
conquering that Zon Warren. It seems
like Zon Warren is going to be the uh
contested battlefield of the day.
Sending the lonely Porro sadly into the
trash there for the Zarens. But that's
okay because we've got a ruin runner.
the big camel himself.
>> Run Runner was one of our stars from
yesterday which showed its stuff and how
strong it can be to not be able to be
affected by spells and abilities. The
opponent cannot choose Ruin Runner.
>> Nope, you absolutely cannot.
And in this case, it's really it's good
against obviously Rebuke. It's good
against Defiant Dance. For the most
part, Aurelia is buffing her own units,
but still just knowing for a fact that
you can't be targeted, can't be charmed,
which we saw be really big in other
matches previously in the tournament.
So, uh, that Ruer Runner is very safe
and is going to be really, really big in
the backline there as the the battle of
the Aurelas has started. Get your memes
out there pointing at each other.
>> Oh my goodness. Wow. Okay, we've gone on
guard on one side, discipline on
another. The these this might is going
up and down. It's wowzer. This is like a
ride of a century. We are go not letting
up on either side. And at this point,
you've got to consider how many
resources are you going to let go at
this point. Barack is out of energy now.
Uh Gau still can keep going if they
choose. Yeah, there's still more cards
in hand on the side of Aurelia here. It
looks like they are going to play
another Ong Guard, which theoretically
is going to cause this trade to happen.
>> Or rather, not trade, this combat win to
happen. Victory.
>> Yes, we're going to use the Blade Dancer
ability to ready the Aurelia as well.
>> We're going to get a Zon Warren's proc.
we're going to be able to move the
Aurelia back. Or rather, we could even
move the Aurelia over to the Vile Mos
because we have the swift foot boots if
we so desire. So, it's a matter of do we
want to leave the Aurelia on a
battlefield here, go up to three, or do
we want to get her safely out of harm's
way?
>> And that's the decision we have to make
is is it advantageous to try for a hold
point here or knowing your opponent has
a unit, is it safer to stay in base? I
like this decision. I think you've got
to like we say protect the princess
especially when you're up against
another. However, Master has lost their
Aurelia, but we do have that ruin runner
which against something like Defiant
Dance can just swing the tides.
>> And we've talked about it a lot over the
broadcast, but it's worth reiterating.
Getting that third point in a normal
game is not nearly as important as
getting those even break points. So,
it's fine if you just randomly get it.
If you if you hold and you go to up to
three, that's not a bad thing, but you
do not want to spend unnecessary
resources to get that third point. And
leaving the Aurelia stranded, especially
on the Vile Mos layer, is not where
you'd want to be.
>> No. Overextending is Aurelia's worst
nightmare. It's honestly the worst thing
that you could probably do by accident.
But I think it's so easy. It's so easily
done when you're up against a similar
style deck. You think, "Oh gosh, I
really need to stay ahead." And at the
moment, uh, Barack is kind of leading
that point war at the moment and just
consistently going above and beyond. And
this is where if you allow yourself to
fall behind, well, I mean, that's going
to be that, isn't it? Who's going to get
to eight first if we're toe-and- toe at
this point,
it's quite quite clear,
>> right? Yeah, absolutely. and Master Y
really good at holding. Not necessarily
as good at doing what Aelia does, which
is take two points a turn and get the
units off. It's more of a I'm going to
set up camp here and and
>> really challenge you to get into combat
with me. And says, "Okay,
>> that's fine. I'm going to send in I'm
going to send in. I'm probably going to
win the combat. I'm going to score on
the other battlefield and I'm going to
get at least one of these units off uh
of the battlefield as well." is
generally what Aelia is doing. You see
Baracket get up to that third point. But
again, it's not four. They're they're
not they have not progressed a turn
further towards winning yet, which means
that the point tempo, as we say, is on
the side of Aurelia if they're able to
get to that fourth point this turn.
Yeah, being able to just take advantage
of the fact that Barack wasn't able to
gain that fourth point here could be a
pivotal moment. If we're able to
challenge the Ruin Runner and take
Valour's layer, that could just catapult
us into the lead.
>> Mhm. And this is I mean this is day two.
This is both players at 8 and0. So now
the mind games start. If you are Aurelia
here, you are very much thinking what
could possibly be in the hand of my
opponent? What is the worst thing that
can be? We know they have on guards.
They've got disciplines. They've got
punch first. So those are the cards that
they are thinking. What range of pump
spells can I play around? Am I willing
to play around? Do I lose to? These are
the things that are going through the
hand. Even if there's not a lot of game
actions being taken, there is so much
going through the heads of these players
right now that needs to be considered.
>> You also have to think about just how
much energy has my opponent got to
spend. Three, right? Okay. So, that
limits the possibilities down a little
bit because they can't play too many
pump spells. And that's really what we
need to be thinking about is what is the
potential and that's where these highle
players really gain advantage knowing
exactly what decks typically play
>> so they're able to react in tow just
hiding a card and choosing to pass the
turn holding on appreciating that you
know we're both not at that four yet so
if I can also strike our whole point
again I'm just staying toeto toe with
you. Yeah, and this is exactly where
Master Y wants to be. Senses a bit of
weakness. You know, Master E was holding
up three energy and had a bunch of cards
in hand that there's a wide range of
spells that could be in hand there.
Aurelia only has two cards in hand. So,
Barack is getting the read here. There's
not too much here. I mean, they could
have had a pump spell. They could have
even had two pump spells, but they were
afraid of what I possibly could have
had. So that gives you a read on the
type of cards that could be in Aelia's
hand. And also there's only two cards.
There's only so much you have to worry
about.
>> Only two. And that's why the Storm
Warren has been fought over so avidly at
the beginning of the game is that
actually that card draw can be so
significant. And especially now when
we're seeing that actually down to two
cards can be just not as scary as uh as
a full lorry of cards in hand. Now Gia
has the really difficult decision of
what to activate. We can't win this
alone. So Porro is going to need a
backup from Tide Turner dragging Aurelia
from base into the Frey.
>> Oh, right. And because of Vile M's lair,
the Tide Turner can't actually move
back. So it just pulls the Aurelia up.
And now Ruin Runner may have gotten into
a fight that they weren't ready to
fight. But we see the discipline
starting it off. Going to try to draw a
card. Get plus two here to see if that
is enough. But no, Gozer says not today.
Not going to draw that card. Let's see
what we get.
>> We've got to punch first. That's going
to add an additional five might taking
Ruin Runner up to 10. It's not quite
enough. Hard bargain comes down.
>> Okay.
>> Do we have a counter to that? We don't.
>> We don't. But we can just you can just
pay the two if you want. Unless I don't
know if it was repeated.
>> I didn't see how much energy they had.
I'm not sure if it was repeated or not.
>> The issue is the first punch also isn't
enough. So, we would need
>> to spend for the hard bargain cost
potentially repeated and then also play
another card. Is it worth it or do we
allow that to just go through? We're
going to spend it.
>> It was repeated. They paid for it. And
now, you know, we're not able to fully
win the combat, but uh we take down an
Aurelia and a lonely Porro who wasn't
lonely. So happy for the Porro. Not
happy for uh Gozer here, who doesn't get
to draw a card.
>> No, not at all. And I I I did a boo boo.
I forgot about Master Y's champion
ability being able to add on that extra
might and that because we were defending
alone. So, we do actually trade entirely
on that one.
>> Yep. So the whole uh as the dust
settles, there are no units on the side
of Aelia. They quickly draw their card
and pass back. And I mean, this is
Barzac in the driver's seat here.
They're going to be able to draw cards
from the clockwork keeper here from the
Stella corner. They're going to be able
to get to that ever so important sixth
point. And now, you know, presenting
lethal just by passing is a place to
that you would definitely like to be.
And that's exactly where Barzac is here.
Go's going to need an absolutely massive
draw here.
>> Trinity Force just to add on pressure
going onto that first mate. We're really
challenging this now. Go has got a lot
of hoops to jump through and zero units
currently in play. We can get things
ready, but it's not going to happen. VC
takes game one of this round nine here
at the Leil Regional qualifier.
>> Yeah, that is uh absolutely
textbook there. I mean it really the
start of the game Aurelia got off to a
fast start was able to take out that
Stellorn herder early but slow and
steady wins the race. That is Master Ye.
>> Oh yeah. To a te. Nothing nothing fast
about the Master Y deck whatsoever. Just
taking a battlefield here. winning a
combat here, holding and playing very
methodically. And we saw that get taken
down there. And here is a quick look at
the Aurelia deck here. Two main deck
Vex. Love that card. Very, very strong,
especially in these green matchups where
there's a lot of combat tricks and these
these battles happening.
>> We just didn't see one.
>> No,
>> we just didn't see one. We've also got
the Flash. I don't think we saw one of
those either. uh charm wasn't able to be
utilized. So actually a lot of the deck
was either just not seen or shut down.
What do we think is potentially going in
from the sideboard?
>> Yeah, we saw the heart of dark ice which
was very good yesterday in the games we
saw. We saw that hard bargain as well.
One of the only ways to actually deal
with a punch first potentially which is
uh certainly one of the cards that makes
a the big has the biggest impact on this
matchup for sure. But Barzak, you can
see here, has the sideboard notes
written down. Now, this is a this is a
uh a tournament tip here. You can't you
can't uh you can bring notes in and look
at them in between the rounds. So, if
you know what you want to sideboard in
for the games, you can have that written
down beforehand. You don't need to try
to figure it out on the fly. You don't
need to try to remember it off the top
of your head. You can have that written
down. can't look at it during the match,
but in between games, you can look at
those sideboard notes and have those
ready for you.
>> Let's have a little look. We've got
Sabotage, Auction, Defy, Not So Fast. A
lot of these feel like they'd be good
into this matchup, but which are the
correct cards to put in and take out. I
think that's always my hardest uh
decision is which cards I don't need in
certain matchups and being able to
remember that. I'm much more of a write
it down gal. Yeah, I if I'm taking a a
tournament seriously, I will have all of
the normal all of the top matchups
written down for my sideboard notes. And
then of course, I'll play against
something completely random and it will
be thrown out the window. But for the
most part, if I'm playing against the
top, you know, five to 10 meta decks,
I'm going to have sideboard notes
written down for those so that I don't
have to think about it. I've got that
mental energy spent elsewhere. And one
card I do like from the sideboard of
Barzac is a card that we saw a decent
amount yesterday in a variety of
different orange decks. And that of
course was the auction being able to
take that guardian angel from Aurelia
can be absolutely
backbreaking in some of these matches.
And as we saw Gozer lost a few units and
then just never was able to recover.
They didn't have any other units to
refill with. And that's that could be a
problem solved by Guardian Angel,
>> right?
>> So again, it's one of those things where
actually it can be troublesome. I'm
really curious to see which battlefields
are going to get chosen because we
really saw the Zorn Warren uh being so
impactful in that game one. Both players
fighting for it avidly because they know
they need the card draw whereas Mlaya
was definitely left to the side. It was
a really awkward one and obviously the
Zorn was much more advantageous at the
beginning. Really valer was only used in
the late game to gain those extra points
that we needed to push forward for that
win. And so we need to see whether we're
going to be able to utilize any of our
card draw in other ways.
>> Yep. We see Forge of the Fluff on the
side of Master Y with Targon Peak for
the Aurelia. Now, Forge of the Fluff one
that we see a lot in Lucian. It is a
very, very good Lucian
battlefield. Targon's Peak really great,
especially if you are going first and
are able to conquer that first. So,
having a turn one play is going to be
huge here for Go as they're going to be
able to threaten that Targon's peak
right off the bat. get that energy
flowing.
>> And we don't have a unit in response yet
from Bartex. So back over to Goa and
they're going to have free reign of it
if they'd like to. And a Stellicorn
Herder now in hand as well. So yep, that
Boro is going in.
>> Yep. Going to conquer. Going to ready
two runes at the end of their turn. They
can even develop a Stellicorn Herder now
if they want and still have energy left
to protect it if they want. That's
exactly what they're going to do.
>> I think that's a wonderful play being
able to utilize that battlefield
perfectly, allowing yourself the extra
wiggle room of having some open energy
at the end of the turn and getting
Stellicorn Herder into play. You can't
make it up.
>> Nope, can't make it up. But that is now
Lonely Porro getting two points. What a
good boy.
>> What a great porro. It's so sad that
he's he's lonely up there, but it is
okay. Got a Stellicorn Herder in the
base that is going to be threatening to
draw so many cards.
>> A much much more dynamic start this time
from Go who's
plummeting theself into the lead here
with two points from Apollo. Stellicorn
Herder threatening to draw more cards
being able to utilize Taran Peak.
Amazing with just an Aurelia and a
Guardian Angel currently on Barex side.
Now it might seem small but it certainly
is scary when Guardian Angel gets
equipped to Aurelia. So we know that the
Fury is coming soon. Yeah, the fury is
absolutely is absolutely coming and it's
going to be a matter of, you know, what
can Barzek do to stem the bleeding here.
They are now down a turn and a half in
terms of point tempo. Obviously, that
equates to three points here. But again,
unlike Aurelia, Barzac is not really
equipped to go in and conquer two
battlefields and leave them safe.
They're they're really good at
conquering one and holding, but right
now they're going to need to do more
than that because Gozer, if if that
happens, Gozer can just conquer the
other battlefield, stay there, and if
the game progresses, is going to win.
>> Having a little look at that uh Forge of
the Fall. Of course, we've got those
boots of swiftness. We could equip
those.
Just having a consider of where they
might go
or whether we're going to play play
something else.
>> Yep. This is a
this is a uh interesting interaction
between Aurelia and Forge of the Fluff
where you can exhaust Aurelia to use
Forge of the Fluff. And they're
wondering if they're able to I wondering
if they're able to also use the Aurelia
Blade Dancer ability.
Okay. No, we're not using the forge of
the flesh. We're just paying and using
the Aurelia ability. Got it. There we
go. So, we're moving the getting the
Stellicorn Herder out of trouble there.
Moving it back, drawing a card for their
troubles. And now we've got uh two not
so lonely Porros and a Stellicorn Herder
with the boots of swiftness in the
backline.
>> And it's a good place to be. But now
Aurelia does have a little bit more free
reign. And with a really nicely
developed hand of useful cards, now it's
time to act. So, we've got Aurelia going
straight into Forge of the Fluff for
that first conquer point of the game,
and we're going to use There we go. our
ability to equip
>> and get some extra power, some extra
might. So, we've got an equip, we've got
extra might. Aelia is feeling pretty
good in that situation. And we have lots
of cards to back it up as well. We could
even target those boots of swiftness
with an Arshan. I was about to say it.
And there he is. We're going to target
the boots of swiftness. And they are
taken by Arshan. We saw this kind of
little combo in effect yesterday and now
we're seeing it today as well. Giving
him ganking which is fantastic. Now
charming the opponent.
>> Oh, very strong here as that is going to
be Stellicorn Herder. Yes, you do still
draw the card because Stellacicorn
Herder is a busted card.
uh in a good way of course, but uh even
on the way out it's still drawing you a
card. But that is Stellhorn Herder gone
for Aurelia here. Master Yi has set up
camp with an Aurelia with a guardian
angel. It is
>> uh the princess is protecting herself at
this point.
>> Oh yeah, she's strong enough to do that.
She knows her place and she is going to
be standing firm trying to now build up
those hold points as well. Unlike the
natural firm
stance of an Aurelia build where
normally you're trying to dodge in and
out of battlefields, you're right.
Master Yi is trying to do quite the
opposite and is trying to hold on in
there, create this almost impenetrable
board state on battlefields themselves.
And we can see from the board state that
Barzek has managed to create that that
is coming into fruition quite nicely.
>> Yeah. And you know, really big turn from
Barzek, but look at the points. Goes are
at four now. Point tempo certainly in
their favor. They don't necessarily
have to do too much right now. Yes,
Barzac is certainly ahead on board, but
they're behind on point tempo, behind on
points. So, Gozer could theoretically
take a turn to develop and then pick
these fights once they've actually got
some reinforcements.
I think that would be a very strong
position to start to put yourself back
into this game. There's a lot of lonely
porros on this board and they're not
looking so lonely right now. I think
that's a bit of a fib I've got to say as
we look to establish a stronger board
alongside these not so lonely borrow.
>> Yeah, we're all alone in this together.
>> Yeah, that's how it goes, right? Vex
joins the crew. Yeah, Vex uh sees all of
the Lonely Porros and is sad about it.
So, it's this is all playing on brand
thematically for sure.
>> Vex has proven time and time again what
a strong card it is. Even though some
were to underestimate Vex, we've seen
that it's a very good card in this deck
and I think good in this matchup.
>> Oh, absolutely. any matchup where you're
going to want to get into these pump
spell wars. Uh if there's a Vex in
combat, you really don't want to be on
the other side of it. It is a It is a
nightmare as someone who made the
mistake of attacking a Vex battlefield
once.
>> That one time and I'll never do it
again.
>> It was the last time. Unfortunately, it
was in the top four of a skirmish and I
lost that game.
>> Oh, I learned my lesson in the next two
games. It's all good.
>> Here we go. a boost of swiftness joining
our Aurelia to give her ganking to go
and see that lonely
>> for the fluff allows you to move the the
equipment that's on Aan.
>> Oh my gosh,
>> that is insane and hilarious.
>> Poor Pora goes down to an Aurelia who
went, "Oh, Aan, just chuck me those with
you, buddy."
>> Yeah. And the master ye cosplay sees
another Ael sees an Aurelia and goes,
"Oh, can I borrow that?" Yes. Now my
cosplay is even better. Now I literally
have the boots of swiftness for my
cosplay.
>> It's perfection. Archan then goes into
for the fluff, gaining that extra point.
The momentum is building and this board
state is starting to become much more
mastery looking with its presence.
>> Yeah. And here's an interesting thing.
If Aan dies, Gozer gets control of the
equipment back.
>> That's true.
>> It doesn't unattach from the unit. Nope.
It just usually does because if the
auction usually is the one holding that
equipment. Yep. But if he's not, it
doesn't unattach it and give it back. It
just says, "Oh, this equipment is still
attached to Aurelia. It's just you
control it." Yeah.
>> Oh, can I unequip it? But
>> no, but you control it.
>> Yeah. Aurelia is like, "I don't want to
take these off yet. I'm not done.
>> These are my ruby slippers.
>> I'm not finished with them. You're going
to have to wait." Vex going in and
saying hello to Arshan, which is quite a
vexing proposition. Yep. And of course,
Master Y ability is going to give that
plus two to Ashan right off the bat. So,
>> discipline is necessary.
>> Discipline is necessary. It's going to
put Aurelia at plus one on this combat
here.
>> We've got a response. It's a thonk.
Thonk
does have to pay an extra energy and a
power to
>> to thw
>> to thw and it is going to be an extra
energy and a power to defy this
very expensive
>> exchange here for Barzek but necessary.
>> Both of them just going no no no not so
fast defy. Oh my goodness.
>> Yep. Not so fast. Does is able to
counter the thonk. So, the Defies
resolve on themselves, but the not so
fast can target the original Thonk, and
that is going to be good enough there.
>> Vex has done exactly what they set out
to do. Looking at the energy that Barack
has left now is incredibly thin. And I
think they're just having a little chat
about how that interaction you just
discussed works where now Arshan's gone.
The boost of swiftness technically.
There in goes his control, but Aurelia
is still wearing them, so she just gets
to keep him on.
>> Yeah. So, and then the question is, can
you use Forge of the Fluff to then move
them back?
>> And I think that is what they are trying
to determine right now if they're able
to do that. I'm I'm not going to make
guesses because uh I'm not a level one
judge, but I think that is what we are
uh seeing here. This is uh you know I've
played a lot of Lucian and I've played
Ashan. I play Ashan in Lucian. I play
Forge of the Fluff. I've not actually
had this interaction come up yet.
>> It's a fun one, that's for sure. I'm
curious to see how the judges resolve
it. Um I I was at a concert once and
someone did steal the shoes off my feet,
so I know it can happen. Uh it's just
whether
>> whether that forged the fluffed, you
know, was I there? Probably. Must have
been, I guess. Uh so we'll have to see.
Did you hear the story about how I got
auctioned in real life?
>> No. Yeah. Right. Exactly.
>> We're we're going to talk about that.
We're let the judges figure that out.
No, I I got ashed in real life. I did in
in uh in Bolognia. We had the card
swinging. I was there uh played against
some players. Had got my uh got my
Trinity Force auctioned in game and then
I forgot to take it back.
>> Oh no.
>> So I went to register my deck and I was
missing a Trinity Force and uh yeah,
Ashan took it in real life. Uh it was uh
a content creator that I know and that
was easy to get it was an accident
obviously and they brought it back. I
got I got an email from Ryan in the
morning say hey someone brought back
your Trinity Force. But it was just
funny that like I literally got ashanded
in real life from Ashan in game.
>> I was like I feel like there should be
39 cards in my deck with champion not
38. And I'm like can I not count
anymore? Like I go,
>> I lost that ability.
>> As one thing that I always do is forget
to pick up my battlefield at the end of
a game. I'm walking halfway across the
venue and someone's like, "Amy, your
battlefield."
>> Okay, so after the judge call, looks
like that has been resolved here.
>> Looks like the boots of swiftness are
still on Aurelia for now.
>> Yes. Whether that changes another
matter, but for now she gets to keep
them on. She's got ganking and that plus
two might from them.
>> Mhm.
>> So we've got seven might on both sides
here. Going to
>> Titer in place. Swapping around with
Vex. Keep Vex safer
>> just to get Vex out of danger there. We
get that fourth point for Barack here.
>> Yeah, we get that hold point. Aurelia
standing strong still in Taran Peak.
>> And now we're going to be working with
fewer runes than we were expecting on
this turn.
>> And is that just the one card in hand?
We have nothing left after that combat
scuffle as well. I think Vex really had
quite the impact.
>> Absolutely. It spent a lot of cards to
basically make your opponent spend cards
too. But the problem is that you also
spent a lot of runes as well. But Lonely
Porros can cash in for additional cards
there. As sad as sad as that is, we get
to cash in the lonely porro there.
That's okay.
>> Yeah, went into the tie turner. Did take
the trade from both sides. Managed to
draw another card. I think it's an on
guard by the looks of things, but that's
not going to help us right now because
we can't get into further combat by
force. Lipro could go ahead and take
that battlefield now, which we are going
to do for the extra point, but it leaves
us incredibly vulnerable.
Not many cards in hand. Of course, we
have the energy to back it up, but
Aurelia is just on her own right now. Is
it worth bringing her back to protect
her, or do we think we have enough
resources just to hold on for dear life?
>> Well, and here's the other thing, too,
is that this gets into that those mind
games of Barzek knows that Gozer knows
that, Barack knows that. You go back and
forth and like I they know that I'm
choosing to leave this at a battlefield,
so what am I representing? And then you
have to think, what is my opponent
representing? How many punch first can
they have? How many combat tricks can
they actually have? They have a
discipline that can lead into more cards
off the top of the deck. Again, how much
am I willing and able to play around?
And not only do you have to think about
that as the player playing around, you
get to think of that as the opponent
saying, "What am I going to pretend or
feain that I have and how is that going
to change my opponent's play?" That's
why we're looking at this. That's why
Barzac is looking at their hand and they
may not
play, but there's a lot of decisions to
be made in that turn. We've got all of
our energy that's currently available,
two cards in hand, but telling Goza that
this could be all I need.
Was there too much contemplation? Does
Goza take the no that Barzek might be
trying for a bluff here?
>> Or maybe go maybe Barzek does have
exactly what they need.
>> We're going to start with a charm
pushing Aurelia back. All right. So, I'm
not going to worry about combat. I'm
going to say you are not going to be in
combat.
>> I don't really fancy going towards that.
Aelia, you have left lots of energy in
play. I'm not feeling good about that.
Aurelia, could you just scoot back there
a few steps? Thank you.
>> Yeah, it's a tempo play. We're going to
be able to get to six nice and easy.
We're going to be able to uh conquer
that target's peak. Just walk on in
there.
>> And you know, we were talking about
playing around things. There are three
Defiant Dances in hand. You can play
around basically everything.
>> Yes, absolutely. We're in a much
stronger position than we were in game
one. And we are on completely opposite
sides here. It was in game one where
Gozer was reluctantly down to a single
or double card hand. And now it's
completely flipped. We're playing the on
guard putting us down to a single card.
One card in hand as Lonely Porro gets
above. But Defiant Dance comes through
and Vex catastrophically
wins that showdown taking Forge of the
Fluff once again with just a single
Aurelia. Now, can Barack pull forward?
>> Yeah, Barsek essentially, you know,
saying, "Hey, I know you probably have a
pump spell here. Which one is it?" I
think they're actually quite happy that
it is the Defiant Dance cuz a that's a
Defiant Dance. one fewer Defiant Dance
that they have. And also, it's going to
cost them a power, which a lot of the
other pump spells won't.
>> And they do still get to draw the card
from Lonely Porro, but even if that is a
favorable exchange here for Barseek,
it is still an uphill battle to say the
least, cuz they're going to need to
conquer. They're going to need to stop
both of these battlefields as Gozer is
at seven here.
>> Oh, we don't want Gozer to draw more
cards. So, we're going into the Vex, but
that does make this combat potentially
trickier. We're going for the Defiant
Dance. Of course, that's going to put
Vex up some might and Aurelia down, but
Defy comes to save the day. That's one
more Defiant Dance dealt with, but we
had that second one in hand. We're going
again. And that gives Goza the win.
We're going to a game three here in
round nine. Le,
>> yep, game three for this. And this was
in a really close match, but it was a
different match for sure. We saw the
units on the side of Aurelia actually be
there. Saw them being able to take that
proactive gameplay, take that target
peak early and be able to play units and
defend them as well.
>> The story so far
is whoever draws more cards wins the
game.
>> I never would have guessed it. It is
cards in hand go up, win percentage of
game go up. Nice and easy.
>> Good math. Good math. And uh this is
exactly what happened games one and two.
Whoever ended up with the uh much m much
much fluffier hand size uh ended up
being able to pull out a win. And again,
I liked their denying your opponent of
the lonely porro trigger near the end
there saying, "Okay, I'm going to try
for this top battlefield. Although I
know Vex is going to be a more difficult
showdown, I don't want you to draw more
cards because you already have more than
me and I don't like that."
>> No, not at all. I mean, Master Yi in
that game especially has to play a game
that
is dictated by the tempo of their hand,
right? They are behind. They're having
to make these potentially suboptimal
plays to try to get that little bit
ahead and then finish the game from
there. And if it doesn't work, you lose.
It's not like not doing that play is
going to cause you to win. You're
actually going for the win there,
potentially trying to see what your
opponent does. You're also getting
information about your opponent as well,
how they play, the types of cards that
they're holding in, how they're playing
when they have these cards. All these
little things are what highlevel players
are looking at, especially as we're
going into day number two.
>> You mentioned something really
interesting there, and that is how your
opponent plays. That's one of the things
you're learning in a best of three.
You're not just knowing the matchup.
You're not just looking at cards. You're
learning your opponent's play style and
you're adapting as you go into this
third game with all of that knowledge.
Both of you have won a game aside. You
know the potential. You know what they
are likely to do. And now it's can you
take advantage of that?
>> Mhm. We see game number three. Grove the
God Willow on the side of Master Yi.
Sunken Temple on the side of Aurelia.
Grove, of course, a battlefield that is
rewarding you for holding, which is
exactly what Master Yi wants to do.
Another great battlefield if you are
going first and have a two drop to play,
which I can see in their hand. It's a
lonely porro.
>> It is a lonely porro, but we saw them to
great effect last game. So, let's see if
we can do some more. Now, we do have um
two battlefields here that both draw us
cards potentially, but it's much easier
for Master Y on that Grove of the God
Willow.
>> Mhm. Yeah, you're able to set up shop
there and start drawing some extra
cards. We saw cards in hand go up, win
rate go up. It's easy enough to do that.
And while there is a two drop to
theoretically contest on the side of
Gozer, well, uh, when defending, all two
drops are not made equal when fighting a
master. Yei as that lonely porro for
some reason is going to be formite on
defense.
>> Huge porro gets a lot fluffier. You
can't quite get through it all. And I
think forcing your opponent's hand here
is also important. You got to remember
if you allow your opponent to hold that
grove of the god Willow, they're going
to draw an extra card at the beginning
of their turn.
>> Mhm. It looks like
>> that can get a little bit tricky.
>> Yep. Not a a problem at all. Looks like
we've got another judge call. Just going
to resolve that. But really great start
for Master Yi here being able to set up
on that Grove of the God Willow early
because yes, Aurelia can at least
potentially contest that. But there's
two energy up on the side of Master Yi.
A lot of potential pump spells. And if
Aurelia is going to contest that, it's
going to be costly.
>> And if they lose that early exchange, it
could be the whole game. We saw in game
number one when they lost one of those
early battles, lost some of their only
units. the game the house of cards
started to crumble for Aurelia and
Master Yi was able to take it over.
>> Exactly that. And we're trying to use,
you know, those units with death nail
abilities that when they do come out of
play, you do draw a card regardless.
It's like a rock in a hard place. It's
okay, I let you have the hold point, but
then you get to draw an extra card, and
I don't like that. But if I do take you
out, then you get a card, and I don't
like that either. So almost something
like a charm feels good here because
you'd be able to push it back rather
than um rather than allowing the whole
point but also not allowing them to draw
a card through defeating the pora.
>> Right. Yeah. Exactly. You're wanting to
attack Master Yi by not attacking him,
which is kind of the weird
>> maybe maybe there's something there's
something philosophical about that. I
don't know.
>> Maybe there is. Maybe
>> uh I don't know. I just like cards in
hand go up, win rate go up. And that's
what Grove the God Willow does for
>> needs to try and pull themselves into
the driver's seat and take this game. It
was very clear from games one and two
what the win condition was between these
two and so they're both going for it and
both making sure that they chose these
battlefields last to give themselves
that opportunity.
>> Absolutely. And it looks like we have
resolved the judge call here. Not sure
what it was, but we are back into the
game. We got the tide turner. There's a
couple pump spells here. I think I saw a
Stellicorn Herder as well. And we're
just Yeah, we're not we're not fighting
the Lonely Porro. It's a It is an uphill
battle. Even the You can see the little
hill that Lonely Porro is on. It's an
uphill battle to try to fight him when
there's a Master Yi backing him up.
>> It's so snowy. It's such a It really is
horrible. You don't really fancy
climbing it right now. But Stellaorn
Hurdle will be much better flying
overhead. So, that goes into base for
now. Ready to once again draw some more
cards. Lonely Porro readies on fast deck
side. We got two lonely porro and then
we get to draw that card for turn. We're
going to for that hold point on the
grove god Willow and then for turn. So
we're actually drawing two cards right
at the beginning here after our effect
from there. And we're already are
already that's a strong looking hand.
>> Yep. Absolutely. And we are attacking in
to try to trade down or actually destroy
win this combat with the tide turner.
But there's a fight being put back up
from the Aurelia side.
>> Here we go. Defying the Ong Guard going
to say nope nope nope nope no. I know
what that does. I play one of those and
I don't like it. So off Tit Turner goes
to the trash as the lonely porro puts up
quite the fight. Quite often lonely
parro are left to go to the trash so you
can draw the card. But in this instance,
Master E doesn't want that. They need to
hold this strong position. Only one
Stallicorn Herder on the other side.
You're thinking, "Ah, yeah, you can only
take one of these and then I get a whole
point and that takes me to four."
>> Mhm. And you can take one of those, but
you as the Aurelia player are going to
have to act first. This is where the
like hidden power of Master Yi is
because you're attacking into a two
drop. That's four might. So that means
you have to act first. You have to play
the first pump spell here and then
Master Yi gets to react to that.
Generally being the reactor is better in
these scenarios. And we see here it is
the discipline starting off
on the Stellicorn Herder.
>> Putting up a fight.
>> Thonk.
Let's see if we're going to defy. Yeah,
we're going to defy the thong. All
right.
>> And we're going to divide the divide
that divide the thonk.
>> Yes. I feel like there's uh some sort of
uh some sort of rap to be made out of.
>> I was thinking nursery rhyme. It's like
the the what is it? The the cat that had
the dog that had the bunny that go that
had Oh, wait. Ivvern. Wait,
>> maybe no.
That's next set. That's next set. But
yes, it's definitely an exchange of
resources here. A battle. And
unfortunately, looks like the Stellorn
Herder was thwked out of the combat
there, which means another two points
for holding another free card from the
Grove of the God Willow.
>> Oh my gosh. And then we get to channel
our runes and then draw another card.
Farc with these two lonely parro looking
in a really strong position. Not only
have more cards, but we also have more
strongholds on those battlefields not
letting go. And that's exactly what
Master Y is trying to achieve.
>> Absolutely. And we see
a card like Defy very powerful in the
right scenario, but even at its best, it
is still costing you a card. It's a one
for one when you play it. The thing is
is that when you're drawing an extra
card every turn, you actually want to be
making as many one for one trades as you
possibly can. So all of these
opportunities for Defy and for Charm are
actually very very good for Barseek.
>> Forcing the Stellicorn Herder forward.
We of course do get the draw. It was a
Defy, but unfortunately it's a little
too late for Stellorn
>> Herder. Stellicorn Herder did did like
you said draw drew an extra card but uh
you get one now but then never any more
from that Stellicorn herder as Aan you
know sometimes is good enough with just
the stats and of course when those stats
are bolstered by Master Yi on defense
you'll love to see it
>> you do love to see it here we go joining
the Frey here as we bring her into base
I don't honestly know if there was a lot
of choice there. We need to start
rebuilding our stance and we need to
start building these units back up and
with just a lonely parro before now
actually not looking so hot. So we
needed to bring Aurelia in here to start
that protect the princess mechanic.
We're going to use ong guard to trigger.
There we go. So that we can trigger the
blade dancer.
>> Yep. We're going to play the on guard.
We're going to ready the Aurelia. out
notably. Uh actually, yes, Aurelia there
going to be ready going to come in and
attack the auction.
>> Aelia says, "That was my stacorn herder.
What do you think you're doing?
>> How dare you?"
>> Winking at them like that. Oh, I'm
coming for you now. So, Archon's in a
little bit of trouble here. We've only
got one energy standing. We are starting
to get a bit low on the on the cards in
hand for Barcel.
We have played a lot. Those combats have
been really bouncing back and forth.
Although, yes, everything is rather
cheap like our defies and our charms.
Yeah. Okay. They're one cost, but those
really do add up when you're thinking
about the cards you're left with in hand
after all of that,
>> right? Yeah. Barsek uh able to make
these trades. And there's a punch to
first. That is a big one. is going to be
tough to overcome that right here. And
that is going to be Barick now at plus
four.
>> Defined dance would do it. But it looks
like there may be a ride the wind which
could get Aurelia out of this mess. And
at least protector going for the
discipline instead. We're going to try
and outmite
this situation.
Okay, looks like we're doing some
we're doing some math here.
>> It's important. There's a lot of
mathematics involved, especially with
these two decks against one another
because we are just going back and forth
with these spells that put might up and
down and all around.
>> Yep. Looks like we've got 11 to 10. Oh,
I just saw the point at the Master Y. I
think they may have forgotten about the
Master Y ability. We've all done it, but
not at this stage of the tournament at 8
and0.
>> Comes in clutch in situations like this.
We've managed to draw some cards. Barex
now got the guardian angel going on to
hold. Wow. Yeah. Going on to try and
take that hold point for the win. Just
making sure that Arshan is going to
stick around. And that's the handshake
as Barc takes it into the victory spot
of this round nine here at Le for our
Riftbound regional qualifier.
>> Yeah, that was a crazy game. These
combat oriented champions doing some of
the very same things. In fact, Master G
looking like an Aelia cosplayer for a
lot of that match, but doing them in
very, very different ways. Master Yi
wanting to set up and get ready, wanting
to hold Battlefield. A Zelia wanting to
obviously dance around. And as we saw
there, sometimes big numbers are good.
And Master Yi just gives you numbers for
free.
>> And that's that's what it's all that's
what it's all about when you're playing
well, remembering that defensive
trigger. When you're defending, you get
extra might. And actually, that is
sometimes enough, but you need to be
defending alone. That's why just having
both units separated, having the Arkshan
with the extra gear just to buff him up
and also have that protection. Lonely
Porro draws me a card. So that might
allow me to progress this even more. So
actually that alone, those two units
seem maybe not so scary, but actually in
the background they have a lot of power
behind them.
>> Yeah, absolutely. when you can turn a
singular lonely porro into the same
might as a regular ashan.
>> Yeah, that's okay.
>> That's pretty good.
>> And and yes, the stats alone are great,
but just the fact like we mentioned in
the match that your opponent attacks
into it and they have to act first.
They're going to have to spend their
resources. They're going to have to show
their hand a bit first before they do
anything because you just got that free
might for defending. That's an
advantage. And we saw little advantages
here and there.
>> And the mathematics of all the spells
that were bouncing around also makes it
incredibly difficult for the players.
Keeping track of that is incredibly
difficult. And also knowing when it's
advantageous to play those cards because
you don't want to leave your opponent
with too much leeway,
>> right? Yeah. It's it it was a lot about
timing. You know, we had we saw Barc
that last match be able to set up get
that grove of the godwill start drawing
cards so that all of these defies and
punch first that may be putting you
behind on some resources, you're able to
keep the cards in your hand cuz you're
drawing an extra card every turn. You're
able to take all these one for one
trades. And if I'm drawing an extra card
and you're not, all these one for one
trades are going to end up with you with
nothing and me with more resources. And
that is at the end of the day, it's a
resources game. We saw Master Yi take
full advantage of that
>> 100%. And although in game two that
faltered a bit as we weren't quite
getting those one for one trades, we
weren't getting the okay, you've
destroyed my porro, I gain a card. Oh,
it's one cost. We weren't seeing that
enough to be able to keep up,
>> right? And we're now getting into or
already in the point of the tournament
where a lot of these top level players,
if they're taking a look at a
prospective metag game going into the
biggest RQ ever, you're going to imagine
there's going to be a lot of Draven,
there's going to be a lot of Aurelia,
there's going to be a lot of Kai'Sa.
Well, there's also going to be a lot of
a whole list of other things when
there's 2,000 people in the event. We
have now narrowed that down to just the
day two. So all of the players who tech
their deck for Aurelia did put in a lot
of matchup uh experience into Draven
have their deck ready for the Kai'Sa
matchup. All of that is now we're going
to see the fruits of those labors. Now
you may have done that and then played
against Victor and Lux and Rexi all day
yesterday and you're not in day two.
Sorry about it. We've all been there.
But in this case, if you put all that
prep into the top of the meta as we saw
here, you if you want to play Aelia,
this is the time for you because that is
the most represented deck in this day
two.
>> In that respect, it can sometimes be
more difficult in day one for you than
it can be in day two because in day two,
you're facing the expected. The
unexpected is what day one can be made
up of and that's where things can really
get a little bit shaky. and we we spoke,
you know, there was a volley bear here
in day two among other jinxes the jinxes
and you think, "Oh my gosh, they're
still here. I'm still unprepared for
them."
>> Mhm.
>> How do I how do I traverse that?
>> Right. Yeah. You may have put in dozens
of hours into Aurelia, Draven, Kai'Sa,
even Victor. Maybe even if you're if
you're looking even further, maybe maybe
you got the Rexai match up. Maybe he's
got the Azir match up. Maybe if you
listen to me, you you've gotten some
reps into Lucian.
>> No shot. You're You have a Jinx game
plan because you know what? I have no
idea what the Jinx deck looks like right
now. So, how could you how could you
know what you're going to be playing
against? I have no idea.
>> Jinx was like almost cosplaying Draven
last time before we had these bands. And
now that we've had the bands, you think,
okay, all the things that were allowing
Jinx to do that are gone,
>> right?
>> So, where does that leave Jinx?
>> Right. I played against in day one of
Bolognia. I played against the eventual
best of winner of Jinx.
>> Oh wow.
>> I did win by the way. Just saying. Uh as
Lucian uh Yeah. Yeah. You know,
>> they didn't ask me on the uh on the
broadcast for no reason. Uh
>> yeah, they had to get you out of the
competition.
>> That's true. They needed they needed to
give other players a chance to get the
best evolution is definitely it. But uh
that deck would look completely
different. That deck is absolutely
illegal. the deck that I played against
as the best of Jinx. So, you know, you
can build it in a different way and and
and maybe we'll see later on in the
event, but right now we have got our
winners interview with that Master E.
Let's throw it on over
you. I'm here on stage with Patrick who
is currently sitting at 9 and0 with his
Mastery mid-range build. And first and
foremost, congrats on your win. I would
like to ask you a question. Why Master
Yi? Why mid-range Master Yi?
>> Yeah. So, uh after the uh big bands, big
wave of bands, uh we got to testing as
soon as possible. We tested some decks
that used to be u pretty bad into some
of the banned cards. In particular,
Fight or Flight was a big boon against
uh for for the for other decks against
Master Eye. And with that gone, we kind
of defaulted that that should be a good
deck. We started testing it. We didn't
lose to any matchup honestly besides
one. And it's firmly in the other
category. Uh so we just kept iterating
on the deck. We put a lot of hours in.
We we found a build that we really
liked. Uh and we arrived at what I'm
playing today and well it seems to be
working out.
>> So is your friend also or like anyone
from the test group also playing it
today on
>> Yes, my friend my friend Pasa is I
believe now 8 and one on the same list
as me.
>> So 8 and one and 9 and zero. That's a
testament to how the deck performs in
testing, right? That's awesome to hear.
Now can you tell me what is the worst
matchup for this deck or do you want not
to say? We have not won a game against
Volora.
>> I don't think you should be worried if
that's the case that that's the one
deck, but it will be so unlucky if you
get paired into like one at day one when
it's like 2,000 people, right?
>> I believe starting 9 and0 uh is a pretty
decent way to dodge volleyball Aurora.
>> That's a good one. All right. So, in
game two, we had this interaction with
action and like then changing the
control. How worried were you? I know
that you lost that particular match game
anyway, but how worried were you that
your opponent will realize that he can
move it with your battlefield still
because he's still the controller
though.
>> Yeah, that is a bit of an awkward
dynamic with Ireelia because that's the
only matchup I play vile most on game
one rather than game two.
>> Mhm.
>> Um but it honestly gives me much bigger
advantage than it would give the Ireelia
player usually. Uh it sometimes happens
uh that will turn off their Ireel legend
from readying their units. So that's a
big deal as well. So in that particular
turn you're you're talking about uh if
they move the boots over to Vex they
cannot ready Vex correct. So it's also
like it would be pretty bad for me worse
than it played out but still quite okay.
I will be satisfied with that.
>> Yeah. Okay. So now uh you're from the
Polish community. Um how do you think
the Polish community is sitting when it
comes to the other communities? Do you
think where the Polish community is
strong or not so much or what what is
your perception over here? Well, I I
think thanks to so many Star Wars to the
community in Poland, we have a very
strong community. Uh, I think League of
Legends is a very popular game in Poland
and it has brought a ton of different
players into the card gaming world as I
think I love about Rebound because you
know I played all sorts of card games
and none of them can bring the non-card
game player
>> to the table and I think Rebound did it
in such an insane way to see Warso
having 80 player Nexus Knights to see
Krakov the city where I'm from having 40
player Nexus Knights and my local store
running 20 player Nexus nights that
these are numbers that I have not heard
of in any other game. And I think the
Polish community is very strong for
that. And I I'm just delighted to be
able to play in such a large and loving
community that keeps together as well.
>> Yeah, that's exactly the same opinion as
I have and the same numbers I see in my
local gaming store. So it's I feel like
it's something that is universal across
Poland when it comes to the local gaming
stores, which is awesome. Now, in the
future, like are the players that you
are looking forward to playing against
in this in this region or you really
don't care who we're playing against?
Well, um I'm not looking forward to
playing anybody because well they are 9
and0 so they have to be fantastic
players on great decks. Uh but well I'm
ready for any challenge. I think my deck
is very good. Um dare I say the best
deck in format.
>> Oh you think so? That must be
>> I genuinely think so. I think there's a
lot of metal card value as well but I
genuinely think that the deck is
absolutely great. I I like my odds. Uh
so whatever whatever comes next I will
be I'll be facing it with a strong
mindset.
>> Okay. So you said that you think Master
Year is the best deck in the format, but
what do you think? What do you think
about the overall meta game when you
seen it? I'm not sure if you've seen the
numbers like it's 15% Urelia on day one,
13% Draven Draven, then 11% um Kai'Sa
and then it was anything else was
between seven essentially to like 5%
from the top decks. What how is your per
overall perception of the metag game?
>> Uh I think we sort of nailed it in our
predictions, but the metag game is so
open that you cannot really prepare for
a meta game. We believe that Raven and A
really have strong decks that are going
to be at the top tables uh uh both in
day one and day two. Uh we prepare for
those matchups. I think our deck is good
against both of those matchups. Uh so no
surprises there and I like my deck
against them. Uh they're not easy
matches, but they're definitely playable
and with some player skill and a little
bit of luck because that's always what
you need in card games. Uh I think I can
push through them. Uh maybe a little bit
scared of some of the more rogue decks.
I played against an Azir player
yesterday and it was a very difficult
match. A well piloted Azir deck is is
very strong.
>> Yeah, we've seen it yesterday on the
feature matches. When an Azir player
knows what he's doing, the deck is
completely different from like a
mediocre player who's playing the Azir.
But now, one of the last questions I
wanted to ask you, is there a card that
you're specifically happy that you have
in your deck?
>> Yes, that would be Ireelia Fervent. I
think that's the biggest game changer we
have found.
>> That's something new in this meta game,
right? Because Master was typically not
playing it. So, what is the reasoning
here? Uh so Maser is a deck that holds
very well as you may know it's a it's a
deck made for holding and it does very
well as when holding. Um but one thing
it struggled with in the past and you
need to use a lot of resources against
towards is retaking battlefields once
you do get counter conquered and now
Ireelia gives a bre of fresh air to be
able to punch through uh uh big boards
without using as many cards or without
having as perfect of a hand. And I think
that is a uh small upgrade that just
puts a lot of pressure to towards our
opponent. If we open like for instance
going second with a two drop into
Ireelia, there is very few good plays
our opponent can make without losing
their entire hand or their entire run
base to combat that and I can still come
out on top of the map.
>> It's kind of like a ruin runner, but
it's cheaper and it's more proactive,
right?
>> Yes.
>> And um it's super helpful. Correct me if
I'm wrong, but Urelia Fven is probably a
great card against Kaisar. Uh not as
good as Ruin Runner of course, but it's
great against Kai'Sa. It's a pretty
difficult threat to deal with. They have
to use a lot of a lot of runes to beat
her and she's also very difficult to
beat in combat which many people don't
realize. Kai'Sa is a unit deck. That's a
unit deck specifically in a in a spell
trench code.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you very much for
the interview. Congrats on the win. 90
is an insane performance so far and
looking forward to your journey in the
next stage of the tournament. Any last
words from you? Um that's it. Thank you
so much everybody. All right.
Thank you guys. And go back to the
casters.
>> Thanks Lothar. And best deck in format
has been called for the first time
today. Master Ye. What year is it? Are
we still in Origins? Master Ye and
Kaisa. What I This is uh I mean this is
the beauty of the ban list of the
changes that happened cuz it was one
meta very very different meta in uh
Bolognia and Vegas and now we're in a
completely new meta a meta as a lot of
people I mean I've not really heard
anyone say negative things about the
meta at all. It's been a breath of fresh
air I think for a lot of people. The
only thing they don't want to see is a
volley bear.
But I hear there's a bear on the loose
at 900. Well, I mean, I don't know if
they're 9000 yet, but they they were
playing a match right now. So, they
could be 900. So, Vol may not he might
not be out of the woods yet with that
one.
>> Yeah, I do think it may be cursed to say
what your worst matchup is in a winners
interview because you are 100% getting
that. I think that's just how the
tournament gods work.
But uh yeah, so really really crazy
first round of the day. We've still got
so much more today here at RQ Le, but
we're going to throw it over to Barcode
for some content and we'll see you
after.
>> Here with Neo, who made it into day two
with the lux strategy actually with a
record of X2 only two defeats. So you
barely made it but still you are in for
tomorrow. Congratulations first of all.
>> Thank you very much.
>> So tell us a little bit more about your
tournament. How did it go? And I mean
the Lux strategy it wasn't expected to
go today too. So tell us everything.
>> Yeah, obviously Lux uh
uh I didn't come to the tournament
saying I will go I will make day two and
I will win the tournament. It's just
more with my friends. Uh I'm the guy
known to play Lux. the only one to play
L. So I just said, yeah, I have a
different version from the internet
and I will just go for the best of metal
metallic cards and uh I just took the
games round by round and uh it did
pretty well. So
>> yeah, you did actually pretty well
considering the fact that now you're
still in for the top eight. Basically,
if you do perfectly tomorrow, you're
going to be in. So that's actually
insane. You told me something about the
round the round one because there was
something very funny. Tell us a little
bit more about that.
>> Yeah, so round one there are like uh 39
Lux players in in a tournament and so
game one I have a mirror match against
my opponent also called Neo.
So both guy nicknamed Neo both playing
Lux. Uh there was like a 0.2% chance to
have that matchup and so unfortunately I
won I drew the I drew more G kill gears
and
>> I mean
>> and more balance breast and so I won the
token battle.
>> It was fortunately for you.
>> Fortunately for me yeah exactly and I
won the tokens battle.
>> So now you're in for the day two.
Do you have more expectations for the
day two? Do you think that you can just
make it into the top eight or are you
still I mean I'm chilling because I
didn't expect that at first.
>> I'm I mean I'm chilling. I I just made
day two with Lux. I think it's just
already
nice accomplishment.
And of course I expect more meta decks,
top tier decks. My first rounds I played
Ani Master Yi Lux
and and the last round were three
victors and one Kaiser. So obviously I
will play against more and more top
tiers next year.
>> Absolutely. Well anyway wish you the
best of luck for the day two. That was
really cool having a lot in the day two
guys. We're going to be back really
soon.
All right, everyone. I'm with Diggy
right here who just made it into day two
with the gym strategy and a record of
seven and one. Congratulations for that
uh last victory. It was absolutely
insane.
>> So tell us a little bit more about your
tournament. How did it go? Your rounds,
everything, the choice of your deck.
Tell us everything.
So, in general, I didn't have that high
hopes for the Jinx. I've been preparing
for a couple of weeks. You know, ever
since the bands dropped, I had a backup
plan, but it involves scrap heap. I
didn't expect the scrap heap band, so I
had to go back to the drawing board. And
I did like a couple of hours after every
single day of work. And then during the
weekend, I managed to put in like a
couple of full eight hour days. So, this
was my prep going into it. And the deck
that I built like the Jinx, it's
basically I couldn't figure out how to
be driven. So if I have to be honest,
I'm super lucky that I face Jod Draven
today because what I ended up doing is I
sacrificed that match all together in
order to have a good match into Kaisa,
into Victor, into
guess what? That's what I played. It
worked actually. And it worked very very
well for you. So, at first, did you
expect to go into day two or did you
expect to go into top eight or didn't
you expect anything to be honest?
>> Well, it is Jinx. So, I'm not expecting
a top eight. It is a metal hunter uh
legend. That being said, I did win the
best of Jinx in Bologona, so I have a
little bit of experience playing Jinx
against people and
people are like most people don't know
what my deck does. So because of that, I
feel like I'm winning matches that I
should not be winning. And thankfully in
such a huge event, like there's 2,000
people here, probably the biggest aru
ever. When I play somebody, it's very
unlikely that they'll ever meet them
again. So they don't get to carry on
that knowledge. So I think this is like
what besides not getting the biggest one
was people not being familiar with like
this rope deck.
>> I mean, and that's something really
important that you just said, the fact
that your opponents are not ready to
play against your deck is a very very
important factor. So maybe you just uh
took the right decision by taking Jinx.
Are you confident that you can make it
into top eight tomorrow?
>> So top eight is very unlikely in my
opinion. I'll do my best. Like of course
I'll get there but uh I need to lose no
more games. Like X2 is almost impossible
to go. I'm X1 so it is possible for me.
>> Uh but you asked before I forgot to to
answer. I did expect to go today too. Uh
I did expect to go 62. So a little bit
above my own expectations.
And my plan for tomorrow uh besides like
being super like uh confident and saying
I'll just get them all in the gyms. Uh
I'm looking to go with uh two losses. So
just one more loss. Okay, one more loss
and it's fine for you. I mean that's
pretty cool. Anyway, I really loved your
energy and I hope that you're going to
do great tomorrow. But for now, this is
going to be it for the interview. We're
going to let Diggy rest a little bit.
Guys, take it away.
Good morning everyone. Welcome to round
10 of RQ Le James and Loatha taking you
through all of the action. Yeah, we're
into the the the real meat of
determining the top eight of the
tournament. It's not the only thing
that's on the line. Of course, once you
reach, I think it's top 64, right? Is
you get a qualifier for the regionals
way later in the year. We, you know, if
you're already locked for that, you're
like, great, I get to, you know, just
look for some prizes in the rest of the
year. But
>> people forget about it that some people
think like, oh, I'm playing only for the
medal for legend. Some people are
thinking like, I'm playing for the top
eight,
>> but actually playing for the top top 64
qualification is a goal in itself. And
many people just kind of forget about it
existing because,
>> you know, it's still so far ahead.
>> Yes. like that that tournament is not
even announcing.
>> Yeah, exactly. We'll be keeping you up
to date on where we are with regards to
the number of players left in the
tournament. I believe we started today
with 320 players. So, we're still a few
few rounds away from determining that
top 64 and then top eight. Uh we are
still, I would say, in the Metal Hunter
rounds, I think, is one way of putting
it of we have a couple of decks left
that there's only a handful of different
players playing and that's what we're
going to try and bring to you when the
round is ready. We are still in the
middle of getting all of the pairings
sorted. Of course, uh 320 players got to
finish all those games.
>> Just think about it this way. 320
players on day two is essentially like a
really big tournament in itself. Like if
you do like an tournament in one country
like just going to be all people from
coming from that one country. There's
probably 300 people coming to one place.
>> In order to enter that tournament, you
have to win another tournament the day
before. So you already have
>> Yeah, exactly. kind of crazy when you
think about it that way. You know, so
many people competed in day one. It's a
feat in itself to be in day two. That's
at least my perception. And many people
can also maybe will downplay a little
bit, but getting a qualification for day
two, you should be proud about it. If
it's your like first card game ever and
you're in day two,
>> you did fantastic.
>> Yeah, exactly. I was speaking with uh
Marshall from Riftman Report, one of our
feature players as well.
>> Is he in day two?
>> Sadly not, but was really like on the
cusp of making it. I think it was like
52 and1 was his score which you're like
you that's already impressive against
the players in this room. Um a lot of
players think that they they would be
able to like yeah I'll make day two easy
and then they come here and you you know
you match up against like you sit down
and Allen is the other side of the
table. You're like oh okay that's that's
a rough match up for me.
>> Um I think that's that's one thing that
I think a lot of players that I speak to
underestimate. They're like wow imagine
the best players at your skirmish and
it's a room full of them. like everybody
here is to that level.
>> Typically, when you think about a local
gaming store, you probably have like
three, maybe four people of a caliber
where
>> they're like trying to win a skirmish or
something, you know, or like will be
able to win a skirmish. And now you're
going into round nine and every single
one of those players will be that kind
of caliber player. But then you have
Yeah. Yeah, but also from that caliber
of players, you will have the next
echelon because there's a big gap in
knowledge between the top top players
and between like the top let's say
middle of the bunch players.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> Like there there's a big skill gap and
it's not very visible. And that's the
thing about card games in general. A lot
of its skill is not visible. It's
something that is hidden behind the
information of like in someone's head
because he's planning with in the inside
of his own deck building his uh thought
process and so on. So you have to
analyze the entire decision making
during entire game and not just see like
110 turn oh this is the reason why this
person won
>> and we and you know those of you
watching at home in chat have it uh as
easy as it can be with the amount of
information you have in a game. We
obviously have both uh sides of the
table. we have good uh understanding and
we're not the ones making the decision
in that moment. I think players
underestimate that when you are sat in a
high pressure environment and and that's
even just on the floor before you get to
a featured match. When you're in that
high pressure,
>> you will make basic mistakes that you
would not normally make in a practice
game or something like that. You just
think, "Oh, you know what? I know it.
I've done it a million times." I will
tell you that on stage the two most
common scenarios that I see when people
are not fully accustomed to being like
in front of a camera is either playing
way way slower
>> Yeah.
>> and they are like really making every
decision like they think about every
decision like 10 times more than they
would normally think or they play way
too fast.
>> Yes.
>> And then they make a decision and they
didn't think it through and they're like
suddenly, oh no, I made a mistake. It's
a blunder. What to do now? And then they
go and slow it down again. Well, and
it's always like a mistake you'd never
make. Like something that is so like uh
just ingrained. Um it's one of the
things that that you know competing at
anything at the highest level is is so
underestimated in the amount of work
that it takes uh to get things together.
But we're getting together towards round
10. A couple minutes left to go. Let's
go over to Barcode to take the
temperature of the room here at Le.
Thank you guys. And yeah, actually I've
got some good news from you from the top
tables. I've been there and I've got a
lot of insight especially about the
players and as you know we are about to
get to top eight very very soon. The
pressure is here and some players might
have a little bit too much pressure on
their on their shoulders. Sorry. A lot
of players are just getting excited
about it. And I've heard about one
player who, for example, forgot to uh
get a point from the Arena's greatest.
And sometimes, you know, he's a bit
difficult. It's a bit hard. He loves the
game thanks to it. But it is what it is.
He's got to move on because he's got the
round 10 real soon. And he's still
probably in for the top eight. From now
on, no mistakes can be made. Will the
round 10 be without mistakes? That is
the question. But for now, we're going
to go back to the casters.
>> Thank you very much, Barcode. Uh the
music choice on that was great when he
was like, "Breaking news."
>> I was waiting for Janna to just like
swoop in. Forecasted. No, that's
>> love love that skin. Great skin. I I
have some breaking news as well. And I'm
sorry to be the one to I have two
pieces. Sorry to be the one to break
this to Blame uh to Amy and Bleven, who
I'm now calling Blamey apparently.
Blamy. Um, of course we were looking at
a volley bear going into uh our first
round of the day today.
>> Mhm.
>> I saw from Twitter that they drew up
against um a content creator and then
essentially as soon as volleyball I
learned they had best of volley. They're
like I'm out. I'm I'm like it's okay.
I'm I'm going from this. So not exactly
what we were hoping for from that one.
The other one that I believe I will get
confirmation of this. I think one of our
featured players as we take a look at
the standings. I believe Randy
unfortunately has picked up a third loss
on the way uh through day two. We'll get
that confirmed for sure as we are
looking at the top 32 of the tournament.
>> I see.
>> Look at this. We have animation model on
8 and1 who was yesterday on stream. If
you were listening to our pre-show, I
mentioned Yhosera who is currently
playing Ezreal. He's 8 and1. I would
really love to cast his game like I am
fully expecting something really weird
in his deck list. I'm looking forward to
that. Rock was yesterday on stream as
well with the Azir. Aiden won Juvani.
Both of those both of those players on
Azir next to each other in the standings
team. But this is looking really spicy.
I love it.
>> Yeah, very uh very Okay, sorry. There
was a guy called Arbus on the bottom
that is angry watermelon.
>> Oh, okay. Wow.
>> In Polish. It was just funny. Fair
enough. Uh my Polish is not good. I will
not try. I can believe you.
That's ah that's shady. Uh so looking at
the our current top 16 now. A couple of
players still at five players at 9 and
zero. Uh Vins still undefeated.
Technically that draw does not count as
being defeated. That's always something
to keep in mind. So six players so far
yet to drop a series. Uh and a good mix
once again. There's an Ezreal
>> play undefeated. I mean sorry. Okay. If
you count the draw, it's not. But if
it's nine zeros, it's five different
levels.
>> Yeah, five different nine zeros. That is
uh very very impressive so far. We got
another Ezreal in there. There's a Rex
side just outside with Excio who we of
course saw yesterday on our our final uh
full feature match of the day. So, you
know, it it's been such an interesting
meta. I think you know, you were talking
with uh some of our players earlier
about how wide the meta is and how well
placed certain decks are. I think that's
such a key point uh as we go through day
two is like we still have no one
individual deck that is like blowing
everybody out of the water.
>> Yeah. And I'm very happy to see this.
There's two things because one thing can
happen when the game has such a wide
metag game that you can't really prepare
for everything. One of the problems in
that kind of metag game is that it
becomes a little bit too extreme and you
will have like some unplayable matchups.
What we have currently is like a wide
open meta and there's basically maybe
like one deck out of 28 different uh
legends that you will have like an 80/20
matchup for example but the everything
else is going to be playable which is
awesome because that means you can sit
down against almost anyone and still
play your game and you're not thinking
like oh I'm such a huge disadvantage you
know in this matchup which is one of the
like feels bad moment when when um when
you play a card game and here like we
The top three decks, Urelia, Draven,
Kai'Sa, all have really decent matchups
in almost everyone. Maybe Kaisen into
Urelia is not the best, but there are
for that as well, right? And then like
for example, Victor, I know he's a
little bit under the 50% win rate, but
he can have a game into everything as
well, you know? Uh, and then Rexi
similar like can play against almost
everything. every single deck that you
will see here in this top that we're
going to be playing now is not going to
be a free win for any
>> exactly. And I think it's it's really
important um just to look back at day
one rather than perhaps day two cuz I
think this is more where it applies for
what your deck selection maybe you're
planning on being utre and thinking okay
what do I do to try and qualify for for
day two. Um when we look at statistics
of decks and matchups and we say like
something's an 80/20 that is very much
like a big pool of numbers um and on
paper yes okay one deck should be very
strong. You still have to play that game
out. It still comes down to the players
the decisions in the game. Um and
eventually you know we'll get to a point
where uh the best players can just win a
bad matchup with with the right kind of
setup. So
>> 8020 is not unwinable.
>> Exactly. There's a 20 there and might be
cope. It might be cope to say you can
make it. But we're going to look at some
metal card hunters right now. As I say
metal card to be honest at this point.
Eight and one on set.
>> Yeah, bro. He's doing fantastic.
>> Exactly. I'm I'm being shady back.
>> All right, let's take a look at this
deck list. We have Tomino here with the
set the boss. Any particular choices
that in this um deck are okay. Well,
there were dragons there. I s dragon I
think is what it's called
>> and that's an very expensive card for
sets to be considering because sets
typically don't get to seven energy very
often. But let's take a look at this
irred as well. No siren in this build
which is one of the marks that we have
to pay attention to because that's
typically would play like either three
boots or two boots and a siren. Yeah. Um
then other win condition over here is
also the Draven which is uh Draven
Audacious sorry the big Draven as you
call him. Um, it's something that I see
a lot of players actually just kind of
distance themselves typically because it
is a liability in some games and it it
is um a very risky play and many people
trying to like mitigate that risk by
playing a secondary Urelia for example
and do it that way. But at the same
time, it's not a bad decision to have it
>> in the deck. You just play a little bit
differently because you have an option
to win the game
>> by having the Draven Audacious. I think
it's worth us coming into this matchup
uh talking a little bit about some of
the changes uh that were made in the
recent Aratas and FAQs. Um specifically
Monastery of Herana with Set. You used
to be able to layer it to get the draw
off the buff by conquering Set. I'm
pretty sure it has now changed that you
no longer have that option. set has to
already have a buff upon conquering in
order to spend the buff to draw a card.
>> Yes, that is correct. The the the reason
for that is to put an item on the chain,
you will have to satisfy the um the
requirement for it. Yes. So to put the
monastery of hyana effect on the chain,
you have to spend the buff. If you
didn't have it before concurring, well,
you cannot do that anymore. So, this
makes um potentially like Warmog's armor
way less efficient. But the thing is set
doesn't really care that much because
your set roller has a buff by being
played. So, he can still do this. He can
still go in um concur and spend his buff
that you already had and draw a card and
then get new one because he's getting us
a buff when he is um
>> That's what I was going to say. you
still get it right after the puncture
because you you spend it first and then
you'll get the new one back. I wonder I
think this is a very minor thing as we
do uh see the first couple of units
coming out of the game. We mentioned Fay
Dragon in the list. Of course, that is a
big unit that you said is difficult to
spend. Uh one of the effects is when it
when you play it uh buff up to four
friendly units. I don't think that that
is specifically in response to that, but
it never is going to hurt buffing things
in a set.
>> I've never seen this card actually buff
more than two units.
>> That's so fair. Yeah. So it's basic just
reads like give one or two buffs um in
most cases. But the thing is in Korean
metag game having a seven might is also
pretty important. Guess
>> why?
>> Because of a something that cost six
energy and one red.
>> Ah yeah ferris four.
>> So it goes over it without spending any
cards or like forces interaction from
your opponents. Right. The thing is
though with a typical set deck, you are
not often going to that area where they
have seven energy because the deck is
just so aggressive at spending its runes
to save their units because of the set's
boss power, which is basically like a
zonas or guardian angel on your legend
built in, which is incredibly powerful
by the way, but it has a cost. And well
for for this reason when you play the
dragon for seven you want to also have
bon shivers because bon shivers then are
trying to make up for the loss of energy
the people have in this deck.
>> Yeah that is uh something we'll keep a
track of throughout the game. That is
set being played uh already as well. So
both chosen champions are out
>> and the Ulia is being pre-equipped with
the guardian angel to make sure that she
doesn't get caught by a challenge. Yes,
such a key matchup. Uh such a key card
in a matchup like this where like
Ireelia has to stay alive. So that
challenge is going to be uh you know
brutal if it ever does catch an Aurelia
unguardian angel.
>> But there comes action.
>> No, never mind. I thought it's action.
>> That's funny looking action.
>> Saw it in its hand in Tobino's hand. And
it's one of the key also cards in this
matchup.
>> Yeah. for specifically the GA or boots
because that's one of those key moments
where feels safe.
>> Yes.
>> And then action comes in, swoops in,
mocks her of of the boots for example or
the GA and suddenly she is out in the
open without much help specifically for
the G. Right. So that's one of the one
of the key moments that we're going to
have in this game where action will come
into the play and affect the board state
when Aurelia will be on the battlefield.
>> And that's always one of the most
difficult things about playing around
set already is how do I kill your units
enough times to actually kill them. They
keep coming back. There is always a way
to keep them alive. So, stealing your
opponent's guardian angel, which is a
card obviously that is not normally uh
available to set as it is outside of the
domain profile uh for set as a legend.
So, Aurelia goes in, looks to conquer
and get the draw of
>> that was a stack deck.
>> H stack deck as well. Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> Let's see the decision over here. We are
spending the uh boots to attach and
untap it and most likely double conquer
or we going to base depending on how the
player feels
when it comes to his hand size hand
amount of uh sorry the amount of buffs
that he has in the hand and also the
fact that he has the G.
>> So in this matchup are you trying to
bring Aurelia back to base as much as
possible so that the context
>> it's really context dependent. Okay,
>> it's it's hard to say what is the
current best play without seeing like
how many units the opponent has, what is
my hand, how many buffs do I have, am I
like hand tripping any cards, all of
that is an actual uh decision m making
it has an effect on your decision-
making because so many factors have to
be taken into consideration
>> and from from my perspective on this
matchup which uh again I'm not a set
player it feels like set has like big
power spikes with regards to like uh a
punch first or using the buff that set
has to to jump really high with one
resource in order to to get high might.
Whereas Aurelia is like, "Okay, I'll
I'll on guard or I I'll discipline and
I'll do little bits but lots of them in
order to see a lot of cards, buff up my
Aurelia." So, I I'm interested to see
how that plays out. There is the Action
you called on the previous turn and now
this is an Aurelia potentially uh you
know in
>> so fast. That is so important and and in
case of set you cannot really repost
that even when you're in the colors only
something that Fiora can do.
>> Yeah, not a signature spell. And for
those of you that perhaps are not
familiar with this interaction um not so
fast also counter syncs at targeted
gear. So it's really important at that
point that Axan can uh can get denied
allows to stay in
>> crucial moment of the game. If that not
so fast wasn't here would have been out
in the open
>> and yeah that is a big big big moment.
Not I don't think it does a second
action in the hand right now. So
>> yeah, doesn't doesn't look like it.
We'll take another look. Uh commonly of
course we see not so fast used against
spells, but of course does affect
abilities too. So
>> it will come up next expansion a lot
when elder dragon for example comes into
game and he starts you know just
>> spitting fire on your units. I think
it's fire. No,
>> but does elder this is not important for
this game and we don't look at all of
the previews in in enough detail. Does
Elder Dragon target?
>> It does.
>> It does. Okay. Oh, cuz it's three. It's
one from each one per per location.
>> Yes, you're right. I just assumed it
comes in and nukes everything. That's I
was like, this card's broken,
>> bro. Stop it. Like,
>> don't put enough already.
>> Don't design cards based on me. Uh,
Aurelia going to move across to using
the boots of swiftness. Uh, this is why
I don't read the cards until we're
actually coming into cast the
tournament. I don't know what's
happening in Unleashed, but Spirit
Forged I'm I'm pretty good on still as
that is a clutch of cards for Urelia.
Um, we saw divine dance in hand, saw an
ong guard, discipline, everything you
could need to to try and turn a combat
back in your favor.
>> Yeah. And now because Tomino lost one of
those outs to try to battle the the
Aelia, he needs to find another scenario
where he will be able to
achieve two goals. one, get the pumps
out of his opponent's uh hand as soon as
possible to get into a more comfortable
position into the late game, and two,
find a way of affecting the Urelia when
she's in base after the recall from the
guardian angel. Now, without the action,
we have to go and fight through the
buffs first. So, essentially, there are
like three potential like scenarios that
have to align for the set to have a good
outcome for him, which is not easy to
achieve. And I'll be honest with you,
I'm not even going to try to predict
because there's so many interactions
>> from both sides here. Like it's hard to
calculate this because you have to take
into context of the tells that the
opponent is doing with how he plays his
hand, how he plays uh the previous
turns. And we'll see. Oh, that's dude. I
said what I said about the dragon that I
never seen it four units.
>> It is happening though.
>> It's literally happening now. Four
buffs.
>> They got to the
>> Oh, we're reading the card. It does
explain the card, but but you know, we
we talked a little bit about playing in
a featured match area. This this is a
moment where three units. I lied.
>> Oh, okay. Well, I'm I'm sure Tats um
>> Well, actually, we could have spent the
buff before doing it
>> to buff up set to eight if you're going
in. Um Tats clearly I'm sure knows what
Fay Dragon does, but at this moment,
it's a card you're not used to seeing.
You want to get the exact wording
correct on this card before you let it
enter and do things just to be sure what
was coming next. You're right though.
There was perhaps
>> a little it ends up buffing itself,
right? Uh let me just double check. It's
plus four.
>> Um so it could have been um it could
have been a very effective way of
getting the set to 12 potentially.
>> But now uh Oh, you mean the her you mean
the dragon? No, no, it it can it can
target fog units overall. And now it's
also a very interesting interaction
because that's not always something you
see. Hana can actually spend a buff that
is not on the unit that is concurring
it.
>> Oh yeah, of course. Of course. So I
think they did. Yeah, just getting
everything buffed utilizing as much as
possible from this turn. Um, so we do
see the fade dragon come out. That's
clearly one of the reasons. And you
know, we had wondered whether the the
changes to buffs and stuff would uh
would affect set in a negative way that
I think people were discussing whether
how huge that was. Overall, I think he's
an a winner in this meta game because
the lack of f fight or flight um is one
of those cards that
>> actually made the game almost
unplayable.
>> Yeah, fair for set because he cannot
commit to any fights when there's a
fight of flight potentially coming to
his head.
>> And he has you telegraph everything when
he says, "Okay, I'll spend the buff
first before I do it." Oh, gogglucky.
Go back to base.
Very true. Is that six points for Tats
already in this game? Um will Ready and
will that be Urelia coming back to base?
Looking at what we have. Yeah, that's
going to be Aurelia coming safety. And
now we're down to how many challenges,
how many ways of removing this Aurelia
are possible or is the game plan for
Tamino? I just have to weather this
storm on the next turn. Put the fade
dragon on one battlefield.
>> Try and get just as much might as I can.
>> It is a little bit awkward, not going to
lie. It's Tats is at six points. There
were like what two showdowns in this
game so far.
>> Yeah, not a not a whole lot of combat.
And I think that's a rebuke right in the
back of uh of Tat's hands.
>> Yeah, that that cut still exists.
>> That exists and that will deal.
>> Fire of flight was a problem because
it's also reaction speed, right? been
hidden, but rebuke is still an issue. In
the next set, there's a card that will
repulse the rebuke, but it's not
something that we have currently. So, a
set would need to find a different way
of playing around it, and that's
>> possible by having sabotage.
>> So, yeah, Tats is a little bit
vulnerable potential to a sabotage.
Didn't I I can't quite remember whether
there's a defy in hand. Um, I think
there's at least one challenge there for
for Tamino, but Tats is Tats has to use
the economy, the four runes available
wisely here because a rebuke is going to
be costly. It's going to be half of the
the uh the economy that is available for
this turn.
>> Set spends the buff, moves into the
battlefield, is going to not contest
this one. There's of course no point,
nothing to do for Aelia. This is about
just getting to the next turn with this
Aurelia intact.
>> Yeah. and then ganking both battlefields
and finishing up the game. So
>> Erdia is going to have 479
energy to untap and play all of the
buffs and try to finish up the game.
It's not going to be easy for set to set
up defenses and now uh Tomino will going
to have to figure out okay how do I set
up my defenses? Do I play all units on
one battlefield but then do I just lose
to a potential hold from Urelia? Is that
is that effective? Do I have a way of
affecting the Urelia when she goes to
the first battlefield or should I just
maybe evenly spread out the might? Those
are like really important questions that
a play that a player will be able to
probably plan when you're playing the
game and you have all the information of
what you have in your hand and what you
track in your opponent's hand. But it's
it's a very complex board set right now.
When you're watching this game, you're
probably not thinking it's that complex,
but trust me, it is incredibly complex.
How do you figure out this puzzle over
here?
>> And there are a few lines that get blown
out really badly here as well. There's
like a death grip in hand for Tamino. If
that death grip goes off first before
the rebuke, that is like backbreaking in
a turn. If you say, "Okay, well, I'll
kill one unit and then send everything
in." Obviously, I don't think that is
likely to be the one. Here comes the
challenge. It will be defitop. move it
somewhere else just to get the buff.
That is probably not worth it. But the
game is coming to an end,
>> right? It's it's most likely going to be
decided in the next turn or two on who's
going to win this.
>> Yeah. Is
>> And there's the hidden blade
>> potentially,
>> which
the unhidden blade, the more hidden than
normal hidden blade by being in hand. Uh
that potentially does slow down Aelia.
Uh, as you said, there is a showstopper
available if you want to move the set
over to this other battlefield as well
on its own here. You probably have to
spend a lot to keep it alive. Um, so it
seems like we have a stack on one side
and then we're probably going to be
sacrif uh sacrificing the set from the
other battlefield first. We'll see. The
plan might be now it it all really
depends on how the will play this round.
Yeah,
>> because the thing is Seth is not winning
>> unless he's double holding or like
conquering and holding a technical turn.
>> I feel like charm makes this really
difficult as well because you can
already you can already assume you're
going to clear this first battlefield
with set and then you can pull something
over and soften up that second
battlefield.
>> So you have charm and rebuke which is
basically just canceling two units.
Yeah, exactly. Then you've got defy and
dance on
>> charm to base. I don't think you need to
in this. I think this one you just crush
him. Um, so yeah, as you said, remove
two units and then you can soften up the
other battlefield. Pump up Aelia. I I I
think this is a really tough spot to be
in for Tamino. Does have a punch first,
but again, it's down to sequencing of
like punch first is action speed. You
let that fully resolve, then you rebuke
or however it goes. Let's take a look at
which direction Tats is going to go on
this on guard first.
>> Yeah.
>> In the showdown,
>> we also on untapping. So, we're going to
be able to then pay one more energy to
untap the legend if necessary to even
buff it even more in the future because
we're probably just going to do
everything if the plan is for Taz
because maybe it's different. I don't
know. But if he's going to try to gank
now, and I probably think he will,
you're going to try to absolutely minmax
the amount of might that you can get to
the Aelia.
>> Yeah. Did we Is there an answer to the
hidden blade? I I didn't quite see it in
hand. There is a defy there, right? That
is in Yeah. Okay.
>> Another defy. Yes.
>> That's That's huge. I think if this
hidden blade goes off, it slows Aelia
down a little bit because as you said,
there's no untap on the the the Aurelia.
It would be exhausted at that point. So,
>> correct. If this would actually go
through, then the Aurelia would be back
and it would be a double hold for
Tamino. So, actually without that Defy,
there was a line for Tamino to close
this game out. It's kind of funny when
when you think about it this way.
>> Yeah, two defies, the challenge and the
uh and yeah, this hidden blade as well.
Really impactful defies coming through.
Here's the charm.
>> Charm to the sunken temple. Get over
here for the fay dragon. This Aelia is
already big enough to be a dragon slayer
right now. And uh
>> I actually think it's the base.
>> Oh, it is the base.
>> Yeah,
>> cuz now we could be to be honest with
you. It doesn't matter. Yeah. But yeah,
but
>> it's it's driving the line. Okay. Yeah,
it's the base. We're not We're not See,
you've done it again.
>> Yeah.
>> I will say that's not supremely clear,
but uh in base, but it's okay. I think
the result is the same regardless.
>> Yeah. 12 to 11. Uh now, let's see.
There's one punch first in hand from
what I remember and not much else. The
fine dance is going to do essentially a
plus punch first in
>> Yeah, when you think about it. Yes.
>> A little bit more flexible.
>> Yeah, basically the same. Still one of I
think the strongest
>> spells from
the map.
>> It's just a little unassuming one. Put
the dice on. They're going away very
very quickly. Fold it all pays the
deflect cost as well. Rebuke back to
hand means Aurelia should clear through
this battlefield. fist bump comes out
and that is going to be game one
>> from Tat still close you know this is it
easily shows us how Tamino has made it
to 8 and one on set because that was
quite an imposing board state and if you
didn't have exactly two defies
>> if there was another hidden blade
>> or another challenge or anything like
that
>> could have been I mean challenge
probably not because there would still
be like a define dance and respond
>> true probably make it very hard to break
the Aurelia to recall to face and
exhaust that. But if there was a second
hidden blade, the game would have been
over and instead would have just taken
it very from a very unassuming position
by the way because
>> and I wanted to reiterate what I said
like 5 minutes ago when this turn
essentially kind of started for both
players or maybe even longer than that.
The board state was incredibly complex
to finish this game. It might have not
looked like that, but it was. Now let's
take a look at Tomino's sideboard. We
have potentially sabotage, cool the
week, hidden blade, salvage, and action.
Are we
>> and maybe call the glory. Those are
there's like six cards that you can
consider sideboarding in. We don't know.
Not sure certain going to what is going
to come in.
>> A card that we do not see very often in
competitive marching orders. So that is
essentially challenge that can be
repeated. Uh choose a friendly unit
anywhere and an enemy unit at a
battlefield. So there's a little bit of
limitation. They deal damage equal to
their might to each other. Yeah. The
problem you can repeat is that it's also
>> weak to defy.
>> Yeah. Uh yeah, cuz it's still defiable.
Oh, if you repeat that. Oh, that's
painful.
>> Yeah. You don't want to you don't want
to
>> defy. Not so fast. Like there's a lot of
things that that can can stop that. So
coming in against Yeah. Maybe not
against green. Maybe not against uh
that's one way you look at it and you're
like, "Ah, that could help." And then
you think about it for any amount of
time and you're like, "Ooh, I get blown
out really quick." I saw cool the week
being sided in which is okay because the
thing is though against most the cool
the week is not really that strong
anymore. Sure
>> because there's a lot of two drops being
played in as well.
>> But at the same time it's just good to
have it because you most likely force
your opponent to play around the cool.
>> But even if you have it at some point
they're going to stop playing around it
because they're going to be forced into
a position where those two drops
probably have to take a fight. And then
sideboarding on Aelia. Are you looking
at taking out two drops at any point? Is
that one of the areas you go or do you
have to go somewhere else?
>> That's a very good question. I'm not an
expert when it comes to playing Urelia
and I feel like I might I might be just
saying some stuff that is not correct.
>> Don't worry. I feel like that for myself
a lot.
>> In many decks when you're going second
because you won the first game, you are
sighting out some of the two drops
because you're starting potentially at
three. So you can have like a different
kind of mindset of what you want to play
on turn one and maybe you just have more
free drops and that will essentially
take the spot of the two drops.
>> But when you typically play against
yellow, I would not do that.
>> Okay? Because the week is really an
incredibly powerful card and it it it is
something that affects the board state
very early on as well. So if you ever
played like a Kai'Sa or Draven and
you're like hm
>> do I obisk of power my Draven on turn
one and just die to gold to week.
>> Yeah.
>> Answer is probably no.
>> So uh you want to avoid those
situations, right? So you want to have
those cheaper units as well.
>> Yeah. Especially now with uh as a
reminder obliska power for those of you
constructing your decks not a legal card
in in the current game. So those choices
are gone. Um, I think that's a really
interesting conversation around like
sometimes you're sideboarding uh for
game two and game three depending on
what the result was of the previous
games can be different where you're like
sometimes you slide back in cards from
your winning game one in game three,
right? It's like I won game one so now I
know I'm going second but now I need the
good stuff for the early game back in
when I eventually make the end up with
the series one and one. Obviously,
you're trying to close out a game two
and zero, but uh that that's not always
how it goes. There is an advantage to
going first. There there is generally
that favorability of why players will do
it. Um so, can't really overlook that in
the way that you're sideboarding.
>> All right. Well, it's an interesting
match so far. I love watching. By the
way, never have we did we even have a
single activation offset the boss?
>> There was one. It was uh one played to
go to six. It wasn't for a showdown. I
think it was just in order to use it. Um
and I think that yeah,
>> I'm not sure exactly why. Maybe there
was like afraid of some way of of
surprise defender or something like
that. But uh nevertheless, I think we
got one. It wasn't particularly
impactful on its own.
>> Oh, there's Lucian. That's going to be
helpful. Never mind. He's going down.
>> He's out of here. He's like, "Nah, get
out of here." Fade dragon.
>> Two challenges. Oh, okay.
>> We talked about how maybe it would be
influential and I mean we are in a
situation where soia
here can go GA and then equip it to
Aurelia on the following turn, right? So
you you go GA turn one or your turn one
on on three and then maybe I'm mistaken.
I'm going to see what happens.
It is definitely a play like G turn one
when you're going second and then Urelia
turn two attach G immediately
>> when you're playing around for example
um challenge hey that's us but the thing
is when you do that
>> judge call okay so we're going to be uh
we're going to be waiting a little bit
for that but let's speak about the
potential like if you go GA into Ireelia
like that then you are kind of weak to
some combos okay
>> by combos I'm not saying like combo
combo synergy, but like by just having
multiple cards like for example call the
week into challenge
>> after like you have some unit there that
requires a really deep board step or
like double cool the week and so on.
You're still like a little bit open. So
in general, I would say like if
possible, Ireelia will probably play a
two drop instead of the G on turn one
anyway,
>> which is exactly exactly what we're
seeing uh in in this scenario is uh will
come through with a Titan
>> and we're playing to nine
>> in this particular game. Aspirine's
climbing a battlefield chosen by Tats.
Do you think he has any tats?
>> I don't see any. Um, so I guess that's
what they call work safe is when they're
>> correct
>> under the under the shirt line or you
know anywhere else. Um, I've seen a lot
of uh, you know, spells in hand for
tats. I'm looking for any other units. I
think I saw a rebuke in there. Not so
fast to find Dance. Of course, you have
Aelia from the chosen champion zone.
>> Um,
>> what is very important is that there's
not a single yellow color in Tomino's
resources right now. So when you think
about it, Taz doesn't have to play
around some of the cards like for
example, hidden blade cool an option
this turn as well. So you have a little
bit of information, but next turn
there's definitely going to be at least
one yellow.
>> Now we're going to start by playing a
rookie that's going to buff our pit um
pit crew and that is going to be not pit
crew first mate.
>> Yeah,
>> I don't know why I said pit crew. Uh
that is a card but you know I always
think it's the same like within the same
uh group of cards I think about I do the
same don't worry.
>> So four might to formite. We have a draw
currently. Now let's see if Tomino is
trying to win this combat. Winning this
combat will also mean that you're
drawing a card because seat of power is
in play.
>> But it's fade dragon and two challenges
in hand. There comes an on guard as
well. So that is going to hold. That's
>> two cards used. It's actually not bad
even if you lose this because remember
we can just recall this unit to base
with this set.
>> This essentially means we sacrificed a
one energy and one
that's it. You sacrifice one energy for
two cards from your opponent which one
was tricked.
>> But still an okay I would say um
exchange for the set. We could consider
this a small win.
>> And this is going to be like a death of
of a thousand cuts. Yeah, and I I think
this scenario that you're you're talking
about as well is changed slightly where
Urelia with Stellinorn Herder draws a
ton of cards. Ireelia with discipline in
hand draws extra cards, which we've seen
one already, but it's a lonely parro, no
Stellicorn Herder. So, it is slightly
lower uh cards seen for Aurelia for the
next couple of turns than you might
expect. It's not that detrimental, but
every time you get that extra spell,
it's consider
a little bit because of the aspirines
climb, but I feel like one of the win
conditions for Tomino could be playing
for the long game and just like kind of
going for the attrition battle.
>> Um, I'm not sure how feasible that will
be.
>> Fade.
>> If Tat will draw the Stellacon herder,
we'll see. You said it buffs up like two
normally and both times we see it.
>> Don't listen to what I'm saying. It's
the second time we see it four.
>> I believe you though because there's a
difference between seeing set playing
fade dragon or fay dragon in general at
other tournaments and then seeing it
when you're eight and one. Uh there's a
reason.
>> It's not even that. I think I think this
is just this particular matchup.
>> I'm trying to save you here.
>> Yeah. Okay. I'm trying to save myself as
well. I feel like it's just a very slow
matchup right now being played in both
games.
>> That's very true. That is very true. but
getting the maximum amount of buffs
coming through uh from the Cedar Power
as well. So, we'll get that.
>> It's kind of crazy when you think about
it. This is like 11 might.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's it's a lot added to the
board. And yeah, Cedar Power because it
was under the the when conquered there
was control of aspirants climb. So,
we'll get the benefit from that. Uh
basically fully buffed up as well from
that fade dragon. So, really strong base
line here. And this is the difference in
the meta that we've seen. Urelia very
strong typically is a single unit with a
lot of support from from cards from hand
and equipment whereas we've seen now set
but Rexi and Victor and Azia go wide and
present really big boards uh from
multiple units.
>> Yep. Correct. So a lot of puzzles over
here. We're going to There's
Okay,
>> that'll fix a little bit of the card
draw
>> potentially. Yes. Um there's going to be
another puzzle for to solve like how
does this unit not die? Yeah, because it
will probably be targeted now
>> by the challenge. So, fortunately for
Taz, he still has a lot of energy open.
One for defy, two for not so fast in
case like two removals.
>> And we're in a moment. You mentioned
about challenge, which obviously it's a
it's a very valid target to attack the
the hand.
>> Is the Aurelia also like which you can
>> there's arguments for both. Is there a
consideration that one is a better
target than the other with challenge of
do you want to take out the right
context? I would say again we have to
look at how many cards does stats have
>> and how many energy does he have open
like let's say we're currently let's
just imagine I'm not certain if this is
the case but I think Tomino might have
two challenges in his hand if we double
challenge the Urelia we're going to have
to pay double deflect and if both of
those get countered how much do we lose
on tempo
>> that's a blowout yeah right but the
Stellacon herder is also a valid target
and your opponent will probably use the
counter spells for that anyway
>> yeah and if you get the defy out of and
and then you get another challenge and
get the kill anyway. You're you're again
fine giving over your runes for now to
stop them drawing.
>> Yeah. So, it's a safer choice to choose
the silicon herder, but we'll see. Yeah,
>> that's exactly the choice that you're
saying. And I think there's a not so
fast in hand as well.
>> And the not so fast is being chosen
because it's more convenient to use it
now instead of like for example, you're
not going to be able to not so fast a
death grip, but you're going to be able
to define a death grip. So cat uses here
the not so fast because it has less
scenarios in which it can be played. So
you want to use it a little bit more
often and also remember that defy
actually cost you more energy so it's
going to be easier to squeeze it in.
>> Yeah, that is a very fair point as we
continue on through the turn of Tamino.
So notice he got one of the cards out of
hand to stop. So a set brawler is going
to come in will get buffed and that is a
pass of the turn. So Stellorn Herder is
going to at least get to move, you'd
imagine, to the seed of power. Um, so
we'll get one draw. Um, so already Tess
is like, fine, I got something from
this.
>> Draws into a draw. Was it?
>> That was a discipline, I think, wasn't
it?
>> It was like very confusing card for What
is this?
>> Let's see if we can get a sight. I was
going to say Lonely Power also needs to
unfortunately hit the trash in order to
get the card.
>> It's a sad borrow now. Okay, so it's a
Vex, right?
>> Oh, it's a Vex. Vex. Okay. Uh, it
>> Vex Cheless, which is a very powerful
card. How much would you have to pay for
punch first if Vex is in the fight?
>> A lot. A lot.
>> Yeah. Two energy and three power.
>> But does it affect too much of the rest
of set? I feel like Yeah, there are some
other abilities that other spells that
are in there. So, Vex is going to get
played. Um,
>> and a not so fast as you mentioned. Not
so fast rebuke. That is a nasty
>> two.
That is a nasty nasty hand. So, Defiant
Dance going to come through. Okay, we're
This is the turn where you're turning
the dial up because you're like, if I
can get into this combat potentially get
all of my spells for for low cost like
Rebuke some suddenly becomes a lot more
cost effective in these scenarios. if
you can wipe out as much of this board
state as possible.
>> I'm not certain what is the plan here
for Tats. So I'm curiously awaiting the
resolution of this combat. Okay. So just
going to say no
>> just this just just set the boss. But
essentially here we're sacrificing
>> the dance for basically a buff,
>> right? because set is saving the unit
and now the the dance and vex will
probably be a target of an attack. So
the reason why I'm a little bit not
certain about how is this worth I I
would consider this a small win again
for Tomino because now he's able to push
go into like seven or eight and and have
a win condition for the next 10 while
the irrelia is still far away from
winning. Is it I I don't know the answer
to this just to to give more context
around the game. Is it perhaps also
about one thing towards getting to five
so that you can then irrelia double
battlefield as often as possible and
like
four
>> true that's actually really really true
cuz I I was just looking at like four
going to nine is a really big climb.
That's three turns worth of point
scoring. Yeah,
>> I don't think that's the main,
>> but the thing is like I'll be honest
with you, I think this is not a good
board state forelia anyway.
>> No, you're totally right.
>> Sometimes you just have to do plays that
just are not the best. They're
suboptimal, but you have no other
choice. It feels like this might be one
of those kind of situations over here.
There's the not so fast,
>> not so fast.
>> Yeah. And this is one of these things we
talked yesterday about. Sometimes you
can be in the tank as a player or as a
commentator looking at one line of
things and and not quite have the the
full picture that we're looking at. So
definitely from Tat's perspective, as
you said, he's playing up against a
giant board state may very well have one
thing in mind that is to him very
obvious or to him the the exact way uh
to go. So we'll we'll see. Obviously Vex
in a showdown, we know how potent Vex
can be. So you have to kind of calculate
through, okay, what spells make Vex
reduction the most deadly. Now, if
you're Tamino going into a showdown,
you're like, okay, how many how many
rebukes can they play? How many how many
pump spells can they play? I I feel like
in this case you try to avoid the Vex
for now and you try to kill the Stacon
Herder first.
>> Yeah,
>> but we'll see the commitment from Tats
here probably. So I would say buff being
spent.
>> There has to be a rebuke here. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. One energy, one power rebuke. That
card's good enough at two and two.
>> Yeah,
>> it's crazy.
>> Yeah, that is.
>> But still doesn't really change much for
the B state. I'll be honest with you.
>> Yeah. Uh I'm trying to look at what was
in hand there. I think there will catch
a glimpse. Now there's a set in hand. I
did see that and I was like I could say
that but I feel like that might be uh
>> might be stating the obvious of what we
just saw. So now uh Doran's played
>> Dorance is a very like boring card. It's
just plus two might but when you think
about the equipment effect and the
possibilities of juggling it between
units now is incredibly important. And
also now going into a combat around the
Vex means anything else is going to be
costly. Plus uh Fiora will be switched
on uh with Oh, it's three keywords,
right? It's like uh is it deflect on
this one? The the fuel
>> deflect, ganking, and shield.
>> And shield. Yeah,
>> she is mighty.
>> Yes, which now she is right with was
already with the buff actually. But uh
>> so because we move now into Celicon
Herder, I'm going to assume we're not
going to attack the uh Vex at all
because we would like to attack for the
seat of power. We first would attack
into the Vex. Yeah,
>> if we would like to let it live, then we
just probably would go first into the
Stacon um her anyway, right? And not try
maybe to attack into Vex
>> because essentially now the rebuke was a
hard removal,
>> right? You use this for one energy, one
power, and the set is permanently
removed. It would have to be played and
then has to wait essentially two turns
to be active unless there's a
showstopper, right, that you can use on
the set who's playing from the hand to
accelerate it essentially.
>> Oh wow. This is just a full full deflect
cost rebuke in order to stop Tamino from
going
up to eight. Of course, we're on
Aspirin's climb. So, as said, that's uh
a game in which we're going to nine.
>> We'll go to seven as well.
>> Pat is at seven. Has four. Oh, he's
>> I was like, "Oh, no. He's just showing a
defy for no reason."
>> No, I think it's fair. Like his the hand
was really not what you want at this
point in a Stellorn Herder, a Defy. Um
not really enough to to keep drawing
cards. And as we said, that decision-m
on what do you attack from that moment,
the Stellorn Herder only getting one
draw off is punishing for Aurelia.
>> Well, the um I would say overall first I
would like to say Tomino played it
really well. I I feel like he set up a
win condition very early on. He was
saving his units, not even going into
battle. He was just like trying to avoid
the combat quite a little bit to amount
enough of enough amount of units and
might at the same time to threaten
Urelas all the time and those little
small battles that he was winning before
when there was like discipline. No, was
it discipline and and guard being
played? Yeah, I think so. Discipline and
guard from one combat, right? Then unit
didn't die because of recalled to base
from the set's ability. All of that kind
of like small battles that he was
draining out the cards from Urelia's
hand were impactful in the long term.
And for Taz, I feel like because he was
lacking the card draw early on, he was
not able to catch up in the late game
because one of the weaknesses of Aelia
right now is the fact that you don't
have a lot of control. And that's the
thing because of the bats. We don't have
dreaming tree. We don't have um rivers
row to actually just also um have more
potential movement with Celakon her or
just saving your Aurelia from combat as
well.
>> Yeah, exactly. A lot of cards did hit
Aurelia and she she still is uh still is
performing well though as the uh deck
with I think the highest uh
representation here in
>> great conversion. One out of four
players playing Aurelia converted to day
two. The population of Urelias increased
overall in the tournament from Did I
take my notes? I didn't. I don't think I
took it with me.
>> I got to remember now off the top of
your head.
>> It was um 15% of Urelia day one.
>> Yeah.
>> And now it's 22 if I remember correctly.
So
>> it's around that. Yeah, I think I think
you're correct. On
>> there's more of Urelia on day two than
on day one when you think about the
entire population of the players that
have here to play in this tournament in
at this stage. And uh so yeah, it's a
very powerful deck. It's just a little
bit less consistent, thank god. So uh
yeah.
>> Yeah, exactly that. Exactly. A little
bit less consistent. And um you know, we
get to see these somewhat unorthodox
matchups of of set in Spirit Forged
against Ireelia. Definitely one of the
more fringe matchups from Tamino's side
of things as uh there is kind of a
benefit of of running a deck uh and
coming to a tournament and and knowing
that you know the match up better than
your opponent.
>> Correct.
>> Because the chances of Tats grinding
this game against set again and again
and again is unlikely. Whereas Tamino
will have said well Aelia is going to be
one of the best decks in the room. So I
will play 100 games against a good Aelia
player and just as practice. Yeah, you
can record your statement and just
change like the names of the characters
and yeah and essentially say that almost
in every single metag game because it's
a very true statement.
>> Uh it's it is an advantage when you're
playing to some degree of course because
you're not potentially playing the best
deck in the format.
>> Sure, but you have secret informations
or like the opponent will have less
experience to your deck which will make
him maybe misplay, maybe plan not
correctly uh because he doesn't know the
interaction or whatever option in your
deck can be. you can catch people off
guard because you're playing uh one of
the surprise cards. Like one of my
favorite green cards is block.
>> Okay,
>> I almost never see it being played, but
one time is going to be played and
someone is going to get completely
outplayed because it's like, wow, it's
plus three. Well,
>> what the hell? That's not the math that
I expected. And suddenly the combat goes
the other way. That was a little bit
like Vex at Bolognia where people knew
kind of what Vex did, but nobody else
had the math on like, okay, how do I
have to pay in in a combat for what now?
>> There was also a very interesting
interaction with Vex when you were able
to just essentially play a free bellow
if you have Ezro Prodigy.
>> No longer the case.
>> Yeah. And there was also a stage in
pre-showdown. There was already combat,
but it was not combat. Yeah.
>> So, it was like pre-showdown where the
Vex didn't make the spells get cheaper,
but you could play spells during a
showdown. That's not that's not the case
anymore, so we don't have to explain it,
but it was the case before. There was
like a lot of new ones.
>> Thankfully, thankfully, we don't have to
explain any of that uh so much anymore.
But, we are into our game three lonely
parro plus some boots as Lucian on the
other side of the table.
>> And we have reopen energy because of tag
peak.
>> Yes, of course. Uh, everyone wants to be
Annie.
Yep.
>> In this matchup. So, some core cards
here. There's a hidden blade. There's an
action in hand. I think there's a ruin
runner in the back if I'm not mistaken
from set's hand.
>> It doesn't feel like the rune runner is
that great against Ireelia.
>> No, there's a few things that it'll deal
with like Rebuke obviously and then
Giant Dance can't go through on it. But
yeah, you're right. And the majority of
what Arelia wants to do is focused on
Urelia.
>> Yes. Exactly. So, it's much better
against decks that like for example
Kaiser.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, we have Warmox armor, but we
didn't equip it. That's an interesting
case
>> because that means we are not trying to
DMP. So, we can read from from this
position a little bit. We go for the
action. He already knows what's
happening
>> and he's weapon mastering uh the
Warmog's armor on the action as well and
then equipping the boots from uh the
effect of action. M so not waiting for
the guardian angel but in a sense in
essence this does slow down Aurelia
quite a lot right cuz you no longer can
just do the loop correct of getting both
points from both battlefields it now
kind of requires a second unit
>> but also um this essentially is a very
hard board state for Urelia to solve yet
with like a potentially charm to kill uh
the action and next turn I'm going to
assume that Tomino has a plan to buff
the action and keep it safe because it
essentially gets a G. So, it's going to
be harder to kill and get the boots back
because of it. Ideally, it won't be by
like for example concurring with the
warog and letting the action be on the
battlefield because that is putting it
in danger. So, ideally would like to see
a buff and be in base and be a threat.
>> Yeah, Aurelia I think is the only unit
option available here to play. I think
is that a ZAS? I know there was a
guardian angel. Uh, but also I think
there's like next to the rebuke
>> an unguard
>> I think there might be a Za's hourglass
in hand which is what is coming out.
>> A hidden card.
>> Hidden card and not yellow. It's not
hidden but
>> no exactly still. I mean now that fight
or flight is gone. Uh there's not too
too many cards that you would imagine in
Aelia that are that are hidden anymore.
I mean tight turner does exist.
>> It can be a block.
>> If it is I I was no block in the deck
list. Um but this Sonia is essentially
an insurance
>> if it is
>> against the cool the week here because
even if this por dies gets recalled to
base essentially because of the zonas
and then the cold the week still doesn't
have an effect.
>> Yeah cuz you also um
am I am I mistaken that because of the
way that things now happen with
something still on the chain? No, I I'm
I'm I'm not going to go down that rabbit
hole. I think I'm actually incorrect.
>> It's getting recalled. But you probably
wanted to like replay it on the
>> No, it's fine. You know what? If if it
comes up, we'll we'll delve into it. But
I think I was about to make an incorrect
statement based on the the recent
rulings.
>> Um yes, as you said, now we're into Axan
going on to the uh the sunken temple
>> and we'll see what follows up here. Pit
rookie is going to buff up the Lucian.
>> Move into battlefield. Now we get to see
what the revealed card indeed does
>> and is. Sorry, I should say. It's very
important that this buff was here on
Lucian because now this unguard doesn't
represent the pro winning the combat.
That is huge play. Very important that
Tomino did this. Like otherwise this
zona could have been used on the Aurelia
next turn. So it is pivotal uh or like
of other importance for for um Tomino to
make sure that this porro gets recalled
and not something else.
>> Yeah, now the on guard will come
through. Yeah, we're going to have to
force Set now to use his set the boss
unless Tomino doesn't want to damp or
maybe he wants to use something else to
go over the porro.
>> Probably not, but we'll see.
>> It is. So, as you said, it will uh
>> uh Oh, okay. So,
um wait, am I mistaken?
>> So, this is what I was It has
>> wondering about chat are going to light
me up if this is wrong. So, I'm sorry if
it's wrong. There were changes to when
the battlefield uh control
uh is lost, and I did hear rumblings of
like if you can zas after losing a unit
because you technically don't lose the
battlefield until after the certific
I apologize if that is incorrect. It's
one of the very minute details that were
recently changed within the game. Um but
it looks like that is the impact of what
has happened in this game. As a
reminder, we as casters uh do not have
like any kind of control over the game
or the judging decision in the game and
the judges will only step in when they
are asked for um by the players. So I
think it is an important
>> thing to note on that one as Urelia will
continue looking at the game as it is
being played from here. And again, I
apologize if any of that is not 100%
right. There have been a lot of changes
recently. Ireelia now uh going to get
the discipline on top as well. Will get
the card draw, see more from the deck,
and potentially
look to threaten. I wonder whether this
is going towards the uh the targets or
just to try and blow out uh both
battlefields this turn. will be sunken
temple first with the higher might
>> 10 to eight and it forces Tomino to do
something about it or just set back to
the base there is a hidden blade in the
hand but with zona and guardian angel
both open it's like something that
doesn't look that inciting you have to
damp by two you're going to be back to
five energy on your followup
And if that get counted then you have to
still use set the boss ability to save
the action because you have to that's
one of the very important things you
don't want to give ganking to Ireelia
now. So uh you would DM back to four.
That is way too much.
>> Yeah that is a painful spot to be in.
Ooh hard bargain in hand. So we know
that already set is low on economy.
It's going to make it even more
punishing if those challenges come out
late in the turn where there's no real
way of maintaining. Haven't really seen
too much presence in the showdowns from
set. That's the difficult thing. A lot
of this game has been played of
conquering battlefields, especially in
game one. Uh that we were expecting a
fight over, but actually both players
have kind of passed away from each other
or like passed by each other. And that's
what's going to happen again here as
Axan goes over uh to Taran's peak. One
way of getting runes is untang them at
the end of the turn. That's
>> not exactly the same, but yes. So
>> for the hard bug actually will matter.
So yeah, you you have a good point here.
Uh now action again gets the the buff so
he can get rescued again and again and
again. Obviously unfortunately the
problem will be once a charm comes in
and like a double combat will happen. We
have the ruin runner being slammed in
base and pass and open two runes for
that potential interaction with a punch
first or a hidden blade uh or a
challenge. It's still an action speed
that's some something that can be used
during combat. But now with only two
open, the hard bargain essentially will
affect every single spell.
>> Yeah. And there's a few different things
you could represent with two, right? We
know there's a salvage there in hand.
There's a I think there's a hidden
blade. Yeah, hidden blade. You know
what? everything in hand other than
spell the week. I I mean everything
technically is uh you have the the the
runes for not all able to do it but
>> so there's a there's a rebuke though.
>> There is that rebuke also will solve the
problem of not having the boots because
if you rebuke it uh if you rebuke the
action to hand then Tomino will have to
replay
>> the the action to take the boots back.
But the problem is if you do that you
kind of open also the GA for the action.
>> Yeah. because now he can change the
target, right? It will be costly because
you have to replay action and pay again
to power,
>> but it might not be ideal to lose the G.
So, probably reuke is not the play.
>> That's a fair point. There's also
defined dance and a discipline in hand.
There's a tide turner there. Um, a few
different things
when it comes to the lines available for
Tats and that Zas is still in base. It's
just going to be pass just saying,
"Okay, I'm at four points. Pass the turn
over to you. don't want to play into
those two open runes and we we move on
as Tamino will hold to four.
>> It's all three of those games are just
so slow on development when it comes
like very very meticulate in in in how
they're being played. It's really a
different kind of gameplay that you
would typically expect from two decks
that are all about brawling it out.
>> It's literally a character called
Brawler.
>> Yeah, it's right there in the name. Um,
and
yeah, it such a such a interesting spot
to be in. Now, as this ruin runner,
we talked about is it as influential
against Urelia as you might think? And
Aurelia is ding to fantast. Okay, so
this is an interesting spot. You're
going to be again, we we're going back
to the game two where small battles
might be something that Tomino will be
looking at as his win condition. He's
going to be trying to grind out the
Aurelia out of cards because again
Urelia doesn't have a lot of card right
now.
>> Yeah, it's it's been a painful two games
for Aelia with like low on the
Stellicorn hunters, low on units. So,
Defant comes down.
>> We have goes to eight into six.
>> So now what are the what are the plays
over here? How much Tomino wants to
sacrifice? Nothing. He just wants to go
back. A small battle, small battle being
won because it it is one card out of
hand from Tats and that is a defiant
dense a really big one when it comes to
like swapping the amount of might that
is on the battlefield.
So six and one
in fact I guess that was seven. Oh cuz
one floating. Uh so seven and one total
as fade dragon going to come down buff
up a bunch of units.
will replace the buff that Ashan just
lost.
>> And now this is an interesting spot.
Tats goes up to five. Most likely will
stay stay at five on the upcoming
follow-up that opens up to Mino to go up
to six for the followup because uh
otherwise that will have to hold the
battlefield.
>> That's going to be the semi ganking.
>> Yeah. So will be able to move the
Aurelia over. That's a big big move.
>> That's a big difference.
>> Yes. The the the reason why I was
explaining that because Tats would have
been not presenting a win condition, not
presenting a potential lethal here for
Tats that is absolutely so important to
do this. So it's a great play by Tats to
recognize that he has to put the
pressure on set.
>> Yeah. Is the line now for Tamino. Clear
out the tide turner.
Salvage one of the gears to get rid of
it. Kill the Aurelia to get rid of the
other. and call the weak to get it rid
of it a third time.
>> That works perfect if there are no
counter spells.
>> If there are no counter spells, that's
what I'm saying. Which is basically
everything. Tats does, I think, have a
>> You know what? I very like that we
actually moving our heads like it makes
a difference when we're
>> tilting to the side. I'm like
>> Yeah, it doesn't change the par the
parallax. You know,
>> it's like when you have a controller in
hand and you're trying to tilt it,
that's the salvage. Not so fast is the
only way. No, sorry, that's not the only
There's the default, right? So, it will
be defies. There's one. So, that first
thing is gone.
>> The question was which one is better
first?
>> Yeah, that's better to challenge first.
>> Uh, are there any challenges in hand? I
know there's a color weak. I know
there's a hidden blade,
>> so it might have to be I think you can
you still get that? It's kill the tide
turner. Uh you but you have too much
limitation on being at a battlefield
because you can't hidden blade and win
via a showdown against
>> I feel like you have to go to 60%.
>> You have to. Yeah. Yeah. So this is
going to be
Oh, okay. You can you can do it the
other way around where it's uh win the
showdown against the Aurelia force the
Za's hourglass cuz you have to get that
out of the way first otherwise the tie
turner will
>> Well, you could be doing it on the tight
turner
>> but then it'll come back with the Zas,
right? So you want the
>> Yeah. Yes, the titan will will going to
come back with the onions if you kill
the titan
>> first. But you want don't you want the
Aurelia to come back
>> or is there a way I guess either way is
you have to get through multiple other
things in order for K the week to kill
the last
>> remaining okay you're on the plan of the
cold the week correctly. Sorry I
misunderstood.
>> No, that's okay. That's that's fair.
That's exactly what I'm talking about is
like there's so many steps to get to an
an open board state if you're Tamino
compared to Tats that there's multiple
ways to get there.
>> So we're now at 14 to9 this turn.
Tats is actually also utilizing the
additional might from his legend power.
So he is valuing the additional might
here because he wants to uh well did it
does it actually make a difference for
anything now? No, there has to be a
reason for this. So, let's wait out for
what is happening next.
>> That's the Mhm.
We're recalling the um the Aurelia to
base. Now,
we're going to be getting the effect of
the targets at the beginning of the next
turn. We're also paying one to activate
the the same thing that Urelia has. when
you conquer, you can pay one to uh untap
your set, which is something that many
people forget. As you can see, Taz was
actually reading it.
>> Yeah, I I I also think this I think I
think there's too many restrictions on
things being at a battlefield in order
to get this GA off the Leona. I think
the salvage had to hit.
Looking at it, I I think the salvage
needed to be the one that that made it
through in the end if you wanted to wipe
the board completely. Whether that is
what Tamino needs or not, maybe Tamino
can just stack enough to to make it that
>> Well, he doesn't have a hidden blade
yet, right?
>> Yeah. Which I guess on the next turn can
be used. I guess it doesn't have to
happen now.
>> Well, he also got a call to glory. Dude,
this is so complex right now.
>> I know. And I'm probably making it worse
with my yapping uh on things.
>> No, no. We We just have to kind of think
about like a lot of scenarios over here.
There's the hidden blade. Not so hidden
anymore because it's going to be Oh, no.
It's a K the week. Okay.
>> Yeah. So, this will hit the Aurelia to
get the GA off and then next turn you at
least can hidden blade when Aelia has to
go aggressive cuz she has to contest one
of the battlefield. So, I was a little
bit too much do everything now whereas
you don't have to. You can you can wait.
>> Yeah. And do we rescue this unit with
the set? Probably not.
>> Don't need to. You you're kind of
winning this from here already.
>> Do you have enough resources available?
Yes. Three runes up and we're going to
get a Targon's peak untap as well right
at the end of the turn.
>> So probably hidden blade. Now it's the
not hidden blade.
>> Not so hidden blade
>> as Tan's untap.
Now it's really off. This top deck needs
to provide
if you could just have it in your hand.
Oh, defy is enough to deal with the
hidden blade, but a defy, a hard
bargain, and a rebuke will not
give Aurelia enough to survive this turn
and next, right? Oh, hidden blade, I
guess, is now because it's hidden.
>> Can be used in response,
>> has to be used in response.
>> Yeah, but now this is a great insurance
because now it's it's not even about
that. It's it's you're able to rescue
your action and it goes back to base so
he doesn't get his shoes back.
>> Oh, and we're now in that situation as
well where the
>> of the cards are played. You have to
play define now. Did hidden blade get
ered to say uh if it dies? That is a
really good question.
>> That's not even important. That right
now the most important interaction over
here is if tats will not defy this
then the action doesn't die and the
boots don't go
>> to.
Okay, that's that is huge. So can't get
to eight this turn. There is the
>> Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh.
>> I think we're going to probably have a
judge.
>> Might be having a judge go over here.
>> Uh it looks like the defy.
>> Yeah, he realized too late. He realized
too late.
>> Yeah, because I believe we've gone to
recycling. We have stepped past it. The
judges are going to come in again. We at
the casted desk can't actually impact
this. So, we'll let the judges resolve
it.
>> The thing is that the rebuke was
resolved. Yes.
>> And because the rebuke was resolved into
the graveyard, that means that the
reaction speed hidden blade already
resolved as well. So it looked like TAD
already confirmed yet this is done.
>> Yeah, because we we had things moved. So
>> it's up to the judges, not up to us.
We're just explaining what could have
happened.
>> We are at competitive real, which means
this is the moment where decisions like
this uh are make or break for a
tournament. And also uh at your nexus
night, we may very well say ah actually
okay, yeah, sure. But here judges will
come in. will uh will help the players
resolve this situation. Um it wouldn't
surprise me if the rebuke because it had
resolved
>> Mhm.
>> was done.
>> I mean, it it was the moment for Urelia
because with the boots now, you're going
to be able to equip it uh after you move
to one of the battlefields, equip it,
untap it, and gang to the other
battlefield, which without the boots
you're not able to do. So if I'm not
mistaken again I can be wrong because I
can't remember every single thing that
was happening there. That's very complex
board state but I think without the
boots there was no way of setting up
potential lethal and the only way would
be playing not to lose the next turn and
then depends on the card draw on the
next one.
>> There is there is a thing just again for
for newer players or players that are
not used to playing a competitive realm.
When you resolve a spell, the board
state is new and there's new
information. And part of that new
information is am I getting those boots
back or not? And if you're not getting
them back, and you're like, "Oh, well
then I would have," which is not what
I'm saying is happening, but you know,
at a nexus night, you'd be like, "Oh, I
I don't get those, maybe I'll do
something different." But a competitive
real like that level of information
interaction is what goes into the the
difference of whether something resolves
or not. And it makes also a difference
between a player who is playing on top
of their game today or not as well,
>> which is rough. All of these like right
down into that minutia of like the the
card is stacked on top of each other and
I got to remember exact wording. And
this is why we say whenever somebody
reads a card like that exact wording on
uh how how an effect plays out is key at
this absolute top level. We're going to
let the judges resolve, but this is
right down to it. could not be at a more
tense spot uh in game three and you're
basically uh continuing through aiming
for that top eight. So, we will give
that a little bit of time.
>> Well, it's still far away from the top.
We still have four rounds. I mean,
including this one.
>> Including this one. But I guess this is
actually almost at that tipping point of
qualifying for regionals.
>> That is true. When it comes to the top
64, this is a very important match for
sure. It will be because you're also
winning. How do I explain this? the the
later you lose, the higher potentially
your tie breaks are.
>> Okay, we have apparently
>> what is the resolution over here?
>> It seems like action is alive. So, the
defy didn't come through because of the
resolution of the rebuke.
>> Yes. Okay, which was what we assumed
would would end up resolving, but it is,
you know, we of course
>> and as we said, we're not the judges
here. So, that does make it really
difficult to test and that is going to
be a scoop. That is an unfortunate way
to
>> not the fight needed to be played
>> come through. Yeah. Unfortunate that is
uh a difficult spot but um it is going
to be actually the other way around.
This graphic is is not toino. Yeah,
Tomino is winning. So we will get this
uh
>> what a legend.
>> There we go. Tamino gets the graphic
>> as Tomino will advance.
>> Uh obviously it is a very tense
situation at that point in the game and
not not the one that you want to be on
either side of. Um, everybody would be
looking for a clean resolution to that
game based purely on on what is the
sequencing going.
>> To be fair, it kind of looked clean
because
>> yeah, I guess the chain was very visible
from the board state and also like the
um body movement. It looked like it was
yet confirmed this is resolving this is
resolving. And now after the real realiz
sorry realization of what's the outcome
of this hidden blade and that the set
will rescue the unit and the action
doesn't die the player went like what
>> maybe that's fine. Yeah, that's
>> what what I mean about clean and not
clean is I think it's one of those
>> frustrating ones, right? As as a player
like uh that's not how I want to lose a
game on on that side. You definitely
feel for Tatsi in that moment, but to me
know a big win.
>> Everyone was in the spot at some point
when playing card games. This is one of
the moments when you learn a lot and
you're like,
>> "Okay, I will never make this mistake
again." Yeah, you know, it's like one of
those things when I'm going to start
paying more attention to those small
details of like how do you order the
chain and what is respon res and so it
it is a um that's what I love about card
games because
>> you do have this kind of a skill when
you have to plan your turns so much
ahead during even like or even actions
and not turns ahead but like actions
ahead and know the potential outcomes of
it. It's a beauty to watch players who
are playing it at at the highest level
and that's what uh just makes this card
game really fun.
>> Yeah. And and this is where we go into
now. Um
>> this isn't an elimination match. No,
like Tats is not out following that and
and obviously that's not much of a
silver lining uh from this situation.
Would have been looking to advance would
and again as I said that is a really
difficult end to the game. This is where
it comes into conditioning of like when
you lose a game in a frustrating way.
How do you turn that around? Like how
what is your own personal way of pulling
yourself back together and saying,
"Okay, I dropped that one, but I'm still
in contention. I'm still looking to win
out for the rest of the day and make it
further in the tournament."
>> I think just taking the lesson from
this, right?
>> Because it's in many cases many people
would say just just forget about it and
just play your next game. Oh no, is you
cannot you cannot forget about it
because uh as we know card games are a
game of knowledge and the knowledge is
the most important thing that you need
to have in your game right so you have
to learn from the mistakes otherwise
you're never going to get better so you
have to take this in you have to think
about this you have to realize this is a
moment where I get better as a player
because this is something that I could
have played better and now you win from
this from this from this lose you have a
win when you become uh instantly a
better player because you're not going
to make this mistake again. And with
that mindset, with that mindset, you go
into the next uh round and you go smash
it, you know,
>> and we we will keep an eye on Tadson
whether that comes back as a bounce back
and and smashing through, but one player
that is smashing through uh well on the
set uh which is not a deck that lots of
players were expecting to play against.
It is one where we're talking about the
meta, it sits just under the meta decks
and in one where a good player can can
pilot it to wins. uh clearly Tamino uh
very very uh proficient at the set in
these matchups
>> and it's also bringing something that
you pointed out before which is the you
don't have a lot of experience against
set right now in in spirit forge there
was almost no set uh now in this in the
spirit forge 2.5 or like 1.5 whatever
they call it we we have set going back
because the yellow orange combination is
getting a little bit better because of
the not um fight orflight not being in
in the game anymore right so
>> I was fully expecting what I was making
a tea video before going to the
tournament. I was saying Fiora is
surprisingly good into this meta game.
>> H but Seth is not far away from her. The
difference here is first and foremost
the difference in signatures. Fiona's
access to repost is really incredible
>> showstoppers
comparative to depends on what the
context is of the particular metrop. But
when it comes to the set's ability now,
that's a powerful one difference.
>> That's also you can see how important
experience is against set because if you
allow the set to like use two of those
abilities in one in one turn because of
the conquer and then tapping it, right,
you don't see it often, but it it does
actually affect the game by quite a lot.
>> And that's something we're seeing in
this meta. There are quite a lot of wide
board states, but there's a lot of
decisions being made of which exact
units do you save, which do you kind of,
you know, on the unit based on the
equipment based decks, which do you
cascade with, how does that sequencing
play out, which leaves
>> an insane branch of paths for each turn
of like which units get saved, which do
I put in first, who do I utilize
different spells on? And that is one of
the the the real like complex but
beautiful things to follow in a
tournament like this is like which line
is the one that takes you over the line,
gets you that last point uh and advances
you in the tournament. And uh you know
we are in the middle of our our second
round of the day but it's round 10 of
the tournament. Um and after 10 rounds
there's been a lot of fun riftbound. Uh
a lot of fun stuff. We've seen some
sets. We uh we've seen yesterday we saw
a volley bear. We've seen
>> the Vol game. If you didn't watch it,
Volibar didn't play a card till till
turn four.
>> Nearly had it though turned corner
>> and he almost made a comeback. It was
like
>> It wasn't close, but it was but it could
have happened if the stars aligned.
>> Always an optimist in my chat. I'll try
and be as positive as possible. Somebody
who will be looking positively on a win
in that round. Uh advancing in the
tournament is Tamino, who is chatting to
Amy right now.
Thanks, James. I'm here with Thomas, the
winner of our feature match with Set.
How are we feeling going further in the
tournament with this fantastic record?
>> I mean, I'm feeling very good. The game
was really close. I He didn't realize
how one interaction works. I probably
won thanks to that, but it was a tough
match.
>> It is. Yeah. is um did you expect to go
this far with set with so many kind of
Aurelia flying around?
>> I mean the tempo Aelia is I think an
okay matchup for set but yeah this is
harder when they're just playing with
the one unit but it's still playable but
yeah I'm mostly scared of Dravens.
>> Oh have you have you seen many Draven
yet? I
>> I I fought them once and that's my only
loss.
>> That was the only loss. Oh wow. So
hopefully you keep dodging the Draven as
you go through this event. What do you
think is the most powerful card in your
deck?
>> Uh
probably challenge, but I like as a
combo I like to Vmok with Fiora on tempo
or Vmok with ruin runner and I can just
save it every round and get trades and
outv value him.
>> Absolutely. And we've seen that come to
fruition in so many matches today. That
ruin runner is so powerful. I think
people are underestimating it, which is
great for you. Do you think you can go
all the way now?
>> I mean, I'm going to try.
>> Yeah, that's what we absolutely love to
hear. Um, when choosing a deck for this
tournament, what made you gravitate
towards set?
>> Uh, I also played set in Bologna.
>> Yes.
>> I I got the best of in Bologna,
actually.
>> Yes. Congratulations.
>> And yeah, I just stuck with the same
deck because I played it a lot. So, and
it's still the same format.
>> Yeah.
>> And Draven got nerfed, which was the
hardest matchup. So, there's I was like,
hopefully there's less Dravens.
>> Honestly, I think you're doing the right
thing. You're a master at the deck
already, so why not run it back? Have
you got anyone you'd like to thank or
shout out while we're here?
>> Uh, shout out to my friend group, NLV. I
guess that's about it.
>> That's perfect. Honestly, thank you so
much for talking to us, Thomas. I really
hope that you do well throughout the
rest of the event. We're going to throw
it over to Barcode for another
interview.
>> Thank you.
>> And speaking about someone who's doing
very well at the event, we've got Roma
right next to me. So, we had an
interview before, so I wanted to have a
bit of a followup because yesterday you
told me that you were not really well in
the tournament. I mean, uh, it was hard
because you didn't sleep, uh, a lot
today. Did you sleep better?
>> Uh, well, not better. At least 1 hour
less than yesterday, but maybe it's the
tech for me to for performing. So, I
think it's okay. But less sleeping and
more pressure. So, I don't know if it's
good, but for for now, it's going pretty
okay.
>> So, yesterday you were undefeated. How
did it go in the morning?
>> Uh, about my my two first one. So the
the first one was against an aer and it
was a loss. I think I didn't handle
pressure well and with the lead on
knight I have I forgot I forgot my point
with arena greatest. So when you're 8 Z
and you forgot this I I think my my
opponent was like loing in in his head
but well I it was my first loss but
after I faced another aier and luck was
luck was with me again because he he
didn't draw gears that he won. So it
went well for me. So now I'm in 91 so
I'm I'm still in the tournament. So I
think it's pretty okay for the moment. I
mean, yeah, I think this is pretty okay
considering the fact that you are still
in. A lot of players would like to have
your record right now. Speaking about
your record, you are still in and you
are one of the last French people right
here in the tournament. Does it add any
extra pressure on your shoulders or are
you still chill?
>> Uh, honestly, for me, it doesn't change
anything.
I guess if a French uh player can win
the French tournament, it's it could be
better, but I'm not that patriotic, so
doesn't matter for me. It doesn't
matter. Only victory for you is what
matters. So, for now, there are only a
few rounds left. Are you confident in
the fact that you can just get to top
eight and maybe win it all? Honestly, my
mindset is mainly go game after game,
not thinking about uh top eight or any
price because it's just going to make me
more pressure on me. After the first
game, the pressure went down uh a lot.
So now I'm pretty chill in the in the
game. I'm still doing my six to seven
points to to lower down the pressure. So
it's just it's just game after game. I
try to get as winner as I can and that's
it.
>> I think that's a very good mindset to be
honest to take one game after one and to
just chill a little bit because I saw a
lot of people they had a lot of pressure
on their shoulders and what I see you to
be honest I think that you are pretty
confident you are just taking things
like they are.
>> Yeah, I try to you know when I'm meeting
my opponent to try to talk a bit where
do do we come from? Um because I'm
trying to say good luck and have fun. I
know it's lots of pressure and in the
tournament, but we are still human. So
we can we can talk and that's why I'm
trying to to talk when I can to and to
have um a sports behavior. Yeah.
Behavior to when when he want to replay
or we are not here to shark. We are here
to play as as best as we can and to try
to get the win. and my opponent and and
I are
wanted to to play as as better as they
can. So, I'm not here to shock, just to
play and enjoy the tournament um as much
as I can.
>> I mean, that's an absolutely great
mindset and I totally love it. Speaking
about opponents, your opponents might be
at your table because the next round is
just around the corner. So, why not just
go back to the stage?
Welcome back everyone. Regional
qualifier le. I'm Blevens joined with
Amy and we are here for a another round
of action here. Only a few more rounds
of Swiss here in day two before we get
to that top cut.
>> Honestly, I've been glued to the
broadcast where I'm here with you or
backstage watching when we're having a
little break because the action has been
undeniable. The buzz in the room is
filtering through to every inch of this
room. And honestly, you can feel the
anticipation as the pressure builds as
we get towards that top hat.
>> Yeah, the action is undeniable. And also
the Axon is undeniable. We have seen
Axon actually be a very key piece in a
lot of these sideboards for Urelia, even
for Draven, for a lot of these decks.
They have these very key pieces of
equipment and Axan just goes yoink I'll
take that and you no longer have it and
oh also by the way I get to keep it and
keep equip it keep it equipped to my
auction and use it against you
>> and I think that's something that is
shown through the bands
that although the format may be similar
it's different enough that gear became
more powerful so then we need things to
deal with gear but not just not just
equipment and spells to deal with gear,
but also units themselves. Arkshan
immediately got a buff through the midst
of other changes and tweaks. And I think
there are still cards that are yet to
explore with that.
>> Yeah, it's addition by subtraction
there. By taking out cards, some other
cards got better without even doing a
thing. And that's great. But people who
have been doing a lot of things are at
the top of our standing. So, let's take
a look at who's performing well in this.
Here we have got our top 32 right now.
Of course, a good number of Aurelia
here. Trying to take a quick look
through. We just saw that set at 9 and
one. Amy, you've got to be beaming over
that one.
>> Oh, I'd be over the moon. You could not
make it up. Nine and one. Imagine
playing nine games of Riftbound, only
losing one. I feel like honestly that
just feels like a lunch break, you know?
Not you're like, "Yeah, okay, that's all
right. That was my refresher." Uh maybe
it was my warm up at the beginning of
the day. And then you go beyond that and
we're looking at Pedro, Neutril, and
Bked, and we're looking at that 100
record. And one thing I'm going to note
really clearly is they are all different
decks.
>> Yeah, that is crazy. Uh, I think maybe
if you ask some insane people, you'd
say, "Oh, I I think that after 10
rounds, Azir is going to be in first
place." Not many people are going to be
saying that unironically, but it is here
today. Draven coming in at fourth. So,
we saw Barek on stream earlier with that
master. He says in his own words, best
deck in format. Well, Pedro and Natural
also having a contest to that. Of
course, likely one of those players, two
of those players are probably going to
play against each other. Now, obviously,
you know, once you have a 2,000 person
tournament, tournament math goes out the
window. So, I'm not going to try, but it
is possible that two of those players
are going to be playing against each
other. And we will potentially only have
after this round. A sole person sitting
at top the standings in first place,
which would be absolutely crazy if it's
not Aurelia or Draven.
>> Phenomenal. And I mean the chance that
being Draven,
>> nope, not
happening. Now the other thing I like to
note when we're looking at standings
like that that there were a few
standouts. We had an Annie in top 16
there in current standings. We had Fiora
there as well. So when you do the math
on how many decks are different out of
16, I'd say we're we're on about 50/50.
>> Yeah, it is a lot of different decks.
And I will note that uh one of the
the top 16 Annie is my boy Prismat who
I've been following for a lot of games.
We saw top eight in Bolognia doing very
well. Got the best of Draven in Bolognia
in a stacked field there and really
really is one of those players and we
talked about this backstage where when I
first saw them in other games I was like
is this guy this person really good?
Cassidov was like no you need you need
to be watching this player. I go are
they really that good? Okay.
>> See, they're playing. Nah, I wouldn't
have made that play. I wouldn't have
made that play. Ah, I wouldn't have made
that play. And then on the fifth turn
after that, I go,
>> it all came together and I go, wait,
>> they're genius.
>> They've been setting this up the whole
time and they end up winning the game
from this crazy line that they took. And
I'm like,
>> oh yeah, I'm bought in. I'm bought into
the Prismat hype trim. I think a lot of
people in Riftbound already are because
the results speak for themselves. You
are not They're going to all these
tournaments. We're seeing them. They
were one of the early players before the
game was even out, you know, playing in
the online tournaments. They won a lot
of those events as well. And just if you
see Prismat play, it's it's with a level
of precision. It's with a level of just
high level that you really don't it it's
very rare.
>> There's a skill to be able to do really
well in a circuit playing a different
deck each time as well. These are decks
that yes, they have similar nuances
between Annie and Draven, but you're
taking a different deck. You've already
got a best off,
>> right?
>> You're going for a different best off or
going all the way,
>> which would also get you best off, which
I think is a
>> just an unspeakable amount of skill
within that being able to do that. We
obviously I just spoke to Tom as our
amazing set player who got best off with
set already going for a second time
running. Yeah.
>> Um which is fantastic. I think that's
very I think it's like having little
trophies, right? You'll have a set of
trophies.
>> Ah, I see what you did there.
>> But going for a different one almost
gives you that
>> that ode that you're not a one-trick
pony. You're not a one deck wonder.
You're giving us so much more and I
think that's that there's so much skill
in that.
>> Oh, absolutely. I mean, I'd be fine
being a one trick pony. I'm I'm a zero
trick pony right now, so I'll take I'll
take even a single trick. But there's
still a lot of action to come in this
round. We actually did ask the public a
few questions about Riftbound. So, let's
see what they had to say.
>> So, where do you come from?
>> I'm from Germany.
>> Poland.
>> From France,
>> Belgium.
>> Bulgaria.
>> From Belgium. I come from Germany, man.
>> What's your favorite legend?
>> My favorite legend is Victor. And I'm
honest. Um, I didn't play any other
legend till now. So, yeah. But I'm very
fine with Victor. Even with the uh
Draven Nerf right now, it's getting
stronger in my opinion. And I love him.
>> My favorite champion overall from League
of Legends would be Zia
>> or Serion.
>> Legend, it has to be Teemo.
>> Teemo. I I love the hidden mechanic.
Being able to just flip up. Oh, surprise
the enemy.
>> What's your favorite card in the game?
>> Uh favorite card? Uh I think a period
cream for Victor.
>> I think it would be the spirit blossom
Ari. She's so gorgeous. She's so pastels
everything. Oh, I love her.
>> I think is my favorite cat. I really
like fees.
>> I have to say rebuke. I love just paying
two two and then returning their high
cost is just so good.
>> I think my favorite car is Kesa the the
red one. It's a lot of value. It's a
good body. So yeah,
>> I think fight or flight but it's banned.
You know
>> that's a bit hard. Yeah.
>> What color combination do you like the
most?
>> Then I got to go with the blue yellow
one.
>> So it will be purple and yellow,
>> green and orange.
>> Purp.
>> I like all the combination with blue. I
think I hate drill. So, blue and purple.
>> Okay.
>> I must say it's blue purple. It's just
so many like trickery and like from hand
from hidden.
>> In your opinion, which deck is going to
win it all?
>> I think Aurelia is pretty strong right
now, but I'm confident today, bro. I
think Victor maybe. Maybe I'm going to
take it on.
>> That's all.
>> Let's say Ari. Let's put it on Ari. I
will repeat, but I think Ezra can do
really good thing or Draven or Era.
>> Definitely not Draven. We can't have
Draven again. I think it's going to be
Alan's EQ with an Ezreal control.
>> That's a take.
>> Let's take out takes and say Victoria.
>> I think Urelia because after the band,
Aurelia got really strong because her
biggest opponent Traven is nerfed pretty
much. You know,
>> it actually makes sense.
Welcome back everyone. Regional
qualifier Leo Blevens joined with Amy.
And I think I think I heard pairings
just start to go up. So players are
going to be walking to their seats here
and we're going to be getting into the
action very soon here. Amy,
>> I'm so excited for some more games. We
have some riveting action so far and
there's much more to come. Right,
barcodes discussion there. I've got to
say that was those are some great
questions. Who's your favorite champion?
Well, I mean, I it's not really a secret
that I'm a a one trick uh one trick
Lucian, despite what Kasanova has said
on this very show. Uh I have actually
said that Lucian is very fun. And I have
pointed out that he's very good many
times. Uh including on this very
broadcast, but did not listen to me. But
that is neither here nor there. We have
got our eight and twos here. So on the
cusp here, need to need to win here to
be in contention. We have got Ezreal
versus Azir. It's all to play for.
There's a lot of pressure on these
players, but we're bringing two very
different style decks to the table.
We've got Ezreal, of course, who is kind
of using these cheap units, taking
advantage of showdowns, and trying to
outresource your opponent with efficient
card draw tactics. Although we lost a
few of those, the legend ability there
still allows us to draw many cards. And
we're going to utilize cards like stack
deck to get there.
>> Yeah. And absolutely, we can see the
deck list here. Very much the control
style. A few interesting choices here.
We've got acceptable losses in the main,
which is a a nod to that gear removal
that we've seen. You know, Aan we're
seeing in the main. We're seeing
salvages in the main for a lot of these
decks. So, it is definitely a nod to
that. But a deck that utilizes gear
very, very well. That is of course Azir
who is making a lot of those sand
soldier tokens using the full effect of
equipment like the brutalizer of our
friend Harold whose eye we have here and
of course that all powerful signature
spell Arise
Arise. We've seen it happen once. We're
going to see it happen again I imagine.
And of course, we've got that fantastic
charm, that uptick of those in the deck,
and lots of not only equipment, but also
spells to be able to try and prevent our
opponents from being able to employ
their own tactics. We're low on units in
the main deck
>> cuz we don't need them. We're going to
make sand soldiers instead. And so then
you have more space in the deck for
these tricks and for equipment because
we're not playing active units cuz we
don't need to. We're making our own.
It's like a build your own unit. You can
just I'll start with a sand soldier for
a base and then uh you can have a sword.
He's going to have a shield.
>> Yep. Absolutely. Able to take advantage
of that. And we saw it yesterday when
you know you can play these spells.
Singularity falling star kills two sand
soldiers. Yeah, you've destroyed two
units technically, but they were token
units. It never quite feels as good as
getting rid of real units, especially
when Azir can go,
>> "All right, I'll play a BF sword, make
another one, I'll play a rise, I'll make
five more sand soldiers," and and kind
of go from there. And the thing that I
want to point out about both of these
decks playing very very different styles
of game, but both of them are, I would
say, two of the higher skill cap decks
in the game. So if players have been
putting the time, putting the reps into
these decks, they are really going to be
able to show it off here.
>> And it's whether they choose to up the
tempo or not. They both are decks which
thrive off of a slow start,
>> but if one of them chooses to try and go
more aggressive, are they going to just
push forward? If we make enough sand
soldiers in the beginning, is Azir going
to be able to kind of overcome what
Ezreal's trying to push upon them?
Especially because their units just
aren't as valuable to them. So, if
Ezreal does try some of these kind of
control tactics, it's kind of like,
okay, I'll make some more anyway. Yeah,
it is it is tough as a control deck in
general if your opponent has a builtin
value engine that you can't really
interact with. You can't stop your
opponent from drawing equipment, playing
it, and making a sand soldier.
When you're playing a control deck, it's
really hard to answer the infinite
amount of value. So, you have to be
quicker a lot of times. So, this this
control Ezreal deck may have a little
bit of a of a struggle there, having to
actually put on pressure against a deck
that is actually also very aggressive.
>> Yeah. And can be flexible with that as
well.
>> That's the nice thing about Azir is that
actually you've got more flexibility
than a lot of people, I think, give it
credit for. You've got flexibility
because of the gear. You've got
flexibility because a lot of your units
are kind of what we've been calling
cheap units. They're discardable and you
don't really mind. And quite often you
could be destroying your own units for
advantage. And so if your opponent is
trying to sort of lock you in a
battlefield or um take out a unit,
you're like, "Uh, okay, well, I'll
destroy my own and then uh I'll draw
some cards and uh actually that's kind
of what I wanted." And that can be a
problem.
>> Yeah. When you're using a singularity to
destroy a sand soldier, which they sense
then say, "Ah, I'll just destroy it
myself and draw two cards." That just
feels horrible. That feels horrible,
right? like let's just go to the next
game at that point, which you shouldn't
do, but I definitely feel like doing
what I'm playing.
>> It's it's horrible because you don't
want to waste resources. Ezreal is a
deck which thrives of winning out of
having more resources than your
opponent, using them efficiently, having
cheap resources as well.
>> But actually,
>> if you've got enough sand soldiers and
you just don't care,
>> then you you can just keep the board
overwhelmed. And that's I think where
Victor decks as well can do quite well
into Ezreal sometimes because it's a
similar kind of formula where you're
like I'm just making recruits, man. I
don't care what you do to them. It's
fine. I've just got a load of them.
>> Absolutely. The one thing I will say for
Ezreal, of course, I mean, the deck has
spoken for itself already. Obviously,
one Bolognia with Allen piloting it.
Different version now, but still the
same idea here. being able to have an
answer for all of the questions that
your opponent is posing to you.
>> One of those answers is a preemptive one
and that is mindsplitter. A card that
we've seen be so so good and be able to
take some of those uh interactive spells
late in the game or even just nab that
arise right away from them. And that can
really put a uh
>> a damper on things.
>> It can put a damper on the Azir's
>> raining on their parade, aren't they?
And that's the problem. We saw it
yesterday. We saw that exact scenario
yesterday where a mine spplitter took
the arise and we were like, "Oh no." And
then it took turns of card draw to get
back to the Arise. They managed to pull
through, but if then you can't get back
into that flow, it can be all over
before you know.
>> Absolutely. But it looks like the
players are sat in and ready. We can see
the spread of battlefields on both
sides. Looks like all of these
battlefields are very much for
themselves and not really necessarily
going to be good for both players as we
see here's Forge on the side of Azir.
We've got the sigil of the storm for
Ezreal. So, let's kick back and start
off game number one.
>> Let's kick it off. We are going straight
in on sporge. That is a um a battlefield
I haven't seen today yet. Yeah, this is
one that I I was actually running in
Lucian for a while. So, uh when you
control this, your first non-token
equipment cost one less to play each
turn. So, you can now if you control
that battlefield, some of your one draw
one drop equipment are now free. You
don't even need to pay for them at all,
which is kind of crazy in a deck that
runs a lot of one drop equipment.
>> Yeah, that that's kind of a that's kind
of a big deal. I'm going to say it.
That's kind of a big deal. And we see
already the call the week played on turn
number one to get rid of a Raven Bloom
Student. That is someone who knows how
this matchup is supposed to go. They
know Raven Bloom Student is actually
very very scary. I needed to deal with
that now and use one of my more powerful
removal spells against it.
>> Yeah, taking away that early lead from
Ezreal is exactly how you deal with him.
You kind of take away exactly what
they're trying to piece together, which
are those cheap early game units that
gain them a lot of advantage and you
just push that back. And if Ezreal then
can't come back from there with another
cheap unit and keep developing that
board, it can spell disaster. And in
fact, we couldn't do that. So, we are
forced into bringing the Ezreal from the
champion zone.
>> Yeah, we're going to play Ezreal right
away. And actually discards the Arcane
Shift. Couple reasons for that. One, a
lot of players are playing around Arcane
Shift, making sure to not give the
Ezreal combat uh unnecessarily when they
have three energy up. The other reason
is that the card Fizz can actually recur
the Arcane Shift. It normally can't
because when you play Arcane Shift, it
banishes itself. But if you just discard
it, it doesn't banish it. It has to
actually be played.
>> I love using Fizz um to kind of make the
trash a secondary draw pile. You're
you're you're stashing that away for
later.
>> It's really kind of smart to be able to
actually have that as a resource that
you know you constantly have access to,
>> right? when you when you're playing
Ezreal, it now says put a card into your
hand still keep a card in your hand and
then draw two. So, it's just a draw two
at that point when you're discarding a
spell and you have access to Fiso.
Really, really strong. We're seeing the
Ezreal take first blood here. Get that
first point and pass it back over
>> straight into that sporge. They know the
value of its might and not wanting your
opponent to take that right now.
probably wise just putting a fight up
and Ezreal has a fantastic effect just
being able to draw so many cards. We
have managed to make that hand a lot
larger this turn. Um
Roto uh Roto I can't say that name. Roto
>> Roto
it's harder in my accent. Okay.
Roar has um a tricky situation now.
We've started to see the Ezreal come
into play. Your opponent has lots of
cards. They can do lots of things. So,
let's uh tenuously move this Lonely
Porro into Sig of the Storm. See if our
opponent has any reaction to that or
whether it is just we're going to score
that first point.
>> Yeah, there is actually a lot of
different options that Ezreal could have
here. There's a couple hard bargains or
sorry a couple of wages of pain, a few
scoopifies. So there's a lot of tricks
on the side of the Ezreal and Roerorado
actually just testing the waters to see
what they uh are able to uh get away
with here. You know, let's see what what
do you have in hand? Are you going to do
something against my Porro? Are you
going to choose something else here? You
going to are you going to wait and try
to protect your Ezreal? And it looks
like they have made the decision to do
that. Eye of the Herald comes down.
We've got our first gear in play. Well,
second. Sorry, I'm silly.
>> We've got Harold's. Poor Herald. He's
without an eye, but we've got it for
you, buddy. Don't worry.
>> Sand Soldiers looking after it.
>> Yeah, Sand Soldiers got it. If you need
it back, just just come see us. We'll
get it for you.
>> It's all good. It's all good. Two sand
soldiers so far. Well, the sand count
has begun.
>> Yes. Did we Did we get the uh the sand
the the accumulating sand graphic, man?
Did we?
>> I don't know. I don't know if we got
that done overnight or not, but the
count is at two. And oh, how about the
leader of the Saiyan soldiers himself,
Azir coming in down in the backline.
>> Azir joining in commander themselves.
A great addition might, you know, much
higher might naturally than these sand
soldiers. So, doesn't quite need any
equipment right now to to make them a
fearsome opponent.
>> Yep. And here is a
rare moment where the shields are
potentially down for a calm deck here.
If there's something like a singularity,
we could take out an Azir, which is
actually a real card. And then you don't
feel as bad about using the other half
of singularity on a sand soldier if you
actually get to take out an Azir.
And there are no spell there or there's
no energy on the side of Azir here to
actually interact with that. Just going
to go for a wages of pain. Take out that
porro. Get our gold gear. Get Ezreal out
of dodge and then pass the turn.
>> Keeping it simple. Ezreal safe. We've
got gold to spend. And we've got a
handful of cards that are going to be
able to be played next turn. Again, this
is how Ezreal does. It looks like you're
not doing much, but actually you're
building up to these big combo turns
later.
>> And there's a lot of there's a lot of
subtleties going on in the uh underneath
the game within the game, if you will,
where you know, on the one hand, we saw
Azir spend all of their energy last turn
maybe saying, "I don't have something
like a discipline or a pump spell to
save my units." Saying, "If you got
singularity, play it. I I'm ready for
it. And then of course on the Ezreal
side, they didn't have a singularity. So
maybe both of these players without
actually playing any cards there are
getting subtle bits of information,
doing the hand reading that we see at
these high levels of play in Riftbound.
These are all things that are being
considered in all of these turns, even
when a card's not being played.
>> Absolutely. You've got to take all of
the information given to you, even if
that's subtle nods, uh how many cards
your opponent has in hand when they have
certain amounts of energy, and then the
likelihood of them drawing into cards
with the amount of energy they've got to
use. So, when we're looking at cards
like Singularity and like kind of those
big ones like Time Warp, well, if you're
not on 10, you can't cast that,
>> right?
>> So, we know that it's safe. And so
actually taking the amount of energy
that your opponent has access to into
account can honestly save you a lot of
thinking.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Here looks like we are
equipping a brutalizer in getting a
conquer here for the sand soldier.
>> Slow and steady wins the race. Now we've
got two sand soldiers and a recruit
across two battlefields. And oh okay,
going for a stupify. We're going to draw
a card and reduce that sand soldier a
little bit. Just just make him a little
less mighty.
>> Yeah, make him a little bit smaller.
>> I like using stupify. Not necessarily
for the full effect, but because it's
not your turn, you'll get to uh because
you are gaining the advantage of the
card draw, it's progressing your turn
further.
>> Yep. Absolutely. And you not only not
only that, you're also giving one of the
two necessary procs or targets rather
for Ezreal which allows you to draw an
extra card. So stupify already a good
card when you draw one card. When it
draws one and a half cards with Ezreal,
it looks even better.
>> Exactly. So it's okay that it didn't
really have a an effect on the sand
soldier. It it doesn't matter because
the card has extra abilities thanks to
uh Ezreal's kind of passive abilities.
Yep, absolutely. And the conquer does
happen. The sigil of the storm is going
to recycle that rune there. We're going
to make a sand soldier.
>> Dude, what?
>> We're going to make a sand soldier.
>> The sand keeps flowing here for Azir.
And how about two more sand soldiers?
That's desert's call. Ring, ring, ring,
ring. It's guess what? More sand.
>> You know what? I think we need some more
sand soldiers.
>> Yeah. And we're thinking about the
weapon master here because again, it
does not matter that Azir himself didn't
make the sand soldiers. Nope.
>> All sand soldiers have weapon master. So
if you want to move one of those
equipment from the battlefield to one of
these sand soldiers in the backline, you
can. Looks like Roado chooses not to and
passes the turn back to
>> absolutely love passive abilities like
that. Just having that legend
allows you to always have weapons master
on all of those sand soldiers. Passive
abilities, I think, are some of the
strongest and most underutilized in the
game. And this is really showing where
the natural power of this deck excels.
>> Yeah, it's one of those things where you
go, "Oh, this makes, you know, two two
might sand soldiers. That's cool." Uh,
you know, we've seen other decks play
it. You know, just sometimes you want
four energy, four might. It's fine. Uh,
but also is you just get that added
benefit of sometimes being able to move
your move your equipment over. And looks
like we are jumping back here. Hi
everyone. We're just getting some things
straightened out in the game. But yes,
like you said, those sand soldiers or
Azir gives you that passive ability. I
also love myself a passive ability. It's
like something something that I have,
you know, when I'm playing Volibear only
I get the rune when I play a mighty
unit. It's like I like that ability to
have that
>> passive ability just for you.
>> Yeah, exactly. It's always on. Uh it's
it's either impossible to turn off or
difficult to turn off whenever a passive
ability is in play. And honestly, I
think that a lot of people forget about
them as well. It's it's not because they
don't respect it. It's just because
there's so much going on.
>> It's also been a very long tournament.
And so naturally, as we saw earlier with
Master Yi's ability, it can be really
difficult to remember all of the factors
in play, especially because it's not
something that is actively played or
activated. It's just there. It just
happens. It constantly exists. And we
have a lot of this in many card games,
but I think it's really well utilized in
Riftbound because it gives that choice
of the champion really to the players in
regards to actually do I want one that I
have to activate. I have to look at
cost. I have to see whether I can
achieve that cost and how quickly I can
and how reliably I'm going to be
utilizing that. I think one of the
reasons that people underestimate set is
because the ability is kind of expensive
when you think about it. And so it may
be underutilized within a game and
that's why a lot of people went over to
Fiora who although there is a cost to
that ability, it is worth it. It's so
advantageous. So you have to weigh up
the pros and cons when choosing a
champion. Whether you would like
something cheap, passive, or expensive,
but worth the risk versus reward,
>> right? Yeah. And you also the beauty I
feel for Riftbound is that you can lean
into or take advantage of the legend
ability to the extent that you want.
There are some decks that are built
entirely around their legend abilities
and there's some decks that
>> it's there.
>> It's there if I need it. It's like Jinx
I think is a really good example of that
actually. Um, a lot of people don't
think it's that powerful a legend
ability, but
>> in certain circumstance it is. And it's
not you're not striving for it. It's not
something you're actively going to want
to happen every single turn. You're not
trying for it, but when it happens, and
if it happens, that's great.
>> Yeah. So, good to be able to to do that.
And I think it's it's a cycle we see in
a lot of card games. we saw in Riftbound
in in early stage and we will see in
unleashed as well where it's Legend
comes out. I see what Legend is doing.
Let's put all of the cards that say the
same thing as Legend in a deck and I go,
"Ah, this deck's not really that good.
It's, you know, feels kind of like a
feels kind of like a starter deck. A
little bit clunky, like I don't need to
put why I put every ambush card in my in
my Rengar deck. Why isn't it working?"
And then you start to get iterations and
optimizations and it's like, "Oh, wait.
I can also play the old cards too with
some of the new ambush cards that are
really good and all of a sudden you've
got a real deck and we're playing in day
two of an RQ with it.
>> Creates presumptions as well
>> cuz the only bit of information you get
when you start a game of Riftbound is
the legend and your chosen champion.
Right.
>> Right.
>> And we saw yesterday that presumptions
could be quite negative
>> with a certain Kaiser deck that we saw
yesterday. You see Kaiser, you see
Kaiser as a chosen champion and you
think, "Oh, okay. I know what this deck
does. I know all about it. I know their
I basically know their entire deck
list." Wrong.
Wrong. And then setting up for the game,
especially in the early game, can be
>> you can almost you can almost put
yourself onto this one track that
actually leads you to damination because
you're you've accidentally kind of um
put blinkers on
>> and you've put the Kaiser blinkers on.
You can't see anywhere else and then
Rumble's over there and you're like,
"Sorry, what?"
>> Absolutely. And I've been actually
taking advantage of this in my testing
recently because I am still playing
Lucian, but I've been playing
I've been playing Lucian Aurora of all
things. And let me tell you, no one
expects Lucian Aurora ever. And
especially the Lucian player, the Lucian
mirror when I'm playing Lucian Aurora
versus a traditional Lucian is one of
the funniest experiences you can ever
have when they're playing all their
units and I go, "Uh, I'm going to play
Catalyst of Eons on turn two." And
they're like
>> I'm like what is that?
>> What? And then I play a roar like oh
you're just playing a bad volley bear
deck. And then I play the combo on my
cadre.
Yeah, it works out pretty well. It ends
up working out pretty well sometimes. I
mean it also fails horribly a lot of the
times, but it's it's it's the iteration
process. You've got to walk before you
can run. And maybe someday we'll see
Lucian Aurora in
>> Nobody expects Lucian Aurora. Not even
me.
>> No, no one does. I think there should be
a specific category. There's there's
best of Lucian and then there's Aurora.
There should be best of Aurora Lucian.
I'm putting it out that that's a freebie
for you. Ryan, there's a free idea for
you from the broadcast. I think that
that should also be a category for best
of.
>> Oh, it really tickled me. That was a
good one. Well done.
>> Yeah. Amy thinks this is a joke. This is
I know you're not kidding. And that's
the best bit. That's the bit that's
really tickling me is I know you're not
kidding. And you've made this
monstrosity.
>> Yes.
>> Oh my goodness gracious. Well, you know,
that's why you're on the desk cuz they
didn't want to let that loosen this all.
>> Yeah. They they they said, "Hold on. We
need to unleashed is next set. We can't
unleash this on the world yet." But
we're back into the game. I see a little
bit of a bellow's breath coming in here.
>> Oo, stinky breath. Then the sand
soldiers aren't a big fan.
>> No, they generally don't like that we do
get the free Brock of Israel.
>> And again, that just adds value. That's
always adding value to these sorts of uh
of spells is that we're getting extra
value for money. We're getting an extra
effect. And that's where when I was
talking about the value of your uh
legend versus your and your chosen
champion, this is where Ezreal has
always been considered powerful because
you're gaining so much. Every single
card essentially has that extra effect,
>> right? Yeah. Every card that chooses
something of your opponents has draw
half a card tagged onto it,
>> right?
>> Half a card rounded down draw uh put on
it. And Bellow's breath plus Watcher is
a wombo combo that we have seen many a
time here. It is going to be threatening
to kill not one, not two, but three
units on the side of Azir, including the
Azir himself.
>> Combo.
And that's where Thousand Tail Watcher,
even though considered a late game unit,
is great against a deck like this. You
don't need to go aggressive. You don't
need to accelerate it. You're just
wanting to reduce the might of those
sand soldiers who have already taken
some damage because of the bellow's
breath.
>> Mhm. Yeah. And you get to get that
damage on first and then the watcher
will reduce the might. The damage does
not go away. So the might gets reduced.
They say, "Hey, wait a second. You've
got one might and one damage. That means
you are going to the trash here."
>> You just kind of watch the sand soldier
fall apart. the armor clinks on the
floor and and that's that's it until we
can uh make some more come back. But
yeah, making sure that we take away that
recruit as well. He's out of here.
And the board state is significantly
less sandy now.
>> Yes, way less sand there. Chose not to
accelerate. The watcher could have
accelerated and potentially threatened
that other sand soldier. But that would
not only be paying the extra power to
accelerate. The watcher would also be
effectively paying another power because
you are conquering that sigil of the
storm. And as we've talked about
throughout the entire tournament, it's
not just but what you're doing on this
turn. It is how you are playing this
entire game. You've got to think about
the future.
>> And that's it. These prolevel players,
they're thinking five, six, seven turns
ahead. They've got almost the entire
game kind of set out in their heads. And
now it's their opponent's job to try and
thwart that plan. It's time for Arise.
>> Yes, we are arising here. That is one,
two, three sand soldiers by my account
coming in here. And of course, two of
them can enter ready. And they of course
again still have weapon master
themselves. So if they want to move some
of that equipment around, they are free
to do so.
>> Indeed, we are arisen. We have got that
board state back under control. Thousand
tail watcher did its job alongside
Bellow's breath, but those sand soldiers
come back easily and that's where these
sorts of decks like Azia can really pull
forward because you're able to recur
those units so easily. Thousand hell
watch is still in play though has a
mighty seven might and so that is going
to come into effect but when you've got
so many little units again we're doing
the same thing just throw one in score a
point overwhelm this Ezreal and you know
we don't have a lot to work with when
you're rug
>> we are looking to retreat the Ezreal and
says not today it's going to get defied
a defy.
>> Yes, it is effectively a two for one.
Not not a lot of the time that you can
turn a Defy into a two for one, but
being able to not only counter
>> the spell itself, you're also
effectively killing that Ezreal, which
is going to be great here for keeping
that board nice and clean on the side of
the Ezreal.
>> Absolutely. And that's what we want to
do is limit the amount that Ezreal can
physically do by pressuring them into
playing these big units like Thousand
Tail Watcher because they're not going
to be able to rinse and repeat that.
>> No, they they aren't. It's uh not going
to be able to get a lot of value,
additional value out of the Thousand
Tail washer. Now, of course, there are
ways to do it, but they are uh a little
bit harder. We may actually see one
here. Fizz on the Ezreal signature spell
can actually reby the watcher which
allows you to uh replay it. But that's
not what we're going for here. We're
going for the Bellow's Breath in this
case.
>> Yep. Going to going to start that little
combo again and Bellow's breath to put
some damage on those sand soldiers. So,
they're going to start out with uh
significantly less going on and then I
imagine we're going to try and kind of
finish those off in a little bit. We're
just assessing the cost there of Fizz
and then the Bellow's breath after the
fact.
Yep. So, we're just
figuring out which of these runes are
exhausted here. which are which are
spent and which were recycled. Yep.
>> Um there
go our handy dandy judge coming over to
save the day and have a little look see
and see which costs need to be paid.
>> Yeah, this this one of the interesting
points with Ezreal and with Fizz of
course as well is that like you said
before your trash is all of a sudden an
extension of your hand. So, every one of
these turns, even we already saw Ezreal
has like what, five, six cards in hand.
That's not to mention the five, six,
seven, maybe even more cards in the
trash that can be rebought with Fizz.
So, you got to think about all of these
interactions. What are you going to play
now? What are you going to, you know,
what card are you going to cash in with
your Fizz? Is it going to also have an
arcane shift which can then reby the
Fizz or Reby the All these things are
being thought of in all of these turns
and all these interactions. That's why,
you know, a deck like Ezreal I just
would not bring to personally would not
bring to an RQ because you will be
seeing steam coming out of my ears as
early as round one and I have a buy in
round one.
>> Gosh, that's Yeah, the Ezreal players
that are out here but are at these top
tables are phenomenal. They've got a lot
to think about, a lot to sequence
properly, and you've got to know when to
utilize those resources well, otherwise
it's all going to crumble and fall
apart. And I think with the amount of
card draw that Ezreal provides, you've
got to remember that actually, yeah,
discarding cards is just as powerful,
especially if they're spells. You want
to kind of use that extension of your
hand by cherrypicking the things that
you want to get back later. And then you
almost don't have the risk of them being
things like sabotaged either. Like no
one can do that. Your your fizz is a
unit so can't be sabotaged out of your
hand. And then you've got the spell you
need safe in the trash,
>> which is not something we'd expect to be
saying,
>> but it is almost a safer zone for it.
You don't want it in the deck. You don't
really want it in your hand in certain
matchups, but actually the trash is
perfect because I can just uh fizz.
>> I'll have that now. Thank you. And then
I'll play it right now so that there
isn't a risk of you being able to
interact with it from my hand.
>> Right. Yeah. We are at a point right now
where there's there's a few ways to
interact with the trash, but not a lot.
And not a lot with your opponent's trash
for sure.
>> Uh it is almost Yeah, like you said,
it's a weirdly safer place for cards to
be when you have access to
>> recur things from the trash like Fizz
does. But Fizz is a card that
>> has been it's been good since the
beginning. I think people saw it and
were like, "Oh, this is amazing." And
then it came down a little bit. It's
like, okay, it's not that
>> you don't want to be playing it in every
single purple deck every single time.
And now I think we're building decks
with Fizz in mind and he's really really
shiny. I mean this Ezreal deck is a
great example when you can set up with
your Ezreal being able to discard your
spells to effectively draw an extra card
or at least still have access to it. It
just gets really really good.
>> I think when you're building when you're
deck building especially with a deck
like Ezreal, it could be tempting to say
why am I playing Fizz? I could play a
cheaper unit and then I could just play
more of the spell I want and then I'm
more likely to see it again. But you
can't really think of it that way
because that's not what Fizz is
achieving. Fizz is not only achieving a
unit on the board, which Ezreal has
quite few of realistically. But also,
you get to use that discard pile uh
trash as a secondary draw pile. You can
use that to discard things, cherry pick
them later to reuse things. And you've
got more flexibility within that because
you don't you're not just relying off
those card draws. You're not relying
what's coming off the top of the deck.
you know what you've got and you can
strategize and plan around the trash
which is a much larger resource pile
when you think of it that way. So
actually instead of thinking about oh
but it's a unit and I don't really care
about that. I could just play more
removal spells like no you can't really
you've got to be flexible and that's
especially with these control variants
of Ezreal. Flexibility is exactly what
we need to get ahead.
>> Yep. And we are back here. Looks like we
have resolved the board state. Ezreal is
going to draw a card. We are seeing the
Bellow's breath played. Some units
getting removed. Fizz still on the
battlefield or Fizz still in the base as
well as the thousand watcher on the
battlefield.
>> Again, just giving ourselves that extra
unit.
>> Another Fizz comes down. We're getting
real fizzy over here as we grab another
spell. We're going wages of pain. Yep,
that is a wages of pain which is just
pure value. We're going to destroy a
unit here. Make a gold gear token
exhausted
while also making a Fizz. And what else
we have? Oh, our good friend Raven Bloom
student who is really managing the back
line here. You'll love to see it.
>> That's a lot of units for an Ezreal
deck. I don't hate it. I like it. I like
it. Thousand tail watchers still going
to stay in that base and try you know
seven might is considerable especially
when you're against sand soldiers
although once they get that equipment on
them they can be quite troublesome. So
let's see how our Azir player chooses to
combat this kind of overwhelming board
state when you think about it from an
Ezreal perspective. This is very unusual
board state but it's working.
>> Yeah it absolutely is. and Fizz once it
once Fizz is in play, he's pretty much
just a vanilla unit three might. But
Raven Bloom student is anything but
that. She is uh has the ability to get
very big. She is not vanilla. She's what
I would call very cheesy. Able to really
pile it on and get bigger and bigger.
For every single spell that is played,
she's getting even bigger.
>> Ezreal likes spells. Fizz likes getting
spells back and Raven Bloom student
loves to take advantage of those. So now
that we have kind of power on the board,
sand soldiers of course come back
quickly with Desert's Call and with our
ability. So we've already got three back
in play, which is pretty standard uh as
far as Azia goes. But that's all we she
wrote on that turn. We're back over to
Rub's turn.
>> Yep, this is Pivotal turn as usual. We
saw the build your own Arise turn, but
those did not did not enter ready, of
course. Wait, it's not actually a rise.
Uh, but still quite good value, but is
actually going to fall behind in point
tempo, assuming that Ezreal takes this
sigil of the storm. They're going to get
to that allimp important six points
first. They're going to do so at a
relatively low cost. likely sending a
Fizz unless they want to unless they
want to do battle and send up the Raven
Bloom student potentially, maybe even
sending everything if they want to try
to hold, but they don't necessarily need
to. They want to get to this six point,
set up in the backline potentially, and
then say, I'm going to threaten to win
next turn. Don't need to worry about it
now.
>> Exactly that. We're building up. Raven
Blue is going in, scoring that sixth
point. And now it's kind of okay. We're
we're at the stage where you can leave
those units there. you can just kind of
challenge both battlefields. You can
challenge for a whole point and it's
looking a bit shifty if you're if you're
your sand soldiers now because there's
there's not that many of them for what
we need to achieve.
>> Right. There is three sand soldiers.
Decent amount of might though not not a
ton. There's no BF sword back there.
There is, I believe, a there is a
brutalizer, which is effectively a is
effectively a BF sword on the turn that
you equip it. Um, but it's not
necessarily going to be it's really not
good at defense, which is what they
need. We're going to see the mind
spplitter come down and strip the hand
of a Roarado.
>> Oo, that's a huge mind spplitter.
Perfectly timed. We're on that six
points. We don't want our opponent to be
pushing ahead here. We have seen the
in their armor. We're taking
advantage of a slow turn that had to be
taken. We don't want them to be able to
come back from this. So now being able
to go into their hand, not only gain the
knowledge of what's in there, but also
remove a card.
>> Yep. And that is off the top deck now
for Azir. What are they going to be able
to do? They need to take both of well
they need to take at least one of these
battlefields potentially defend but
they're going to need to defend against
a lot of might. I believe 20 might in
the backline right now
>> with only one card in hand. We're living
on top deck city and it's an
uncomfortable place to be.
>> Yeah, I think I saw that was uh Herold's
other eye which is certainly I think not
going to do it. I'm no I'm no math
wizard, but I think 20 is bigger than a
lot of what's going to be able to be
defended here.
>> But unless we put up a fight, we're not
going to progress the game. We can't let
him just have the battlefield. So, we're
going to have to contest it. Going in
with the brutalizer, attaching it, kind
of like you say, being that pseudo BF
sword and challenging the Raven Bloom
student.
All right, we get to play acceptable
losses at action speed, which is going
to force the sacrifice of a gear of each
player's choice. Of course, Ezreal has
no gear in play, so it's it's a
one-sided. Each player destroys one of
their own gear, which is also, of
course, going to give the Raven Bloom
student plus one.
>> Tricky decision. Do we go for the Eye of
the Herald knowing that we have another?
If we need it, we've got one. Yes, is
the answer. And then we of course do win
that combat. So, we do get the point,
but it's going to be tough to keep hold
of it. So, at this point in time, are we
going to have to kind of build up on
that one battlefield? Are we just going
to have to put everything in and hope
that it's enough? But I I don't think
it's going to be enough. We've got so
much might on the other side there that
being able to
>> stop our opponent at this stage is going
to be a tricky tricky feat.
>> Yep, absolutely. It is it is a tough one
and there's so much might in the
backline like you said. I quick maths.
It doesn't look like it's enough. I
think Roado is even just deciding are
they going to even try to do it here?
And it looks like they are not. That's
going to be game number one here in
round 11 going to Ezreal.
>> Ezreal proving once again that slow and
steady does win the race. We have
managed to build that board up using
cheap early game units until it was time
to bring out the big guns. Thousand tail
watcher and mind spplitter not only to
disadvantage our opponent but also just
pose some really big threats on the
backline so that you know victory was uh
in sight there.
>> Absolutely. I did see a card in the
sideboard of Ezreal Hick pocket which
normally is used to destroy seals or
destroy gear or sorry to destroy uh gold
tokens but uh it does in fact say one or
less. So some of these one cost gear
which are actually very very important
for Azir can actually be picked off for
value with the pick pocket. So that can
actually be quite a devastating card to
see for Ezreal.
>> We've said it once, I'm going to say it
again. Gear got better. So gear removal
also got better. And having it in your
sideboard, no matter what deck you're
playing at this point, I think
everyone's at least considered one gear
removal card. And I think most
sideboards include them at this stage.
>> Yeah, unless you got to respect it.
>> Yeah, unless you're of course playing
against me on Lucian, in which case you
don't need that gear removal at all.
Don't no need for gear hate. We love
gear. Don't don't need it. You just
don't need it. But uh yes, I am going to
keep spreading this misinformation about
how to play against Lucian specifically
when I'm playing it. Uh but I think
everyone knows yes, you want your gear
removal. You want uh it did get a lot
better because gear got better. Like you
said, it is very, very strong. Some
decks like Azir, like I know Lucian, and
a few others are completely built around
gear and utilizing them. Then we even
see decks like Aurelia who aren't
necessarily built around gear, but very
heavily use them.
>> Yeah. And the gears that can be crucial
to your overall strategy,
being able to take those away. Yes,
please. And that's why we see even
Arshan and things like that who is able
to take those away from people. We saw
it in the last game that we cast
together that was used to very full
effect and honestly it can be the sort
of uh turns that completely change the
pace of the game and can give you that
opportunity of a comeback.
>> Yeah, absolutely. We just saw the I mean
we really did see the Ezreal game plan
come through. There it is. Control the
board, keep up with the cheap units, and
then control the board, clear the board
out, and then potentially
overdevelop there and get that big swing
near the end. Here we see Marai Spire on
the side of Ezreal with the Trafarian
War Camp here for game number two.
>> That's a pretty good one. Marai Spire.
When you control this battlefield,
friendly repeat costs cost one less.
>> Yes. So, of course, Ezreal going to be
taking uh full advantage of that
battlefield, but Azir does have a few
cards. Of course, the Desert's Call is a
repeat card, so maybe able to even get
value himself, but I think for the most
part, Ezreal is going to be the one that
is taking full advantage of that.
>> Absolutely. And again, it begs the
question, do I use the Trifarian War
camp to prevent that combination of
Bellow's Breath and uh the Thousand
Tower Watcher that we saw last time, or
am I taking away the excess repeat cost
from my opponent? So, the decision of
which
battlefield you're going to move into
here could be a little bit tricky.
>> Mhm. Absolutely. Yes, you definitely
need to You're wanting to consider it.
It is not just an easy, oh, I'm going to
take the Mariah Spire cuz I get an extra
ability and I'm preventing my opponent
from one. Yes, that's true. But also
then I of the Herald is a lot better
when your recruit is a two might instead
of a one might. And having extra units
at the Trafarian War camp effectively
makes your board stronger. And that's
exactly what Azir is thinking here.
That's Eye of the Herald making that
recruit token, getting that first point
of the game. Yeah, you get an extra
might per unit and we can make those
real quickly
>> and you can just overwhelm the opponent
in that way. And honestly, I think it's
a really great shout. We've got our Dor
and shield, another piece of equipment
down. We've got our gold that we can
still spend at some point going ahead.
Sand soldier on that. Holding on to the
gold for now. And we've got a couple of
energy to wiggle around with if we need
it. Yeah, having that energy up is of
course always going to be very strong.
We see a pair of Bell's Rest and the
Watcher. We see the acceptable losses,
which
>> is a great card in this matchup. The
problem is you can't really cast it now
because you cast a card sharp and gave
your opponent a gold. They said, "I call
your bluff. I want that gold. Thank
you."
>> And that's the problem. card. Although
great for advancing your own game
because you get a gold, but if your
opponent chooses to take the gold, it
can be a little bit tricky.
>> Yes, I would say that the free gold gear
token that my opponent gave me is an
acceptable loss that I can take in this
scenario. And we're seeing a bellow's
breath actually get discarded from the
Ezreal. Of course, as we've mentioned
many times in this game, Fizz does have
the ability to potentially get that
back, but still one Bellow's breath down
in this case.
>> Trafarian War Cam really putting in some
effort as well there. Bellow's breath
not being as valuable as it could be
right in this moment. So, stashing it in
the trash for later kind of helpful.
You're just putting it at the top of the
trash pile. You're like, "Okay, I'll
just leave that on the top and I'll come
back and get that later." It's hovering.
>> No one's going to go in there because
it's the trash. Yeah, it hasn't it
hasn't broken the seal of the trash.
It's hovering above the seal of the
trash. You can still you can still get
it later, right?
>> It's okay. It's the 3-second rule,
right?
>> Exactly. It's only been in the trash.
It's a three- turn rule. If it's been in
the trash for three turns,
>> you can still eat it.
>> It's still fine.
>> Wait, what are you doing with these
cards in the trash? Wait. Uh anyway, we
are back here. Azir has now taken the
turn getting that hold point, which it
is not only the hold point that you're
getting. you have the ability to move
that Eye of the Herald around. And when
you do, that is going to create even
more recruits. Now, you have to ask the
question, do you want to move it out of
the safety of the Trafarian War Camp? I
don't know the answer to it, but Roado
is going to be figuring that out as they
play a Brutalizer for this turn. See
what the rest of the turn leads for
them.
>> Brutalizer really does look like just
that. I wouldn't want I don't want
anyone to hit me with that.
No, I I think I can pretty safely say I
don't want to get hit with any of the
equipment that is currently in the game,
including Harold's weird eye that is
randomly missing.
>> I was going to say the the eye I'm like,
"Oh, yeah. It's a bit creepy, but fine."
Uh the shield. Yeah. Okay. Brutaliz. No.
No.
>> Just the the the squishing noise is what
I think is really going to is going to
do for I won't I won't do it for
broadcast. I don't think broadcast is
ready for me to do the squishing noise
on camera. Maybe maybe for the top
eight. We'll save that. But uh yeah,
that's that's not the pain. It's the
>> it's everything else about the eye of
the herald that is creeping me out here.
>> More equipment. And it's all going onto
the same sand soldier. We of course get
the bonus for the brutalizer on this
turn. So we are going to be moving that
straight on in to Marai Spire.
>> Yep. And this is we talked about this
yesterday in the Azir match. We saw this
is a scenario where fighter flight would
be a really good card against this.
Would basically stop the whole turn.
would strand the equipment on an
exhausted unit. Well, fighterflight does
not exist anymore in this format. So now
>> don't have to worry about fighter
flight. We are going to see the action
speed acceptable losses here. So choice
needs to be made from Rod. They're going
to go ahead and hit that eye of the
herald on the other battlefield.
>> It's irrelevant right now. It's not
important to this. We have more eyes. We
can have them later.
>> We do. That's that that's that's what
everyone says when they lose an eye. Ah,
I've got more of those.
>> It's okay.
>> Poor Herald.
>> Just go down to the store and grab
another one.
>> Waves of pain. Looking like we're
wanting to make those gold tokens again
for ourselves.
>> Make a gold token. Also put three damage
on to the sand soldier.
>> Which currently is, I believe, not going
to be enough. I think we're off. Yeah,
we are currently off by one might here
to actually take down the sand soldier
and not going to happen here.
>> Such a shame when you don't get to quite
use it for full effect, but maybe the
gold token is important for a future
turn if Rub has some important cards in
hand that are going to cost a little bit
extra.
>> That is also again it's technically draw
half a card. If you're able to get
another choose this turn, you can pop
your Ezreal, which is not irrelevant for
sure. Not sure if they're going to get
the ability to do so, and it looks like
they may not.
Another sand soldier comes into play.
Weapons master activates, and we've
moved one of our equipment from our
existing sand soldier onto the new one,
bringing our sand soldier and recruit
back from Trifarian War Camp, assuming
they're a little bit safer. But
actually, I wonder whether they are
still in danger due to Bellow's breath
kind of them not having that extra might
because of the Trifarian War camp might
bite them.
>> Yes, it it very well may. And also
little bit of an optimization thing
here. We saw them move the units back
there. could have moved before that
combat with the eye of the herald and
there would be one more recruit in the
battlefield now or in the base now. It's
possible that because the sequence of
the turn happened the way it did that it
changed what they were going to do. But
if they were going to move it there
anyway, they could have gotten that
recruit beforehand and maybe that could
have changed it. I don't know if that's
necessarily correct. It's just something
to consider here as another acceptable
losses is played and that is a Dorne
shield hitting the bin.
>> Mhm. acceptable losses coming back via
Fizz proving that we're we're afraid of
this equipment. The sand soldiers on
their own, they're okay, but when you
get to build your own and you get to
kind of put your own unit together using
all this equipment, it does become
rather terrifying and we're limiting the
effect that Arise can have.
>> Absolutely. I think that is you hit the
nail on the head. That is the absolute
biggest reason here is that Arise really
can turn the tides here. And there it
is. The Bellow's breath repeated is
going to do it. Now
>> that will take it out. Now, of course,
uh the extra recruit in this case would
have gotten hit by one of the extraneous
Bella's breath targets, so it didn't end
up mattering, but still something to
point out in case it might have. Yeah,
still a consideration to make. And
again, we're always trying to assess
whether we're using all of our cards to
their fullest potential. And in this
case, it didn't matter, but it's always
worth considering.
>> There's a a
theoretical game state where it would
have mattered, but it is not here. So,
we move along and we're now at the same
point tempo here currently. If Azir is
able to conquer this other battlefield,
they're going to get that allimp
important fourth point which will put
them ahead. But the hand looks a little
bit clunky. And now that some of these
equipment have gone,
>> even not feeling good.
>> Yeah, even a top deck arise is not
looking as good as it once would have.
>> No, not at all. I mean, we would get
what, two sand soldiers out of that, but
that's a little bit lackluster because
you're using an arise, but it feels like
a desert's call.
>> Yeah, an expensive Desert's Call is not
usually where you want to be.
>> We're instead going to play guards.
>> And yes, you have to say it like that.
It has an exclamation mark in the text.
You have to yell it. It's canon.
>> That's why I let you do it.
But gourds does equip the brutalizer
with the with the weapon master here and
it can enter ready which they choose to
do. And that is going to go for that
fourth point here. Contesting the Ezreal
on the Trafarian War camp.
>> But that is not necessarily always a
safe bet when the opponent has cards in
hand and energy available.
>> But it was all a bluff. Ezreal goes down
or it just wasn't worthwhile spending
the energy
>> right now. Ezreal wasn't worth saving
right now. We've got other things we
might be able to do later. And now we're
using Desert's Call and we do get more
sand sold.
>> Actually, the Marai uh the Marai temple
is actually relevant because they only
had three energy left. So, they're able
to use the reduced cost of the repeat to
make both of the sand soldiers. This is
actually crazy.
>> Chef's kiss.
>> Beautiful.
>> Being able to utilize your opponent's
battlefields. We've seen it once before.
We're seeing it again here. Not just
your own, but your opponents can be so
advantageous to your end game.
>> Yes. And we are seeing here we see a
thousand tailed watcher, we see another
Fizz, we see a mindslitter. Lot of
decisions here on top of a wages of pain
as well. again like Fizz allows you to
you see him fanning out the disc the
trash there because we're considering
what the other options are with Fizz and
we're using it like that excess kind of
pool of resources that we have access
to.
>> Yeah, we're going to see a Fizz come in
kill a sand soldier that got stupified.
That's going to conquer that battlefield
up to a third point. Now, their repeats
are going to cost less, which is
relevant here because there is a Fizz
and a Bellow's breath in the trash.
And that might just be what's about to
occur as we kind of get that energy
ready.
And here comes Fizz. Or maybe not. Here
comes Fizz.
>> There's Fizz.
Question is, what is being targeted
here? Oh, it was the bellows. That was
instantaneous. They knew what they were
doing. You were absolutely right.
>> Always going to be bellows.
>> Going to take down two sand soldiers
for effectively free, but it's still it
cost runes. It's not nothing. You do get
to recoup a card with Ezreal, of course.
>> All that hard work to bring back so many
sand soldiers and we're left with one.
>> Yep, just the one. And there she is, the
Raven Bloom student in the backline.
>> Always studious and ever so good at
learning from those spells, learning how
to get bigger every time one is cast.
>> Absolutely. And leaving anything on a
battlefield when your opponent has a
Raven Bloom student that can attack and
cards in hand is a very tough call to
make to say the least.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I would say that it's uh not
a unit you particularly want to be left
kind of hanging around, especially when
we get into those spells slinger style
combats, which uh these decks are both
known for. So, I think that that really
goes to tell that this is not something
you want to leave alone if at all
possible. It's time. Go on, do the
thing.
>> Guards,
>> thank you. Uh going ahead and grabbing
ourselves uh another unit which can be
readied. Um, and we're going to, of
course, do. So,
>> I think they need to make an alt art.
Now, this is another I know I've been
saying we you get one for free, right?
But here's another free one. It's a
Nexus Knight promo card. That is an alt
art of guards, but it's judge.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I love it.
>> I think I think that should be a uh that
should definitely be an arcade promo or
something.
>> Yeah, absolutely. With a gavl as well.
Like the whole
>> the whole thing.
>> The whole shebang. Yeah,
>> I think that's a great idea. Here we go.
Sand Soldier challenging Fizz for that
Mirage Spire.
Looks like we're going for a retreat.
The added value with Fizz. You can bring
the Fizz back to then play the Fizz to
then use the retreat to then retreat the
Fizz again if you wanted to. Now, of
course, then the retreat would get
recycled. So, it's not an infinite
cycle, but uh you can uh you can spin
the wheels a bit if you'd like.
>> You can indeed. We also get another
little rune exhausted there, which is
nice. Good tempo for Ezreal. It's what
we need to be able to keep up uh with
all of this sandy madness on the other
side of the board is always being able
to come back. Now, we're only going into
his turn with two sand soldiers this
time. So, maybe Rub can uh kind of take
advantage of that weakness now.
>> Yeah,
>> we're low on points. for low on points,
but opponent is absolutely not low on
points. Few resources potentially here,
but Ezreal needs to thread the needle
because there are still cards on the
side of Roorado here. There is not a ton
of energy for Ezreal here to be able to
play all of the cards in their hand.
They're going to have to pick and choose
and if one gets countered they need to
be able to see are they able to come
through anyway.
>> Raven Bloom student trudging into the
trifarian war camp just to gain that
extra point get us get us that momentum
get things started. Now the nice thing
is our opponent doesn't have a lot of
cards in hand. There's only two sand
soldiers. There's two equipment but
there is also always the potential of
making another sand soldier. So even if
you were to disrupt your opponent's
hand, even if you were to take cards out
of it with Mindsplitter, you've always
got the opportunity to make more sand
soldiers. So it doesn't necessarily
matter. You can you can squeeze them for
every unit they've got and they can
still make another sand soldier.
>> Yeah. Any equipment off the top of the
deck is just another unit that you can
play that can wear these equipment and
all that. We're going to play a Fizz to
the battlefield. likely going to get
back a
at least potentially going to get back a
wages of pain. Maybe the bellow's
breath. Nages of pain.
>> Nice and clean.
We've got a five might unit with three
damage on it. We can use two or get put
three more on it, which would of course
threaten to destroy it and get another
gold gear token for your troubles. I
love this kind of bouncing Fizz back to
yourself to be able to play it again and
get that really strong effect. Fizz is
showing showing off really why it gives
that flexibility to your play style. And
I think it gives a lot to the various
matchups that you're going to have to
traverse throughout the day, especially
when you come up against things that you
maybe weren't expecting as much. Azir, I
don't think was something that people
were preparing for in quite the capacity
they clearly should have been. Um, so
maybe as something that would trip up
certain other deck styles. However,
Ezreal is so flexible with the way that
they play that they can pretty much get
out of any situation.
>> Absolutely. Azir definitely is one that
was on people's radars. I can't say that
it came out of absolutely nowhere,
>> but like you said, it was not at the top
of people's uh gauntlets that they were,
you know, testing against. was almost
certainly Aelia that followed by Draven,
followed by Kai'Sa, followed by Victor,
followed by like
>> I was going to say the only kind of
similar style deck that you see being
played that people might have prepared
for would have been Victor and the play
style against this deck will be similar
to that of Victor.
It is a bit similar for sure in terms of
the being able to generate those units
at a very consistent clip, but the
problem is that it actually ends up also
playing quite differently because
it uh uh plays a bit of a more control
variant there. But Azir hanging over in
the chosen champstone able to come in
accelerated, move that giant unit over
and take that winning point for game
number two.
>> All of that gear removal just wasn't
enough. We managed to kind of squeeze
everything out of the Azir as we could.
Took down the sand soldiers. Essentially
did exactly what we did in game one, but
it just didn't work out this time,
>> right? And you know, cards like
acceptable losses and the other gear
removal are strong against Azir. They're
necessary against Azir, but Azir doesn't
necessarily care when you kill one
particular piece of equipment. They just
want a number of equipment and they're
going to get value off of them.
Especially when they get to choose what
to actually destroy. Oh, here's a
Doran's shield I'm not going to use.
Here's an Eye of the Herald that's
already made a recruit. I don't really
care after that. It's just I just want a
number of equipment in I want a number
of gear and equipment in play to be able
to get that value off of Arise. It's
getting tense now. We're in round 11
here at the regional qualifier in Le
and this is the impactful game of the
series. This is the round where you need
to be in it to win it.
>> Absolutely.
>> These players are not in the clear for
top eight yet. Both of them need this
win to progress. We're on 82 apiece on
Ezreal and Azia. Who's going to win the
third match of this fight and see it
through and get closer to that
championship title of our regional
qualifier?
And we see here Targon Peak as the
opening battlefield for Ezreal with Vile
Lair on the side of Azir. Taran Be of
course we've seen it time and time again
be a very very strong battlefield when
you are going first and have a play on
turn one. If you're able to conquer that
Targon speak first you are at a massive
advantage and we'll see if Ezreal is
able to pull that off or if they're just
going to pass. No turn one unit.
>> Oh, we don't like that. We don't love
that from Ezreal. Really, what you want
to be doing is getting those cheap units
down. A lot of the time, an Ezreal
player will mulligan towards that. And
we didn't quite pull it off this time.
So, I have the Heralds going down. And
of course, what we going to do?
>> We are going to make a sand soldier.
Every single time we see an equipment,
we're going to do that. It is almost It
is not impossible to miss when you're
going second. Here we've got that early
acceptable losses, but uh again, this is
a relatively acceptable loss on the side
of Azir. If you had to choose an
equipment to have to get rid of, it's
probably eye of the Herald a lot of the
time
>> and and this early in the game as well
kind of you did what you wanted to do.
You made the sand soldier had an
equipment. It doesn't aim more. Oh well.
>> Yep. And we see wages of pain come down
to try to stop that target peak. But no,
that is a defy.
>> And with not a lot of energy because
we're so early in the game, that defy
goes through without a hitch.
>> Yep, goes through without a hitch. Now,
this does slow down the game plan of
Roado a little bit because they would
have definitely liked to have played the
BF sword and made a sand soldier with it
rather than just a Doran's blade. But I
think getting that conquer, getting that
targets peak is certainly more important
than just developing another equipment
in unit.
>> Absolutely. And you know, being able to
get that pressure of having this early
game point when there's nothing on your
opponent's side of the board as well,
that's kind of huge. Going for a
stupify, I imagine just for the card
draws.
>> Yep.
>> Just again to give us all of the options
that we're going to have to work with on
this turn. and Wages of Bane again. Here
we go.
>> Here we go. Stupify to draw a card and
prevent any shenanigans there. Wages of
Bane finishes off the unit. And of
course, when they both have draw half a
card on them, you get to draw that card
with the Ezreal Prodigy.
>> Here comes Raven Bloom Student. One card
that you don't want to see early on, but
here she is to play. And we've got a lot
more resources to play with now with
that gold token additionally. So, we're
going to need to start seeing some more
Sandy shenanigans from Azia to really
push forward. Going for that second
point. Okay, the BF sword finally here.
And of course, we're going to plop a
sand soldier to wield it.
>> Yep, why not? Let's get the one of the
best equipments that you can get with
Azir and uh get a nice sand soldier as
well. Get some runes ready to keep get
that second point, which is oh so
important. and keep the pressure on. And
now it is on Ezreal to see what are they
going to be able to do. How are they
going to try to answer this? It's going
to start with a Fizz.
>> Well, it's coming back.
>> Looks like I'm assuming maybe a wages of
pain would be a nice clean
potential kill here. would we have the
potential for it
>> could also be the acceptable losses
could be a stupify as well to say hey I
need to draw a card here
>> yeah I need to keep pushing forward and
it is going to be the stupify on this
occasion sand soldier not feeling as
wise in this moment
the Raven Bloom student obviously
benefits from that stupify makes soldier
go down it's almost like the Raven Bloom
student just took a little bit of a
brain cell from them.
>> Yes. Took one grain of sand and put it
in their hand here. It is now three
fighting into two. A lot of resources on
the side of Ezreal and three on the side
of Azir as well with some cards in hand.
But it had to decide is this a fight
actually worth taking. Says nah, not
yet.
>> Nope. Early game. We've still got our
equipment. That's the important stuff
right now. Sand soldiers can come back.
Equipment is forever. Wait, no. Uh,
that's not right. Uh,
>> not always.
>> No. Equipment is the name of the game
here, though. That's what we want to
keep developing so that our RIS have
maximum effect. And as we saw in the
last game, our opponent was quite eager
to be getting that gone.
>> Yeah, trying to get rid of that
equipment as fast as possible. And there
is a pair of two drops here. We're going
to get two runes readied from a target's
peak. Of course, Raven Bloom student
sitting at top the peak right now in
danger a bit or at least being
threatened here. We of course see a
decent number of cards on the side of
Ezreal. And it is much like getting into
a fight with Aelia or getting into a
fight with Vex. Getting into a fight
with Raven Bloom Student is not always
the safest.
>> No, they're going to try out some of
their new spells that they just learned
on you. And sometimes they're quite
dangerous. Sometimes they can just
explode.
>> I wouldn't want to be in that line of
fire.
>> Okay.
>> Looking like we are taking the fight to
the sand soldier. That's going to be
hard to come back from. So I imagine
this sand soldier is probably going to
go down, but it is our last one. So is
it worthwhile kind of fighting back on
that? We have the energy to do so. On
guard, I say.
>> Yes. It was uh 3 to3. It is now 5-3
on the side of the Azir. We've got the
retreat just to get the sand or sorry
the Raven Bloom student out of trouble
here. Valuing having those resources.
Valuing having Raven Bloom student. And
looks like Roado is going to conquer
which of course is going to proc the
target peak. It's going to get another
point. Mhm.
>> Are they going to be able to get this
third or they got the third point. Are
they going to be able to get this fourth
point is the question.
>> Hold point's going to be difficult here.
So to get to that fourth, we're going to
have to take that bottom battlefield. We
need the V's layer or we're just going
to have to leave it until next turn,
which if you're wanting to really put
the pressure on your opponent, you want
to try and score that fourth point now.
Yeah, you would like to score, but
again, you don't necessarily want to
leave too many of your resources
stranding if you don't have to. So, this
is a this is a very key moment of the
game here. We are going to play the
Arise for just two equipment, but that's
okay or for two sand soldiers rather.
That is going to get two ready sand
soldiers into play.
>> And that's the key part. They're ready.
They're ready to go. And so we can get
to that fourth point. If it wasn't
advantageous to do it, we wouldn't be
doing it. Two sand soldiers, not ideal.
We do want a little bit more than value
for our uh energy usually, but in this
instance, actually going up to four
points is really important. So pushing
for that now is worthwhile. We're not
expecting these sand soldiers to stay
there. We're not usually gaining points
via holding. That is rather irrelevant.
We just need to get this fourth point
because it really puts us in the
driver's seat of this game. Three.
>> Yeah. And notably, of course, Taran's
Peak procking there was just going to
ready two of the runes there. Having
three energy versus having one energy
opens up the field of cards that you can
have quite a bit. So, Ezreal is going to
have to play a little bit more
cautiously. Going to start by playing
our chosen champion there. Get a couple
of new cards.
>> We need them. Our hand is looking pretty
thin and sparse as it stands. So, Raven
Bloom Student, who our opponent already
knew about, is going into the trash at
this stage. And now we're looking
towards what to play because we need to
start with some harsh removal on some of
these sand soldiers. Fizz just going in
there taking out the easy one. We knew
that there wasn't really going to be a
push back because that's not what these
Sun Soldiers are about. They're not
necessarily about
holding. And right now for Roto Ratho,
they are ahead in points. So they don't
mind if their opponent is gaining via
conquer.
>> Yep, we are seeing the arcane shift
happen. That is going to banish the
Fizz, then you are able to replay it,
which of course when Fizz is played, he
gets to then recycle a car uh recycle a
spell and recast it as well. Yeah, the
arcane shift kind of uh Fizz Fizz
disappears for a minute and then flashes
back into play and we get to reestablish
that ability. It's an incredibly
powerful spell. Like you said, a lot of
people have been playing around it,
which is fair because it's so powerful
in combination with Fizz.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And we see both of
these combats or effective combats
happen. No pump spell played on the side
of Roado. I think we may have seen at
least one if there was one. So Ezreal is
going to have that hand read of unlikely
to have something like discipline or on
guard or if they are they are saving it
for a very specific moment but this is
potentially the moment right now only
one unit left on the side of Roado
playing that arise last turn either
means they really didn't have anything
better to do or maybe they have a second
arise but uh it is not a sign of power.
I wouldn't say if I'm sitting in
Ezreal's seat.
>> Yeah, Rub is at this point with their
Ezreal deck kind of using resources very
wisely. They're not overextending, but
they're doing enough just to push back
at Roarato, who unfortunately is in the
point momentum lead right now. And if
they stay that way, they're just going
to win. And it is game three. We can't
let that happen. So, we need to start
piecing together our own board in the
back while also just continuously
dealing with these sand soldiers.
>> Yep, we've got the Fizz there with the
frigid touch.
>> Annabella's breath.
>> Bellow's breath. Yep, we are removing
the unit. And now again, there is
Accelerate obviously on the side of
Azir. see it uh in the chosen champion
zone of course,
>> but the
not having anything on board is
certainly not a place that is super
great to be.
>> No. And there's a few cards in hand at
this stage as well. I think we've only
got three, which again kind of signals
to your opponent that you're starting to
falter. The momentum in your play is
going to start to lose pace. So although
we're ahead on points right now, can we
back that up? We need units now.
>> Yep, absolutely need to do something
here. Desert's Call, not bad. I mean,
it's effectively the same number. Well,
it is literally the same number of units
that the Arise made last turn that an
Arise this turn would have made. Of
course, does not have Accelerate, but it
is still that board presence. This is
not likely going to be an attack turn.
It's going to be a set up and get things
going turn. There's a shears. There's an
Azir proc.
So, we have got
the
>> that allows us to grab our sand soldier
and pop them onto the shears. We have a
couple of energy left. So, of course,
we're going to put a por. We've got zero
cards in hand, which
is an interesting kind of predicament to
be in. Yes. Mind spplitter.
>> Yeah, that's true. It's a weird way to
play around mind spplitter, but it is a
way. Having cards in your hand is
knowledge and knowledge is power. Being
able to take that away from your
opponent and them getting the read that
there's literally nothing you can do.
There's no way for you to respond. Even
if you had energy up, you've got
literally no cards in hand, so you
cannot respond. That gives your opponent
so much freedom on their turn. There's
no whatifs, there's no buts, there's
just play. Yep, absolutely. The board I
mean not looking bad on the side of
Azir, but we are
potentially I mean we're actually still
technically ahead on point tempo for
Azir. But there it is, the pick pocket
we talked about in between the game
being able to destroy one of those
equipment for free and also get a gold
gear token is just so strong.
>> I think being able to pickpocket a whole
shield is really impressive. They
clearly are skilled. Yeah. Where I mean
you just just putting it under a shirt,
using it as a backpack. Yeah. Yeah. I
had this thing the whole time. Don't
worry about it.
>> Oh, and we're bringing it back. Wow.
Okay. Going again with that combo we
mentioned earlier. Fizz is back in the
hand. We can reuse that later to get
back from our trash and just keep on
going. Going to spend a gold token there
as well. And again, that just kind of
allows us to stash resources so that we
can carry on playing this turnout. We
can play the Bellow's Breath and not
have to overextend. We're going to use
that other gold token. Of course, we
just need to pay the one for the
Bellow's Breath. And then we can go
ahead and
>> Yep. We
>> damage these sand soldiers.
>> Yeah. In the rare scenario where you
actually choose to reduce the energy
cost of Bellow's of the additional
Bellow's breath rather than the power
cost with Ezreal, you're able to just
spend power to pump up that repeat on
the Bellow's breath with Ezreal, remove
a few sand soldiers and go from there.
Now, the thing about this for Azir is
that they still, if they get to six
points this turn, they're still
threatening to win on the following
turn. Now,
>> the problem is they've got one card in
hand,
>> and I don't know what that card is, but
>> we are potentially, looks like we may
actually be in turns right now. We've
gone to time. This is actually the first
round on broadcast that we've gone to
time. I forgot that that was even a
thing. I honestly haven't been paying
attention to the timer. I'll be honest
with you, because I was so glued to the
game
>> that it completely passed me by. We are
within a potential wins scenario because
of points. So, we we're still looking
good for being able to close out this
game.
>> Yeah, it does certainly look like it
would potentially be a possibility
to win the game. We see the acceptable
losses happen and the sacred shears gets
taken down which is it's a tough pill to
swallow considering you really want to
be able to draw some cards and not going
to be able to now that the shears is
gone makes future arises worse. That's
an eye of the Herald. Our good friend
Harold coming through here with his eye.
going to make a sand soldier. Yeah.
>> And possibly play the Azir from the
champion zone as well, I imagine, just
to continue to press forward. Even if we
don't accelerate it, even if we just
kind of have it in base cuz we have the
energy to do so. We get the extra
recruit, which is great cuz that's what
we need right now is bodies on the
ground. We need to be able to uh stand
up a little bit against this backline
that we see that Estreal's built up,
>> right? And there is the
sand soldier there. We're seeing Azir
get played. Yep. In the backline. We are
face up here. No tricks to be had.
Ezreal has free reign here, but notably
at five and not six.
>> That's a huge difference, especially in
Riftbound. We need to get to eight and
we can only really gain two this turn.
So, this isn't going to be a winning
turn. But if you can take enough power
away from Roarato, then we could be in
an advantageous position to win the
game.
>> Yeah, we need to send this in to you.
You have the ability to set up exactly
how you want here. There are no tricks.
There's no cards in hand. There's no
onboard tricks here. So, you can set up
the combats exactly how you want as
Ezreal here. So, it's a matter of
figuring out the puzzle. What is the
best way to do this that leaves you in
the best position to defend against what
is in play? And one random card off the
top.
>> It might even be worth just holding back
here. We're on six now. We need eight to
close out the game. So, taking two
battlefields next turn might be better.
Or we can just go ahead score that
seventh point so that we are in a
stronger position knowing that our
opponent is low on units. So, we're
going for the Plundering Porro in there,
grabbing that seventh point. We also
generate that gold token, which again
might further our stance for next time.
And just going really all in on VMO's
layer.
>> Okay, we pass the turn over. We see a
card drawn from Azir surveying the
battlefield, seeing what they have
access to. Are they going to be able to
do it?
>> This is so tense. They could go either
way and both players need this win.
We're at 82 here and round 11 of our
regional qualifier in Leo.
>> Okay, off. We're floating in energy.
We're going to equip the BF sword.
>> Where's it going to go? We're just
counting up there. We've got 10 might
total on Valour's layer. We need to be
able to take both battlefields, but that
would secure a win. We're going on the
sand soldier to begin with and we're
heading in to the porro taking that
seventh point
and now it's just about that bottom
battlefield. Can we deal with it or do
we build up knowing that it's going to
be difficult for our opponent to put
anything in there?
>> Okay, it's an on guard
is here and we're going in.
>> We're going in. I love
>> I'm bringing everyone with us. Come on,
chums. Another mistake.
>> Wow. The Ong Guard able to get it in the
end there. Azir taking down that match
against Ezreal and keeping the
tournament life alive.
>> Phenomenal plays and Fortuit's top decks
brought us into the winning spot just in
a nick of time. Yeah, absolutely insane
there. And I mean this has been it's
becoming the talk of the tournament
here. Azir is over performing. It is a
deck that was not in really that top top
echelon of people's discussions coming
into this. I think everyone said uh
here's the top decks. It's Aurelia. It's
Draven. It's Kai'Sa. It's maybe Victor.
And then there's a bunch of other decks
that can also win. I am one of those
people that said those things. Don't
worry, you're not alone. But Azir has
risen to top. We've seen Rexi. We've
seen a few other decks really putting up
not just a oh one of the best of decks
is doing well. We'll see a random deck
in top eight. It's like no. Azir and a
few of these other decks are really
making a run for the actual win of the
tournament which is crazy.
>> Honestly, the fact that we've now got
that just arising to the top of our
event. We're going all the way now.
Being able to go with X2 in to the next
round is just phenomenal. Being able to
overcome Ezreal and its flexibility and
the bouncing of those Fizz, being able
to continuously grab back those spells.
It was impressive to see Azir overcome
that. Yeah, being and we we said before
an expertly piloted Azir is a very very
scary thing and I think we are going to
see a bit more of this as we progress
through the tournament. But that is it
for this round. Of course, we saw it go
to time, but we do have some interviews
over with barcode.
All right, guys. We're back. I've got a
booster pack right here, and you can get
it. But first, we'll have to find this
card. You can ask me anything. Now is
your time.
>> Okay, let's go. Um, what energy cost?
>> I mean, one energy and one power.
>> One energy, one power. Uh, one energy,
one power. Is it uh blue?
>> It is not blue.
>> It is not blue. Is it green?
>> It is green. Actually,
>> it's green. Is it spirit forge?
>> It is uh not spirit forge.
>> Is it origin?
>> It is origin.
>> One energy, one power. Is it a spell? It
is a spelling one and it is defy. You
get a booster pack actually.
>> Are we cracking it open right here?
Right now for the
>> What do we get in there?
>> For the arico.
>> Okay. Okay. Cert Wages of Pain. Very
good card.
>> Temptation. Sun shifter. Big pocket.
Nice one. Approise. Not so good. Forgot
many.
>> Big pocket.
>> Another one.
>> Air. And ah
>> okay. So which color is it?
>> The color is green.
>> Green. Is it a unit?
>> It is a unit and a very good one.
>> What's the energy cost?
>> The energy cost is five. No power.
>> No power. Green five. A good one. Uh is
it a champion unit?
>> It is actually a champion unit
>> that has a legend.
>> Yeah.
>> And five green that has a legend. Is it
set one? It is set two.
>> Set two. Uh, is it a is it a female
character?
>> Absolutely.
>> It's Ireelia Green.
>> It is Ireelia Green indeed. So, you've
got the booster pack. I mean, sometimes
things are very simple. Congratulations.
Here is the booster pack. And here is
the card.
>> Are you ready?
>> Yes.
>> Perfect. Let's go.
>> Uh, is it a purple cup?
>> It is actually a purple card.
>> All right. Uh
is it banned?
>> It is not banned.
>> All right. Um
>> how much it cost?
>> It is like a two cost but also have a
power cost.
>> Is it a common one?
>> It is actually a common one.
>> It is rider win.
>> It is rider win. Congratulations. This
was the card. So here is your booster
packs
is going to be unleashed real soon. But
what car do you expect the most from the
set? Uh the card I expect the most is of
course the bewitching spirit because I'm
an Israel player and I want to play it
make someone discard play aren shift
make discard play retreat replay and
remake discard so I waiting discard a
lot
>> for me v hotaded overnumber bike
>> I'm excited to play Baron because I'm an
Aurora player
>> it makes sense
>> yeah and I'm really happy that it's time
too soon.
>> Yeah,
>> one of the main card I expect is the sin
nature spell from Rengar, which is uh I
think a perfect way for a deck that want
to play with units to just dodge
removals because such decks are always
weak to removals and this spell just
allows to dodge a removal and then in
the same time conquer on the opposite
battlefield which is a crazy insane.
Yeah, I I I think I will personally
really enjoy the the card.
>> I think it's Donna purple because in
Israel it will be amazing.
>> Same colors as Diana for Israel.
>> Maybe Reg Renar signature spell or star
crossed. It's broken. Star cross is a
crazy card. So yeah.
>> Uh I really want to play Vex. So I would
say the purple champion unit Vex. Really
excited for that card. I think uh it
will really offer a new game plan, new
possibilities for set three. So, really
excited about that card.
>> I really like the Vex overnumber.
Normally, I'm not like really into
collecting the rare cards, the expensive
cards, but that one really caught my
eye. I really want to try and get that
one.
>> I'm expecting Elder Drake to be very
popular in Dazzling Aurora, and I enjoy
a lot Dazzling Aurora, so might just put
some elder on the board and win some
games.
Time for round 12 of RQ. Le James and
Lothar taking you through all of the
action for this round. And now we really
are determining who are the top top
players this event. Earlier I was kind
of teasing us with who's going to make
top 64, that type of thing. Um, now we
actually are looking at who is getting
those last spaces and last wins on the
road to top eight.
>> Those going to be important matches, one
of the most important matches maybe of
your entire career because not always
you're in a spot when you're going to be
playing for a potentially a way to get
into the top eight, right? So, uh,
remember that with some of the players
might just not even played the last
round because they might just get a
draw, right? and that's it and just get
in for the top eight.
>> So that's also a thing.
>> Yeah, always have to do the calculations
of are you iding at any point. We'll
we'll actually make it a little bit
easier for everybody and show the
standings and we can take a look at
exactly where everybody is. So this is
the top 32 players that are left in the
tournament of course I think um
>> there's a lot of in there a lot of
Aurelius couple of Rocklo is there as an
Azir. We've been talking about Rocklo
across the weekend. Mstasio, a Rex side
player as well, potentially in the
running. Uh, all of these players on
this uh part of the screen. There's no
question they have to win. Like a win
here gives you a chance. I believe
>> it's going to be very low. It's going to
be low chance.
>> Very low chance.
>> When we look at then the next uh screen,
it should be the top 16 players. These
are the ones where now if you're 10 and
one, these are the ones.
>> Yeah. You know what? actually probably
uh out of the running for it. Now that
I'm looking at the math here, uh I
really would say the cut off is likely
at the the 13 players that have 10 wins
to their name are the ones that we're
looking at. So going from their
prismaticisms there, animation module we
saw on screen. Um
>> lot of big names, but you know, not to
to to hit someone perhaps while they're
down, but Allen's name does not feature
on this list. So our reigning champion
has been dethroned. But I think is
pretty much official at this point with
the the standings as
>> definitely like he's if he's not on this
first page.
>> Yeah, exactly. He is not likely to be
anywhere there. It's not like uh you
know there's no like money in the bank
contract type thing from wrestling. You
can just cash it in and uh be in be in a
final.
>> Quite quite interesting standings when
it comes to the legends. We have a lot
of variety over here.
>> Yeah. Yeah, exactly. A lot of variety.
Uh we're we're following a couple of the
different legends here as we come into
the last few rounds. We are of course
looking at the the top table. So there
will be some similar similarity over the
rest of the games. I think you know
we're we're wanting to see surprising to
say wanting to see a little bit more
Draven uh and we get a master match up
at the same time. So days gone by we'll
be like oo another Draven match up but
actually at this point in the tournament
we've seen not so much on featured
matches.
>> Yeah on feature match I think this is
the second or third time if I'm not not
mistaken. Master Yi is also appearing
minimum the second time. At least today
it's the second time and Mi is
absolutely making some appearances in
the top tables. In the round before the
top table was uh Bick playing against
Azir the um and that was essentially
Master Y versus Azir but I also seen two
other Masteries as well in the top
tables. So Master mid-range deck is
actually making a splash. But let's talk
about this Draven mid-range. Anything
surprising over here? I'm looking
through Teemo. There is
>> There is a Teemo that uh
>> highest team ever been.
>> Best off Teemo. No, not really cuz
you're not in the chosen champion zone.
Um yeah, there's a few different things
here that that just, you know, standard
in different lists of Draven. I always
am surprised, even though it is normal
to see Edge of Knight, I'm always like,
"Oh, there's an Edge of Knight in
there." Like, we do see it from time to
time. It's been in a lot of the
mid-range decks since the the deck was
made. Yeah, there's potentially a lot of
hidden cards here. We have tight turner.
We have um edge of knight. We have the
tee. We have uh something else.
>> Switcheroo can be hidden.
>> Yeah, switcheroo. So that's four
potential different options when it
comes to the hidden cards. So there's a
lot that has to be played around once a
card is hidden. So this is why you have
so many one-offs as well to just make
your opponent question yourself. And
>> come back to Teemo in game. Let's talk
about that as well because I I think I
have some some thoughts on that as we
look at Master Yi this time around. Uh
one thing to know that we're not on
Unleashed. This is not quite the Mastery
that we're looking for uh for today as
Master Yi uh still the one from
there we go the one that gives plus two
to a unit when it is defending. Let's
take a a little look at the list. I'm
assuming it's going to be fairly
standard as well from what we've seen. a
little bit different because this one is
a um let's say a lot of people are
innovating in a way they're implementing
like for example fervent
>> okay
>> so that's one of the inclusions
>> and here we have a little more previous
metag game version where we do have ruin
runners mostly right and then the navor
card is a four energy drop with no power
cost
>> yes you were talking about that
yesterday a little bit is that the
reasoning is you don't damp to play a
n'vori scout compared to some other you
>> well definitely you're trying to put
that to battle like Kaisers for example,
you know, it's like this is what a very
annoying unit for Kai'Sa to deal with,
right? Because four four HP, four might
is not an easy number to get with
removal and then the deflect essentially
makes almost every single spell just
super clunky to use against it. So, it's
a very like just weird unit to deal with
as a Kaisa for example against a master.
That was one of the main reasons why I
have it in the metag game. Um but in
this case um
>> Urelia Fever is just another step in the
evolution, right? We know that uh Ruin
Runner is just a little bit awkward
because of the six cost
>> and it's like you cannot damp at any
point in in the previous um if you're
going first like you cannot damp if you
ever want to play him on turn three for
example. So a little bit more restrained
in a way that you have to play the game
with fervent. Sorry for to cut you off.
With aia fervent, you don't have to do
anything because she doesn't have a
power cost and she's has a similar role
to nav scout and to ruin runner.
>> But in in this deck, right, it's the
navor scout version rather than Aurelia.
So that's something that we may see
later throughout uh the rest of the day.
We're talking a little bit about Teemo.
While we have a stack deck resolving, uh
I want to kind of bring back just one
benefit maybe of a Teemo. Um, one of the
things that made Draven really annoying
to play against is things like spinning
axe that can't be countered, where it's
like you add power to a battlefield that
can't be defied or can't be reposted or
can't be, you know, insert counter spell
here. Teemo fulfills a similar uh spot
where he's going to add four might to a
battlefield uh and just out of nowhere
come out. Okay, I'm going to turn this a
little bit. I don't necessarily think it
is a a must play or anything like that,
but when I'm looking at what would the
reasons be to run a Teemo, that feels
like another version of that effect.
It's also has a synergy with the Draven
Legend because it adds another body,
which makes it easier for you to win a
combat and stay relevant on the
battlefield to draw a card. Right.
Right.
>> Um yeah, so uh Teemo is nice as a just
adding a little bit of spice in the
potential hidden cards essentially. Uh,
another thing I wanted to talk about
here, we have Forge of the Fluff for the
Draven as the first battlefield. And the
reason for that is because we can now
swap the position of the spinning X, for
example, will be on a safe unit. So, it
doesn't get like overrun because you see
from the board state alone that maybe
like the unit with the spinning X will
lose. So, you can move your um spinning
ax to a unit that is in the base.
>> But, this is one of the unique things
about Riftbound where uh Sean, I was
looking at their battlefields. They run
Forge of the Fluffed as well. And in
this match up, you're like, "Oh, well, I
will utilize that forge of the fluff and
has tapped the Master Y in order to
attach the Trinity Force." So, we'll
kind of skip a little bit of the uh
Dramp that perhaps you might expect to
have come through on that.
>> It's actually incredibly impactful over
here when you think about it because not
only you save the one energy, right, but
you force your opponent to do something
about this hold otherwise you're getting
two points.
Yeah, that's the that's thing that's
that's that's the thing that is
happening right now. And Sha is getting
just two points with this one Sense
Soldier.
>> So now you get to have six runes on this
turn rather than the five where you
>> Wait, is it a Trinity Force that is
being played on underneath it?
>> I think so, wasn't it? We were showing
Trinity Force in the bottom right.
Apologies if that wasn't correct on my
side. I just assumed
>> I just assumed Yeah, that you're right.
>> It was. And we we were showing it. There
is one in hand, so that very well may
be. And he has gone up to three. Yeah,
it must be. I was like a little bit
uncertain because we didn't go to three.
>> Uh we are trying to win the game.
>> You cannot have two trinity forces in
League of Legends. No. So that this is
like gamebreaking.
>> Tons of winning points uh on this now.
Uh two two runes up. Two runes in a
master. There's there are quite a few
things that is a Kaiser of course is
going to be able to
battlefield. Ooh, but not too much.
That's going to help.
>> Not too much to break this.
>> We have We have six energy, I think.
>> No, seven. So, we can play a Daruse into
a two drop. This could be a Teemo or
right the wind to try to combat the sand
soldier with the six might. But the
problem is there's two open energy
potentially a punch first, a discipline,
maybe unguard, maybe two unguards,
right? So, when you count the Yeah. the
the amount of might that can be added
with um with two energy for a master Yi
is pretty high. Like worst case
scenario, it's actually plus seven punch
first and ungod.
>> Yeah. And you know this is a really
really rare circumstance. Wow. That's
actually just Ferris 4unner.
>> Oh my.
>> Just accepting that my opponent's going
to six. This is a very rare situation
where your own battlefield choice is
going to bite you really quick in a
game. We don't often see this like this.
>> We've seen it. yesterday, but it was
like chunked.
>> Yeah, but it it's never this fast where
you're like, I play a battlefield and
and my opponent is going to six.
>> The God will draw multiple cards and
yeah, win the war of attrition.
>> The reason I want to say that's
impactful, yes, you probably could have
played two Trinity Force anyway, but not
DMPing is what allows you to have the
extra resources available there to have
two up and play around that. And now on
this turn, you can just get to play
whatever you want. Um, make sure that
you have control over the battlefields.
This is a really tough spot. So I
understand it's ferris 4runner to
represent a push on the next turn.
Obviously you lose if you don't uh
dethrone this sand soldier on the
battlefield. So
>> of course like the sand soldier here
represents six when it comes to like
spells and stuff, but when it comes to
defense is going to be an eight as well,
right? So
>> yep. Yep.
>> Uh when I was saying like plus seven
from the hand, you have to completely
forgot to mention that the plus two
basic from master as well. Yeah, that is
uh one of those effects that is really
easy not to to count for. Okay, so this
is saying you actually need to take both
battlefields this turn. So now it
depends how big can that sand soldier
get. That is uh was that
>> this sand soldier now is going to be a
six on defense going to stay there and
porro is also going to be a six on
defense
>> on via lair. So now I really like this
play by Sha because it sets up like
>> it diversifies his win condition.
>> Two roads to winning off this and you
have to ask both of
>> one point right in this case and it
doesn't matter if he holds it with the
Trinity Force or not, but he just
divides the amount of might that is on
both battlefields. So it's very clunky
for how do we read his name? Kamzy.
>> Yeah, let's go with that. And and this
is a direct result of battlefield
choices for Draven in game one being
banned out. Reaver's Row was always one
that you could reliably say, okay, maybe
I'm playing that game one. There there
were others choices that you could make,
but having to swap to other battlefields
has has put us in a situation where,
okay, I'll try Forge of the Fluffed.
>> Maybe we could have chosen a different
one. You know, you never have to start
with the same one.
>> True. True.
>> Yeah. And
>> but I think for seeing this down the
rabbit hole of Trinity Force is not that
easy. Yeah, exactly. So, both of those
units now are representing a trade with
the Ferris 4 forrunner and you have to
deal with both units because otherwise
you're just straight up losing, right?
Kai'Sa is not strong enough to go
through the defenses of any of the units
on the battlefield. And so, those are
two drops by the way.
>> So, it's it's Darius plus what as an
option? I I haven't been paying
attention to uh
>> there's also right to win
>> his hand which can like help Darius on
top
>> activated. Yeah.
>> Um
we have the Dar
>> there is Darius. So four remaining up.
So there are options like this game
isn't over completely. It does depend
that as you said there's a ride the
wind. But the problem is that even
though if you break those battlefields
right here and you
>> don't lose this turn, you still have to
play around what your opponent is going
to be doing next turn and next turn is
like most likely from the the champion
zone and then throw the the Trinity
Force back on it as well.
>> So how do you deal with that then?
Right. And now you still have to
calculate your opponent has free energy
open was almost not spending anything
like he didn't use any spells before
essentially. So, do you think he doesn't
have anything in hand? It is a
possibility, but you have to calculate
that as well.
>> Thonk. There were a lot of cards that
were painful in this moment. And Thonk
is perhaps the most brutal to just say,
well, now you just got a Kaiser at four,
so what else have you got? Hard comes
through and that's going to get
referred.
He's like, you got me here.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> that is key. I I saw four going and I
was like, you don't need to repeat it.
And luckily he realizes he doesn't
either as uh only one rune available for
Sha. So now what else is there? One
there. If there is a punch first in
hand, it kind of has to be now. Um or
you could save it for the lonely power
if you really wanted to. But that Darius
does untap from the hard bargain.
>> Mhm.
>> Will get the extra plus two might as
well. I hope our players don't end up
forgetting that. That's a significant
change in this game.
>> Who's dying here? The Kaiser is dying to
deny the card draw
>> and also to deny the two mechs, right?
The two bodies the other side
>> as they are actually would be giving
back the Draven a little bit of tempo.
>> Yes,
>> in this position. So that's something
that Sh doesn't want to do and it's a
very smart assessment of the situation
of the and the board state. Now we see a
seven attack to six might
>> on guard.
>> And that's the on guard. And if you
don't have anything,
>> there's a ride the wind, right?
>> You can write the wind the um diffuser
for honor and help out.
>> But you kind of have to because
>> you have to, right?
>> Yeah. Depending on what else hand I I
mean I see units. Yeah, it's going to be
ride the wind.
>> Yep.
>> Ferris 4runner comes over.
will of course uh put this battlefield
now in favor of our Draven player.
>> The thing is now that you cannot move
those units back because this is via
muzzle as well.
>> Oh wow, that is huge. Yeah, you're so
right.
>> You can I feel like what can happen here
is Shan might not kill any unit. Wait,
he decided to kill it
>> which is going to give the two mechs,
right? But if you kill the Darius and
the four
>> No, you cannot kill the Well, you could
you could kill the Darius, right?
Because heard on guard. So you should be
up above the Darius.
>> So I'm a little bit surprised
>> to give the mechs because otherwise
4Runner is stuck on the Violet Moors and
you'd end up in a situation with the
Anyway, let's go forward. Um mechs are
now in base. There's also a hidden card.
>> Could be four cards now. It could be
Switcheroo, Teemo,
>> Teemo, Switch, and uh the
>> Edge of Light.
>> Edge of Night. Yeah, we got that. It's a
it's a quiz on which of the the cards
are are still hidden. So in the worst
case scenario is plus four might for
Master Yi when it comes to breaking that
battlefield. He's completely tapped out.
It's a five on defense and so it can go
up to nine. I'm not certain though that
Sh will even calculate that there might
be a plus four. He would probably just
say plus three with the edge of knight.
But now he's drawing a card from
conquering the of the fluff
>> from being a seven. And honestly,
through all of this, I kind of had
missed that there was a first mate there
as the second unit cuz I was thinking,
ah, you got to conquer both this turn.
But that's not too difficult when a
master is going to come in readied. It's
just down to the hidden card. And in
this situation, in the old meta, you'd
think fight or flight, but in the new
meta, you have to consider other
options. We gave you the four choices
from it. Which is it going to reveal a
hidden Teemo?
>> It's a Teemo. And now it's just down to
is there enough power left in the hand
of Sha to get this conquer through
combat tricks and end up winning the
game. So Teemo gets played. I believe
that's nine.
>> Yeah, that was nine. I wonder if there
are any like counter spells for Sha. Oh,
also one of the reasons why maybe he
allowed the Federon to die last turn was
to essentially force the defender to do
something first because otherwise he
would have be attacking six into six.
>> Yeah, I was going to say, is that the
calculation? So, so you know that you're
attacking with both. I think that's
actually the line that you're talking
about. Uh
>> so attacking into a five.
>> See, that's why I'm never saying someone
made a mistake on the broadcast because
you I I might just be missing something.
Someone else might be missing something.
Maybe there's a different complete
different line of play.
>> Oh, no combat trick in hand. Is there
something else though that can be played
out? We haven't seen Sha's hand in a
while. I I do the same thing where I
stack my hand on the table. I realize
how annoying that can be when you're
trying to see trying to see what's in
the in the hand.
>> They didn't utilize any of the Trinity
Forces, though.
H
>> Am I missing something?
>> Yeah. Am I missing something? Were they
on the battlefield?
Did they go to trash? Did they
accidentally go to trash when the units
were picked up? And he should have
>> No, no, they're here. He's attaching
them now right now. But I'm a little bit
surprised that he didn't attach it to
Master Yi
>> for the for the mighty attack.
>> He did control for the fluff.
>> You saw his um body language. I feel
like he just made it forgot about it
moment.
>> You're right. I I cuz you had forge of
the fluff could have could have zero as
well and then pay for the other one
before attacking but yeah let's let's
assume that maybe he had a different but
>> okay so now we get to five points from
Kamzi or
the K is silent
>> and the X is silent
>> yeah as well
uh it's one of
We scooping it.
>> Are we scooping?
>> We'll we'll get confirmation. I see the
the uh the game tally has been added to
Sha's side of things. So, it looks like
um
>> like there wasn't enough in order to to
disrupt that battlefield with the the
hold on the Trinity Forces. So,
apologies for losing a little bit of
track of of that end game. I think uh
Sha was uh surprised to get to seven
points quite so quickly after that. And
so were we, if I'm being caught off
guard. So, so were we. I was not quite
expecting it to go that quickly as um
now we look for game two. So, Draven in
the sideboard. Um I have to feel like
So, first of all, this is Sha's
sideboard for uh the master. So, where
do where do you what do you bring in at
this point? Not so many spells that
you'd want to counter. We're talking
about exactly that with the spinning
axes and maybe Teemo, that type of
thing.
Well,
it feels like to some degree we didn't
get a lot of informations from this game
as well.
>> So, the amount of sideboarding that can
happen from Master Y side is actually
not that big. It's more on Hamzy's over
here who's going to probably go into the
mind spplitters. Like the information is
so crucial,
>> specifically when you play against the
decks that are green and they're like
having those tricks in their hands,
right? Would you say that was kind of a
warped game one? Because I think if you
only look at game one, you'd be like,
"Well, gear removal makes sense." But I
don't think game two is going to play
out in the same way. So, you don't
actually don't want it, right? And
that's my point is like
>> somebody that maybe doesn't know this
matchup might look at it and say, "Well,
the Trinity Forces were the problem."
Well, maybe only in that isolated
incident, but uh you have to draw them
and then have the ability to play them.
So, I agree on the mind spplitters
definitely seems like one way to go.
And if the if the removal for the gear
is going to be one thermal beam, it's
like that's a super expensive card. So
to like affect one card from your
opponent that might be played even
before you have a chance to use uh the
ter the beam. So that's one of the
things that you have to consider as
well. And in many cases like okay there
might be a guardian angel and that's
probably more important but then it's
like the board state is affected more by
the by the guardian angel even though
it's a less expensive card than the
trinity force. Yeah. And I guess you
also you play uh spinning axes. You play
Edge of Knight, so you kind of don't
want to thermo beam. Uh yeah, it's
really awkward. Um really really a a
strange game one in order to come into a
game two decide how you're going to
change it. Uh wouldn't be surprised to
see Forge with the fluff here from
Master
>> and we said it might not go the same
way.
>> It might not. Uh we'll see what we are
going on to for game two as uh as we
update.
>> Sean is very animated with his
reactions.
>> I love that though. I like that
>> there is the forge of the fluffed second
one.
>> Okay, so we have targets looking to
forge of the fluff.
>> If it happens again,
>> I would be so surprised.
>> Deja vi. Are we in the matrix?
>> Didn't get to see the hand. It's okay.
No trinity forces now. They have to come
off the top. This is Yeah, this is this
is like a consistent hand is is my
feeling on that. You got a turn one
play, you got good turn two plays. On
the other side, uh Draven playing
overzealous fan turn one I think is like
the quintessential spirit forge turn
>> to open the game.
>> All right, now we have It's so different
when you don't see a windmill slam of a
Draven Vanquisher on turn two. It's just
like sometimes it was a consideration.
Or maybe I'll just play him on the
battlefield alongside the fan, you know.
>> Yeah. Oh, that felt so brutal to try and
play around.
>> So, now we have the trigger from um
Tagon Speak. We're going to get two
energy up. Oh, there is the
>> thermo beam.
>> Okay.
>> Wow.
>> We do have a spinning axe as well. So,
probably try to utilize the axe before
we have the chance of using the thermal
beam. Also, there might be a zero chance
of using the herring beam in the future
if no equipment is being drawn from
>> Exactly. And and we've seen that Shan's
hand is is unit focused and unit heavy
based on the, you know, quote
traditional master that we've seen over
the weekend. Uh, but that's kind of like
the thing about a closed deckless
tournament like this is if you only see
Trinity Forces as like the winning
combination from that game, you're like,
well, maybe my opponent's running a
weird list or maybe my opponent's
running an equipment only focus. But
here you can see the impact of the
bands. Instead of a Draven Vanquisher
being being played this turn, you have a
game jammer and nothing else. That's one
of the reasons why there are two schools
of building a new way way of Draven,
which is either including some three or
four drops or just including more two
drops instead.
>> This is Tran saying, "I want a card. I'm
going to make you lose that overzealous
fan one way or the other. There's no
reason for you to uh push me back unless
you want to deny me a card. I'll take
the trade. I'll I'll get the unit. I'll
get the card." Mhm.
>> And we can move on with the rest of our
turn. Wouldn't be surprised to see
Stellorn her to come down following
this. It's actually going to be a
desert's call.
>> Yeah, this is called with repeat for two
units, which is nice. Now it's going to
be able to utilize
>> both directions of the battlefields
here. And also because Kamzy had four
four resources open
>> this turn. You didn't want to like even
give him a chance of utilizing anything
right now, which is kind of nice because
Cheams essentially wasted the turn too.
Yeah,
>> like he played the two drop but doesn't
really impact that game that much.
>> And I guess if you play Stellorn Herter,
you're vulnerable to like falling star
if opponent wants to take that choice.
>> I mean, you're still vulnerable to um
falling star over here.
>> But I don't I mean, you do care about
two things, but the comparison between
losing a vital unit like a Stellicorn
Hurder is I think the the thing that
titer,
>> we're swapping the two drops. Not that
that has mattered much.
And now remember also that there's a
define in hand of short.
>> Okay.
>> So that's going to be something that
it's going to be very important to keep
track of. And also remember that falling
star cannot be defined,
>> right?
>> Power cost.
>> Second power cost makes it undefiable.
>> But piercing light is something that
really doesn't like doesn't like defy at
all.
>> And you got to know your ins and outs on
that. You got to know which which
counter spell hits which thing. uh what
you can't catch with the counter spells
in hand. That's something that again for
newer players, you've really got to
drill that. You got to just play it
again and again until you know it.
Here's so it wasn't in hand at the
beginning. So now will the thermo beam
pay off cuz there's no equipment on the
battlefield for uh Kamzy.
>> But that's very interesting situation
because now Kamzi has to make a
decision. Do I play spinning axe
to win over the opponent? Most likely
unless Sha is going to buff his unit.
But then if you want to tame beam this
the sprinty force, your spinning ax is
going to eat it as well.
>> Uh but if if Sha wins his combat,
spinity that spinity force I mean yeah
he's going to win the combat. He's going
to die off right temporary will spinity
force will get out of there at that
point. Uh punch. Wow, that is
>> that is a big commitment.
>> A big commitment. And but that then
shows you how much the Trinity Force uh
strategy of holding in Sha's mind is is
necessary potentially.
>> A reactive right the wind.
>> Okay.
So we're using the right the wind to
move out our tide turner to the or
battlefield
>> I or to base. There was a tap in the
back.
>> Right to base.
>> Right. Yeah. It's the the beneficial one
of charm to base. uh yet will get
brought back. Um noting that Targon
speak was conquered this turn. So this
tells me thermmo beam is not coming now.
You wouldn't do this if you were going
to blow up your spinning ax anyway.
>> Definitely not. But it is kind of
interesting because you could attack the
forge of the fluff. It would have been
five to four forcing Sha to use another
spell. I guess are you are you ex all
exhausted and therefore don't want to
follow up something that that then turns
>> your resources are pretty in a bad spot
like you're going to be at
>> after that right to win if that if that
attack would fail you're going to be at
>> six resources and you will have two and
a one might unit in the base not looking
great into breaking potential defenses
of a mastery because now we have a four
four defense on forge of the fluff and
we have four uh six defense on Tagon
speak and two energy open for the defy
and potentially for a unguard or a
discipline depending on what the
opponent does. Now Kami has to play
around all of those options. You have to
now think about how do I sequence this
to make sure that I don't fall into a
trap of a potential unguard defy unguard
punch first punch first defy and
disappear.
>> I don't remember.
>> Did I miss something?
>> Possibly. I I was too distracted by the
runes and the units and the gear all
being side by side. I like I can see it.
Luckily, I have the the vision here, but
I this if this was my board state, I'd
be like, I can't handle this. Like, I
need to move.
>> Understand this.
>> Uh so, some big big uh cost things in
hand for for Cami is there's a ferris
for and a thermmo beam. And as we said,
you wouldn't save the spinning ax on the
unit if you were just going to thermmo
immediately after. I like the planning
with the right to wind because if you're
able to do the conquer on forge of the
fluff this turn with more reasonable
like positions maybe then you can
transfer the spinning axe after you
conquer the fluff and then maybe go into
the other battlefield as well.
>> Yeah, that's true. That is very true.
And uh the showdown going to begin
>> and we pushing with two units. Very nice
play because the the reason in many
other cases you would probably attack
one by one but because Draven wants to
win the fight.
>> Yes,
>> you have to win with at least one unit.
>> You want to get the draw.
>> Yes. You want to get the draw. And in
this case, even if one of your units
dies, um it's okay because you get the
draw from the top of the deck.
>> Yeah. Which is so different to like the
Azers that we see that want to cascade
the equipment uh from unit to unit. Uh,
as you said, very different dynamic
>> in how that plays out.
>> Sean is thinking hard about this
showdown. 74. What does he have? What
What would be Oh, a twang for the five
might.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's going that is actually that
is something that I didn't mention. See,
I missed something. And twang is
actually the worst case scenario because
the thing is you cannot now transfer the
spinning axe. It's
>> ah yeah, you don't conquer the
battlefield, so you don't have control
over it.
>> I mean, yes, you can.
>> And it's stuck on there as well. You're
right.
>> And the unit didn't die, so the spinning
X is just sitting there idling.
>> That's that's what you meant by it.
Yeah, I I understand what you mean uh on
that. That's a very fair point as uh
again, the mastery
static ability, let's let's call it that
potentially. The legend ability is uh is
going to give that sand soldier the plus
two. That's why it didn't end up
trading. And for the again those of you
that perhaps don't play against a whole
lot of Master Yi, you've always got to
remember that when you're defending
alone, you're going to get that.
>> Look, I will tell you one thing. If you
ever missed a trigger of of sorry of the
passive of Master Yi in one of your
games, don't feel bad. I know pro
players in our game who are missing it
constantly.
>> You count up and you're like, "Yeah, I
think I got everything." You move in and
your opponent's like taps the legend.
Yeah, it it happened more than you think
in at regional level at like 101 101 um
boards
>> forced to transfer at that point uh by
not really having any choice as the
lonely pro is going to go over to the
battlefield. Sand soldier will come back
again saying if you are going to conquer
this battlefield I'll get a card from
it.
>> Mhm. And we get two points from Trinity
Force by the way this turn as well. So
>> that that is actually happening again.
>> Oh I said forced the transfer. What I
meant was the spinning axe was off the
unit, but of course that will be
temporary and dies in the beginning of
the turn. So it does go over to the
trash. Now it's just the ferris 4runner
and a treasure hunter.
>> Rebuke is being as well drawn.
>> Oh, but none of these units you don't
really want to rebuke. Like it's two
sand soldiers. Yes, it's
>> sold removed and the um
>> force is resolved as well. You can
attack with the treasure hunter to
target dragon speak and then use rebuke
mid combat to see if your opponent if
they have a not so fast well unlucky but
if they don't then you will draw a card
as well because you do it mid combat and
you win the combat because of it. So
that's one of the options that we can
>> we are able to do as the Draven player.
You can also just go and trade
potentially trade sorry uh with the sand
soldier that has the trinity force when
you push with the ferris for hana or you
can just start the turn. Oh, a judge
call will be now done. So we're going to
be let's talk a little bit of now.
>> Yeah.
>> So potentially you can also go into into
the combat and then pass. It's going to
be six versus six. your opponent might
do something, might play like a buff and
then you might just not respond but the
next when you get priority you can play
your thermal beam and destroy the
trinity force, right? Because it can be
used as an action and then essentially
you negate the value of a potential buff
with like a discipline for example,
right? So you still end up trading but
the thing is
>> it I don't know if this is worth it like
use again just playing for this board
state doesn't win you the game. you have
to think ahead. It's like what is the
thing that I'm going to do after this
turn? And it does like any of the
scenarios here doesn't look great
>> for it's literally the same as the
previous game. Like when you go here and
you try to do something about the bulk
state like next turn it's going to be
mastery.
>> Yeah, it is. It is indeed. Thermo beam
does come through will end up taking out
the Trinity Force. So uh Sha will not be
able to jump up towards uh winning the
game. I mean, that's a dangerous place
to have been in because Shawn would have
held
>> to eight.
>> That might be that that Trinity Force
had stayed. So, I think that's another
thing to consider there. That would have
been a winning line uh from having the
uh the lonely power. Of course, you
could have got the power off off that
battlefield, but still a dangerous
situation for that Yi to come in and
look at scoring the second point,
whereas now Sha has to wait at least
another turn to try and represent
Lethal.
>> Mhm. We also moved the treasure hunter
to generate the gold. When you think
about it, just because we are so low on
resources when it comes to Kamzy, so he
feels like he needs more.
>> I never feel like I wouldn't want more
gold if possible. Is this what you give
for it? What is the What is the
trade-off?
>> It's It's uh Would be nice if the
treasure hunter would generate real
gold.
>> Well, if you're good enough with it at
an RQ, it can.
>> Ah, okay. So, it's printing money
anyway.
>> Exactly. Exactly. as these players are
playing for,
you know, they're they're playing to
give themselves the best chance of
making top eight. It is it is hard to
know exactly with the uh current scores
on the round and we we do feel like some
of our players are going to be looking
at tiebreers to get in. Um as Master E
comes out of the chosen champion zone,
Sha is going to send everything.
>> Everything is going in
>> at Taran's Peak
>> drawing first for the movement. And
that's a first mate, so it doesn't
really matter too much. Now, this
>> this right? Yeah.
>> Is going to be a huge punch to the gut.
>> So, that goes I guess on the E. Yeah.
>> No defy because the second energy.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, that's what I was going to say.
>> You know what you're talking about.
>> I I got that one. That would have to
have been a not so fast to have uh
stopped that one.
>> Treasure hunter dies for this entire
exchange. That's That's the toughest
treasure hunter I've ever seen in my
life.
>> Just give me the gold. Just give me the
one gold and get out of here.
>> But it took a four might hit. Now the
thing is though, there is the master y
um in the hand by the way.
Uh technically according to the rules,
you have to like replace the sleeve now
to match the rest of the deck, but
not not really that important, I would
say. Uh, I think it's pretty at this
stage.
>> I think Hamsy might be on to it that he
has it in his hand, you know.
>> And have we had an effect that's like
discard a card at random?
>> No, not yet.
>> Okay. I think when that comes in, then
it'll be more important.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, it's titan
hand.
>> That's That's pretty influential.
>> That is huge.
>> So,
I was thinking we were on Vomor, but
we're not. So, Titaners are actually
really useful at this point to to move
the Forerunner where you need it to be.
>> Lo, I am sorry.
>> We don't affect the game.
>> My bad. My bad.
>> I think we all see what happened on the
stream there as the green sleeve is
being removed. Uh, I see that is funny
though. And actually it is a good point
u because part of it is information and
it is a big glaring glaring sign that
the mastery hasn't been you know
discarded.
>> It happens so often when you play Kai'Sa
and you're just like oh you retreat my
Kaiser and then you're like
>> there's like a you're holding the hand
and there's just one sticking out just
like I'm here. Hello I'm here.
>> Oh what's in hand? Who could know?
>> Did he shuffle it as well? You will
never know what it is.
>> I would leave it in in the green sleeve
and shuffle. Just be like my opponent
will never know. Never know.
>> Oh,
>> how many cards do you have in hand?
Four. Is there a master in it? You will
never know.
>> You know, if he doesn't show a master
and ends up out of uh cards in hand, you
know, something else has gone wrong.
H it's funny, but it's part of being
prepared for a tournament is having the
correct, you know, sleeves, replacement
sleeves, all that kind of thing. Uh for
for those that want to play Oh,
>> well, actually, we're not leaving open.
Never mind. Tight Turner. Tight Turner.
>> Okay, so you essentially are swapping a
six for a seven. I mean, you could
reinforce what I'm talking about. You
could reinforce the target speak with
the Draven from base, which would
essentially be a seven might.
>> Yes. because this version of Draven,
Draven Showboat is going to get a point
uh get an extra might for every point
you have. So currently at four for Kamzy
that would be uh as you said swapping
six seven
>> that hand is clunky.
>> Yeah, there's a
>> two not so fast at the five first maid
and a master.
>> And that means the the rebuke last turn
when it was only one rune available.
That was the difference there between
you know rebuke cannot be defied. It can
be mastered but you have to pay the two
for it and it wasn't available.
>> Yeah. What are we doing now? Because
playing the master, I mean, we are not
like we're not in a problematic
situation. I'll be honest with you.
Sean, I feel like could just reinforce
the battlefield by playing a huge unit
on the forge of the fluff and retreat.
>> And because of that, you're just setting
up a lethal with your master either. Now
we know we know there's another tide
turner in hand and that'll be played to
bring the ferris forrunner back to the
base and allow it to go then to the
forge of fluff with the Draven. So that
is a lot of damage
>> and unfortunately you cannot not so fast
a tight turner
>> right because it doesn't opponent thing.
>> Imagine how broken that card would be if
it would target opponent cards as well.
>> Yeah that that would be broken. I think
that is likely to be the sequence here
as uh if that EI falls. I think that is
a lot of the presence that Sha has on
this game.
>> Do we have to make him swap the sleeve
back to the green one?
>> No, that's not a real thing. I'm just
I'm I'm me on the tactic. Don't look for
answers.
>> Hard bargain.
>> Is it worth it though when your
opponent's only got one rune up now? Cuz
wouldn't you rather save the hard
bargain for the punch face? There is
one.
>> Yeah, but he has already good answers in
this against this board state within his
hand. And if he would play a hard
bargain, free runes are open. So you
cannot play tight turn and rebuke.
>> M.
>> So I feel like that's probably something
that you want to avoid. So you just let
this go through.
>> You're just like, "Yeah, that's fine.
That's okay." Um, does he even have a
hard bargain? No, it's a Titan or a No.
>> Titan and Ruby.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. I I I realized
what you were were saying on that.
So, but what you said before is still
possible to be done. You can detect
>> that's
>> uh
>> Oh, okay. He's just shortcutting. Okay.
shortcutting a little bit of
representing it a little bit
unorthodoxyly but yeah that will be what
happen is the Ferris 4runner while ready
gets tight turned back to the base will
go from the base over to Sha uh sorry
Sha's battlefield of forge of the
fluffed with the Draven
>> Warner will be enough to overpower from
there now holding a rebuke Kamzi is in a
pretty good spot to hold both hidden
cards so we've seen two tight turners
could be an edge knight could be a teemo
correct
>> could be a Switcheroo.
>> And that was a card drawn after winning
the combat.
>> Exactly. So important to give another
option now knowing there's a rebuke in
hand, knowing now there's at least
another Titan for might.
>> And this prow will now be useful because
you can sacrifice it by going to target
peak and one force the hidden card to be
used. Yes. Two, even if it dies, you
still get to draw a card. Yeah.
>> So yeah, we're starting with this.
There's a pass.
This one's a tide turner because it was
played
>> earlier in the tournament.
They can swap places.
>> I was just joking about the titers, but
yes, this can also happen.
>> This also can happen which makes it kind
of tricky as uh 4Erunner doing its best
job of being at every battlefield at
once.
>> Is there another unit alongside the
first mate? Because the first mate is in
hand.
>> Earlier we didn't see one.
>> Yes. So now now we saw the UN
Sha is shaking his hand.
>> There's a factory recall. So most likely
there might be not another unit now.
That's the first mate.
>> And does that mean Shawn passes the turn
and it is going to be going up to
>> Oh.
>> Oh, there is an first mate.
>> So it depends on what the hidden card
is. Did you see that?
>> Both of them are a disaster
>> because you cannot counter any of them.
>> But do you have enough with three?
>> Three plus unguard is five. If it's a
Teemo, it's dead.
>> So you rebuke this and you essentially
win the fight, but you can also just
reveal the hidden card first.
>> Oh yeah, you got a rebuke as well. So
you win the Yeah, exactly that. There's
the rebuke is the other option to this
that is clean. It just says rebuke the
first maid out, but there's not so fast
potentially available. Yeah,
>> but then you have the hidden card.
>> Every option just depends what that last
one
>> rune is used for from Shabbs
on top. Cami really the debate between
Rebuke or hidden card. It's rebuke is
going to get revealed. Not so fast is
going to follow this up and that will
force the hidden card.
>> Yeah.
>> And now is it the Teemo?
>> And it's also just down to what is
Wait, what is going on?
>> I'm just kidding.
>> Surely you got to play the hidden card.
>> Yeah, surely. Surely.
>> It's a switcheroo.
>> So,
>> but now if there is extra additional
power here, if there's any combat trick
on guard should put it up after the
switcheroo has resolved. He's going to
mean first mate will take down the tide
turner. And now it's just what even can
come through for this 4runner? You have
to get the forerunner from one
battlefield over to the other or it's
like an accelerated Kaiser. It's ride
the wind accelerated Kaiser. Any unit
that can come out or damage spell
doesn't do
>> Oh, because of the the master. Yes,
exactly. A damage spell would do it. I
didn't
>> Tit were being played. So, another
Titaner would have done it,
>> right? Because you can play Titan and
exchange it places and just do it again
like he did before. What is that?
>> There's nothing. No,
>> no, it's a two drop. It's just uh Is
that a uh Yeah, that's it.
>> Wa! What a close match.
>> That was down to the wire. Impressive
from Sha just coming out of the gates
from game one, stacking the Trinity
Forces, jumping up and then playing
around that last part of combat just
enough to get over the line, make sure
you could hold the next turn, forced
Draven to rely on the top of the deck
and it did not deliver as Sha picks up a
win in round 12
>> with the mid-range master that I got a
lot of comments about how I'm wrong
about saying that mid master is a good
deck. uh vindication.
>> Yeah, I am being vindicated a little bit
because this is the third Midrange
Master Yi that is currently at top
tables and I put midran master Y in like
in my A tier like saying like this is
really good deck right now in the metag
game coming after the bands and you can
also see how the bands actually affected
the Draven.
>> I'm I'm going to pull up your YouTube
and leave good comments right now. Right
now while we're on stream I'll be like
look that was vindicated. So, but you
can literally see how the bands are
affecting the Draven. The lack of really
good curve on turn two was affecting
both games. In game one, we had a game
jam. No, wait, that was the game two
game jammer. Game one was it um can't
remember anymore, but yeah, both turns
were like half used essentially. So,
you're not putting a incredible amount
of might like you had been before with
Draven Vanquisher. D and Vancrua just
represents a a conquer against any two
drop from the master. Yeah,
>> like that is such a huge dynamic change
when it comes to this particular
matchup. This is why I think mid-range
master is just so good right now because
it's not easy for any deck to break that
hold when you're playing the two drops,
right? And even if they they break that
hold of the two drops, they probably
sacrifice a lot of resources for that
because you have four might units on
your battlefield. So, it's a it's a
really wellpositioned deck. Um, very
happy to see it perform and
>> I would want to say well played by by
Sha, although the Trinity Forces from
the game one didn't end up biting him
back as well when he forgot that they
existed for a moment. But yeah, it was
funny. It was a unorthodox game overall
because the game one was double
>> and I think that really warps the way
that that ex that best of three played
out
>> because of the the battlefield changes
to Draven. Reaver's row not being an
option is a big hit for Draven on top of
everything else you were saying and and
that's what when we talk about the meta.
Yes. Okay. Draven is still performing
very well at the tournament in general,
but it has to find different answers to
before. Perhaps Draven's route to uh
playing was a little too easy with the
the curve that was being played, the
security that was being played, the
consistency that the deck had. Whereas
now you have to find different options.
and we're finding a couple of other
decks like the Master Yi there say, "Ah,
that's a that's a really cool Forge of
the Fluff. What if I use that against
you really well in game one?" So, yeah,
it's it's such a such an interesting
dynamic where we are in the meta right
now. Um,
>> so many of the decks though, there's a
there's a trend emerging like Azir and
Master, these sand soldiers with
additional capabilities like the Master
Yi uh legend ability that is granting
plus two on defense, surprisingly
difficult to break.
>> Yeah. And also cascading your equipment
is one of the biggest signs of this meta
game, how it changed because
>> fight or flight was directly affecting
the possibilities of um of essentially
cancelling the jugging of the equipment
because the unit just gets bounced back
to base still holds the swords and the
shield and be like well now I cannot
give it to someone else like I cannot
give it to you and now you cannot
attack. Right? We have seen this uh type
of interaction when someone gets stunned
but the tools that are stunning people
are definitely less flexible than fight
or flight was right. So um it it's a
very interesting dynamic. We finally can
see the full power of equipment cards
because now they are just like shining
this they are in the spotlight.
>> We needed to get that pesky fight or
flight out of there just needed needed
to go and finally the equipment were
able to shine. It has been a really uh
really cool set of games that we've
we've had the fortune of casting for the
last couple of days. That was the last
Swiss round that Lothar and I will be
bringing you, but we do have one more
Swiss round left. That'll be after an
interview and after a few more things.
Let's throw it over to Blev Blevins on
the stage.
>> Yes, there's more than one of me here,
but actually maybe it's just one. I am
Blevens and I'm joined here with Shawn
who has just secured a win with Master
Ye. Congratulations. How are you
feeling? I can I can see it on. How are
you feeling after that win?
>> I can't Well, I've got no impression.
I'm still It's a rough game. It was
really good. Yeah.
>> But
still impressed of it. Uh so, uh got my
whole team with it and they also like
partying for it. So, I'm really happy.
>> Yeah. So, Master Yi, I mean, if we look
back at Origins, was one of the top
decks for sure. And then it seemed like
everyone sort of forgot about Master Y
and Spirit Forged. bands happen. I
didn't really see many many people
talking about Master G. What led you to
this path?
>> I tried to grind it since day one. I
tried to do the best with it and just
got short intervention with Civia for
months, but after it I saw
>> there's still a good place with it.
There's still with punch first for the
second thing and not so fast. So,
there's big improvement and also after
the bands when Kaiser gets stronger.
Yeah,
>> he gets stronger.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And you don't have to
worry about the the fighter flights
being in there. You can you can stop
worrying about that. And one thing that
I really love about Master Yi and these
versions of it is the Trinity Force. I
am a I'm a Lucian player at heart. So, I
love a Trinity Force. Tell me about
Trinity Force and Master Yi.
>> Okay. The first game was quite wild
because I instantly get my sand soldier.
Yeah. And next turn I got the uh Trinity
Force, attached it with my battlefield
>> and uh following turn I got it again. So
got free holding points with it and
there was wild wild really wild but I'm
happy it worked.
>> Yeah. And the sand soldiers I saw you
were running Desert's Call. That's not
that's one that we've seen in a lot of
the master decks but not all of them. Is
has that been a really great card for
you?
>> Uh completely. Uh I think a Ye got one
big uh problem and it's against yellow
when it got cold weeks.
>> Yeah.
>> And I have to do something against it.
So I'll put desert call in it and it's
sometimes that second turn the best
thing to protect my king and queens.
>> Yes. The kings and queens being
protected. But you are here at this
event. You just got a massive win. When
you were coming here to Le were you
thinking this is where I'm going to be
or is this is this beyond your wildest
imagination?
>> H it's wild. Uh it was my plan to do
well but not that well
completely happy really.
>> It's a big uh it's a big road. It's a
big thing to do and that way. So I'm
happy.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm happy.
>> Can't complain with that. And obviously
we saw you take down a Draven. What has
your road been like so far? Have you
seen a lot of Dravens? a lot of Aellas.
What What has it been like?
>> Uh Draven, Kaiser. It's the third
Draven. Uh two Kaisers I think two
Victors.
>> Okay.
>> So it was quite uh Deita quite deer game
but
>> some other things like I think my last
match yesterday was Dario the best of
Darius. He was really really good
>> and so
>> quite good but no Aelia. So
>> no Aelia yet. How do you feel about that
match up? cuz I have to imagine I
haven't seen the exact spread right now.
I have to imagine you're probably going
to see it at some point if you keep
winning.
>> Yeah, I'm happy that I didn't see it
because uh when I'm second it's a bit uh
worth about I think 40 45% win and when
I'm first it's even getting better. But
dice roll a bit,
>> right? Dice roll. Well, you've won a
number of dice rolls in dodging the
Aurelia. Is that sort of the the worst
matchup for you? Are there other ones
that you're like, "Oh, please, oh,
please, oh, please don't be my next
opponent."
>> I think my worst matchup is really Leona
when I see her. It's really uncommon.
But we got a Leona player on our locals
and she throws all the stuns at me and
I'm like, "Okay, I could do anything."
>> Yeah, you're you're you're doing so well
at the RQ, but because you played at
your locals, you're like, "Oh, this
deck's not that good. I keep losing my
Nexus Knight." But it turns out Leona
has not done uh not done.
>> I'm happy that Okay, that's good. Now
obviously you're doing great in this
event. Master Yi, are your eyes set on
Master Yi for Unleash? Have you even
thought about that yet?
>> Yeah, I thought about it. There are some
very good new cards for it. So like the
new Nami, it's perfect for it. You got
stun. It can make things ready and the
buff and also Renga to put it in.
>> And I think maybe I'll play it for the
third set also.
>> Yeah. Are you are you going to still
play the same master year or are you
looking at the new one?
>> Uh, no. I want to say for the old year
with the the OG one. I like it.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's done well so far.
It's continuing to do well for you here.
Now, how if you had to pick your path up
through the top eight, what would you
want to see coming up? Uh, I would like
to see some Kaisers first to make it a
bit easier probably, but no, it's still
a hard match up of course and when they
have the Watcher and I don't got a
Trunk, it's always hard,
>> but uh, first Kaisers would be happy.
Draven would be good. And maybe Ireelia
for the last.
>> We'll see.
>> Just to prove that you were there for
it, but that is absolutely
fantastic. Any other last thoughts you
have? Any any shout outs you want to
give? I'm happy for doing that big event
here. I'm happy that you do it so
professional here and
>> want to see you next time again.
>> Yeah. Well, really appreciate that,
Sean. Thank you so much for this
interview and congratulations. I'll let
you go. Get ready for your next round,
but we're going to send it back to the
desk.
>> Cheers.
>> Thank you, professional singular blev.
Uh, we're like I love when people are
saying like they're so professional and
I'm here forgetting my co-caster's name
is James here ready to show you. I lied,
by the way. That's how professional I
am. I I lied and said we were done. We
actually have a second feature match to
round out for this round. So, apologies
if you were hoping to to see the back of
us for the Okay, nice.
>> And another Mari Bek. We we just heard
about this uh matchup from uh our
players in the interview where less than
three UOU
is uh on the Kaiser which we we just
heard him talk about. Mi is is Sean
talked about how good Master into Kaiser
can be.
>> It is it is it was a good matchup in set
sorry set one as no sorry not set one.
If you were playing mid-range master Y
in set one already with like a lot of
deflect units, it probably was not the
like not the choice.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. But uh in set two, it was
definitely something possible already.
And because that was really bad matchup
for the Kai'Sa. here. Unless the Kaisa
build that we going to see here is going
to be more unit oriented, you're not
going to see a lot of um like you know,
sorry, we're not going to see a great
matchup for less than three.
>> We could nickname them hard if we wanted
to, but that would be
>> that is not a good opening. Sorry for
interrupting.
>> No, you got way more important things to
say.
>> That is not a good opening. I was
thinking like maybe that stupify is
there to like activate a Noxus hopeful
maybe.
>> But it was just to card draw.
>> Yeah, just to card draw and pass. So
what do we have here? We have a smoke
screen, a watcher, a falling star, a
brin here, a
not certain what else is there, but
overall with this kind of start,
you're chances are really looking bleak
because now Masti is just running away
with holding a field and just
reinforcing it. And because of the lack
of pressure from Kaisar early on in the
game, Master most likely is going to
able be will be able to build up his
resources. When Master E builds up
resources, it's kind of similar to like
a Reelia. You don't want to play against
a Relia that has like seven seven open
all the time.
>> Yeah. And that's a ruin runner, right?
That's a punch first and ruin runner. I
think
>> punch first and a ruin runner. So, we're
thinking about setting them up on the
top of the bottom depending on how
important they are. And Runer Runner is
helpful against
>> pretty good against Kaiser. Yeah,
exactly. So much of Kaiser's uh
interaction is based on uh targeting.
Looks like Ruin Runner is going to the
top in the current way. It looked like
he like Barek was about to put those
cards back.
>> The the puncher is not yet that
important because you are most likely
not being under pressure for the next
turn as well.
>> And it's action speed, right? So it's
not just like answer everything. It's
not going to be helpful against a
falling stun. Not going to be helpful
against a singularity for example as
well. Get excited is that possibility
depending on which kind of build of
Kaiser we have. And that's a retreat.
>> Ooh, that is not what you want to see
when you don't have the units there. Of
course, Kaiser is available from the
champion zone and sometimes you do just
have to do that.
>> Yeah, I was look I I was not trying to
like question the turn two play because
I was thinking the stupify is there for
a reason, right?
>> Yeah. But we we could have just played
the Kai'Sa on turn two.
>> But then I guess are you concerned that
of like a charm coming through?
>> Of course. That's always a
consideration.
>> But the thing is what what if there's no
charm and
>> Yeah. Is it better to do the do the
thing and and and
>> your hand was really bad. Like really
really bad. And you would
>> from that situation.
>> Yeah.
So, accelerated Kaisa gets the point,
gets a card draw, but now is stuck on
the V vile mos layer. And by the way,
it's so funny. I I never somehow
connected it, but this is literally VM,
the unit that we're going to be getting
and unleashed.
>> Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
>> How did I not connect those dots?
>> Uh, they're different stats. It's fine.
You
>> right. Or I cannot read.
>> Fair. Uh, it happens to the best of us.
Uh, I'm sure something like that is is
going to be the case for me, too. And
there actually is a charm I think in
hand. Yeah, there is one. So, if we
didn't quite catch the hand at the
beginning uh to note, but had that charm
been in hand at the beginning, that
would have been a very difficult
scenario to play the Kaiser out into.
And when that does happen, Kaiser really
struggles. So now supervi
the battlefield.
>> Of course, as a reminder, you don't get
the Y bonus if you're not defending.
Mhm.
>> So if there is no showdown happening,
you just have the the might printed on
the card plus the equipment of the GA
that was there.
>> Now the retreat will actually come in
handy after the attack from potentially
the rune runner trying to this to just
destroy the Kaiser and the Vimos layer.
And the Ruin Runner like holding a
Voslayer, that is a fine um that is a
fine unit to have there. Like you're not
really being punished by anything and uh
you cannot be destroyed by spells. So it
doesn't matter if the spell is targeting
battlefield because runa cannot be
targeted. Now rare guard is not a unit
that we often see in a kaiisa deck but
it's a reasonable addition also
specifically is more useful in decks
that do play a lot of um equipment for
example because you have like in Lucian
you're going to see some rare guards
because they are able to utilize the
equipment that otherwise would be maybe
standing there still
>> defy or notify notify
Kaisa. or does he does he have the same
sleeve, right? Does she have the same
sleeve? It's there. It's I like the
outline uh looks like it's correct.
That's an interaction just again for
newer players. I like to give some some
things that perhaps you don't always
see. First of all, retreat puts the card
to hand. So, Vilemore's layers effect
does not prevent that from happening.
Vilemore just prevents going back to
base only. So, uh correct very basic
point that we've seen many many times
with Kaiser, but always good to refresh
on the very basics of the game for those
of you that are joining us. uh for the
first or an you know first few times.
Welcome if you are. Hope you're enjoying
Riftband so far. Uh what you won't be
enjoying if you're a Kaiser player is
your opponent having two ruin runners
because they cannot be targeted.
>> Two ruin runners they are totally
seclude like they cannot be affected by
any spell from Kaisar but they can be
affected by your own spells and
abilities. So you can still play
anything that you want. discipline uh
unguard bring it like you know more
might to those units
>> and that makes it really difficult when
this second ruin runner maybe goes to
Candalis Sanctum eventually or or if
you're holding both battlefields with
ruin runners in the Y deck they're seven
in in the showdown right so that's
already difficult that that matches
Darius plus a card depending on what the
the card is if Kaiser is in fact running
that so it matches some of the higher
end now the one card that will dig you
out of that spot is Thousand Tail
Watcher is that effect does go around
the side of the ruin runner's effect
because it does not target. So a watcher
is exactly what is coming now. So we'll
be able to get through the one ruin
runner with relative ease and then the
first mate will also fall to the legion
rear guard.
>> Well, not exactly because you're getting
to one uh but is going to add the
passive is going to be only mattering
when it's in combat.
>> You're so right. I even warned myself
about that to begin to begin this game.
So now we're going to have a 7 to4. And
now the punch first is making a
difference. It's going to be a 9 to7.
>> Ah, you just retreat the watcher.
>> Oh, actually, sorry. Eight. Is it eight?
>> Should be nine. No,
>> I think you just retreat the watcher
regardless, right? And you just say
>> defy
>> on the second retreat. Now, I
unfortunately cannot remember if that
second defy was already in the hand, but
if this defy was in the hand on the
previous turn when the Kaiser was being
retreated and we didn't see it used,
that is a such a heads up play by Bk
over here because it would mean that he
understands what can happen to his rune
runner. What is the loose condition over
here? This is I would really again I
will have to check if he had it in the
hand before. If he did that choice while
having it and that was a heads up play
that is really showcasing how much he
understands this matchup because the
watcher is the thing that will be
affecting his board state the most. Not
every nothing else is as important as
the watcher here.
>> The good news for lesson three is that
there is another watcher in hand.
>> So that retreat would have basically
represented a third watcher that needs
to be answered but there is still a
second. Uh so it is now down to BCH to
find enough of an answer. You know, we
just saw one punch first damp, but
weather through the storm uh and and
take one out. Trinity Force
>> is I'm I'm trying to do the math would
help, but you're still be one short, I
think, on then you're going to get to
four and then you're going to go up to
six.
>> Yes, you're one short compared to
Watcher alone.
>> But the thing is now we have a lethal on
board. So,
>> and there's another punch first.
>> I'm not certain if there is.
>> I I saw it in in Bach's hand.
>> Okay. Well, then that is a
>> pretty sure
>> and less than three has to find a
solution to this entire debacle over
here. And I I it could have been maybe
maybe the Trinity Force could have gone
over as well to the um to the first mate
to like put a win condition on the first
mate as well because you want to kill
the ruin runner with your watcher,
right? Again, replay the watcher, kill
the um ruin runner, but then if you do
that, you you cannot allow the first
mate to live because the first m just
wins the game by the hold with the
trinity force. But now the puzzle that
less than three has to solve is we can
kill the ruin runner and we can allow
the first mate to live.
>> I guess the thought process here is
there is only one answer to this ruin
runner and it is the thousand tailed
watcher whereas first mate would die to
a falling star
>> uh even with trinity force. So that
would deny that lethal uh line. Here's
that punch first comes through and the
fist bump comes through as well for
Barek.
>> It's going to go up to 11 and one. Punch
first goes onto the rune runner with the
Trinity Force. That'll be enough to
hold.
>> That is incredible. Now 11 and one
Master Masti is making a resurgence over
here like ma really making a splash.
truly truly is as Barek does get the win
in this game and that will round out our
round 12 for us as uh Barek knows his
stuff with TCG history from from that
deck box is all I'll say. Those are the
players you got to be afraid of. the
ones that show up with that box that is
really worn out
>> and specifically that one as well when
you
>> I had the same deck box like 20 years
ago like 18 years no 18 years ago I
would say something like that
>> that strikes fear in the hearts of those
of you that know in TCG uh competitive
scene. Um that is going to be our final
one from round 12. Uh again, Mari, I
think really showing in in some of these
top table matchups the the pressure that
it can apply by holding, which is very
different to what we've known. We've
known it to be all about kind of
attacking and combat in Spirit Forge.
Now we're a little bit in holding and
we'll hold space for a moment for
Barcode who has an interview with the
winner.
>> Thank you guys. Yeah, indeed I am back
in the venue with some very good news.
As you see this mine smiling and of
course for a very good reason because I
mean we can almost say that you're in
right.
>> Yes. Yes. So I have 11 wins. I didn't
lose. I have one draw. I think it should
be enough for top cut.
>> Yeah actually it should. So
congratulation John. You were playing
Ireelia the blade dancer. What led you
to that choice?
>> So at the beginning of set two I was
already I will play Aurelia. Like she
looks so much fun. And I love the
movement. I love the control aspect from
it. And I was playing a lot of Aurelia,
you know, before the bands and
everything. And it worked good. You
know, Draven, mid-range Draven was very
strong because of fight or flight. And
after the bands, I was like in a bit of
crisis because the meta changed so much.
I played Aurelia and it felt different.
I was like, "Oh, I don't understand the
deck anymore." Really, I was like, I I
don't understand the deck anymore. And
like this week, like in the last two
days, it switched. I switched my deck
like three times the deck list and I had
a switch. I played online games. I won
like nine games in a row. I was like,
"Okay, this is the deck." And yeah, it's
it's such a good deck. I think it's the
deck with the most versatility. It can
do the best from going second. So, I
think is the best choice for a big
tournament like this. I mean to be
honest and as an I really I mean
defender I really like this champion. I
totally agree with you on this one. But
tell us about you. How do you feel right
now? Do you feel released? Did you
expect to be uh in the top eight? Tell
us everything.
>> Oh, I'm so excited right now. I'm really
like I can't even believe it's true. I'm
like oh my god. Is this like you know
it's a dream come true. I was like, when
I was like 12, I wanted always to go to,
you know, TCG tournaments. And I was,
you know, cards are expensive and you
have no money as a 12-year-old. And now
I'm like, you know, um, fulfilling my
childhood dreams. And I'm like, this
today is crazy. Yesterday was crazy
because on Friday in the pre-ift, I went
4 and two. So I was a bit shaky, you
know, I didn't play that well. It it was
enough, but you know, not like like now
11 wins. I'm like, "Oh, insane." Insane.
I feel great.
>> That is actually insane because when I
saw you, I saw your smile on the face
and I have to tell Zel people off
camera, we talked a little bit and you
had such a good energy. You were always
happy to be there and always you feel
very confident indeed. You told me that
yesterday, yeah, it wasn't I mean on
Friday it wasn't very good for you with
the 42, but now I see a man who's very
confident in his ability to win it all.
So now I mean you are in top eight
basically. Do you think that you can
take the crown?
>> I I don't want to be arrogant because we
have so many good players. But uh yeah I
feel confident in my deck. I feel conf
confident especially in the mirror
because I played three mirrors. I didn't
lose one. So this is like for me okay I
know the mirror as a lot of players and
yeah let's see. I think I'm I'm very
happy with top eight, but you know, more
is always better, you know.
>> That's actually incredible to have you
there. We will let you go into your next
round, but for now, we are going to go
back to some more content.
>> Hello everyone and I guess we're the
content. Amy, I am Blevens. This is Amy.
We are here on the precipice of round 13
of RQ Le. Now, if you are not paying
attention at home, round 13 is the final
round of Swiss before our top eight cut.
So, this is the winning ends, the make
or breaks. This is the time for players
to shine.
>> It's crunch time and we're going to see
who makes it and who doesn't. There are
a few guarantees there. We've got some
players already locked for top eight,
but this is where everyone has
everything to play for. It's incredibly
important they bring their agame because
there's not a lot of time left. The
clock is ticking
>> and we're going to have some action real
soon to see which of our players is
going to continue to advance throughout
this tournament.
>> This is the time, this round
specifically is the time that you
imagine while you're playing at your
nexus. You imagine while you're playing
at your skirmish, you imagine in the
hours that you are testing for this
event. This is the time that you have
been nesting for. For a lot of people,
it's going to be a win and in a lose,
and maybe top 32, but not make top
eight, not get that best of. This is the
difference maker. This is for a lot of
people the most important round of
Riftbound they have ever played. And I
don't mean to set the stakes so high and
put the pressure on, but it's true.
>> The stakes are high. I don't know how
they got up there, but we do know. I
know they're all the way up there.
>> I can smell them.
They're that close, but ever so high.
And I imagine the pressure is gaining on
our players. They've been
>> diligently battling it out in this
tournament. And thus far, we've had so
many rounds across the two days. We've
had amazing feature matches. We've had
incredible diversity of decks like we've
never seen before. And I imagine that's
going to continue into our top eight.
>> Yeah. I mean, we've seen Master Yi have
a breakout performance. Took took a
little time off. Had had breakout
performances in Origins way early on.
Even fell out of favor a little bit in
Origins, too.
>> Little bit.
>> Came back, just had an interview uh with
Shawn there, who won that last round
with Master Yi, talking about how he's
been on it since the beginning, and he
actually thinks it's gotten better. It
did. It did fall off a little bit. We've
seen Azir being played so so well. Rex
eye in the earlier rounds and I think
that there may still be one flo one or
two floating out there in contention
having these breakout performances.
We've not really seen we've certainly
not seen Azir do well we did see Azir
top eight one Chinese event a while ago
and then never do anything since then.
Now we're actually seeing these decks
rise to the top with this set 2.5 meta
and really make an impact. And that's
honestly the most exciting part about
today is that we're seeing the impact
that the first bands have had and
they're significant. They're significant
enough that decks have changed. People
have adapted. New decks have come out of
the woodworks that were maybe being
suppressed by some of the cards that
were just a little too tricky to get
around. And now we're seeing this
wonderful kind of bonus format. Yeah,
it's it is uh something that is really
beautiful to see. But let's take a look
at the standings. Let's see who's in
contention, who maybe has locked their
spot. Let's take a look. This is the
first time I'm seeing this. We got our
top 32 here. Got a number of so most of
these X2s in the event. It is certainly
going to be a lose and out. It's not
necessarily a win in. As you can see
here, there's a full page of 10 and
twos. There may even be more after this.
So, it's not a guaranteed win and in.
But if you lose, you are certainly out
in here. But we see some Annies. There's
a Yasuo down there at 10 and two. What?
That's incredible. Love to see it.
Yasuo. Annie. We've still got the Azir
and Draven and Kaiser representing. Of
course, we've got Aurelia. I'm expecting
to see at least one in our top eight,
but there are others such as Fiora still
battling it out. And of course, we've
got a huge Annie up there as well from
Prismaticism.
>> Yes, my boy Prismat. We tal I talked
about him earlier at 11 1 and zero.
Again, top aided in Bolognia with
Draven. looking like they may be able to
ID pot. Again, I'm not going to try to
do tournament math, especially when I am
not in the event, but certainly in a
good spot here to top eight, but we see
a lot of these players are not
necessarily going to be able to. We're
going to see depending cuz there's
there's 101s, there's a bunch of 10
twos, there's a bunch of 11 1 and zeros.
So, there's going to be a lot of these
players that in a smaller tournament may
be able to ID here, but the math is
certainly murky and it gets murkier once
you have a 2,000 person event like we
had here.
>> It's a long way. That's a lot of games
to win. And you know, this the stakes
are ever so high and it's just getting
to the wire now. We've not got long to
go and there's some interesting matchup
math in there as well in regards to the
amount of mirror matches that are going
to face off. Will they knock enough of
each other out to have that diverse top
cut? We can see a lot of people at the
top of the standings there on a variety
of decks which interact with each other
very interestingly and I can't wait to
see that unfold. I'd love to see like an
Annie versus a Azia for example. That
would be a really fun one to watch. So
there's a lot that could go on and I
think there's a lot to look forward to.
>> Oh absolutely. I mean, just off the top
of my head, Annie, Azir,
uh, obviously Aurelia, Draven, Kai'Sa,
Victor, that's six decks that we saw on
that front page.
>> There's probably more. Fiora again,
that's seven different in the top eight.
I mean, it's a poss, we could possibly,
>> and I'm probably jinxing it here. Sorry,
there's no jinx. There's no jinx. I'm
probably jinxing it here by saying we
could possibly see a, you know, six to
seven different decks in the top eight,
which is certainly I think we saw five
in Vegas or Bolognia. I can't I can't
remember off the top of my head, but
certainly this could be the most diverse
top eight we've ever seen at an RQ.
>> Absolutely. And with that diversity of
decks, it brings diversity of matchup
and of skill, and it really is going to
put our players to the test. There is no
easy way out here. There's no, "Oh, it's
fine. It's all Aurelia and I win against
Aurelia." This is
>> Oh my goodness. Every single game is
going to be different. I have to employ
different tactics. I have to be flexible
and I have to keep my head in the game
to be able to keep going forwards.
>> Yes. And like we said before, almost
certainly all of these players have
tested for Aurelia. They've tested for
Draven. They've tested for Kai'Sa.
>> Yeah.
>> I would say most probably tested for
Victor. And then once you start getting
to the the people who are really going
deep, then you've gotten getting the
full matchup spread. But even then, you
have to you only have a certain number
of hours in the day. And the bands
really weren't that long ago. This is
the first big event on the bands.
There's been a few, you know, online
tournaments here and there, but there
really has not been there there
certainly has not been an event of this
scale for this set 2.5 meta, postb meta,
whatever you want to call it. This is
the first big one. This is the biggest
one. I mean, it's the biggest RQ we've
had. So, this is the test. Has your
testing and preparation put you in a
position to win this round and
potentially top eight, the biggest
event?
>> Was it enough? That's the question.
>> Was all of the preparation enough? Were
you ready for Annie? Were you ready for
Azir? Were you ready for Master Yi or
even Yasawo?
>> Yeah. Were you also potentially needing
to be ready for Yasawo? I think I'm
going to go ahead and say if we asked
all 2,000 players, I'm going to say
under one was testing for the Yasawa
match specifically. I'm picking the
under on one.
>> And that's cuz their best friend plays
it. I know that
>> it's because their brother is the one
playing Yasua in the tournament.
>> He's like, "Oh, I need to know.
>> I need I need to know this matchup
spread against Yasuo. I think, you know,
I I played a little bit of Yasuo in
Origins, but it's certainly a different
deck now. I mean, X2 is nothing to
sneeze at for sure. I mean, we could we
could easily see a Yasu in top 16.
Again, I'm not going to try to do math.
Can you float all the way up if the
stars align? I don't know. Maybe. I I
mean, I hope that would be the craziest
thing. I think the entire venue would
pop off if they announced a Yasuo in top
eight. I think that would that would
blow the roof off of this venue.
>> At least the stakes would come down.
>> The stakes? Yes. The No. No. The stakes
would fly up if the if the roof flew off
the ble off the window. But here we are.
We are here in the final round of Swiss
Year, round 13. We've got Aurelia versus
Draven, the Clash of the Titans.
>> A classic tale. Who will prevail when we
have Aurelia versus Draven? Draven
notoriously tough, wants to get into
combat, wants to be big and
intimidating. Aurelia quite the
opposite. Has very few units. is not
giving Draven the opportunity to use
their combative skills to draw cards.
Instead, Aurelia says, "No, actually,
I'm going to use some combat trickery to
buff myself up and allow uh kind of
allow myself to stick around.
>> Yep. going to, as you so eloquently put
it, protect the princess, get Aurelia
out and protect her, have her dance
around with her ability and her combat
tricks to be able to do that. And
protect the princess is great, but
protect the absolute monstrosity that is
Stellicorn Herder is a way to do it.
Now, here we have our deck list here.
Now, this is a very interesting one. Two
Dravens. I have not seen many lists in
recent memory with two of that purple
Draven and Draven Audacious. It's one of
my favorite cards in all of Riftbound
and we see two here in the Aurelia
build. Maybe a bit of bolstering to the
unit count in an Aurelia deck.
>> Honestly, I think this is going to be a
great matchup against Draven when we're
using Draven Audacious against the
bigger units in that effect. I think
that's kind of the way to go with this.
And it might be what we need to just
really
>> trample over the big threat that is
Draven is kind of take, you know, take
him a taste of his own medicine,
>> right? Yeah. We talk about in most in a
fair in a fair and honest game of
Riftbound, you're able to score two
points in a turn. And that's why those
even point thresholds are so important.
Getting to 2, four, six, and then
finally getting the winning point as
eight. very important. However, Draven
Audacious. He's an audacious cheater and
he can take points from anywhere, can
get those extra points with the purple
Draven. But we've also, of course, got
Draven Legend here using some of just
the best cards that you can play. As we
see here, Kai'Sa, it's got Spinning X.
We of course know our good friend Ferris
Forerunner is there. And we've seen
these Draven decks really leaning
towards the removal package with Falling
Stars in the main deck.
>> Yeah, we've also got that Cleave, a card
that's been coming back into decks a
little bit more and Brit Thundersong who
we have assessed has been one of the
bigger threats when facing Aurelia.
Yeah, just such a Aurelia spends all
this game building up resources,
building up their board, building up
combat tricks in hand, and Brin here
just says, "No, no, no, no, no. I don't
want to have to deal with any of that.
You're going to need to play it all now
or not play it at all." And that is a
really great spot to be in if you are
the Brin here player because the Aurelia
needs to try to guess how much they need
to commit and play face up, right? If
you can turn the game into a math
problem, well, I have a spoiler for you.
A lot of these players in in contention
for top eight are probably pretty good
at math.
>> Yeah, I I would say so. Strangely
enough, it's something that is a skill
that uh is definitely necessary in
Riftbound. And I got to say, I'm not the
best mathematician, but playing
Riftbound has made me better at math.
So, actually, this is just a learning
moment. We're only getting better
together, kids,
>> right? And uh we as casters have to do
less math because we've got the awesome
graphics, the might counter graphics
courtesy of production so that we don't
have to uh stumble through trying to
calculate how big that Stellorn Herder
monstrosity is. But we'll take a look at
the battlefields here on the side of
both players. We got target peak
aspirants climb and sunken temple for
Aurelia with the target peak the forge
of the fluff and the treasure horde for
Draven here. I don't know if we have
seen two Dravens have the same spread of
Battlefields this entire event.
>> No. And I think that's uh I think that
is a props to the designers to the team
>> uh who made this game because
>> battlefields are such an important part
of your game plan, but they're also
really flexible and they allow people to
deck build in original ways and you've
got to weigh up whether your battlefield
is too good for your opponent.
>> Yep. And here we are. The fists have
been bumped. Game number one, round 13.
Aurelia versus Draven. Let's start it
off.
>> Just a lonely Porro, but he won't be
lonely for long. We know that Aurelia
loves to look after them. Stack deck
comes into play. One of our most
>> ferocious consistency factors, but that
looked like a really good hand. That
well, it looked like a really good stack
deck. Yeah.
>> And we can only pick one of the cards.
The others are going to have to go to
the bottom and we won't be seeing them
for a very long time.
>> Ooh, that is a very nice way to start
your turn one if you are going second.
The stacked deck into the Noxus hopeful
being able to put the most amount of
might into play for just two energy. And
oh, by the way, you get to draw the card
that you wanted from the top three.
>> Even better. Even better. Can't make it
up, but Noxville is a mighty unit at
that. whole four might is really big
when it's essentially a pseudo two cost
at this point which always feels good.
Uh lowly porro going into the forge of
the fluffed to uh hopefully find some
friends later on but for now some swifty
boots and uh there we go. They're going
to get attached thanks to the effect of
forge of the fluffed and moving over.
Yeah, Aurelia, a deck that uh I dare say
can take better advantage of Forge of
the Fluff than Draven can. It is a deck
that runs a lot of equipment. It's not
an equipment deck in the same sense that
a Lucian deck or perhaps an Azir deck
is. She's not technically procking off
of specifically equipment, but equipment
work very very well in Aurelia. And we
tend to see, you know, six plus pieces
of equipment in these Aurelia decks.
>> Mhm. So, not only does it work for you,
but it works for your opponent. So maybe
choosing that first is a wise decision
because we're getting this game one off.
We have the least amount of amount of
knowledge about our opponent's deck
lists at this stage. So getting a
battlefield that is advantageous for
your opponent out of the way early can
allow for a bit more flexibility in game
two.
>> Mhm. And we see of course the spinning
axe there able to take a favorable trade
on to that lonely Porro going to be able
to take down some of that material and
also you know draw a card because that's
what Draven does.
>> Draven does that and it does it very
well. Uh I like that three bet has
clearly played this deck a lot and not
just throughout this tournament but
every single time sack deck is going
down. It looks to me like there are some
great cards coming off the top of the
deck, but they know exactly what they
want and they're taking them with pride.
>> Yep. And there's Overzezel Fan, a card
that has been the bane of many attacking
players existence because Overzeeal Fan
Yes.
>> Fighterflight got banned. Overzealous
didn't. And Overzeeal Fan does a really
good fighter impression.
>> Yeah, he does indeed. And that's why
being there with an Nox's hopeful and a
spinning axe is quite the scary
feat for an Aurelia player. We don't
currently have any units in, but Aurelia
is going to come and fix that. She's
coming into play, attaching some gear,
and off we go. But still no progress.
We're going to get a hold point here for
three bit going up to two. And that's
going to start to help just pick up the
pace a little bit here. But we've
already got a lot of units out and we're
going to see some more this turn, no
doubt.
>> Yep. And this is where these mid-range
Draven decks shine. They get ahead and
they, you know, they're not doing
anything too fancy, right? We're I would
imagine we're probably going to see a
Ferris 4Runner here. We're going to see
some units moved back. If we want to get
want to get cheeky, we can potentially
leave the units there for a hold, but I
would imagine we're probably going to
see just a develop of a 4Runner pass the
turn. You're ahead on point tempo. And
again, you don't need to be fancy like
Aurelia, but if you can still score
those two points a turn, you're going to
get the job done.
>> Absolutely. And that's that's all we
really need to do. So I think Ferris
Bora might be a very good shout here as
we see
>> surprise surprise
>> and yeah coming back because I think
yeah being a bit too overzealous with
attempting a second whole point there
>> is probably a stretch especially when
you're up against Aelia who could
potentially come in there do some
trickery and grab all of those points
and take down your unit. Yeah, and of
course Aurelia really good at getting
those two points a turn, getting out and
going from there. What Aelia is
generally not amazing at is getting
ahead, pushing ahead on point tempo
here, which they're currently behind.
But this version of Aurelia has not one
but two copies of Draven Audacious,
which is in fact a way to sort of sneak
an extra point, jump ahead on point
tempo potentially out of nowhere and
really catch three bet off guard. may be
feigning
a a a lack of power here and then coming
out of nowhere and getting that extra
point with Draven Audacious.
>> Speaking of Draven, it's uh three bets
turn once again. Aurelia is stuck at
Sunken Temple right now, but does have
lots of gear to back her up. So, not too
worried about that. Leaving her there is
not an issue, but we have a lot of cards
we can play this turn. We've got a
decent amount of energy as well. And
we've got three units back here on the
side of three bet. It's just choosing
where to deploy those. We want to get
the two points this turn, but Aurelia is
kind of being a bit of a pain. She's in
the way. We don't really want to have to
go through her. We will if we have to,
but I don't like the amount of energy
that Nemrot's left up.
Yeah, Draven is not really that good at
playing combat tricks, but Brin here, we
talked about it before, says, "I don't
care what you've got for combat tricks.
Let's see them right now, or else you
are not playing them."
>> Yep.
>> Your opponent's not going to be able to
play after this, so it's now or never.
>> All right, we are going to get the
Aurelia up to 10. With the discipline,
we could go up to I think as much as 17
if my quick maths go. If they play both
of the on guards and also ready the
Aurelia, that would be 17.
>> Is it worth it though? You'd be doing
yourself out of resources for future
turns and
>> I just don't know if that's going to be
worthwhile. Briner here is really making
a big effect here and it's why it snuck
into these decks quite so importantly
because Aurelia can really struggle. It
forces you into a corner and Aurelia
doesn't like that.
>> Well, it the question becomes
>> does how much does three bet want to
trade not for Aurelia for this guardian
angel? Because the guardian angel is
there. So even if you kill the Aurelia,
it's just going to send her back and get
rid of the guardian angel. Yes, you'll
of course conquer as well, but that's
not really as good as of course getting
rid of the Aurelia fully.
>> No, it's not dealing with the crux of
the problem. It's getting our fourth
point which is very important do not get
me wrong but not really actively dealing
with the crux of the issue which is
Aurelia is still about. Now of course we
get those two mech tokens from the
Ferris 4Runner getting destroyed but we
still are on that nice even count of
points. So actually in a really lovely
position here although we've spent all
our energy it kind of doesn't matter too
much. We don't mind at this stage uh
going ahead and of course moving that
spinning axe down to Briner here to uh
keep it safe in base rather than having
it on Nox's hopeful who's probably not
going to be sticking around too much
longer.
>> Yeah, Forge of the Fluff is not one that
I've seen a lot in Draven. And I was
wondering what really is the use case
for and we're seeing it right here.
>> That spinning axe is so strong when
you've got all these units. You can
cascade that spinning axe into a lot.
you can get that extra might. And a lot
of players play it as though, oh, I'm
going to get my buff. If I win the
fight, I keep it around. If I don't,
>> oh well,
>> that spinning axe is gone. But three bet
really putting value on keeping that
spinning axe around. And it's a really a
different angle that we've seen Draven
here. Obviously, it's working out in uh
in their tournament, and we'll see how
it plays out in this game.
>> It's a nice way to circumvent the fact
that you are out of energy on this turn.
utilizing that to that forge of the
fluff ability. Genius. Absolutely
wonderful. And it also makes it really
kind of tempting for Nerott to then go
and go for that overzealous fan, which
is exactly what they've done. They've
kind of fed into the plan a little bit
there. And yep, overzealous fans going
to suffer from that one.
>> Not too much of a problem. Really
doesn't mind our units going down at
this point. And again, it's just those
cheap early game units. We're not too
worried about those right now. On guard
coming into play. We're getting that
Aurelia ready to go again. Probably
going into this Nox is hopeful as well.
There we go.
>> Yeah. And it's a it's an interesting one
because the overzealous fan actually
used the ability on Aurelia, which of
course does have deflect. So had to pay
that power cost to target it, but it did
prevent the Aurelia from getting that
conquer from actually getting that uh
point obviously. So now not on four, but
instead on three, but able to get it
back into the base and gets pushed back
to the base and get it back into the
battlefield via the Ong Guard. And now
it is big enough to take out the Brin
here and therefore that spinning axe as
well.
So, we're on an awkward number numero
three
in points, but knowing that we have the
audaciousness to do so,
>> uh, means that, you know, later on we
might be able to take a cheeky extra
point and then it doesn't matter so
much. So, actually, NeoRock has ways of
manipulating the amount of points they
can score in a turn, which means that
actually we're not too worried about
that. We don't mind that much. This is
fine. Yeah, especially at this point in
the game, the sort of the midame point
totals at least it's it's fine to be
behind a turn. You can make up that that
leeway. It's about chipping away at the
resources. And as we saw here, Aurelia
was able to take out a lot of the units,
able to take out the spinning axe as
well. And that is very, very strong as
there are only two mechs left here to
contest. And I doubt that we're going to
want to send one into this Aurelia.
>> No, Aurelia certainly isn't someone you
want to mess with in this scenario.
>> So, uh, it's going to be a little bit
sticky. We do have another spinning axe
in hand. So, it can come back into play,
but on a mech, it's not quite so well
used.
>> No, not not the best. And if you lose
the spinning axe here,
it's a lot of resources to spend to try
to, you know, kill an Aurelia. Now, of
course, if you can kill the Aurelia,
it's very good, but it is just that's a
tall order with three energy and a bunch
of cards in hand. That's going to be a
tough one to do.
>> But what is the play this turn? Do we
build the back line? Are we building
reestablishing a board so that we can
then kind of fight a little more
toe-to-toe with Aurelia? We don't really
want to overextend here. We're on a
decent amount of points. We, as far as
we know, ahead of our opponent and kind
of comfortable in that spot,
>> right, we are that turn ahead. So, I
think it's going to just be develop and
see what we can do. What can we get into
the backline? What kind of resources can
we preserve here? Looks like it's just a
Darius played into the backline. Not one
that you generally see with just the
single card played. Darius in the
backline. No need to get that second or
that ability to ready him. Just playing
that in the backline to get five might
unit. Not the I mean not certainly not
the ideal usage of Darius.
>> No, but we do need to reestablish that
board. We need to be able to put up a
fight against Aurelia and all of her
combat tricks. So sometimes you do just
have to be ready to go aggressive next
time. And sometimes these kind of, you
know, these decks that do just have that
potential to be exclusively the
aggressor uh just need to build up a
little bit first.
>> Yep. And here we have the the good old
Reed forge the fluffed. Certainly a
common one. We've already seen that come
up in an earlier round of how it works.
Looks like we're even going to take an
ask of the judge and how Forge of the
Fluff interacts with Aurelia. Certainly
one that is uh it's not necessarily the
most obvious. Um but it looks like we've
figured it out.
>> Boots of swiftness become attached. We
obviously get uh some lovely extra might
from that. And Aurelia Aurelia's looking
pretty good in regards to sticking
around for a while, which is exactly
what we want. That's what the deck's
trying to do. Although we have very few
units, it doesn't matter. And we're
going to charm that Darius right on over
to Forge of the Fluff.
>> Yeah, Darius getting charmed over. More
resources being taken away from three
bet here. Not what they want to see. I
think they're deciding here. Are they
going to try to fight over this? It is
an uphill battle. I don't know that
there's anything that they could have
here. We do see that spinning X, but
it's certainly not enough.
>> No,
>> be spinning X plus something else.
>> I think that's it. I don't think Darius
can take it. Darius is down. Aurelia has
stayed strong and dealt with a unit that
could have become troublesome on a
future turn all in one go.
>> Yeah, the consolation prize is that at
least
your opponent isn't drawing a card when
you lose a combat. If you're Draven and
you're playing against Aurelia, you just
lose your unit. But in this case, it
feels like it is going to be uh not
great for the Draven player here as that
board has been relatively taken away.
Now, of course, if you can score with
this mech here, that will put you to
six. Then you can at least threaten to
win on the following turn. The question
is, are you going to be able to do that?
going to be able to put up enough might
while also
being able to
contest that Ireelia. We are going to
have to see here.
>> This feels like a consideration of an
accelerated Kaiser. We're going to take
the point first and then we have sunken
temples to ourselves from the mech. Ooh,
we're going with Draven. Okay, we've got
our chosen champion Draven and a Kaiisa
spending all of our energy here, putting
as much into play as possible. Quite a
bit. We've got a nine might Draven with
a four might Kai'Sa of course, but with
when your Aurelia opponent is willing to
just pass the turn and play nothing,
>> it sometimes it's great. That means they
have nothing. When they have a bunch of
cards at hand, it could not be scarier.
>> No, that is absolutely terrifying when
they're just like, "Yeah, no, I'm good
here. I'm going to I'm going to hold."
You're like, "What? What?
>> I'm not even going to bother playing
anything here. I don't need to. I'm
going to keep cards in hand cuz I've got
so much interaction." And that's, you
know, exactly what it seems like is
happening here. Even drawing another
card from the sunken temple going up to
seven. So now it is make or break.
Draven is going to have to break this
Urelia here. An Aurelia that has a bunch
of cards in hand, a lot of energy up.
And are they going to be able to thread
the needle and actually be able to crack
the defenses?
>> At this point, Neoth's looking at
needing to play another unit just to
score that last point. So, I imagine
that's going to come down. Yep, there we
are. And now it's Neoth's turn to be on
the back foot and just try and keep this
Aurelia alive at all costs. Three bet is
going to need to take it down this turn
to have any chance of winning this game.
>> Absolutely going to have to try to take
out the currently eight might Aurelia.
Not necessarily going to be eight might
forever. We see that seventh point come
out on the side of Draven. Going to be a
Kai'Sa conquer which is going to draw a
card. Now we've got the resources for
the turn. What do we have? I see a
couple of flashes. Those aren't going to
help you win this turn. They're not
going to help you be offensive.
>> We need to either There's two choices.
We either got to build up for the fluff
so much that that lonely Porro can't
jump on in there and take the final
point, but we also need to take down
that Aurelia.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, otherwise NRO just wins,
>> right? Yeah. You we need to we need to
stop the uh the double conquer next
turn, but that that comes after we deal
with this Aurelia. I'm not sure what
we're going for here. Going to start
with a Darius coming down.
Darius Trafarian.
And there's nothing more scary than one
of those. And a spinning axe here.
That's going to be five plus two plus
three. That is seven might on that
Darius. And of course,
>> we're going all in on that Aurelia.
>> You've got to
>> brothers in battle. Here they go.
>> Yep. And that's an extra one on top for
the Draven. So we've got a 10 might
Draven, a 10 might Darius handh holding
20 might into this Aurelia
>> the priority of battle. Here we go.
Let's see if Nerock can do enough or
whether that is a handshake and the
first game goes to three bet.
>> Wow, there it is. A ton of energy, a ton
of cards in hand and it's not even
really a bluff called. It was just a
forced play. Had to go for it. And
sometimes uh big number do good. That's
that's what we found out in this game.
>> Big guys go bash.
>> There we go.
>> That's the latest here for the riftbound
regional qualifier wheel.
>> Absolutely. As we take a look at the
sideboard for three bet, we've got of
course that Mindsplitter. Another Ferris
4Runner. I'm not sure. I'm conflicted on
the 4Runners in the chaos matchup
because they can get rebuke, but also
like what about the games that they
don't have rebuke?
>> Seems fine. We've also got the thermo
beam which again is not necessarily an
equipment deck but does utilize
equipment very well. If you can use a
thermmo beam to get rid of something
like a guardian angel that's really
really good. Uh we could possibly see
that come in in the sideboard of
Aurelia. What are we looking at Amy? I
kind of like this sideb. We've got three
tie turner, really flexible uh mind
spplitters, which we love for being able
to just uh pluck something out of your
opponent's hand, but also give you that
extra oomph that you're going to need in
units. So, I don't dislike the idea um
of having that um available right now.
So, there's a lot of interesting
decisions that could be made.
I'm just overtly aware of
headphonage. I don't want to say too
much.
>> Well, the one thing I will say is that
you can potentially
you can potentially make these have your
sideboard guide pre-prepared. So, you
know, if I see a Draven, I'm going to
sideboard this way. Well, the thing is,
was the Draven that you were testing
against playing Forge of the Fluffed?
I'm going to go ahead and say probably
not. I didn't see any of those lists
floating around. I'm not in all of the
secret discords and all the high testing
groups. People don't want to talk to me
about that because all I want to play is
Lucian Aurora. But that's besides the
point. There are, you know, you're not
necessarily
teched against these very heavily teched
out Draven decks and and different Aelia
decks. I mean, we've seen anywhere
between zero and three charm in the
main. And that the difference of each
one of those cards is very impactful for
how you are playing the matchup. So yes,
you may have your sideboard guide for
Draven, but not all Dravens are created
equal, even though they're technically
the same mid-range Draven still.
>> Yeah, they do very similar to what they
used to, but there are definitely
notches in the armor now. And there are
a lot of ways that as Aelia you can now
start to fight back against the Dravens.
And if we do see the Draven Audacious,
which wasn't revealed last game, that
could really change what happens in this
game and how three bet reacts,
>> right? I I mean, you imagine a a Draven
Audacious comes in. There was a few
there's a few times that the Aurelia
basically took a free Battlefield by
eating a mech or eating a a tide turner
or something like I can't remember
exactly what it was, but one of them was
definitely a mech. Imagine that it was a
I'm going to play Draven Audacious. I'm
going to play a uh an ong guard conquer
it. I'm going to get two points and go.
Uh my math of how this game was going to
play out went uh completely out the
window because they got an extra point.
>> Yeah, went very sideways there. We've
got our new battlefields. We've got
Taran Peak and Treasure Horde. Both
pretty okay for both players actually,
I'd say.
>> Yeah, I think uh Taran Peak is one that
we have seen. I said it before and I'll
say it again. very good if you have a
two drop unit to play on your first turn
to be able to conquer that and take that
advantage of the target peak. Extra
energy generated and well no punish
because three bet also did not have a
unit to play and potentially go after
that peak.
>> That is a slow roll when you're playing
a Draven deck. It's not the most fun.
We've got Guardian Angel down for Nera,
which is a great start, but again, no
units in play on either side currently.
>> Yeah, this is uh what we oldtimes like
to call draw go, where you draw your
card, channel your runes, past the turn.
We have not seen anything really get
played except for a guardian angel. No
units being developed at all. I'm
wondering if this is a I can't quite see
the hands of both players. I'm wondering
if this is a specific decision being
made to not play units or if it is just
a uh side effect of not drawing them.
Well, there's a tide turner coming in
for three bet and uh off to the races as
they say.
>> Yeah, just holding fire, going slow.
Aurelia's back. She was a menace in game
one. Let's see if she's going to be a
menace in game two. And of course, she's
got her trusty guardian angel.
>> Mhm. Of course. Few things scarier than
that. Just hard hard to deal with. Very
annoying. I mean, you could technically
falling star the Aurelia now, but you're
going to have to pay the two runes that
it cost plus two deflect and then
they're probably Oh, I guess you can't
defy it at least. But that's just going
to proc a guardian angel, and that's
just not great.
>> Titer swimming on in to the target peak
there, gaining our first point of the
game. of course not going to be sticking
around for long. Doesn't matter. All we
needed to do was just get started. We
need to now start this backto back
playing of larger units just to make it
really difficult for Aurelia to move
around.
>> Yeah, we're just playing we're just
playing Darius Trafarian in the
backline. I don't know if I've ever seen
this many Darius just played as a five
drop unit. I've never seen him look
worse, but also still be fine with him
being played back there. I got to
develop that might and get him in.
I think I see Do I see three rebukes?
>> I think that might be Yeah, I I've been
trying to count for myself and I was
like there's a one.
>> It sure is.
>> Oh, wow. This is going to be a game. A
game of all time.
>> Well, splitter. Oh, well,
>> going to get shown.
>> Yep.
>> And cue the laugh track in three, two,
one.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Oh, sorry. But one was a ride the wind.
>> Oh, it was okay. All right. Two reviews.
Fine. Fine. Fine.
>> No need for the laugh track.
>> No. No. But still some interesting
decisions that need to be made here.
Which one's going to say goodbye?
The early mind spplitter. A huge unit. I
was hoping it would come into effect
this game. A little more kind of a
aggressive play from our Aurelia player
as we try and target down some of some
of Draven's larger than life units.
We've gone for the rebuke knowing now
that only one can be played. Shame we
can't go for the two,
>> right? You if you could just take all of
the copies of a card that would make a
card that is already very very good
somehow even better in the mindslitter.
But that I guess fortunately for us that
like cards uh not not the way that the
card works. But we are seeing that
mindsplitter in the back. We're seeing
of course the Aurelia
holding down the fort on the targets
peak two energy up. Is it going to be
enough? I mean we could threaten the
rebuke, but we're representing uh at
least a few combat tricks. potentially a
not so fast as well would not
necessarily be good. Yes, we know
>> factory recalls.
>> No factory recalls coming. Yep.
>> Yep. Neckrot was like, "Yeah, I'm ready.
Go ahead. I know exactly what's in the
hand." And this is the power of hand
knowledge. It's not just getting a large
unit. It's not just being able to take
one of those cards and put it in the
trash. It's also just knowing what can
potentially come your way this turn,
>> right? It's about knowing the likely
line of play that your opponents are
going to take. And that is a another
Darius Trafarian. Well, what's scarier
than two Dar or than a Darius Trafarian?
It is two Darius Trafarians both proing
off of that second spell being played.
And that is 14 coming in to the now four
of Aurelia.
>> That I think Yep. Yep. We're going to on
guard. That's going to help a little
bit, but not quite enough.
>> Yep. And uh that'll give plus three
potentially plus four if they want to
ready it as well. I
>> think we're potentially just going to
try and take out one of the Darius.
Yeah, just to reduce the the ongoing
threat. So the on guard was just to kind
of uh weaken three bet stance there.
Take him down back to one unit rather
than two. still do take down the Aurelia
itself though and that is a really bad
position for NROT to be in.
>> Yeah. And I you know I don't like to
point out misplays on the broadcast but
I have to you've got to kill the alt art
one for sure
>> when when given the choice you have to
destroy your opponent's alt artic
one because I mean it's
>> it's demoralizing.
>> Yeah. You're like oh man now I got to
take the beautiful one out of play. Do I
have to? You go. Yes.
>> Yes you have to. That is the one I
should judge.
>> Mind splitters ready, but on their
lonesome. And although Aurelia decks do
thrive when there's only one unit out
cuz they're pretty used to it at this
point, it is going to slow down our
scoring potential.
>> Yeah, it it sure is. Um the the good
news that uh mind spplitter is pretty
good and you can dance around the
mindslitter. And you know, I I do want
to I do want to imagine this giant like
cosmic horror dancing around in the sky,
but also that's horrifying. But that's
what's happening right now potentially.
>> Yep. And that might need to be what
happens. But again, we might be uh we
might be passing the turnover with a lot
of energy up this turn again. And again,
that's that's scary. I wouldn't want to
get into a fight with those mind
spplitters when we've got quite a few
energy still remaining. And yep,
Guardian Angel's coming back down. We
knew that was still in the hand, so was
a very likely outcome.
>> Yep, Guardian Angel coming down here.
Looking and seeing what do they want to
do? What does Aurelia want to do with
their turn here? They can guardian
angel. They can blade dance ready the
mind spplitter if they'd like. Move it
back. A lot of different options.
>> Yep. going to equip the guardian angel
for now. Try and keep Mind Splitter safe
as currently their only unit, which
makes a lot of sense. We want to keep
that in play for as long as possible.
Now, Aurelia is not here.
>> Yeah, I mean, we've seen these Aurelia
decks struggle uh with unit counts,
right? We we we talked about uh in a
previous round how an Aurelia lost their
Stellicorn Herder, they lost a few of
their other units, and they just did not
have the ability to win. They had a
bunch of cards in hand. There's all a
bunch of combat tricks. Well, they're
not that good when they don't have a
unit to target. But speaking of that,
Draven also not really with a lot of
units in hand. No, not at all. Darius
going into the treasure horde. Bet he's
having loads of fun in there. And of
course, we get to get the gold for the
conquer effect there on that
battlefield. But now it really is about
rebuilding that board state. We do only
have that one unit. So both players are
slowing down when it comes to gaining
points. Although three bet is in a much
more advantageous position as far as
they're aware.
>> Yeah, absolutely. We are seeing good
friend Draven coming in.
Let's see. He's going to be a seven
might. That second spell will ready the
Darius. Be able to move him back. We've
got overzealous fan. So we're head on
point tempo. Yep,
>> we are head on point tempo. We've
developed a lot of might in the backline
and this is exactly what Draven
generally wants to do and they've going
to they're going to have to use those
spells remaining to try to thread the
needle to get to that winning point.
>> That's all we want to do. Bring
everything back. Bring everyone into the
safe zone for now. We're going to go in
together. Teamwork makes the dream work.
We're going to win combat. We're going
to draw cards. We're going to get
points. And that's how we're going to
win this game.
>> Absolutely. And there's a charm
starting to get rid of a bunch of the
might on the side of three bet. Get rid
of that Darius
to start it off. We're going to get the
boots of swiftness as well. We're going
to equip and we're going to gank on over
to the treasure horde. Score a point.
Now we're neck and neck making it
happen. We know that you can't respond.
You got no energy, mate. I'm gonna do
what I want. I'm gonna float float
around. We're gonna gain some points.
But again, is it enough? Do we need more
units or are we just going to keep this
energy up ready in case we need to use
some spells to try and avoid scary
combat? Of course, we're going to spend
one to get the gold token because of the
effect of treasure horde and pass the
turnover. And we're banking up those
resources with that gold. We've got
three open. Not a bad place to be. I see
a rebuke on the side of three bets. So
potentially could make a move here.
Could get that sixth point. The problem
is if you have to rebuke a
mindspplitter, it's not the best. It
does very much slow down what Nemrot is
doing here, but it is scary to have to
rebuke a unit that is such high value.
>> Indeed. But sometimes
sometimes that's just what you've got to
do to
>> Yeah.
>> to keep this advantage because at the
moment three bet does have that
momentum. They do have the point
advantage as far as turns go right now.
NROT does have ways of bringing that
back, but we're yet to see any of that
yet. Khiv.
>> Okay, we're uh we're just going for it
now.
>> Dang. 8 + 3 is 11. All the way to 11
versus 10 on the side
>> of the mind. Yep. In that showdown,
that's going to be another plus two for
the mind splitter, which will put them
ahead here. Now one
>> three bet has to decide how are they
going to sequence this. They've got a
few options. We're going to keep going.
>> What do we do? Looks like a rebuke.
>> Rebuke. We're going to say absolutely
not.
>> Okay, we are going to
>> That's it. It's down. Yep. Oo, mind
spplitter goes,
which means we are going to get that
sixth point here. We're going to be able
to draw from Draven. We're going to
be able to potentially make a gold and
see what we do from there. Do see the
nons or the uh hard bargain and flash.
So potentially going to be able to deal
with what
Aurelia is able to put forth.
So we're going to draw from Draven.
Another card. Looks like
>> a Noxis hopeful, which is a good amount
of might and still leaves some
interaction as well.
>> Really cheap unit to play right now as
we've made so many actions so far. So we
get that Legion effect.
Yeah. I'm wondering,
>> are they wanting to bank these this uh
energy?
>> Oh,
>> yeah. There we go. Noox is hopeful.
We're just going to we're going to Yeah.
really buff up the Overze. Overzealous
fan loves to have another unit in with
it. It always is a little bit more
dangerous that way.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And there's the mind
spplitter. The question is, are we going
to
flash now? That is the question. Looks
like we are. What are we flashing?
Looks like we're going to flash Draven.
Makes sense.
We don't necessarily want to flash
either of the other units because like
you said, that overzealous fan is there.
But
>> oh, defying them.
>> Defying the hard bargain. All in
response. That's a way to play around
mind splitter. I hate you. No hands.
Look, ma. No hands.
>> You can't ever look. If there isn't
anything in here, I've played at all.
>> Yeah.
>> Again, another misplay. You got to you
got to give the Jazz hands when you've
got nothing in hand in your opponent
mind. Splitters. I mean, that's again
the the mental game needs to be played
here.
>> They must be exhausted. It's got to be
that. It's got to be that.
>> Yeah. Most of most of the time they
don't miss that one.
>> No, no, no. Most of the time that
happens. Uh, you know, they played 12
rounds across two days at this point.
>> All right, you get everybody gets one.
That's fine. That's fine.
>> Yeah. Yeah. All right.
>> We got a single mind spplitter.
>> We haven't got much more to work with.
We might be equipping. Little cheeky
equip. And we certainly have to equip
here because we need to we need to
conquer this battlefield or at least
present the ability to try to do
something against the battlefield. Yep.
>> We're equipping guardian angel and
moving in.
>> It's going to be eight on the side of
the mind spitter. I mean, we're going to
need to at least put the boots on
because the Draven is going to go up to
10 here on the hold again. We have Yep,
we see it. We're going to go up to 10 as
well. So, now it's off the top for
Draven. Are they going to be able to
find something to interact with this
Mind Splitter? If they do, that is going
to be the game and potentially a top
eight birth here for Draven. What's that
top deck going to be?
>> I couldn't see.
>> I think it was a 4Runner, which doesn't
win outright. However,
we now have to decide
if we want to trade for the guardian
angel. I'm not sure that we necessarily
need to.
>> No, I don't know if it's worth it.
>> We can just hold.
>> I think just holding is wise here. You
know, Nemro isn't going to win on this
next turn unless they pull some real
shenanigans. They could, don't get me
wrong, but
>> three bet might be in a solid enough
position just to go I'm going to wait
and draw another card and take a turn,
man.
>> Right. It's
It is a tough one
and I have to
>> My gut definitely says hold is correct,
but I mean this is where you take your
time, right? Tough decision.
>> Such a huge one. It is a potential make
or break here.
>> It definitely does not feel great to get
rid of a maximum power Draven for a
single proc of guardian angel. And
that's not what they're going to do.
They're going to
>> We're going to hang on in there.
>> Yes.
>> Ferris.
>> Ferris forerunner. We now have 22 might
on the side. Five energy for the
Aurelia. going up to six here. They need
to break this. They need to break 22
might through an overzealous fan with
just five energy. But if there is a deck
that can do it, it is Aurelia. Let's see
what they've got.
>> They got to try and take this away from
three bet. They can move the mind
spplitter. They have charm, so they can
move another unit away,
which will help a lot cuz you can move
that Draven across or you can push back
the ferris 4runner. So that doesn't
>> that doesn't pose issue.
>> We've got enough in hand to be doing
something, but it isn't enough. And we
had to we had to expend so many runes.
We have recycled a lot of them last
turn. So we have really limited energy.
And if we use up too much, that's not
going to leave us in goodstead to be
able to continue next time, especially
if we do manage to take out the Ferris
4runner in combat. That's still going to
allow three bet to have two mech tokens
next turn.
>> Right. If we have enough for rebuke plus
on guard plus charm, I think we might
weirdly enough be able to survive here
cuz we're going to need to charm
probably the forerunner if I had to
guess.
Oh no, the overzealous fan. That makes
sense.
>> You can charm the overzealous fan over.
That makes a lot of sense. Okay, so now
this attack
>> gets a lot easier here.
>> Yeah. Now, but we are still 20 to 10.
>> And yes,
>> we've got Okay, so
my concern here is that if even if we do
get through this, right, let's think of
the next turn.
>> Mhm. Three bets going to have two mech
tokens minimum and then whatever the top
deck is. Is it going to be enough? They
won't get a card draw out of winning
combat cuz if they win the combat they
just win. We're rebuking bringing that
down to 14. Defant
>> defiant dance. I didn't defant dance
>> that changes everything. And an on guard
using all of their resources to wipe
three vets board completely.
Use every piece of your hand to do it.
And three bet is
>> in absolute disbelief as they look at
the top of their deck. Is there anything
they can do? No, we're going to a game
three.
>> Phenomenal play from Nero using
literally every single resource, not
only in their hand, but also using
pretty much all of their energy up by
recycling those runes. taking the big
gamble that there was nothing else that
we could have done to jump back. We
would have needed an acceleratable unit
to have had any chance to come back into
that game and clutch the win. It wasn't
there. And now we've got a little bit
more sideboarding time just to make sure
we're putting every single advantage
card into our deck. Make sure the ball
is in our court solidly for this game
three.
>> Yeah, absolutely insane. I mean, you
don't get to uh you don't get to take
those runes into the next game. might as
well use them. Put them back in your
rune deck. Just makes it easier to
shuffle up for next game.
>> Had 11 of their runes in the rune deck
there as they get the win there in a a
really back and forth game. I thought in
multiple points in that game that either
player like if we had an advantage bar,
it would have been moving wildly from
side to side there saying, "Oh, this
player's going to win. Oh, no, no, this
player's going to win." I'm like, "Oh,
well, Draven is 100% going to win." But
actually, maybe it's 99 and we found the
1% to actually get there for Urelia. So,
we are going to get the pleasure and the
treat of game number three.
>> Just a little treat for all of you guys.
We're going to do another one. And
honestly, I could not be more thrilled.
Love seeing this matchup. Love seeing
some old favorites. And two of the decks
that were expected to be going really
far in this event. two of the decks
which we have we know we know they're
strong but what happens when they
interact with one another? Draven has
had a lot hit by those bands and Aurelia
has said oh actually I I can deal with
you now earlier that was a little bit
tricky but now I have maybe a little bit
more of an advantage than I used to. So,
finally these decks feel like they are
on what I would call as equal footing as
we've ever had.
>> Yep. And we get to see equal footing
here in game number three as the fists
are bumped. Good luck. Have fun. Let's
start it off. Aelia versus Draven.
Aspirin climb on the side of Aurelia and
Targon Peak on the side of the Draven.
everything to play for. It's an
important game. We're needing to push
ourselves into that top eight. This is
game three, round 13, our final Swiss
round.
>> Yep. And we are seeing a tale of two
targets speak before. We did not see a
unit on turn one to conquer that target
seek. Well, that is not the case here.
We are seeing a unit and a great unit to
get out early. the treasure hunter
generating that gold, generating that
effective extra energy as well via the
target speak.
>> A much better turn. And we're continuing
with that really fantastic early game
advantage with this stack deck to have a
look at more cards, decide exactly what
we'd like, and pop the rest to the
bottom of the deck. That's going to help
cherrypick exactly the cards that are
going to help us win like we did in game
one.
>> Absolutely. There.
>> And another one. How about another one?
If you don't like the first stack deck,
try again. Looks like that was maybe a
Darius there taken
I think
>> potentially. So, getting some mid to
late game there and
>> and it's a pass over to NRO.
>> Mhm. Able to keep all of that energy up.
And while you may be able to contest
this, you just don't necessarily want to
when your opponent has everything in
play. You just don't necessarily want to
do that. We've got the Ireelia here
>> and we're passing back over.
>> Just playing her out.
>> Yep. Sometimes that's what you got to do
is just build the board on both sides.
That does allow Three Bet to take the
whole point which again launches him
into the commanding seat in this game.
But we saw how Neotro didn't mind last
game. It didn't matter that he allowed
Three Bet to go ahead. That was okay.
And that could happen again.
>> Yeah. And I don't think that we see one,
but we do know that there were falling
stars in the deck of three bet. This
would be an opportune time. Even though
it would cost a lot, it would probably
be worth it to throw a falling star into
an Aurelia when they have no resources
up. Really just sort of forced into
playing that Aurelia here naked, if you
will. No protection whatsoever.
>> It' be a nice It'd be a nice thing to
see. It'd be a very spicy little a go
on. Let's see if you can respond to
this.
>> Yep, absolutely. But I don't know that
three bet has anything to interact with
the Aurelia yet. I imagine that would be
slammed as fast as possible if there
were
>> Titer have a little swiftly swap with
the treasure hunter there. And that does
indeed gain us more treasure. And guess
what? If we move it back again, we get
some more. Yep, even more treasure.
We're getting that third point. Again,
don't necessarily want to overextend to
do that, but when a treasure hunter has
already generated three gold, I think
you're you're pretty much okay with it.
Uh it's it's done its time.
>> They're doing their job at that point.
Now, we're at the amount of energy where
we can consider the facts. We already
have one unit in play. We've got a boost
of swiftness. Our opponent doesn't have
many high might units. So, I was going
to say exactly this. That's surely the
time to play mind spplitter and then you
can cherrypick possibly a bigger unit
from that hand and know what's coming.
>> Yep, you absolutely can do that. We've
got spinning axe, Brin here,
thundersong, hard bargain, Darius,
Trafarian, and Rebuke. So, a couple
pieces of interaction, a pump gear, and
two relatively big units. So, really
what Nerott takes here is of course
going to paint the picture of what game
they are trying to play here.
>> It's a tough decision. I don't want to
see the Brin here. I don't want to see
the Rebuke and I don't want to see the
Darius. We've gone for the Rebuke. I
respect it. Yeah, the rebuke here is
likely the scariest because it is the
one that definitely prevents Aelia from
attacking here.
>> Yeah,
>> can
equip if they need to or just even not
equip. Oh, no, they can't equip. They've
got no chaos energy. They got no chaos
runes here. So, can't equip is able to
take out the treasure hunter who found a
lot of treasure on their hunt.
>> They did a great job. Now they can go
rest in the trash.
>> Yeah, but now this Aurelia is a sitting
duck. We know that there's a Darius plus
a spinning axe here that's going to
threaten to kill this Urelia.
>> I suppose that's the risk you have to
take. The risk versus reward at this
stage is great as we're in our game
three. You kind of do have to to take
those big turns.
Although we do have the Aurelia kind of
as a sitting duck, we do have at least
the we do have a big seven might unit in
base. So next turn isn't looking totally
fruitless.
>> Yeah, it's certainly not a complete wash
here. That mindsitter is of course being
very very impactful here. It's a matter
of, you know, yes, you have the resource
to expend, but should is that what you
want to be doing? Of course, maybe not
left with much of a choice as we see the
Darius come out.
>> And now, oh, treasure hunter even better
cuz you don't actually need the might
from the spinning axe. You just needed
the proc because Darius is going to be a
seven. And that is going to take out the
Aurelia for free which is going to get
another point up to five which in this
game with Aspirin's climb it is odd
point totals that we are looking for.
>> So we got to go that extra little step.
We got to we got to go all the way to
the tippity top. Game three making us go
that extra reach to get to the top of
Aspirin's climb. But with no energy in
sight, we had to take the nod from our
opponent that actually Darius was going
to easily win that showdown. Neoth's
turn begins.
I think we're just considering what on
earth we're going to do, what the
approach is going to be here. We have a
lot of spells in hand, but nothing kind
of active that we can go for. I think it
might just be having to run into combat
and see if we can just keep the pressure
up. Yeah, this looks a lot like set one
riftbound. A lot of lot of combats
happening, a lot of trades, a lot of
units being stranded, but it's just the
texture of the match. It is what has
been necessary. We do fortunately have
the boots of swiftness for Aurelia, so
we can jump we can jump this uh mind
splitter around if we want. We've of
course have the guardian angel to
protect it from any sort of shenanigans
there in case they are able to threaten
to kill it. But we're going in to three
bets turn here facing down this gigantic
cosmic horror of all sorts. It is rather
large and it's got a guardian angel to
back it up which also can be rather
problematic and we saw it to great use
last game so I imagine it's going to
come in pretty handy this time too. Now
we've only got a couple of smaller units
if you three bet. We've only got our tie
turner and our treasure hunter. We have
a lot of energy though and two gold
tokens so we can go for these bigger
plays. Speaking of
>> Yep, there's a Brin here. All right,
let's see what you got. Now, this is an
interesting one because
again, if Nemrot wants to do anything,
they have to do it at reaction speed and
they have to do it literally now or else
it's not happening. So,
>> three bet is essentially saying, "Hey,
what are you willing to do? How much do
you want to commit to try to protect the
mindsitter?" Nimrod says, "Nothing. You
ain't getting anything out of me.
>> Oh, it's now or never. And uh we've
chosen never. So uh well, next turn, I
suppose.
>> Bluff called. Three bet says okay.
>> All right. Sure. Sure thing. Uh Kaiser
goes down again. Just building up that
board of larger units ready for combat
in the future. We're ahead. We've got
six points to two. At this point, you
can take your time a little bit, build
up that board, and then go in with a
fury and try and wipe out Nemrott's
units of which currently there is only
the one.
Yeah, we are holding on to the strand of
a mindspplitter here. We're still behind
on point tempo, but we are trying our
absolute best to keep up here, defend
these battlefields. I mean, you're
behind on point tempo. But if you're
scoring two points a turn from bouncing
from battlefield to battlefield and your
opponent is only scoring one point, you
are going to win that exchange
eventually.
>> Exactly. But that's why three bet really
needed to start building up this board.
So eventually we can go for a really
dynamic showdown, but Neot has cards in
hand and all energy standing. So they're
really signaling that threat of if
you're gonna come for me, I'm ready.
>> Yep. I see a ride the wind a spinning
axe hard bargain.
>> Okay, that that feels like enough toys
in the pram to to have some impact.
Let's see if Three Bet decides to go
aggressive now or if we're just going to
take the slow road, go to Aspirin's
Climb, take an extra point, maybe put
Draven into play this turn and just
continue to build the board up ready
because we do need to be quite confident
we're going to win if we're going to go
in. Ooh, okay. Neoth's going aggressive,
going to ride the wind.
>> Yeah, that is a way to break point
tempo. score points on your opponent's
turn. Why not? We're going to also
threaten to kill a unit here. And this
is something that I would imagine three
bet did not want to send Kai'Sa into the
Frey for. So just the lowly tide turner
going in. Neatrot seeing the opportunity
to not only get rid of a piece of
material on the side of three, but also
hey, I'll get the point. I'll go ahead.
That will put me up to five. I'll score.
I'll hold to six and then conquer to
seven. That is within striking distance.
That is going up a full turn in terms of
point tempo here for Nemrot. Now what do
we do? Do we
try and go aggressive? Do we have
enough? We have the spinning ax, but
that's not going to be enough. And yeah,
indeed, we just don't have the push we
need. So Neber does go up to five here
and that is really significant because
if we now don't respond going up to six
and then being able to bounce that
around still is looking a little bit
sticky.
>> Yeah, it's not looking super great here
if you are
uh trying to get through this this
mindspplitter right now. I mean it is
massive. You really need something like
a rebuke. We saw a few rebukes on the
side of Nembra, but I've not seen one on
the side of three bet yet. But Draven is
a big boy here.
>> Draven's coming in to reestablish that
big strong backline to eventually have
the strength to deal with that mind
spplitter. But for now, seven is enough.
Seven is within the range of what we
need. We need to get to nine because of
aspirin's climb. And Nero is currently
on six. So, can't do it this turn unless
there's some shenanigans.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean, how crazy
would it be to uh have a uh a Draven
Audacious here? I guess it wouldn't
actually be pushing you forward, but it
would be a scary proposition if there is
another ride the wind or something that
you could possibly threaten to win on
your opponent's turn with Draven
Audacious. That's what I'm talking
about. We scored a point in our
opponent's turn last time.
>> Mhm.
It looks like we've got a judge call.
So, just going to make sure that
everything is up to snuff here. So,
going to come back to us. I'm still Amy.
We are in the heat of this match here.
Again, this is a absolutely some of the
highest stakes match. I mean, this is
>> it really is. It's not necessarily a win
and for both players, but it is
definitely a lose and not get into top
eight.
>> They need to be able to try and win this
game to even have an opportunity to get
there. And it also pushes them forward
when we're thinking about potential best
of as well. Like where those final
standings end up sitting, this could
push them forward towards that. So, at
this point, every single player who's
out there is playing to really progress
and put themselves as high in the
standings as possible. Whether that
catapults you into top eight or not,
sometimes there's more to be playing
for.
>> Right. Absolutely. Yeah. It it is an
event unlike many other where deep into
the event you are seeing players playing
for those best of continuing to play on
and you know at X3 X4 and in in a world
where normally it's like okay I hit X2 I
I maybe have a chance here I hit X3 I'm
probably not making it in this it's like
you may have someone at X4
playing the most important game of their
lives in the last round because that
could be the the make or break between
getting a best of or not.
>> Yeah, exactly that. And that's why
everyone you saw out there in the crowd,
everyone is now eagerly anticipating
who's going to get into that top eight.
We're going to see everything fall into
place and everyone's got to try their
best to make sure they're in the best
possible position to allow for that
eventuality.
>> Yep. Absolutely want to be in that
absolute best position. You don't want
to leave anything to chance when it
comes to uh events like this. You want
to control your own destiny, right? You
want to be able to make it or break it
yourselves. And of course, we're seeing
this in the heat of this uh round 13 as
we're not even into top eight and the
stakes are high here as we jump back in
to the match here. Mindsplitter is
ganking over. Looks like we are going to
see a ride the wind ourselves here.
>> That's one way to get out of a sketchy
combat. But defy comes into play. Ride
the wind will not conclude.
>> Yeah, Ride the Wind is not happening
here. Defy
will stop that though. We do tech.
>> We have another one and we have the
ability to hard bargain potentially.
Doesn't look like we need to do that
yet. I think possibly we we play the
next one and then if that also gets
defied then you have the hard bargain.
>> Yeah, I I do like that.
>> This is a tough decision.
>> This is a really tough decision. It's a
really tough decision and it's a really
uh impactful decision because this is
potentially for the game because if that
ride the wind resolves and there's not a
way to bring the mind spplitter back
over that would be an eighth point for
Draven. And if they're not able to get
it over, that would be the holding for
the ninth point, which in this case is
the winning point.
>> It's a huge turn. The stakes are so
high.
>> Yeah. I can't even see him anymore, Amy.
>> We know they're gone and
we're in game three. So, we've got all
to play for. You can't really take a
risk. You need to be doing what's right.
But you don't know the ifs, the buts,
and you don't know what's in your
opponent's hand. You don't know the
potential that is still looming over
this game. And so making these decisions
under this really high pressure
environment can be so tough, but we need
to do what's best. We're going to allow
that Kaiser to go down. Then Brock going
up to that seven points.
Just pushing themselves into
that position where they could get the
extra points to be able to clutch this
win. three bet on their turn is going to
be looking to try and take both
battlefields and that's why this tie
turner comes in just to put more
aggression on that target peak.
>> Yep. We see here this could be the turn.
Seven points with is within striking
distance for three bet. What are they
starting off with? Well, the thing you
want to start off all of your potential
winning turns with it is Brin here,
Thundersong, which means interaction
needs to happen now. It is now or never.
And if it is never, then it is a math
problem for the Draven to try to solve.
>> That is a tough cookie to follow.
Grin here really bringing the pressure,
saying, "Look, I know you've got a lot
of energy up there. or I'm not really
feeling it. So, uh, you can do things
now, but then we're going to then we're
going to have to take a little pause and
I'm going to see whether I can
confidently take this battlefield.
Diviant Dance is going to come into
effect. Going to have to choose what
targets that's going to be pllopped
onto.
>> Yep, targets are being chosen. That
potentially does throw a bit of a wrench
into the plan.
>> And there's an on guard as well. So we
now have 16 might, sorry, 15 might on
the side here.
>> The nice thing about this Brin here is
what it does. It forces your opponent to
play down those cards so that you know
exactly what you're dealing with. It
takes away the the whatifs, the the what
if Nemrot has this in his hand. Well,
actually, he's been able to play it. So,
now I can return the favor and I can
know exactly what I'm dealing with
without risk of something coming back to
bite me.
>> Yep. Here we go. We're going to start by
conquering the other battlefield here.
>> That's up to eight. We need that. But
it's not quite a win yet. We got to get
to nine because of aspirin climb. It
rhymes, so it must be true.
>> Yes. Nine for Aspirants. It a climb. It
rhymes. So now is the time for Draven.
They say in league it's Draven time. We
are ride the winding. The Brin here over
and that is two spinning axe and the
handshake is extended. That is a Draven
taking down Urelia here in round number
13 in spectacular fashion. A very
typical play. Draven bringing their heat
regardless of the bands. Bringing the
double spinning axe to close out round
13. Three bet taking the win.
>> I've never seen someone so happy to win
a potential win in for top eight. Three
bet is right here. I mean, not a not a
smile cracked there. That's okay, buddy.
We're happy for you. What an amazing
match there, Amy. I mean, back and
forth, not just in game to game, but the
match itself, and we got a game three.
Both players threatened to win multiple
times that game.
>> It was phenomenal. And both of them
played to every out. They made sure that
every every single energy was accounted
for, every possibility was assessed. The
level of play there was phenomenal. And
I'm so glad we got to witness it.
>> Yeah, I mean that is a that's an iconic
matchup. I mean we called it Clash of
the Titans, Battle of the B, whatever
you want to call it there. That is two
of the top decks in the meta. Regardless
of what you want to say, we've seen some
breakout decks here, but the two
the two four runners, Ferris four
runners here, the only one deck can
actually run. The two top guns coming
into this event were certainly Aurelia
or Draven. If you asked virtually
anyone, we saw that play out there. And
I don't know, I I think you mentioned it
earlier in the match. The matchup is way
closer than it has been previously.
Depending on player skill, depending on
deck choices, depending on card draw,
that matchup can play differently every
time.
>> You're right. There's so many factors
that go into it. Some of it is luck of
the card draw. A lot of it is player
skill. And a lot of people like to think
that Aurelia has a little bit more of an
advantage than it used to into Draven.
And we saw that cuz we went to a best of
three and it was so tight. It was so so
tight that you could have thought either
player could have won. And there were
moments big swing turns in there and
moments that made it so clear that these
players are very very wellversed in this
matchup.
>> Yeah. But at the end of the day, you can
have, we saw the rebukes in the hand of
the Aurelia go, I can't possibly be
touched. And then you see the Brin here,
thundersaw go
>> like, oh,
>> not a chance. Can't play these action
speed spells. Not on my turn at the very
least. And we see the Draven take it
down there. Again, I'm not going to try
to predict tournament math when in a
2,000 person tournament with a pair
down, a pair up. We don't know who all
this stuff. So, I'm going to leave it
for that announcement to happen. But,
uh, I mean, you certainly have put
yourself in the best possible position
when you win that game there.
>> Exactly. And unless we have Draven in
the top eight guaranteed, that again
just launches you up into a possibility
of being best of Draven. I don't know.
We don't have anyone kind of locked
necessarily for that top eight. We need
to have a little uh need to have a
little check on those standings later
on, I'm sure. But for now, we have a
little bit of a preview of what's going
to be coming soon as we got to play a
little unleashed on Friday.
>> Hey everyone and welcome. We've got a
really special game here today. I am
Blevens joined with Amy. We're going to
be playing some Unleashed Champion
decks. And I've got Vex here. Amy,
you've got Vai. And you told me you've
actually not seen these cards at all.
This is the first time you're seeing
these cards. And we're going to be
playing them.
>> It absolutely is. I'm really excited. I
don't like seeing things before. I can
see them in the flesh. So, I'm really
excited to draw cards from this deck and
discover them for the very first time.
>> Well, let's go ahead and do that. We're
going to start it up. Uh, I guess we'll
do a quick even or odd. Your choice.
>> Odds, please.
>> Odds. That is odds. It is going to be
your choice. We'll draw up and start to
play here.
>> Okay. Ooh,
>> let's have a look.
>> These look like some fun ones.
>> Well, that has a that has a keyword I
like here. I'm going to
>> Okay, we're going to go for one.
>> Yeah. I'm also going to mulligan one
here.
>> Ooh, yes. That was perfect.
>> Yes. And with that, I think we are ready
to play good luck. Have fun.
>> Okay, first up,
two fury. That's nice. I will use those
to play Inferna.
>> Ooh.
>> So, they've got ambush. So, I can play
it as a reaction, but it's the it's a
nice easy two drop for the beginning as
well, cuz I do like that it's got the
assault. So,
>> the most surprising thing is playing it
not as a surprise.
>> I know, right?
All right, I am going to channel three
here as I'm going second.
Okay,
I want to get this started off early.
We're playing one of my favorite
characters in Riot lore. This is Trevor
Snoozebottom.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Yes, he's he's a sleepy boy. I feel him
right now. Uh he's got shield and when I
hold uh when he holds I get a three
might sprite. So, I'm going to get the
sprites going here and I'll pass the
turn.
>> Incredible. He is adorable.
And I very much feel the snoozy part.
>> Okay, there we go. Channel some more
runes. And oh goodness, he looks scary.
>> That's interesting. Let's go for it. Why
not? So, we're going to go for three,
but we're going to pay an extra and do a
cheeky recycle because I would like to
accelerate this sharkling into play.
>> Oo.
>> And then
>> that is terrifying.
>> Thank you. And I think I would like them
to head into Zorn Warren.
>> Yep. I've got no responses to that.
>> Lovely. We'll score one point. I'm just
going to mark that here. And then I get
to discard one and draw one for the
conquer. So I'm going to discard right
of conquest and draw one. Lovely. And
then I'm going to go ahead and try and
move Inferna into Raven Blue.
>> That's good for me.
>> Lovely jobly. Let's go for a two there.
And that's going to be my turnover. Over
to you.
>> All right. I don't like being down two
zero this early, but I don't really have
much of a choice. I don't think.
Okay.
Oh, that's an interesting one.
It's not that interesting though. Or
maybe it is. Okay. So,
we are going to start
by moving
our good friend Trevor into Zon Warren.
>> Now, when he's not attacking,
Sharkling's a little more shy. He
doesn't get that assault force, so he
goes away.
>> Not quite as strong. That'll give me my
first point here. And I will trigger the
Z warren
which is going to discard
here to draw a card.
All right. Now we're going to get a bit
a bit cheeky here. I'm going to exhaust
four runes
and hey one chaos power here
to play the blast cone. So this says
when you play this I move an enemy unit.
When I move an enemy unit, I may exhaust
this to stun it.
>> No.
>> So, I'm going to go ahead and do that.
And normally, Inferno would be trading
with Trevor, but uh she's a bit stunned
here.
>> No, I can't do anything. I don't have
any
>> There we go.
>> thing to come back with.
>> Trevor may be snoozy, but he's still all
those all those yortal ears are very
sharp here. Uh and with that, I'll pass.
>> Oh, goodness. Okay. Right. I feel like
I'm starting from scratch now. Channel
two more runes and draw for turn.
Okay.
Tough decisions, I tell you that for
sure.
I think it's going to be best for me
just to bring Vi into action now.
>> Yep. and then
simply pass the turn. Unfortunately,
taking all my units away did me up a
little bit there.
>> I am doing what the deck wants to, which
is holding. So, that will give me my
second point. Um, which also says, "Vex,
when I when I or an ally hold, I may
exhaust me to draw one." So, I'm going
to go ahead and do that
>> because that sounds good. Um, then I am
also going to get my Sprite token. Oh,
>> which is great. That's going to help me
defend for the next turns. We're going
to channel and we're going to draw for
our turn.
Okay, what do we have here? Two, four,
and six. Well, I do like Trevor being at
a battlefield, so I think we're going to
we're going to keep that going.
I'm now going to pay three energy and
one calm power to play a moss stomper,
which is going to feature the new the
new mechanic here in Unleashed, which is
XP.
>> Uh, when he conquers, he's going to be
giving me XP, and when I get to level
three, he's going to be even bigger.
But from there, I believe I'm actually,
you know what? I'm going to go ahead and
pay another power because because I can.
We're going to
>> We're going to hide. We're going to hide
a card. Pay no attention to that.
There's nothing to worry about there.
>> Yeah, it's fine.
>> There's nothing at all to worry about
there. And I'll pass the turn.
>> Oh, I think I am worried. Uh, okie
dokie. Let's go. Let's go ahead and
channel
and have a card. Oh, that's nice. Um
Oh, wow. Okay.
Crumbs. All right. So, we've got four,
seven.
Okay.
Um,
>> even the art of VI is just menacing.
Like, but also, how are you gonna Are
you going to punch Trevor?
>> I am.
>> You can't punch Trevor.
>> I'm going to try. I'm going to
>> illegal.
>> Go ahead and play Vault Breaker.
>> Oh, boy.
>> So, we've got an assault two and ganking
this turn.
>> Okay.
>> Now, so that brings me up a little bit.
>> Yes.
>> And then
VI is effectively 1 billion if you want
it to be. I think
>> I know that's what I'm thinking is um
>> that's the scary part.
>> What the right way to do this is but I
am going to I think I will go for it.
Yep.
>> And we're going to double the might this
turn.
>> Yep. So
>> six might.
>> She's six might with assault too. Yep.
>> Yep.
>> Um and then
I'm going to go four
>> square up.
>> What is that?
>> Um so uh I've got a repeat discard one
which I am going to do. Give a unit
assault four this turn. So it'll be
assault eight.
>> Okay.
>> 10 assault 10 power six. So an effective
16. Um, I'm going to discard
>> um, mage seekers investigator.
>> Yep.
>> And then try and move Vi in on this
battlefield.
>> How could you do this to Trevor? And
look how cute that sprite is.
>> I know, but um, as Vi would say, plan, I
don't need a plan.
>> Well, unfortunately for Vi, I did have a
plan.
>> No.
>> Uh, and this is back off. Vex wants
nothing to do with this. Uh, this just
stuns a unit. I'm going to stun by
>> uh and yeah, just just just get by out
of here. So,
>> I try.
>> We'll have none of that.
>> Okie dokie. I've done that. It's over.
>> Okay. So, we're going to we're going to
shortcut through this a bit. We're going
to get our hold point here.
>> Up to three. We're going to exhaust Vi
to draw a card. Uh, Temporary is going
to kill the sprite. Trevor's going to
put the sprite back. Yep.
>> And we're going to channel two. And then
we are back and ready for action here.
Ooh, that's a fun card.
That is a fun card here. All right.
Well, let's start off by moving Mr. Moss
Stomper over here.
>> I have no nothing to say about that.
Stomp the moss.
>> That is going to go up to four. That is
going to get me two XP. One away.
>> Oh, that is scary.
>> A big old moss stomper. You know what? I
really liked Trevor on that battlefield.
Let's Let's put Trevor on this
battlefield as well.
>> And no need to hide anything. We'll play
face up here.
>> Right. Let's go. Oh, no. Come on. V.
Okay. Um
fine. Right. We're going to try and head
on in here.
>> Okay.
Um,
and
I think
let's do the I should have done this
beforehand.
>> So, yeah, you can do that before to
double
>> to double the Y. So, that's up to six
now. So, we would be trading at this
stage.
>> Okay.
>> 1 2 3 4 five.
>> Oh, I don't like that.
>> And a one to move a VIP peacekeeper in
there. with ambush.
>> Yeah.
And when I attack, stun an enemy unit
here. Okay. So, you also get to stun a
unit.
>> Yes.
>> I don't like that. I'm guessing you're
Are you
>> I will be stunning. Yeah,
>> my boy. Look what they did to my boy.
>> He's stunning.
>> He is stunning. And unfortunately for
Trevor, he is also uh no no longer. We
take up to three and I will discard one
draw one because it was Zor Morance and
because I conquered um I didn't Oh, I
did more than three excess damage.
>> So, I'm going to ready vibe peacekeeper
and bring them back to base.
>> That makes sense.
>> And pass the turn to you.
>> Okay,
let's do this little song and dance.
We'll go up to five from the hold. We
will exhaust Vi to draw a card.
We will make a sprite and we will
channel.
Draw a card.
Okay.
You know what? Let's uh
let's let's fortify here. We're going to
play shadow. So, this is VI's chosen
VI's signature unit here. I've got the
ability to stun units. Uh and if I play
it to Battlefield, it enters ready. So,
that is good to go there. And because I
had so much fun the last time I did it.
Let's
>> Oh gosh.
>> Let's hide another card.
>> Oh no. I
>> I don't need to be I don't need to do
anything else. Let's pass the turn.
>> Okie dokie. Let's go. Let's go. Let's
go.
Let's see if I can do anything.
>> And you'll get your hold point for
point. What's one of those
>> in the rare case that Vi actually holds?
>> Wow.
Okay. Um, so currently
>> level two.
>> Yep. Nine.
When you conquer you get
>> Yeah. So this is just 12 face up right
now.
>> So I'm going to go for two for a soul
harvest on the moss stomper.
>> Oh no. I've got no response.
>> Kill at a battlefield with three or
less.
>> Except that I'm sad.
And then we'll go
one here for vault breaker on five
peacekeeper.
>> Mhm.
>> And I'm going to So I'm at five,
six, seven.
Yeah. Seven.
>> Yep.
>> Currently at nine.
>> Oh, I don't know if this going to be
enough. Do I just go and assign damage?
Um,
I'll bring this vi back.
>> Yep.
>> I'm going to go for two. And we're going
to get rid of this rune as well for this
one.
>> Three vines.
>> Three vi. How many vi do you want? All
of them.
>> I feel like uh there's a there's a da
meme somewhere here.
>> And
I think I am going to go in because when
I attack, I get to stun an enemy unit.
So, I will choose to stun Shadow.
>> Shadow is no longer going to be doing
damage this turn.
>> And then I'm going to do what was it?
Five, six. So, an effective seven.
>> Here's the thing.
>> Go ahead.
>> Is that Shadow whether they're stunned
or not, I can still stun the VI.
>> You can you can stun the Vi.
>> I'm going to go ahead and do that.
>> Sadness. So, that is Vi all done and
dusted.
>> So, she's How How big was she?
>> Um, it's a five, but an effective So,
she just bounces back cuz I've only got
six because this shadow was
>> stunned.
>> And it's over to you.
>> Okay, let's do our favorite song and
dance here. We're going to get up to six
points. We're going to draw a card from
Vex. Uh, this does already.
Let's go here. Let's draw a card for
turn. Ooh, that's a fun one.
I see your three vise in play another
vex,
>> the scary one from Spirit Forge that is
currently doing
a lot of stuff in the meta. Um, okay.
So, I want to do a tricky thing here.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah. I'm going to
>> I'm going to reveal Evelyn who says,
"When I play me from face down on my
turn, I can move an enemy unit at a
different location to this battlefield."
>> Oh,
>> and while this is a giant VI, this VI
can get very big. So, I'm going to go
ahead and move this VI. And when I move
a VI, when I move a unit,
>> I can stun it. Yeah. So, I'm just going
to go ahead and eat that eat that VI.
And I do actually get the Raven Bloom uh
conservatory trigger,
>> which is going to put a unit on the
bottom.
But with that, I'm going to pass the
turn and hope that you can't break
through my fort.
>> Well, I don't have a hand. So, let's
see. We're playing off the top deck and
maybe it's good. Oh, okay.
>> I don't want to hear that.
>> I can play that. Maybe. Um, okay. So, I
I feel like we've What you on six?
Should we go all in?
You can stun.
You know what? I'm not afraid.
>> Oh, no. We're going to go here.
>> Yep.
>> And so with my am with ambush effects, I
can just kind of go in now or do I have
to wait for you to
>> uh No, you can.
>> I can just go in. I thought I'm just
going to go ahead and just um pop Lord
in there as well.
>> Um so all of my other units get assault
this turn as well. So assault one, but
it's only my other units. Yeah,
>> this one's because I'm attacking is
going to stun an enemy unit. Going to
stun
>> five or Yep.
>> And then we've got uh an effective six,
an effective four, and then the five
>> 15.
>> Yes.
>> And I've got three, six, 9, 10, 11.
Well, first things first,
we're going to go ahead and and stun.
We're gonna stun
>> y
>> Vi with with shadow here.
>> Yep,
>> that is definitely happening. You still
got
>> 10.
>> Uh nine. Five and four is nine. I've got
three
six
>> 9 11 uh 3 6 9 10 11.
>> Yeah, Evelyn Evelyn is still there.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh I think
Yeah,
because my spells cost one less. I'm
going to play another back off.
>> Oh,
>> back off, Lord Broadman.
>> I'm saving some of my units here because
I played it for my hand. I get to draw a
card.
>> And let's uh let's resolve the combat
here. You get to deal four damage.
>> I have four damage to assign. Um I will
go for shadow, please.
>> Shadow is gone. And um I think your uh
this VI will survive.
>> Oh, really?
>> Yeah, cuz I I had 11.
>> Oh, you did? Yeah.
>> Yeah. At 11. So I can uh this this and
the other VI.
>> Yeah. Five.
>> You want to do that? Yeah. No worries.
And then this will come back. No, that's
fine.
>> That That's me. Okay.
>> I have no cards in hand.
>> Yep.
Song and dance. We're going up to seven
here. We're going to draw our card.
Let's do this. We're going to draw a
card for turn. You know what?
We got some big stuff. Let's do it. Two,
four, five, six, seven. We're playing
I'm not going to try to pronounce it.
Yascula. I I tried to pronounce it.
We're going to pay a power here. We've
got a lot of stuff on here.
>> Gosh.
>> I'll let you do the math, passenger.
>> Oh, no. I don't like doing the math. I I
don't need a plan. That's the whole
thing. So, we're just gosh. Um,
okay. So, Oh god, no. I definitely can't
do enough. And then you will go ahead.
So, I believe that is a good game, sir.
>> Good game. Well, that was uh that was
the champion decks, Vex versus Vi. I
maybe wasn't a believer before in the
Vex, but that was uh kind of crazy. I am
excited to play Vi as well. Let us know
what you think. What decks are you
excited to play for play with in
unleashes coming out soon?
I'm just going to leave it on that for
screenshoted.
>> Welcome back everybody. Uh we are in I I
guess there's like kind of like the
purgatory now, I guess you could say,
between the Swiss and the top eight. So,
um don't expect us to go into game just
yet. We have to get everything sorted.
We are patiently waiting for the final
top eight to be announced. But not only
that, because not only the top eight is
important, the top 64 is important and
also the best offs are important and
we're going to have a lot of high stake
matches in the top eight as well because
not all of the, you know, legends are
going to be decided when it comes to top
eight. So, uh, sorry, when it comes to
best off, right, because some of them
will still be probably in conclusion
during the top eight. So there there are
additional stakes apart from winning the
entire tournament.
>> Yeah, there is a lot still being worked
out by our judging team in the
background. I think the announcement has
gone out in the venue, but of course as
we are making sure we got everything in
line. Uh we will have that update for
you ASAP. Uh you're with us though for a
few minutes while we can recap the Swiss
portion. Um
>> 15 rounds.
>> Yeah, 15 rounds and we've learned a lot
from it. Um I think there's a couple
things to touch on. Uh Rexi, I don't
believe has made the top eight. And and
that's one of the decks that people
said, "Oh, it's going to be good coming
into this event." I mean, and it has
been good. It was solid,
>> but I think it just misses the cut.
>> Well, it wasn't super populated, right?
It was like 5% of the entire field,
which is not a lot, but it's still like
in the top eight of most played decks, I
think. At least during day one. Day two
was definitely a little bit worse. Um,
but in general, I would say that Rexi
still showed up in numbers when it comes
to like the results on day one. Yeah.
And it would looked like it's a solid
deck. Um, although definitely the red
version was going
I don't even know. We didn't see any
single yellow, but I feel like the
yellow version is just not flexible
enough to actually perform during a such
a big tournament like this. similar deck
that hasn't necessarily shown up as
consistently, I believe has put one in
the top eight is Azir. Still has been
good. Azir has looked good in a lot of
the featured games, but I think uh it's
one of those decks that people were
wondering over the last week or so like
is it going to be the top deck and I
think the consistency of the deck has
been a little bit of a liability coming
into
>> for sure. And it's a also another thing
that you can question about this deck is
like maybe it's not the deck but the
player that is actually performing. Who
knows?
>> Oh is performing. I thought you saying
is inconsistent.
>> No, no, no. I was like maybe it's not a
maybe this player would have been
performing on a on a different deck, you
know, like maybe it would have been
better. We don't know. But it's um it's
a good moment for that Azir to showcase
us like is it worth to be playing an
Azir in a big tournament. And I feel
like this is still the best uh ever
performance from the deck overall, like
from the Azir overall during a big
tournament like this.
>> Yeah, I think uh aside from the China
regionals back at the very beginning of
Spirit Forge before we really had
figured some something out, I think we
did have that Annie Azia uh like finals,
but that again is a a specific
tournament and we're talking on such a
bigger scale of the number of players,
the the width of of decks that are here
at RQ Le. Um, another deck, and this
isn't say any of these decks are bad, by
the way. If you're thinking, "What do I
want to play at my skirmish?" All of
these decks will take down a skirmish
for you. Just being being confident,
being practiced will do well. Uh,
especially in your local games. It's
about the execution.
>> No, not not the Draven, but Victor.
Another deck that is like really, really
strong. Uh, and but sometimes has a few
consistency issues. Uh,
>> which is funny because when you think
about it, Victor should be one of the
most consistent players because it has
the ability to always play a one drop,
right? Literally a one drop. Yeah.
>> Right. It always has ability to fill out
the curve. But then
>> even though with access to blue, you are
not consistently like having enough
answers to the board state or like not
enough card draw to like match it,
right? So,
>> it's um it's kind of like a semi-
reactive deck that maybe should become
more proactive in in to have a chance to
perform, but I I'm like I would still
like to see the final results to see
like the judgment on like how the deck
performs because I feel like we still
had decent showings from Victors overall
during argu agree all three decks we've
just talked about I would say have been
decent and above uh perhaps you know
above average on on the the way of
playing. I think everyone was talking
about Kaiser, Urelia, and Draven coming
into the tournament. I think it is
generally where we're at. I want to
check the top eight actually for the
number of Kaisers. Part of me feels like
>> if I'm not mistaken, there will be zero
KA in the top eight. And
>> I think that's correct.
>> Like the highest Kai'Sa.
>> I might be very off about about this by
the way, but if I if nothing change, it
should be around like top 30.
>> Okay,
>> something like that, you know. So, not
the best showing from Crisis unless
something will change after the entire
top eight is going to be finalized.
>> As we said, of course, we will get
updated uh details on the actual uh
placement of all of the legends. Ael and
Draven do feature in the top eight. We
do know that for sure. Another champion
that joins them that that some people
>> were expecting. I know that you put it
in in your videos of Master Yi. Uh the
mid-range build, not the Aurora build. I
I we didn't see any Aurora Ye and I
would guess that of the two there's no
reason to play Aurora right now. It's
mostly about that mid-range.
>> I definitely with the yellow being
>> up in numbers overall in the metag game
seems like Master Yi Aurora even though
it's probably the best Aurora deck to be
played right now in the entire metag
game. It's still probably not a wise
choice in this open meta game where you
will have to face Victor, Rexai, Fiora
to some degree also set which can play
like Cold Weeks as well. Um that might
be problematic, right? So
>> whereas mid-range you have good little
units. You have like Desert's Call
allows you to use sand soldier, some
equipment in there, the the ye uh legend
ability uh bumping up your units on
defense. So, uh, it's been a surprise if
you haven't been paying attention is the
way that I would put it. I know people
have been talking about Y for about a
week or so, a few weeks. Um, if you were
coming into this expecting just the meta
with a few bands and our Draven will
still be good, Ireelia will still be
good, you probably weren't prepared for
Master E.
>> That's the thing, like, not sure if you
remember, but after the announcement of
the bands for like the first 48 hours,
people were saying, "Oh, Draven, ah, not
worth playing."
>> Yeah, true. Well, maybe not as dramatic
as I just made an impression of. Some
people were
>> where okay but in in my eyes he he was
still very playable like instantly after
the bans I was like yeah the mid Draven
still is okay like you can curve out
still and be fine you know uh so it
wasn't that big of a surprise to me to
see that Draven still performs but it is
definitely a more fair deck. Yeah, that
is that is very fair that it is a very
more fair deck is the way that we should
should put that. And yeah, never
underestimate the ability of uh
community members to be vocal with a a
very whiplash
uh you know, posting about, oh, this
deck's rubbish. It's out of here.
Players, listening to them talk like,
no, no, this this card is utter garbage.
It's trash. Never play it. Then it's
being played in 15% of the decks next
week. You know, it's like it's always
like that.
>> Everybody has an opinion. Somebody whose
opinion or at least thoughts I want to
hear about is barcodes.
>> All right, I've got a special one.
Yamato, welcome again.
>> Thank you very much, man.
>> We saw each other on Friday for
interview, but now you have two more
days of competition behind you.
>> How do you feel?
>> I feel more addicted to rift bound than
before, which is dangerous. Um uh the
matches didn't go my way. Uh but that's
fine. Like I went 52 to1 for so I didn't
make the top cut uh for the next day for
the main event, but I had the backup
rebound and that didn't go too well.
Like I woke up early. I should have
slept longer and just uh skipped it. But
it was fine. It's like it's always
unique cuz you run into decks for the
first time and I have to read cards and
you learn, you know, you learn.
>> Yeah, absolutely. But uh I mean what
doesn't kill you makes you learn more.
That's what we usually say. So, I mean,
now you've got been told some uh very
useful
>> secret.
>> I hope so. But in general, what do you
think about the atmosphere about uh
about the event? Because on Friday, you
told me it was absolutely insane. Now,
you've got more experience about it.
>> How is it?
>> You know, for me, I think the Rift Pound
community is the best community I've
ever interacted with. It's not even
close. Uh people are always nice at
events of course like in League of
Legends at events and so forth it's
always been nice but you know a
difficult thing for me is that I spent
my entire life in esports so all my all
my friends like my best friend is in
Texas I have a friend in the UK it's
like we don't meet and uh playing with
the local community like in in my
hometown and the towns that are close by
h it's good to feel that I have like I
I've met friends this way you know that
I can hang out with which is really nice
and then to go here with them and to
spend that time. It's like after every
game rush out and it's like, "Oh, how
did it go? How did it go?" "Oh, you got
you didn't get a two drop on your turn
one. Oh, sucks. Me too." Yeah. It's like
I love that aspect. And everyone's super
super nice. I didn't have a single
negative interaction. H it's just good
to come to this event and feel like a
child again, you know, like I feel like
the entire outside world is just closed
off and u uh to have that moment feels
good, you know. feels like all the
responsibilities they take a back note
for just one weekend which uh I think
everyone kind of deserves sometimes you
know
>> true that and yeah every single time
when I'm asking some people they always
tell tell me the same thing they are so
happy to be there they always have some
good interactions even on top tables I
see some players that uh managed to be
in top cut and they were so happy you
know relieved and that feels so good to
see that so I can totally relate with
what you are saying right So you told me
that you were I mean a bit more addicted
to this game.
>> So are you going to train for the next
event?
>> I will. I will way harder because I
played more riftbound during these three
days than I have had played in total. So
like I I felt I was getting better and
better. So that's nice. Um but for the
unleashed and utre like I'm a competitor
at heart. So this is a very dangerous
combination. So I will be playing so
much unleash. Uh, I will be unleashed.
>> Oh, you will be unleashed. I will be
unleashed. We will be unleashed because
I actually will train as well. So, maybe
we will train together. We'll do
something like that and we will see
who's coming out on top after the next
tournament. But for now, we are going to
go back on stage for what's coming up
next.
All right, we're back with BK who is
here and who is qualified in the top
eight. So, first of all,
congratulations.
>> Thank you so much. Yeah, it's it's been
such an insane run and I'm I'm so happy
to to have made it.
>> I mean, we can see that you're always
smiling. I saw you in the row and you
were very very happy.
>> This is insane. you are playing Master
Yi. And to be honest, I'm going totally
honest with you, I didn't expect Master
Yi to do that well at the event. And I
think there are two or three Master Y
right now in top eight or in the in the
top tables. I mean, did you choose
Mastery knowing that it was a very good
deck in this meta game? Uh, so of course
the metal card added value was of course
there because I knew this was not going
to be the most popular deck. But we
started testing it right after Fighter
Flight got cut from the standard format
and we believe that we just kept
winning. We just we just couldn't lose
against anything. So we kept iterating
on the deck and we arrived at a deck
list that I believe is just favored in
the most of the meta game. Uh, and well
I was hoping for top eight of course but
I was not expecting it to get this far.
So, so yeah, Mastery was definitely a
little bit of a metro card value pick,
but also we strongly believe that the
deck is very, very good.
>> So, now the top eight is absolutely
secured. You're fine. And there are
three more games to win to get the
title. Are you confident? And do you
think that you can just win it all?
>> Uh, I'm going to do what I can and I'm
confident that my deck is great and I've
been playing very well today. So, let's
get it.
>> Any final words?
>> Uh, h I think I think that's fine. Uh,
thank you everybody for for cheing on me
on. I've got I've gotten so many
messages on on Twitter, on uh Discord,
from my friends. So, everybody was
rooting for me and I I truly truly
appreciate it. So, uh if you were
rooting for me, thank you so much. I
love you all.
>> He said absolutely everything. You know
what to do. Wait for the next round. But
for now, we've got some more content.
Back to you.
>> Thank you very much. Barcode and bar
check. Yeah, put that back. Put that
back. Don't No, no stealing. Don't Don't
tell them where all the unleashed packs
are that we're hiding back here. Top
secret information is here.
>> Oh, you do?
>> No, I lied.
>> Oh, okay. I was going to say, well, uh
it won't be top secret information very
long cuz we are soon to find out our top
eight. Uh very close to getting there
and I promise you once we do show you
the top eight, uh we are going to get
quite quickly into game as well. So, uh
lovely to hear from Barek there. Uh one
of the Master Yi players. It was awesome
to see him earlier in the feature match
because now we have some kind of story
line that we can follow, right? Because
we have seen him how he played in his
game and we're going to be able to now
follow his top eight journey as well.
>> And here it is. Here's the top eight.
Here are the matchups. Here is
everything that we're going to have for
the rest of the day. We are down to
eight players. So, it is Pedro, also
known as Squirtle and Bachek. At the
top, it is Azir and Master Yi. We have
Natural uh Urelia going up against
Shaun's master Yi. So it could very well
be a Yi uh team kill later or it could
be Aelia as who knows.
>> Uh then we got Ziden on Draven going up
against Urelia with Martin and then
Prismaticism makes his I believe third
>> third appearance in a top. We have to
like a little bit spend time about
talking about this. This is insanity.
is able to get a third top eight in a
regional qualifier in this short history
of Riftbound. Now, that is absolutely
mental. This guy is so talented and he's
doing it if I'm not mistaken. I might be
wrong, but I think it's with every time
he did it with a different legend.
>> Uh we'll have to double check that.
We'll have to uh I think you may very
well be right. And then Aurelia to round
things out at the bottom of the bracket
for Alex Shans. So, uh, three Aurelia,
two Master Y, an Azia, a Draven, and an
Annie.
>> I'm very, um, happy with because first
and foremost, okay, never mind. Let's
talk about the deck list from the Annie.
So, we have a very aggressive list with
the actually, no, it's not as aggressive
as I thought it would be because there
are no deck hands over here, right? Am I
missing deck hands? No, we have seen
already Prismat play once this deck on
stream. Uh, the Rangers were coming in
really in handy. Rangers found their
place currently um in a deck which just
untaps, you know, energy during your
opponent's turn and suddenly you have a
defender potentially for free might on
your battlefield that you control or
just a ready unit in your base whenever
there's a trigger open and you can
>> and if you are using it aggressively,
it's extra might that can't be
countered. It's not a spell that is
going to do things against like an Aelia
that can counter in the meta right now.
And it is an Aurelia matchup that we're
going to see from Prismaticism and Alex
Shans. Of course, we are showing you the
deck list now for this match. Uh
>> doing like a ooh because I see two
Draven audacious that is not a common
choice.
>> Okay,
>> because it when you have two Dven
audacious, what this tells me is I am
trying to actually have them as a win
condition like it's not a oneoff that
sometimes come in comes in and not like
I'm actually planning my game around a
two off in my deck. So this is a a very
good signal to have when it comes to
like now deciding also how the um
>> that is notism
Alex but we'll get that
>> and uh Squirtle
>> yeah exactly and
>> but um I wanted to say that this Urelia
with the double double Dravens and
Squirtle not Squirtle and the scout deck
hands yeah
>> is something that is like trying to
squeeze additional points means we have
right the winds, we have scout deck
hands, right? We have um the Draven as
well to close out the game in an
unexpected fast manner. So that is
pretty aggressive from like an Aelia
deck. Um we'll I'm actually happy to see
this kind of deck um in the in the top
eight as well.
>> Yeah. Uh and there is some variance
there in the top eight as well. We've
got a number of Aelas. We will focus in
on this match up in just a second. As
I'm sure you can tell, we are just
making sure everything is in place uh
before we go in. Um, as you said, some
variants there. Urelia is going to have
a few different types of matchups uh to
to face down. You got some wide boards.
You got the Annie with some direct
damage. Um, but yeah, I I would say this
prismaticism list, I'm intrigued to see
where this matchup
>> kind of ends up for Prismaticism against
awesome if you could bring up the list
from Prismatic again on screen. Um, not
sure if that's going to be possible
before we go to the match, but uh, his
list is unorthodox, I would say. Yeah,
that I was trying to place it in my head
of like exactly how much damage is in
there whereas how many how much of it is
unit based.
>> It's uh I can remember he plays flashes
as well.
>> I saw I'm now now I'm thinking cuz
whether it was in Aelia what I I'm sure
you do in Annie as you get the untap. It
always is such a consistent uh moment to
be. such a a you know a foundational
card from proving grounds as as you know
Annie plus yeah
>> this is what our players are playing for
at the end of the top eight
>> regional qualified first place 2026
that's what it says
>> only the second European RQ winner from
this and of course that puts you in a
great position the blade of the ruin
king
>> so what if you want to play with this
champion card by the way
>> uh you actually have to just put that in
your deck
>> no you no you just have to make every
single card a deck map. Exactly.
>> Exactly. Uh do that be I would just
shuffle be over this um my hand over
here. Right. So when you would be
shuffling you would I don't know how
>> cycling like this.
>> Yeah. Do you want to cut
>> with what? With a chainsaw or something.
>> Exactly that. Uh yeah it is um a an
incredibly I I don't want to say unique
cuz obviously our Bolognia winner Allan
did of course get the Blade King but
hyper limited is the way of putting it.
You have to win an RQ to be able to get
that.
>> Exactly. Yeah. Uh I think it's a awesome
unique aspect. Like we have few things
when it comes to rift that that is like
this incentive to perform well in in a
tournament. We have the top eight cards.
We have the champion card of course and
we have the metal foil cards. I mean you
think about it. The person who wins the
entire event gets the metal foil card
and gets the champion promo which is
insane.
>> That's a lot of swag to have uh from
your wins. There are a couple of players
in the top eight though that will know
uh that they are the best of. for
instance, prismaticism will know is the
oni. So, best of is already locked. Uh
the best of cards, I believe, for the
the Swiss rounds have already been
handed out uh in the background as well.
So, I'm sure you all can uh I know
people are tracking, people are keeping
an eye on who's getting what best of at
home. We see we uh hopefully have been
telling the stories as best as possible
throughout the weekend. But with nearly
2,000 players, there's a lot to a lot to
follow.
>> It's going to be easier though in the
future.
>> Yeah. Because the more history we get
with the riftbound events that we have
over here, uh we're going to have more
players that are going to we're getting
to know them better. We're going to get
the uh names in our heads that going to
be like now ingrained there. Like Prisad
for now
>> is already one of those kind of players.
Allan is another one that is ingrained
as well, right? Those are the people who
are just consistently showing up and
we're going to have repeated history of
those players. are going to be
performing all the time most likely in
the span of years and then we're going
to be building those story lines. So in
like for example hopefully in like 3
years when we're going to be sitting and
watching a regional we're going to be
going ah I know this guy.
>> Yeah from RQ Leil.
>> Yeah exactly. Oh Bologna and so on.
>> That's the interesting thing. We've got
some recognizable players here, some uh
some names that we haven't really seen
too much before in Riftbound and and a
big omission in that we're going to have
a new RQ champion here for Europe as we
are just getting through things uh for
our feature match of the top eight. Um I
believe we uh we'll find out exactly
which matchup we are are following as we
need just a couple more minutes before
we actually get there. We're just
building the suspense for you. We're
just
>> to to finish the train of thought since
we have some a little bit of course time
to yap. I love yapping if you didn't
know. Uh so what I wanted to say even
though I kind of wanted to showcase that
the more games we get, the more
tournaments we get, we are building up
this kind of story lines for players.
But what is the beautiful aspect of card
games is that it doesn't matter if you
have history or not, you can still
perform and you can still win a card
gamebased tournament. So, it's always
there's always an opening for someone
new to suddenly pop up and perform. And
because it's a one v one game, you don't
need a team or or you don't need a staff
of people just working with you. You can
literally do it by yourself and out of
nowhere, out of the blue, you can just
show up, go into a tournament and be in
the top eight and suddenly you're you're
there. You know, it's like because you
did it yourself. It's a beautiful story
that many people associate with, for
example, esports where pe people just
form teams and just suddenly perform
with a qualifier, go to a major
tournament, win it, and suddenly there
are stars, you know, and it's something
that can happen in card games as well.
>> Yeah, it can. And it it certainly has.
You and I both have a storied history
with card games and and different
esports as you said. So, I always love
that team aspect. Um I I look forward to
more Riftbound teams forming. It's why
whenever I I look at the the standings
and you see ah challenge a TCG at there,
challenge a TCG at there all the way
down the line. I've been talking to
Alexander the greatest who is one of the
the players that is heavily involved and
talking about how well the players have
been.
>> He's always teasing me by the way.
>> They're not the only
>> We'll get you Alex one some point. You
know,
>> they're obviously not the only team uh
that is represented uh for RiftM. We do
have a few others and I would love to
tell your stories as uh we do more and
more events. So, if you are forming a
Riftband team or a collective of pro
players, reach out to the broadcast
team. We we want to showcase your
stories. We want to put you forward in
the spotlight cuz as much as we love
yapping, we need things to yap about. We
need to be able to tell your stories.
So,
>> but the beautiful thing about car, even
though we might be in in a team, it's
still a one v one. Although
>> our game is built with multiplayer in
mind as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Who knows? Maybe in the future we're
going to have formats, different formats
than a 1v one that are going to be
competitive, right? I'm like always
imagining because it's League of
Legends, it would be so cool if you had
like a team versus team 5v5 where you
divide people by lanes, right? So you
have the bot lane, top lane, mid lane,
and you choose legends accordingly to
their characteristics in League of
Legends. And then you play against
another team that also does the same.
And you have a fight between the lanes,
you know,
>> and that just means the one v one
portion has to be top lane on an island.
So you have play over there.
>> Oh, that would be so cool. One v one top
lane, one v one mid lane. And then you
have a 2v2
>> of bot lane.
>> Of bot lane. And the jungle doesn't
matter around. AFK anyway.
>> Yeah. So, uh just as an update, we um I
believe are jumping to our other
featured match of Azia versus Master Yi,
which does mean we are following uh our
highest seated player of Squirtle coming
into this bracket. So, uh we were
looking at Prismaticism before. It is
actually going to be Squirtle and Barack
that we are following for this first
round or of the top eight. So, we will
hopefully get you deck lists and things
like that before we jump into the game.
But, uh, we will be getting there soon.
>> We will be there.
>> Look at the players contemplating,
>> meditating
>> in your uh your your your setup there
where you're talking about the different
positions.
>> Do you also have to basically draft your
team? Like do you do you have to like
look at the riftbound pool of of
champions? You have to say, "Okay, I'll
pick a jungler. I'll pick a mid laner."
>> But you should still go prepared to an
event with a deck already, right?
>> Yeah. I mean, that always is the most
interesting part about League when you
uh have people run random things as uh
and make it work as we uh we will get
your uh information up on stream for the
deck lists as these two are awaiting
their top eight match. Both of these
players have played on featured match a
number of times over the weekend and
have been very successful in their
attempts. Obviously bringing them to the
top eight. So
now this is because I was thinking about
the match up between Annie and and uh
andia before I'm actually now giving it
a little bit of thought. How how do we
expect a master perform against a Azir?
And I'll be honest with you, this is
going to be one of those matchups that
I'm going to be learning as we go as
learning.
>> Um,
>> let's theor similarity is what I would
say, but there's both tend to use sand
soldiers plus equipment. Um, obviously
Master Yi only wants to put one unit at
a battlefield. So
>> the question there is how does Azia
select which units to go aggressive
with? because you're unlikely to be able
to cascade in this matchup. You're
unlikely to be able to send just one
unit in to overcome the the master.
>> I I think you kind of have to change
your strategy a little bit and instead
of for example using sand soldiers that
you know use the weapon master to equip
the different equipment that you play
and then you become like oh you have
four sand soldiers each of them has one
equipment. Instead, you might actually
not use the weapon master, okay, on the
units and just build one giga soldier.
>> One big one. What would be the upgrade
from sand soldier to what? What would be
>> sand general? Well, I guess he is kind
of general. So,
>> what would he What if he upgrade the
word sand? What would it be?
>> Oh, I What? I I don't sand.
>> Yeah, I don't know where that's going. I
I my my geology is not really where it
should be.
>> Rock soldier.
>> Yeah. Um, but the thing is if you build
up one huge soldier with potentially
like, you know, multiple BF swords and
then as shield on top of it, then you
have plus seven. So you're you're at
nine. Now you can attack one of the
holds from Master Y. So you're not going
to utilize the weapon masters from the
sand soldiers, but you're trying to fix
the matchup in this way, right? So
you're potentially finding a way in to
break the battlefields. And then Master
has a bigger problem in how to break it
back, right? because Masi does struggle
with reconquering the battlefields that
they lost. But the thing is Barek is and
a lot of Vasi players are currently and
also Jax players by the way because this
is the same direction that the green
color was taking are including now the
Urelia fervent in the decks like Jax
like Master where the uh the Urelia does
actually help into being a little bit
more aggressive because now we're going
to be able to essentially turn any kind
of spell that targets Urelia into
additional plus one. So we have uh a
discipline becoming a plus three. we
have the uh on on guard becoming also
plus three right of course if she's
alone in the base which is not always
the case by the way with master it's not
you know
>> yeah it sometimes it is sometimes she
isn't
>> but then you can always play it in a in
a battlefield what I'm talking about
anyway the point is there's going to be
an interesting dynamic between those two
decks and both of them are also playing
counter spells which is going to be
important the defies and the uh wait do
we have any windwall there are two
windols in the list from Azir inside
board.
>> Although yeah, we should uh for just a
moment I without seeing the players in
game with their headsets on I don't
necessarily want to
>> Yes. I mean no no no they should this
should be public information.
>> Okay. In that in that case that's fair.
I just uh I know that as we are in
between the rounds I think
>> things that are changing in top eight.
One of the rulings that is affecting
players in top is the highest seat is
choosing who's starting.
>> Yes.
that there's no dice rolls, there's no
uh rock, paper, scissors or or whatever.
There will be scissors in this uh
>> Yeah, there will be Yeah.
>> And there might be some rocks as well.
Um small sand, small rocks.
>> See, that's what that's where the
conversation was going.
>> I see you're back. You're back.
>> All right. So, uh I'm rambling a little
bit. Um
>> you were saying uh about deck list being
>> Yes. And the deck list should be
completely open because now once we
establish in top eight the information
to be fair and to have a competitive
integrity everyone should know what
everyone is playing in the decks because
some people could be exposed to more uh
scouting or less scouting or literally
on the broadcast and so on. So uh you
have to equalize the state of of the
informations and because of that top is
open deckless
>> understandable understandable at that
point. So you were talking about the
wind wall. Uh
>> yes and in the sideboard we do have the
two wind walls uh that are going to it
actually they are not as important I
would say in this particular matchup
when I'm thinking about it. It would be
important if the master player would
actually have the wind ball because that
would potentially stop the rise.
>> A rise but that's not going to be
happening. For Masido, we have two
actions in the side board,
>> which is something that might actually
fix a little bit of the aggressiveness
in this particular matchup. It will damp
you by two runes, but getting a BF sword
>> and then Azir doesn't have an easy way
of dealing with the action who might be
just sitting in a base might be
something that will be problematic.
Also, one of the bigger targets for um
action will be for example the shears
because if you don't have the secret
shears you cannot fix the main problem
of Azir which is another thing that can
happen as well the one guardian angel
that we have in every single Azir being
played on the planet can also be a nice
target for the action but this is all
happening in game two potentially three
because those are sideboard choices and
in the main
>> it's going to be a little bit more
honest and it's the I think okay I'm
going to ask you a question
>> okay
>> and I'm going to check your memory what
was the deciding factor in the games of
Azir that we did see on the broadcast
>> was that today it feels like a long time
ago
>> I don't know man we watched like 50
>> I know that's what I'm saying um I'm
trying
>> but the card that was finishing the game
there was a specific two energy card
>> that was grabbing
grabbing two energy grabbing
>> what what can be grabbing something.
>> Oh, do you mean uh death grip in in that
regard? Yeah. Okay.
>> Death Grip is one of those cards that
might be important.
>> I' I've got to be honest.
>> I intentionally forgot some of those
interactions with death grip from
yesterday, so I figured uh I wasn't
following you on that. I'm with you
though. Death Grip. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Death grip was one of the deciding
factors in the previous Azir matches.
>> It certainly was. And in this particular
matchup, I feel like it's also going to
be important because you're going to be
able to utilize one of the units from
the other battlefield after already like
being buffed by the equipment. You go
conquer one of the holds from uh from
Master Yi. Now the unit is kind of
useless there. So you can death grip it,
unlock the equipment from it, right? And
then also
>> kind of double the might from the
equipment already on the other unit.
then potentially equip the equipment
again and now push to the other
battlefield and master doesn't really
have much to do apart from defying the
death
>> grip that there's a lot of targets for
the defy to be like actually considered
here and how important some of those
cards are like face breaker we have
potentially gods hidden blade um there
salvage one salvage there are so many
targets of the fight that you can have
to plan
>> something we haven't talked about too
much uh as the players do seem to be
getting into game which is where we want
to be heading. Um we talked about how um
Squirtle, also known as Pedro on stream,
um has side selection. So that means you
know at least in game one and then
should you need a game three, you'll
know that you are the one playing first,
which means you are likely to be the one
conquering first and maybe puts Master
Y.
>> Shouldn't be Barack higher. Uh,
Squirtle's 11 and 1102, so should have
an extra point, right?
>> No, it's Bach who should have one extra
point, right? Because
losses are in the middle.
>> Losses are in the middle.
>> Okay. Of course.
>> Of course.
>> Valerant is
>> Yes. And traditional sports are putting
draws in the middle. Yeah.
>> Okay. No, it's it's 11:02. I haven't
realized you can't draw in Valerant. It
doesn't matter. I don't know what I'm
talking about. I I don't do shooter
games. That's I haven't done that in a
long time. Uh, yeah. Well, what I was
going to say is Azia on
>> the aggressive side means Yei is in that
awkward spot of trying to break holds a
little bit more often potentially
depending on how the cards come out in
the the opening hands. It's possible
that Barek has to play the conquer game
like to retake um now there there's a
there's a shooter game turn it has to
retake battlefields rather than be the
ones to
>> How much utility will they have for the
retake?
>> Uh just don't peak. That's the That's
what I
>> wait for your teammates. Don't go alone.
Although in case of Mi that might be a
>> Yeah, actually do go alone on this one.
Don't wait for the teammates otherwise
you uh you don't get that plus two.
>> But that's only on defense and not on
retake.
>> Uh I think we've exhausted the the the
limits. I haven't played Valerant in
quite a few years. But we're playing
Riftband. That's the important thing.
We're into the game. It is top eight
time between Squirtle and Barack. We've
got Azir going up against Master Yi.
Halls of Legends will not be a
battlefield that Master will like to
utilize a lot. Although there is
actually use case here because Forge of
the Flop will be able to utilize your
legend to tap in in in some degree.
>> Oh yeah, you could uh potentially do
some ready unready.
>> Yeah. And you move like a piece of
equipment twice in a turn.
>> Possibility probably will never happen,
but yeah, it's going to be funny.
Anyway, um we're going to have Pro aka
Squirtle starting on Azir with turn one.
Uh let's see if we have an equipment for
turn one. There's the eye. We're going
to spawn the sand soldier and we have an
aggressive opening already.
>> And this is exactly what I was kind of
alluding to is being on the play as
Azir. You get that from being uh the top
seed here in the in the top eight means
you can play the first unit. It's a good
sign for Barek that there is a turn one
play here. I think if there's no turn
one play, this game starts getting quite
difficult with the sand soldier moving
towards a battlefield to begin.
>> Yeah. And it's also even more important
where
>> if that would be a a turn one play, but
it would be equipment,
>> right?
>> Interesting goes over to the hall of
legends. So of course that Azia was
exhausted in order to
>> Yeah, that of course there's the second
sand soldier. So, because there was an
equipment blade, because it was radied
off all of Legends, suddenly three sand
soldiers already on the board, each with
um some version of support. There's a
recruit token, of course, on the one
side and then uh equipment on the two
that are in base. So, now it's down to
BK to say, okay, what are my what are my
plays here? Looks like there's a
confront. I think that was an Aurelia
fervent as Barek flicked through. Yeah,
I mean the thing is now now we have to
establish do I want to control the forge
of the fluff for the upcoming turn and
signal how much potential energy can be
spent on buffs or do I just develop the
board in the backside and leave the
clockwork completely open because he's
dead on site. Yes,
>> we have a five might actually six might
with the attack with the eye that
potentially can go into that
battlefield, right? It will be exchanged
for some of the units from the opponent.
But that is a calculation that BCH needs
to do because he needs to set up this
turn and then the turn after that. So we
are on the curve. We're playing the
Aurelia Fervent. In the next turn, we're
potentially looking for spells to buff
the Aravent and like maybe play a small
unit to base or maybe we're going to go
for the Master Yi if it's going to be
strong enough to actually go into a
battlefield, but that again would open
us to interaction from the opponent's
Azir. That's not ideal.
>> Shields are down right now for this
Aurelia. It's not so big of a deal
compared to the Aurelia matchup itself.
And there's no color weak in the main
board of uh of Squirtle deck. So that is
something to to note that is a
difference to what we perhaps would
think about on the Aurelia matchup
specifically. Uh but that Aurelia is a
little bit vulnerable when you don't
have the protection there. As mentioned
though, it is not the lynch pin of this
deck. It is not everything that you
need.
>> There's uh that will be a charm in the
main.
>> Okay. So difficulty in actually
attacking the uh the Aurelia. And when
you think about it, this changes the
dynamic of the game so much because when
you're playing against closed deck list,
right? You might be thinking, okay, I
have to play around cool the week. I
have to play around the charm to some
degree. I might be doing different kind
of plays than uh than I would typically
do. But here with full information, you
can actually play in a way that kind of
would not make sense when you're playing
in um a closed deckless environment.
So we have Urelia with five might and on
the battlefield we have currently nine.
If you are first time tuning in this
weekend at the bottom of the screen you
have both uh battlefields mentioned and
they have updated might counters in
every single moment and they are updated
very fast and very quick. Thank you
production for that and it's uh it's
this way it's very easy to understand
what's currently happening. So,
confront, see if there's a response. We
did talk about how there are some cards
like Defy in the main board for
Squirtle. We'll let let that resolve.
So, get to confront into confront as uh
card draw into card draw sometimes isn't
the worst of things. It's card draw into
card draw later as that. Well, now
actually, sorry, because of the
confront. So, we'll draw off the Stellan
Herder. So cadra and cadra and cadro
>> always good. Always good. This game is
going to be a little bit slower now.
Well, actually I said a little bit
slower, but judging by the way that
we're just advancing the number of units
on the Azir side, we might actually just
be speeding up a lot.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm trying to look at what is
in the main deck of a Pedro.
Potentially, if this was a big swing
from the Urelia, it won't be. It'll be a
pass then to begin the next turn for
Squirtle. Now, as the ready step comes
through from awakening,
>> we have one energy open for Bick. So,
he's going to be able to play Anguard.
That's basically it.
>> Uh, defy or punch first, right? From
from
>> Oh, wait. Is there even anard? Yeah, he
has three guards, of course.
>> So, there are a few options. Um,
>> punch first in three copies. I just
realized. Wow, that is a lot of punch
first. So you are representing multiple
pieces of interaction uh on Barek's
side. So now it's down to to Pedro to
Squirtle to uh figure out exactly which
the best way forward is and you know
just put another BF sword onto the
battlefield or at least onto the uh the
base for now and will get equipped. In
theory, Azir has limited amount of units
that he can generate during a game. But
in practice, it doesn't matter. Like the
game will just end at some point. Either
the Azir loses or wins with the amount
of units that he can generate.
>> Um
>> cuz now you can potentially use the uh
legend ability now that you played
another piece of equipment. You'll get
another unit from the eye of the Herald
moving in. So, it really is a case of
just trying to overwhelm some of these
individual units from Master Yi and uh
just get as much small additional
resources, small units like these
recruits on the back end of the trade.
Um,
>> wow.
>> We are transferring the B. See,
>> here is the rock soldier.
>> Yeah, there's the rock soldier. I told
you to do two BFs, I said. And a shield
has an AR.
>> No shield. Who needs Who needs a shield?
Just get more swords. I was wrong, but
it is one big soldier and that is what
is happening currently. Uh well, okay,
it's accompanied by a recruit. Um what
is currently happening and for Master E?
This is not an easy decision to make.
>> Oh, good. It seems like if you're B
check, it's an easy decision and just
slam that punch first and say, okay,
does the math work out with the Master E
plus two now plus five on top makes it
10, I believe. And now we've got a
discipline coming
>> to 11. And there's no energy to
>> the cannot be answered. So that is DM
plus losing the unit for B checkek.
>> Yeah, you can see the difference. I feel
like BK is a little bit I'm not certain
like he's not ah he's thinking about one
>> deciding what because he as he said it's
11 but the one is coming from the
recruit.
The recruit does conquer, but you do
lose uh all of the uh the might at
least, but the equipment just will
return to to base.
>> There's legit a decision here because
this equipment would be stuck on that
battlefield on that one particular unit.
So, to some degree, you can think about
the decision. Should I kill it or not?
Or should in this case, the decision was
still to kill it because your opponent
at least has to reuse energy and root to
attach the equipment there. I think also
if it's like vile moors, it's a slightly
different uh conversation. But in this
game where you can move freely between
battlefields, it certainly is a little
bit more fluid in the way you can get
those equipment pieces moved around. Uh
if we had like a a a tempo checker of
like who we feel is ahead, I would say
it feels in the Azir uh control quite
heavily right now.
>> Yes, I would agree. Uh Barek is going to
need to make every single resource count
in order to turn this game back around
cuz that is a big stacked battlefield on
Forge of the Fluff.
>> Plus then just these recruits are being
really annoying getting one extra point,
one extra thing per turn. Confront draws
into I think that was a lonely power by
the looks of it off the top. That is not
what you need at this point because
there's just too much equipment on the
side of Squirtle to be able to use a
small unit like that on the attack. And
that's the problem we said with Master
Yi. Defending is where you want to be.
Holding is where you want to be.
>> But against this Azir going first, it's
very very difficult.
>> Yeah. And I feel I have a deja vi here.
Like we already seen this.
>> We have confronts card. So we'll get
another
one open. And that was the decision with
the punch first the last turn as well.
Right. So the problem is that when Bick
made the decision to play the punch
first the turn before he was open to one
of the disciplines, one of the death
grips as well, open to enuard. There
were potentially eight cards and also a
face breaker, right? Because you can
then recruit face breaker the recruit
and uh and the opponent, right? So there
were like nine cards that would go over
the top of his one punch first. So, it
would have could have been a
consideration of is it even worth doing
this, right? But, uh I feel like when
you do kind this kind of play, it shows
a little bit of I don't want to like use
the word desperation, but it kind of is.
>> But looking at the opponent, yeah,
exactly. You have to play to the out.
>> This is your calculated decision where
if you hit it and you make your opponent
not have the answer, suddenly you might
be in the driver's seat.
>> Yes. But then it comes with the big
caveat of if your opponent has the
answer then you were doomed for it
anyway. And it's just the same kind of
thing here with the on guard. It will be
a trade from the on guard. So again
trying to just eat into the resources
but that pesky little recruit is there
once again can look to reestablish
control of the hall if necessary. But
Squirtle already being at six points
means a potential turn uh as we go
towards the next uh turn for Squirtle
just setting up for that final hold or
final uh double conquer and it's it's a
really difficult spot for Barek to be
in.
>> Yeah, he would have to deal with the
units but then every single unit that is
newly being played has still has the
ability to re-equip the equipment and be
a threat. So there are like multiple
angles of what B needs to do to find a
solution to this problem on the board
state and it's not looking great on that
>> and and it feels like it basically has
to be Ye from the champion zone
>> and then he's tapping out essentially
because he's going to have to open.
>> Yeah. So you're you're
>> very limited in
>> Is that even enough with the the amount
of might that is stacked? There's
another BF sword there to put onto a
unit which is Yeah. Just shove it all on
one battlefield. if you don't mind
losing the other, but this is stacked so
high that you kind of have to I mean you
you'd have to go in with both and you
can't it's a desert's call to put more
soldiers raise the army more onto the
board and it's in the base as just a
security like 12 might you would have to
go ye and Urelia onto that one
battlefield but then the recruit goes
yeah I'm I'm big enough to win this game
you Oh, is that three lonely parros? It
is a bluff of parro. There is a forge,
but it is not what they needed for Barek
in this game. And that is Squirtle going
one and zero.
>> In this game, when you get three of the
kind, you don't upgrade them higher.
>> You they become the giant parro like the
parro.
>> It's not There were lonely porros. Now
they are pack of not so lonely poros.
>> Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Uh it is a fluff
of porros. That is that's the the uh in
universe term for it. Correct.
Yeah, that's uh
>> sorry, there's a a wealth of random
knowledge in my head from 15 years of
League of Legends and that is one of
them. Um, so Barek now uh will have to
look towards
>> Here we go. We taking a look at the deck
list over here.
>> Yeah. So players like wait I get to see
as players will communicate with the
judges. I think
>> I wanted to talk a little bit about the
previous game stuff though. Sure go for
So, I wanted to highlight how important
was the battlefield selection over here
because I'm actually not certain if Hall
of Legends is a uh battlefield that
typically uh Squirtle, sorry, Pedro
would be opening with because that is
the one that you want to go first with.
>> Like you can see here how it actually
matters. Turn two was massive. creating
two sand soldiers in one turn is
incredible in that like that's like
playing almost a Draven Vanquisher over
there.
>> Yeah, it's it's a massive amount of
might and just bodies.
>> Yeah, I'm using the the metaphor for
driving vanquisher because it's such a
powerful play, right? But it's like it
is actually when you think about it, you
play an equipment, you get to play two
token units, both of them are two might.
That's four might. So, you most likely
are in the range of five, six might for
your full resources, right? And the
funny thing is in this matchup, as I
said before, Botek doesn't even really
get to use it himself. So now we're
going to have the battlefields to be
chosen by um by Pedro, which is going to
be se of power in Trfaren War camp.
>> And in in case of Trfaren War camp, that
is a phenomenal battlefield against
Master. Master is not going to benefit
from that almost at all. Exactly. And
now every single recruit from the eye
becomes a twoight. every soldier becomes
three and it kind of nullifies at least,
>> you know, all you got to do is two units
into uh three units actually at that
point to offset the the war camp used
for Y, but three units means it
nullifies a legend ability. It's it's
when you start thinking about the
matchups in this way, you're like
starting to find like a lot of patterns
where you can get a little bit of an
edge, you know, and it feels like really
this Azir might be well positioned in
this particular matchup that we have in
front of our eyes over here. And uh now
when it comes to the sideboard, we don't
know exactly what is going to be coming
in, but most likely the cool week might
be just
>> it feels it feels good in this matchup.
You'd imagine
>> uh it's still not that big of a factor
when opponent is playing like lonely
porros keepers and so on.
>> Sure.
>> But there are moments where your
opponent might actually now think did
you side in the one cool the week
because we did seeia just come in as a
solo unit essentially. Right.
>> Is there anything else here? We talked
about charm in the game. Is that
something you to look at or is that
>> charm is fantastic? Yeah,
>> charm is fantastic because you can charm
to base
>> and also
>> I mean it does matter because if you
charm to base a unit from master E like
if it's not rune run it like you just lo
you just lost your battle.
>> Yeah, that that's fair. You also can
force Master E to be on the attack as
one of the units. So again, we've talked
about how you want them to be uh on on
the battlefield defending to get that
legend ability in place.
>> Face breaker is also a fantastic card
over here. is another it's another tempo
card that can be used because you don't
really care like if your unit on the
defense you don't really care if your
unit gets stunned like it still bounces
away your opponent. So the thing is for
Bic it seems like um ruin runners might
be incredibly important in this in this
particular uh uh matchup. So he might be
one of those that might be one of those
cards that he's fishing for during the
mulligan to just have a possibility to
drop it on turn three when he's going
first. But that also means he cannot
damp on turn one and two. I mean who D
ramps on turn one? I think that only
Rexai players. But on two on two it
might be actually you know at case
>> is is the sideboard plan then
potentially for Mari to attack the
equipment like the axons and the
disarming rake potentially coming. I I
think we are looking here at potentially
a lot of sideboard sabotage action defy
disarming raid
>> sabotage fast to no probably not so fast
probably not but sabotage is also a good
>> get rid of the arise.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Or potentially any pumps you
know like or potentially any like defies
from your opponent. Tonk not so
important this matchup I would say.
Although we do see the shift that
something that I was anticipating before
the game started right when the Azir is
building up one big soldier then the
twon actually has more value.
>> Interesting. Uh we were talking about
battlefield choice and whether war camp
perhaps is is beneficial. Uh Squirtle
>> choosing seed of power. Uh we'll we'll
>> watch as we go and and see how it pans
out.
>> Well, he he meant you know
>> he knows this match up better than we
do. I'll I'll guarantee that. And also
like does it matter if he's going now
with the seed of power or um or trfarian
war? He's still going to have a
>> both if if you're going game three. So
you will end up and perhaps that's the
advantage then of being on the play
again with Trafarian War campus. You're
like well I I have now two advantages
potentially.
>> Actually you're right it you do have an
advantage when going first against
specifically Master as well because as
we explained before Master has a problem
with breaking holds right. So if you're
holding Trfaren War camp with two units
again another obstacle for master to go
through right so uh yeah you are right I
think war camp is going to be a choice I
mean for sure it's going to be a choice
we got game
>> wow what a statement by me
>> vek's trying to make a statement with a
teleorn hoorder uh just coming out on
curve really good here comes the
brutalizer on the other side though
>> and the big soldier
>> cuz you don't want to give another card
so it gro the guard will was saying I'll
give you one card now from the lonely
power more. I'll give you one card at
the beginning of the next turn. And it's
way better to just break that. Don't
give him the point at the same time.
>> But now we are in the same spot as we
explained before. There's a big unit
sitting on the growth of the godwillow
and the silicon herder is not that
intimidating. It's a free might unit and
you'll have to break a four might
soldier. So you're going to have to
utilize your energy and a card
essentially. If it's if it's discipline,
okay, that is fine. But if it's not a
one would be maybe Trinity Force, but
then you damp and you're not going to be
able to play a potentially Spirit Runner
on three. There's no Spirit Runner even.
>> Some good information for us here as
that's a G and an action uh a charm and
two defies and uh
>> this might be an action turn.
>> It it could very well be take out um I
mean sadly you can't utilize the
brutalizer while it uh gets attached. So
is it just Stellorn her goes over to the
seed of power draw a card? Uh it is
indeed that draw the card. Uh get the
information that looked like another
action.
>> Yeah, he's drawing in pairs
that two defies two actions in that
hand.
>> So it is an action turn which makes
sense. And what do you attack now? Is it
the shield or I mean the brutalizer is
so much value if it moves.
And now the the thing is though that you
just allowed the opponent to get
additional card draw like that is a big
deal because we highlighted before how
Azir has problem with card draw. If
you're getting additional value like
this if you break this need of power
those are two cards.
>> Yeah because you're controlling the
growth of the godwiller already.
>> That is true as uh
I think BK may very well have reminded
about the growth of the godwiller there.
smaller responsible for you know keeping
the state maintaining the board state.
You are correct. Uh a lot of players
don't realize that you are uh both
responsible and missing an advantageous
trigger can be seen as uh unsportsmanly
is one way to put it. So not what we're
saying for this game but just generally
in your games at home. Keep track of the
board state.
>> Mhm.
>> We're trying to keep track of this board
state here as well in game as BF sword
played. It is now a decision on where to
go. you just say, "Okay, I'll just again
stack up one soldier."
>> Yeah. I in this case, I feel like it's
pivotal to break that seat of power. So,
you want to go aggressive. You want to
go over that um that silicon herder.
You're going to have five might. Your
opponent will be forced either to Damp
with a punch first, right? or
essentially use double unguard or maybe
one discipline and that doesn't really
help that much because the unit dies
anyway,
>> right? As uh we are making the decision
now. I believe that's off the weapon
master trigger that we're we're waiting.
No, we've moved past it now. Is that is
a hidden not so hidden uh and just
>> might be breaker though.
>> Oh,
okay.
>> Okay. So, we're building the one big
mega soldier
>> and we're letting the Stellorn Herder
live
>> that will fuel more card draw for Master
Yi. This feels like a blessing a little
bit. Something that Master Yi might
actually be very happy about over here.
But the thing is, I mean, you would
probably leave the seed of power, but
then if you leave the seed of power, now
Pedro is going to draw another card with
Grove of the Godwill. If you were
watching the broadcast yesterday, we had
one match when Grover of the God willow
from was just abused by the opponent.
Just never let go. And that was never
the intended battlefield. By the way,
second action, we're just stealing the
BF.
>> Yeah. And now, can you force the hidden
blade with a charm or something like
that? Would that have been a I guess
maybe you want to hold the charm for
>> St.
It's actually still can be a defy.
Yeah, there could be a defy to the defy,
but I think we've gone past. Yeah, we
are going to let that resolve. So, uh I
believe Squirtle doesn't have one in
hand. Uh I didn't quite catch all of
Squirtle's hand as we were were looking
at it. Um but we have seen Defy the Defy
a few times today already.
>> Wait, is the Sovereign Azir on the board
or
>> No, no, I I believe the Azir sovereign
is in the chosen champion zone.
>> Yeah, it was otherwise in the previous
games. It was always
>> It was the other way around. You are you
are correct. Um I do not believe that
the Azir has been played from the chosen
champion zone because I think it was
only really the last turn that it was
BF sword.
>> So that is uh a little bit um visually
confusing but uh nevertheless we will
>> we will keep track of when that hits the
board.
Ston her moves back after the conqueror
on the other battlefields. So trying to
again make use of as much of this from
Cedar Power. No, no, of power on you
works when you conquer and you have to
conquer the
>> Yes, you're right. The state of power is
second.
>> Thank you, which is another reason to
move the cell back. Otherwise, you're
holding.
>> Yeah, good point.
>> I was getting there.
>> Yeah,
>> you got to the station.
>> Definitely didn't make a mistake on the
way there. There's a face breaker.
>> There's a face breaker. Yeah,
>> but now how do we break that go growth
of the godwillow? It
>> Now, Azir is I told you I'll tell you
when it uh
>> Thank you. You're keeping track of it.
Exactly. That would make him do
>> we but we are not accelerating the Azir
sovereign. So making us set up
potentially for the next turn which is
opening himself to a potential charm.
But if I remember correctly there's a
define.
>> So there's a insurance against at least
one copy of the define. We're hiding the
face breaker. And as I explained before,
it doesn't really matter in this matchup
that much that you're stunning yourself
because typically Master Yi wouldn't
have an option to break you with two
units. But in this case actually we have
Bick with two units in the back. So this
might be forced out if Bick will attack
with the Sakon her first because maybe
he will anticipate this might be a
hidden blade. He might force out the
fitting blade but there's going to be a
face breaker and then it doesn't matter
much.
>> Yes, you're you're you're correct.
>> And then remember that the defender is
stunned for the entire turn. So, a
secondary unit going into that
battlefield is going to be uh just
smoked, right? So, this is why we see
the reinforcements as well.
>> But, and this is very peculiar in this
matchup.
>> When you think about it, stacking one
battlefield typically announces that ah
okay, I'm ahead on points. I'm trying to
like establish myself as the one the
first one that will be holding to eight.
This is not the case because in this
particular metrop is currently ahead.
Yeah,
>> but the Azir Sovereign is one of those
units that allows you to go back and
like catch up in points because you're
going to move all the tokens from the
other battlefield. But the thing is this
Azir might not see the light of day for
the next turn because we are fully
tapped out.
>> So the charm is available and of course
Axan will get the added bonus from the
Mari from defending alone. Looking at
what else is in the hand guardian angel
there. There's a Stellorn Herder
Confront I believe was one of the cards
drawn either this turn or recently. I
think there's a discipline maybe even
two. Barek is not struggling for cards
because this Stellicorn Herder has been
able to do work.
>> Plus the grove of the guard willow has
drawn at least one now for uh for Barek.
>> That is an interesting turn. Okay, so
we're going to have guardian angel
equipped to the action because we are
guarding the the BF sword that is on it.
Yes, because that's an important
interaction as a face breaker will
happen exactly as you were saying.
>> And none on the recruit
>> on the sideboard. So BK knew that was a
possibility as
>> and now he's also drawing a card from
the seat of power.
>> Lonely Power not going to do too too
much here. But here's the charm as
mentioned. Oh, really hurting his own uh
rune pool here. But that doesn't matter
if you're going to look to win the game
from this. clearing the board out
as that is Azia sovereign gone as well.
One rune available out of two
>> and his opponent sitting at what
>> that's runes and buy in hand as well
soldier. Nothing much. Now we're moving
with the um with the silicon herder to
get additional card draw. You could even
leave it
>> on that battlefield because it's still
essentially plus one but your unit is
smaller so it's easier to break. So
there's one thing not represented here
by VC is punch first because there's
only one orange rune available. Uh you
are still representing defy and on guard
which you both have to you have to play
around both can't represent discipline
cuz that is a two energy
spell. So discipline comes through onto
sand soldier will draw a card. Yeah.
That guardian angel does make it
difficult though because that axon you
have to break it twice otherwise both
axons on the following turn will just
conquer and win. And with only four
energy available for Pedro for Squirtle.
It is difficult to take both
battlefields and hold them for the next
turn.
>> It's so funny because they have such
similar sleeves. I was thinking for a
moment that Action only has equipment
stolen from Squirtle, but it's actually
not true. No, it's one one GA as well.
Uh we got to make sure that they uh give
them cards again. Oh, that's happened
before. Not in Riftbound, but uh I've
seen that tail. Uh as Pedro will take
one battlefield from the Grove of the
Godwillow. I think that's an acceptable
uh exchange from Barek's side because
this is all setting up for a double or
at least a conquer and a hold turn
potentially. Yeah, it's not an easy like
it's not an easy scenario to solve for
Pedro and it's looking bleak, I'll be
honest with you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We were talking about if you
had a momentum tracker in game one. If
it was this time, it would be solidly in
M's favor for our second game because
now it's you have to somehow get Axan
off that uh seat of power, then defend
both battlefields the following turn.
And and it is just a question of do you
even have the resources available in
hand to do it. That's going to be in
likely an equip here on I guess the door
and shield because it is a uh
>> recruit
>> one one big recruit. Oh, it's actually a
hidden card. Sorry, that is the other
thing. I think there was a copy of
guards potentially in hand. We'll we'll
keep an eye on that. Uh there is a death
grip, but I don't think it's going to do
anything at this point. At least not
enough. Yeah, it could be utilized if we
equip the shield on the recruit and if
that hidden card would be a guard and
then you just basically spawn a unit and
then you death rip the recruit to give
like the
>> order guy plus two, but it doesn't
really change much.
>> And doing it on your opponent's turn
means you have no option to re-equip uh
even further onto the second one. So I
think this now is just Barek's decision
of which line to win the game are you
going to pick? only four runes
available. So there aren't it's not like
he can do every single thing that he
wants to do here.
>> But he's so ahead in this game is
actually kind of crazy.
>> So what line does Barek maybe have to
think?
>> He could he could essentially like not
even try to attack because there could
be a face breaker, but he has the fight.
So that's actually a very easy decision
over here. But if he wouldn't have the
fight, he could have just stacked the
auto battlefield and just chill.
>> You know what would help?
>> Charm to base.
>> Yeah, to base forces card out. Uh forces
a hidden card just in case it's a hidden
blade. Obviously, you can't just swing
in with Yakshan and and dismiss it. It
does have the Defy, though. But, as you
said, four runes available. There's
still quite a few things that Pedro
could have as an option here. So, taking
the safe route and saying, "Lonely parro
pass." And this is saying you're in a
bad spot. I don't have to win right now.
I can win by holding next turn or
develop enough of a board in order to,
you know, hold with Yakshan or conquer
the second battlefield on the following
turn. again. It forces Pedro have a fast
enough unit. No, not yet. Is it? No,
just
>> I was too speedy. Sorry for that.
>> It did look a little like it.
>> And remember that the action on the suit
of power does actually have a guardian
angel.
>> Yes. So even if it's dealt with, it's
just going back there.
>> Exactly. And can then just play out from
>> But how do you even deal with it? Just
just hit him bladed.
>> Yeah, if you can from hand that would be
one way. That's again it's just going to
go back to the base. You have to deal
with it again again as uh
>> it really is so hard being on five
points from this moment. Guards will be
used
>> as uh
>> going to be able to stack the
battlefield.
>> Mhm.
>> Of course has to deal with the axan this
turn. At least move it off the
battlefield uh of seed of power. At
least that much.
>> I'm not even certain if he sided in
charms. Okay, that
it's hard to know whether there are
actually any options that do reliably
get Squirtle out.
>> So, we play a ready guard in the base,
but that can be met with defy and just
saying nope, you don't have that option.
But actually,
>> do you want to save the defy? Right.
>> But the thing is like you have a win
condition on the board and it's just
like how much power does your opponent
have here to actually go through? So,
we're looking at the death grip.
death grip for three, mate. That's not
enough. That's going to be to up to
five.
>> So, you are trying to draw into an
endgard to go to eight,
>> but that's literally like doing nothing.
Like, even if you're going to trade,
your opponent still has multiple units
and just double conquers.
>> And yeah, and then you're leaving just a
recruit on the grove of the god Willow
to hold through. Even the lonely parro
is likely to just walk over that
unfortunately for Pedro. But, you know,
we're in the top eight. These are
untimed rounds. You kind of do have to
play to your outs. You have to force
your opponent to go through the motions
until the game is done as uh of course
this one is done for game two pretty
much. Uh I I'm not going to say 100% but
the defy is going to come through on the
death grip
>> and that's
>> and that is the scoop. Yeah, that that
that is it. As said it's almost
impossible I believe for Pedro, maybe
even so to turn that game around. So now
does look to a game three. We go back to
sideboarding. We go back to um the in
between stage.
>> And if you are new to Riftbound, I'm
going to be making a lot of statements
if you're new to Rift because I feel
like during the top eight, a lot of
people are tuning in who never watched
Riftbound before.
>> Hello if you are.
>> Yeah, awesome to have you here. And I
wanted to say that in Riftbound, you
have specifically a very interesting
dynamic because when you're site
boarding, you are taking into account
the fact that you're going first or
second because it changes the amount of
um energy that you have possible to be
used on turn one and on turn two. In
some decks, you might actually change
the amount of two drops or three drops
or five drops, for example, depending on
if you're going first or second. And
will that be the case in this game? I'm
not certain. We don't know. But it it is
a consideration for most decks. who are
playing in this game.
>> Yeah. And I think that's one of the
places that that novice and beginner
players uh when you're starting your
journey onto a summoner skirmish, which
you should, by the way, check out uh the
Riftband website and find out where the
the closest skirmish is to you. I think
that's one of the things that players
say, "Oo, that's what really helped me
understand the game a bit more is like,
wow, understanding sideboarding and
matchups is like key to being able to
show up and play your best within the
day because you don't want to do things
blind. You don't want to come in and not
know anything about how to sideboard.
Take the time, learn a little bit of
sideboarding and it'll go a long way in
improving your game.
>> I feel like when you will make your own
decision without anyone influencing you
like you know without reading sideboard
guides and so on. But if you play a game
and you see context of a game and then
you go to sideboard and you say, "Ah,
this action actually will influence my
decision on what to sideboard and this
other thing that happened in this game
is also influencing my decision on what
to sideboard."
>> You leveled up.
>> That is one of those moments when you
click with the game and you start making
conscious decisions that are just not
pre-planned decisions when when you just
start the game.
>> And it's at least understanding the why,
right? of if you are reading something
whether it's an article or a guide or
anything like that of somebody else's
decision making on sideboards if you can
dig into the why why is this coming in
because that's going to help you in the
game when you're like ah that's why I'm
bringing this card in and now I see it
post sideboard um our players did just
have
yeah which as you said the sleeves are
quite similar so uh you loth you were on
a crusade for sleeves today you've
already forced the player to swap one on
broadcast
>> when we're watching ing in the green
room. Um, I was able to like do a
premonition on on several plays that
were like that were like ahead of time
happening, you know. So maybe on to
something here, you know.
>> Can you tell me uh
>> next lot numbers?
>> Yeah, that's what I was going to say.
Uh,
>> dude, if I could, I would never tell
anyone and you would never know.
>> Just I'm going to every time I start a
game, I'm going to be like, Loa, what is
my opening hand? Like what what's what's
the first five cards after that, please?
>> I will tell you though, one thing. I am
cursing myself often. I'm like, "Oh, is
this going to be another game where I
don't draw two drop?" And of course, I
don't.
>> Of course you don't.
>> I have to stop saying stuff like this,
you know. It's just like, or stop even
thinking about it.
>> Just draw the right cards, okay? That's
how you get good at a game. Just Just
draw the right cards.
>> So easy. Thank you. Thank you, J.
>> It's good. Uh, that's my level of
advice. You can buy my guide. Uh,
it's free. Um, but we are in a very high
stakes game because up until this point,
players have not necessarily been
eliminated when losing a series.
>> Are you going to touch on the topic on
the metal foil count?
>> We can indeed touch on that
>> because in a support where he's actually
actively fighting for it because we have
two masteries in the top eight.
>> That is very true. So, it is influential
in that you want to to be advancing. Um,
but I was also just going to say that
this is it. It is now down to one game
between these two players. One of these
players will advance to the semi-finals.
The other will be eliminated with a head
held high, but uh definitely with a
sight on future top eight top
appearances. Top eight in a almost 2,000
people tournament. That is an insane
achievement. Like in general, career
history in TCGs is measured by the
ability not to win tournaments, but to
be consistently in top eight. That is
that is the measurement. You know,
>> it really is because so much has to go
right, including your decisions, but so
much has to go right on the day to make
a top eight at a a premier tournament
>> like an
perfect opener for the true firing war
camp. That is the thing that you want to
have.
>> Yes. And as the reason it's perfect is
because the eye of the herald is going
to allow them to create a recruit as you
move over to Trafarian War camp
>> and that creates a five might hold by by
default.
>> We I believe have another quick judge
call so you're coming back to seeing us
just in case you haven't had enough of
us already today.
>> If you watching the entire broadcast you
probably seen hours of our faces
already. Sorry for that. Deepest
condolences.
Ah I yeah I mean I I would say thank you
to those of you that have been joining
us uh throughout the weekend and uh you
know get involved on social media # RQ
Leal as we
>> don't confuse with Lilia that's
unleashed.
>> Yeah, that's set three. Uh and I put
this up for set three. That's how long
of a day it's me.
>> So good that we're not depending on math
in this game. You know it's
>> that's why we put the mic counter at the
bottom so I don't have to do it. Uh that
is why it is here. So, uh, the might
counter can now be counting up all of
the Trafarian War camp, uh, information
as we continue through this. Desert's
call comes through, creates another sand
soldier, and
Pedro will play one to the war cam.
That is such a huge hold on Trafaran War
camp. It's eight might already on it.
It's turn two. As you can see, this is
like why this battlefield is so
one-sided I would feel like in this
particular um matchup. And then we could
have said that as well in the game one
about the hall of legends. So,
>> this is like really one of those like
matchups where the battlefields are
mattering so much and it's going to be I
don't know, man. How do you break that
as? You have to like multiple punch
first, but then a face breaker breaks
your face. Yeah, there there's so much
that can can kind of stop that punch
first from really having the the impact
that that you're expecting it to.
>> Kind face breaker in this way kind of
like a fight or flight. Hey, actually I
made the comparison of fight or flights
to stunts and I said on the broadcast.
So yeah, it's literally this kind of
interaction.
>> We're actually just a vehicle to plug
your content. Uh
>> no, I was here on the on the broadcast.
Okay. Yeah, I was talking about on the
broadcast that even though you know
fight or flight is banned, we still have
a kind of a supplement of fight or
flight in form of stunts, but they're
not as common in this meta game, right?
So, in this case, when you're holding
the war camp and you have a phase
breaker, your one attacking unit just
goes to base like it just got fight
orflighted.
>> Yeah. Oh, what this is eye of the Herald
moves over another recruit just stack
the one battlefield and
>> we are ahead of points. We are ahead of
points. We can stack this battlefield to
a point where Mastery is not able to do
anything about that hold and we're going
to finish the game with an Azir
submarine which by the way is now in the
correct place so it's not confusing. I
think that might have been the break
>> and that is the
>> Oh, but we just placing it but we tapped
out. Wait, are we actually finishing the
turn without having an insurance against
a charm?
That that was the thing that happened on
game two and I feel like it it is a win
condition in this particular plan. I was
at least envisioning it this way for
Pedro because if you're ahead yeah if
you have a lead in points and you build
up all those tokens then you just move
all those tokens with the Azir submarine
and that's how you finish the game.
>> I guess the other point to that is if
you're ahead on point tempo it's a slow
game of just holding one point to win
but you know you're not going to get
broken uh or potentially not going to
get broken on the war camp. Um, you're
right though, you want to accelerate
that game plan as fast as possible and
and get over to the line, get over the
line as quickly as you can. Uh, no charm
in hand right now. It's a punch first,
two disciplines, and a lonely power, I
believe. In fact,
>> this is not looking,
>> man. Oh, man. This is not looking a
clockwork keeper.
>> Yeah, we're digging for answers. Seeing
this,
>> paying for the clockwork keeper. That's
an action. There's not even that much
equipment. All you're doing is stopping
the eye of the herald from making it
worse and worse.
>> And look how difficult this position is.
Like you cannot move the uh Stellacon
her because of your fire move flare.
>> Oh yeah. You don't want to be
>> You cannot just go in and go back. So
you're stuck in this position. You have
the best card draw engine, but it's like
stuck between a rock and a hard place.
>> Yeah. And we came out of game one
thinking, "Oh, War Camp looks good for
Azir." And then even better on
>> combined with the vile masar insane vile
moors on the other and getting eye of
the herald turn one into recruit put it
to into sand soldier put it to the
battlefield for trafarium war camp
>> and how do you break this
>> there's no way there's like it's so hard
>> at least when we look at domain profiles
not in green orange like a down well is
like the only thing from purple that
will really deal with this
>> correct and now but you can see that
varic is actually trying to make this
work because he's building up his base.
So, he has multiple units. Those
multiple units to some degree will
nullify the effect of the terran war
camp. But Pedro knows what is happening.
He is stacking that battlefield. He's
putting more units. He currently has
three, six, seven units over there,
right? So, he's going to be able to just
make it more clunky for for his opponent
to even calculate how to attack this
because of the one hidden card. And
Bick's one opening is going to be one
push.
>> That's it. That's all you get because
you're going to have to play the punch
first. You're going to have to play the
disciplines. You're going to have to
also divide them because if you put it
on one unit, you get face broken or
hidden bladed. And if you don't have the
buy, it's it's gone.
>> Yeah. and and it's likely to go wherever
the punch first is going. Uh that that
spell to remove as much and of course
then BK we got to look at the the
economy the resources that are
available. Uh one orange rune right now
of course likely to draw into it. They
are six and six on their rune profile.
So guaranteed one off the top at least.
>> Oh is that an attack? Okay
>> it is. We we do have a guardian angel um
attached to the Azir so of rain and
we're attacking for nine might to five
to seven currently
>> discipline is this just so it's five up
to seven is this just for a draw hoping
for an ong guard
>> charm
>> cannot be used midfight of course
>> so 9 to seven that's it we're breaking
the guardian angel we're breaking the
units
We're breaking the guardian angel and
the one
>> one recruit. So that is one way of
getting back from finer since it is not
a move. A recall will just send to base.
>> The thing is like if you would have left
the um the Azir So he's going to stuck
there,
>> right? But then you still have the
problem of fire and war camp just like
how do you go through that? This is
looking really grim for Bick and let's
see what he's going to be able to figure
it out because now a second second
hidden card is establishing control over
a vile musler and those hidden cards can
be a god can be an face breaker can be a
um hidden blade and I think that's all.
Am I missing
>> is even as you said is even difficult to
to play around now cuz it puts more
might onto the battlefield
>> and it has a weapon master.
>> Yeah.
to transfer one of the equipment.
>> Exactly. And okay, lonely power just
looking for card draw at this point.
>> We have guards here.
>> It's kind of interesting because
>> okay, so is going to commit into this
with a discipline.
>> So we have four to four in this
>> and that's the discipline is in response
to guards, right? So the the we now have
the chain with guards as the first
correct spell being cast. discipline in
response once the draw before the
resolution of guards.
>> Mhm. It would be giving you a chance to
defy, for example, to not be able to
weapon master as you can see.
>> And in this case, it's a five versus
four. And Bar is like not really happy
about this.
It looks like a Clockwork Keeper, I
think, came uh either at the beginning
of the turn or or later. Looks like a
lonely parro as well. Not the cards you
want in hand to be able to to to break
that giant battlefield. Not that there
are too many that even will, but Lonely
Parro of course
>> on the death nail will get another, but
will trade with something. I don't think
we're quite at
>> uh the damage and combat resolution step
yet. I believe Squirtle may very well be
thinking about any actions to take.
>> Well, and they can. There's no time
limit in the exact
>> thinking about every small detail over
here is going to be important.
And also remember that the uh unit with
the shield has tank. So has to be
assigned damage first, I think. Yeah,
just deciding whether there was anything
before that resolution of combat damage
to go through now. Uh it's a p a second
punch first. Can't play both in one
turn.
>> Mhm. Mhm.
Now let's see what is even the plan.
Look, we still have a true firing war
camp which is basically not under
pressure for the entire game. So now
we're talking with two. All that plan
that BK had to build up his base to
attack into the firing warup at some
point is currently destroyed by this
commitment over here.
>> Can you kind of death by a thousand cuts
with the charms to the other
battlefield? Or is this eye of the
Herald doing too much? Because every
time it gets reset onto another unit and
cascades, it's oh, we'll just refill it
at Tarian War camp. So every time you
use a spell and resources, it's just
getting refreshed.
Oh, what a tough spot to be in.
>> And now we have a death grip as well.
And Bak is thinking about using
something in response. There's actually
nothing in response that can be used to
my knowledge there in the hand. Might be
a bluff, you know.
>> Yeah,
for some reason I was looking at that
charm as if it was a defy and it is not.
But one thing I can say is that Vick is
really drawing in pairs or in triples.
Triplets.
>> Yeah. Uh full houses is triple porro.
Triple.
>> Now we have.
>> So how many two drops did he drew?
>> Quite a lot. A frustrating amount of
lonely parros.
>> And we have clockwork keepers over here
as well. Then double charm, double punch
first,
>> double discipline.
>> And it it's not the side of the deck
necessarily that the BK would be looking
for uh here. I do think this is a really
tough spot anyway to be in, but the rest
of the deck is is not exactly uh
proficient at dealing with one wide but
like also tall battlefield uh of
>> Trafarian War Camp. And again, this goes
to Battlefield selection of just how
important we've seen a couple of games
today of how important Battlefield
selection ends up being.
This is a crazy match. Like I I'll be
honest with you, on paper, I didn't
think that uh this matchup might be that
one-sided, but holy.
>> So, can't react to the death grip, of
course, cuz punch first is an action.
So, death grip will have to resolve
first and then punch first will speed.
>> Yeah. Little little bit of a a shortcut/
sequencing error, but I think both
players understand the the the way that
that will go.
So now we're actually going 10 into a
five.
>> And this is a huge commitment because
you're just trying to break the VMOS
slayer when we're still behind on
points. So we're we got the card draw
from from the Stellacon her. But the
Stellon Herder is still going to be
under pressure because now we just have
a five might unit in Vimos while the
opponent literally has a five M unit if
it's equipped with the shield in base as
well.
>> Clockwork keeper in base. Is there any
reason to do sabotage may change the
decision-m in the sense of it'll give
information and then you can look at
potentially using the two charms
>> but is this the turn to do it? Is this
where it's a safer spot to break the
Azir? Cuz you know your punch first has
gone through on the stoner. No, the
answer is going to be lonely power
developed.
>> And now look this is maximum of plus two
might on that uh on the teleon herder.
What Azir can do is attach the shield to
one of the recruits or sand soldiers on
the Trafana War camp and then transfer
that token to the Azir sovereign to
attack the battlefield on the VMA's
layer and essentially never lose the
Azir sovereign because the tank is going
to get the damage first.
>> Yeah, and a brutalizer comes in as well
gets equipped onto Azir Sora weak in
hand as well. This this board state not
necessarily the best for it but always
going to be a good option to just reduce
down the units that are available for
Barek. It's a Stellicorn Herder.
>> It's a 725.
>> Yeah, it looked like the thought process
was is dying, but no, of course, the
brutalizer being attached this turn
means it has the additional plus two.
>> And that's Pedro at win condition.
>> Six points. He is reaching lethal for at
the start of the next turn. And Bart is
going to have to find a quick solution
to at least one of those problems. But
this is just delaying the inevitable.
>> Pays one,
floats one in order to uh equip
>> either herald to a recruit.
>> No, to a sand soldier.
>> Brings it back to base.
>> Setting up just units for the next turn.
May call the week off the new recruit.
We see that a lot in Victor. um doesn't
have to, but it's again another option
available
should you want to uh to to thin the
thin the base, thin the units, keep BK
on the back foot, and it feels like
Squirtle is going to be uh
in a good position going into
potentially Barek's last turn of the
tournament. How good can it be? How good
can the top deck be? Two charms, a punch
first,
>> an action. and Ashan a little late. If
it could have cut into the eye of the
Heralds potentially earlier, maybe there
was something to do about it, but it
does feel like things are winding up in
favor of Azia, in favor of Pedro.
Sabotage thought about for a moment
there
>> at this stage is like not important what
is in the hand of the opponent. But is
it just to see just to see within the
game the inevitability as you're saying
it is the board state and there aren't
too too many options left from this
situation. Sabotage comes out. Is the
game done? Is that it? We know at home
it is likely to be the case from what is
in at least Barek's hand. Pedro deciding
whether he wants to even give that
information.
>> But it feels all but done. Ong guard
used so that it can't be taken out of
the hand. Koi gets taken out of Pedro's
hand. No cards in hand. Pedro is
hellbent, but looks focused on
potentially getting through to the
semifinals. Can Bar turn this around?
Potentially. There's a nine might attack
going into Viamo's lair. But it it does
it does sound like a last ditch effort.
Now, let's see what is what is going to
be the play for Bick.
>> And it won't be Nine Might. stays on the
battlefield though because it is
obviously throwing everything
>> into this attack.
>> Throwing everything at that Azir. That's
why the uh the pump spell was used first
in order to make sure that you're
trading against the units.
So is it punch first on the lonely parro
potentially when when you go in for
this? It's going to be a charm
>> charm tofaring ward.
>> Yes, cuz can't charm to base.
>> But yes, that's true. from Vile Wars.
>> That's true. But also it it would
actually make sense to move him to the
trifire war camp as well because then he
cannot move from base to the other
battlefield and take the units with him.
>> That is very true. That is very true. It
is on the attack trigger for the Azia.
So looking to slow down for one more
turn.
And this is why we always say play to
your outs. Play to what is the one thing
that can keep you from losing the game?
Well, it's stopping vile moors being
held at the beginning.
>> So, we're moving the Azir so rain.
Vama's lair is now open.
>> Vek
>> is going to blow a kiss, charm the
audience, and Petra will charming
>> accepting defeat in the most charismatic
of ways.
>> Ah, that was great. That was fantastic.
Love it. Loved it. Congrats to Pedro on
advancing to the top four.
>> Big congratulations going through to the
semi-finals for Pedro as part accepts
his defeat. I think it may all have been
done from the sabotage seeing Yeah.
Okay. You'll I realize you only have two
cards in hand. Blow kiss to the audience
and Barek. Um we'll talk about Pedro in
a second. will obviously have more on
their journey through the top four. Now,
uh let's focus on Barek playing a deck
that that some people were expecting to
do well coming into the event on the
Master E. Top eight performance uh
getting one game away from the top four
as well. Fantastic performance for a
player that is sure to make their name
for themselves and be remembered for
that uh kiss to the camera.
>> For sure. And he's a seasoned veteran of
TCGs already.
>> Yes, exactly. Hopefully, we're going to
be seeing him now more often in rift
bound as well. I I feel like he has to
be motivated after this performance in
this tournament. So, really awesome to
see another as well Polish player this
my little bias is coming out of here,
right? But I'm I'm really happy to see
the Polish community perform so
consistently at regionals so far. So, um
that that is music to my ears and also
it's awesome to see how many different
legends are coming into the top eight
regionals and as you said with a deck
that many not expected to be performing
but at the same time I think it was a
deck that could have been um you know
under the radar a little bit when it
comes to the mid tree.
>> This was a really interesting series
looking at two decks that on paper have
similar cards but play in in very
different play styles. You know, we're
talking about how it's sand soldiers are
a lot of the focus of the game and
whether you're holding or whether you
are on the aggressive front.
>> Oh, that sounds like a big audience. I
hope you can hear that on stream. That
that makes me happy for the rest of the
day. Um, yes, the difference between
being on the aggressive front or being
on the defensive. And that is the key.
We talked about it coming into game one.
Having a side selection, having the
choice of whether you're going first or
second,
>> really key coming out of Swiss as the
top ranked player, as the person that
will be choosing it throughout the
entire event. Pedro is in a great
position to make sure that that Azia has
those good turn one plays, is able to
keep the pressure on. And we'll see how
that kind of matches up against the
other decks that we're likely to see in
the top four. Yeah, it's actually very
impactful if you're able to choose if
you're going first or second because of
the Swiss positions and also it affects
the the battlefields. Like it really it
really changes the entire dynamic
because when you're building your deck,
you're just going like neutral
battlefield game one. Then if I lose,
I'm going first. I'm choosing a specific
battlefield when I'm going first and
then specific Battlefield where I'm
going second. this dynamic can be
completely shifted and will change the
way that you're perceiving matchups as
well, which is very important.
>> Yeah, very very important. Um, and you
know, as said, we'll uh we'll see more
from Pedro through the semi-final
rounds. Uh, we will shortly get you an
update at some point on the other
matches in the top eight. For now
though, we are ready to hear from Amy
with one of our players.
Welcome back everybody. My name's Amy.
I'm here with Pedro who was the winner
of our feature match with Azia. How are
we feeling going further into the
tournament?
>> I'm feeling good. I'm going first first
seat. So being on the play with Azir
helps a lot.
>> Absolutely.
>> So I'm confident.
>> Yeah, that's what we like to see. Were
you confident coming into the event with
Azir? Did you think you were going to be
in this seat right now? I mean I I yes I
was confident with that here but I
didn't thought I would be here. So it's
a nice surprise.
>> Honestly that is the best thing that we
could possibly hear. Uh what was your
consideration? Why did you bring Azir to
this event today? Well, I used to play
Asir and one of the worst matchups was
Mirale and and Draven in range and with
fight orflight gone, I could fight
Draven, which was a nogo. And my other
option was was Rexai. I found some
problems late in the testing, so I moved
to what I knew that was a
>> Oh, amazing.
>> So, here I am.
>> Were there any matchups that you were
like, I really don't want to see that
throughout the event?
>> Not really. I mean, Draven is still bad,
but not as unwininnable as it was
before. So, I it's okay if I see a
Draven.
>> That's amazing. Thank you so much. Have
you got any shout outs to anyone who
helped you get here?
>> H yes, I want to thank first of all my
my team
>> that we have been come together. They
are cheering for me there.
>> And then to my family and my girlfriend
Gabby that I know they are looking to
they don't know the game, but they are
supporting me. That's the best when
everyone supports you regardless. Even
if they don't get it, they can pretend.
>> Thank you so much for joining us. We're
going to let you get a rest before your
next game because you've got a lot to
play for, my friends. So, we're going to
head back to the studio. We'll catch up
with Pedro later.
>> Always good to hear from our winners
from Pedro. And yeah, I shout out
Challenger earlier. Shout out to my
games as well. I see you on Twitter. I
see you uh posting and getting the
teams. We need more teams in Riftband.
I'm I'm looking forward to seeing more
teams.
>> You seem to be adamant about that.
>> I mean, we both come from team
backgrounds in League of Legends. I
worked at Mad Lions and Spice. You
worked at G2 and, you know, many other
teams across your your time in esports.
So, it's natural for me to say, "Hey,
practicing is great together. Practicing
getting that uh you know, we call it
scrims in uh in esports, but
>> I feel I feel like players also call it
scrims."
>> Cool. We can call it scrims. We can do
that. Uh and you know what else we can
do? we can show you a highlight of our
second feature match from the round of
eight. I believe this is the
prismaticism
match up that we were going to look at
originally with the Annie. So, we are
going to fly through this very quickly
just looking at top moments from the
game. Prismaticism here at six points
already
>> uh in order to try and take the
battlefield. I haven't done this one
before, but we are going to just show
>> Oh my god, it's going to be so hard to
actually establish what's happening,
especially against Urelia. Like, what
the hell?
>> Yeah, prismaticism at this point up to
seven points. Alex Chan uh looking to
break that game point here in the first
game of the series.
A cleave goes up to three on the
assault. Negates the minus two from the
dance. This is where the feature with
the might actually comes in very handy.
>> It really does. We get to see everything
and there's some real playbyplay to
happen. Rebuke comes back onto the
4Runner in order to try and hold this
seat of power.
>> Three energy being used for what?
>> Ah, there's the Rengar. Ky goes in plus
five 10 to 10
>> plus another one is another cleave comes
out and that is game one going over to
Prismaticism. So a key end to the game
from that as Alex Chans now looking in
game two to turn things back around. But
Prismaticism had quite a quick start on
this. Getting to two points obviously
with the early drops. Six points a
piece. We we jump to with a big old
board for Prismaticism. A lot of units.
>> They spawned like it's a minion wave.
>> I know it's nothing. And then we jump
forward to an entire board state. And um
from here we know Aurelia obviously has
a lot of presence. There is a Vex active
here. So important to note the spells
from Annie during those showdowns will
of course be more uh costly. But the
>> Why is it a showdown? Because it was a
right to win or what happened here?
>> Uh not on the Vex, but yeah, it's I was
just mentioning that there is a Vex
hidden under the Aurelia, so we would
have to keep an eye on
>> Oh, wait. It's zoned warren showdown.
No, sorry. Exactly. No, no, that's uh
that was me confusing things with the
Vex. So this was a a key moment in the
game
in order
to hold through.
>> So two to five in the might department.
Then we're going to see prismat again
probably with the cleave. Yeah, we're
going five to five.
>> Remember it's the bos is six to six
points. So this is like already
establishing potential lethals.
>> Going to win the best of cleave
cards for this event. Is that three Rex
size in the trash forism?
So, this has been quite a a long slog of
a game.
>> Although the the timer says 25 minutes,
so
>> I'm guessing you're not that bad. Uh
this has just been a very fastpaced
game.
>> I mean, it is an Annie that is designed
to be like a pretty aggressive deck.
>> Trying to look for as much information
on the the board state as possible.
Aelia has a million cards in hand as
always and a lot of runes up. So we uh
jump through a lot of units now stacked
onto that Zorn Warren. Aelia trying to
break it now. Vex is in the showdown. So
16 might at 20. So Alexr only has to
overcome just a little bit more of the
might. But what does Annie have in hand?
Now remember this hidden card will be
costing you one energy or one power as
well because back is going to be in
combat.
>> And a rebuke which is a hand from Alex
trans is going to cost less. A
discipline only for one is already
disgusting.
>> That already feels great. Draw a card,
get plus two. In fact, plus three cuz
it's on the Aurelia. Um
>> we're going 20 to 19 over here.
>> Yeah. And there's the rebuke and a not
so far not so fast for any interaction.
There is the rebuke
>> for one energy and one power. Another
disgusting card.
>> Turns out this card's even better when
it gets shortcut into uh so only one
card in hand by the looks of things for
prismaticism. Will be forced to pay for
a switcheroo. That is a huge thing. But
we know there's a not so fast in hand.
And you do have to target. So if you pay
the deflect and then end up getting not
so fasted for one and one, that is
brutal. And he's saving the purple while
re uh while paying for the deflect with
the red which kind of might signal a
rebuke as well.
>> Another Yeah, exactly. A rebuke coming.
>> Although with really even
>> hard bargain for three is the other
thing means that Alex TR cannot pay for
the not so fast.
>> So that is going to end up turning the
damage back around.
We had to pay also a power and the
energy as well for um because of Vex.
>> Yeah. Which I believe was paid with the
the extra floating and then one
recycled. So the Aurelia all of that
might is going to go over to it looks
like the target was uh I think it might
be a merchant on the bottom
>> or a treasure whichever is a two drop
that's underneath.
>> 26 to9 that flipped really quickly.
That is a big swing of might and a key
moment in this game because if this goes
through, Prismaticism would be taking
control. That is going to be the one
cost rebuke to get rid of all of the
might that got transferred over. The
math needs to be done still. And that is
a hand as Prismaticism goes from top
eight to top four on the Annie and
advances to the semi-finals.
>> That was the quickest game of rift bound
I have ever seen.
>> Yeah, that was lightning fast. But we
wanted to make sure we brought you the
action from two future matches and
action.
>> You got just the action.
>> That is the one time when you can do
playbyplay as you said.
>> Yeah. I which to be fair requires quite
a lot of uh scanning and knowledge on on
the board state. I'm like immediately
recognize the information on the game.
But you know who can give some
information to us? Uh Barcode can give
us something to talk about.
special one because we've seen him
before. Flash here again and now with a
male card. I mean, you told us how much
you love Teemo and it turns out that uh
it was pretty good for you.
>> How are you doing?
>> Well, it was very hard to be I was quite
lucky a few times. Like I have to admit
it. I was quite lucky, but I'm very very
happy. I played well my games played
very very very well some some of them.
And as I said, I couldn't get to day two
and it seems like it has still been
enough. So I'm very happy about it.
>> But there is still a victory because of
course having this best of male for Timo
is very very cool. So what are you going
to do with the legend? Are you still
going to play it?
>> That's that's a very good question. Like
I I'm I'm thinking about it for a while
now. Like do I want to stick with Temo
because I have a lot of fun with it or
do I want to play something a bit
better? Uh I don't know. I'm I'm a big
fan of Katarina in League of Legends.
And she's coming red. So that's not my
colors. So I don't know. I'm in a in a
big in a big dilemma at the moment. I
still need to think about it because
I've seen that a lot of times. You were
like, "Do I still play Teemo? Do I want
to play something which is more meta or
anything?" But still, you always play
this legend because it looks like it
brings you a lot of joy. So maybe you
should just stick to it basically.
>> Maybe. Maybe that's maybe that's what
that's the conclusion I'm going to take
at the end. Yeah.
>> Yeah, indeed. But in general, what does
it mean to you to have this metal card
because you are literally the best
player in the room? Do you even realize
it?
>> I don't think I can realize it right
now. Like as I as I said, I feel I feel
I feel very lucky like from some of my
game like they they were so close and it
just came out so well for me. like it's
yeah I'm I'm very very happy for the
moment and uh and I think I'll need to
like rest a bit to
>> rest a bit and just uh you know chill a
little bit more. So what's the next step
for you? Are you going to play another
tournament real soon?
>> Well, I want to do as many regionals as
I can but I think come in at the wrong
time for me so I might not be able to do
it. I still don't know, but uh I'll do
as many as I can for sure. Like this is
just so fun to be fair.
>> I totally agree with you. I think this
is the right mindset and maybe you will
get another medal card at the next
tournament. At least we wish that for
you. That being said, we are going to
get back some more content. Back to you
guys.
Welcome back everyone. RQ Leal top four.
I am Blevens joined by Amy and wow that
was a crazy top eight. Azir we saw win.
We just saw Prismat on Annie make it and
uh I'm not neither of those two were
either Draven or Aurelia.
>> No, no. In fact, um those those decks
are starting to become a little bit
thinner as we move into our top four
here at the regional qualifier in Le. I
could not be more excited to see which
decks are going to prevail and to get
into some exciting gameplay to boot very
very soon. Yeah, it is. It's been the
talk of the tournament since we started
what feels like only a few hours ago,
but it was actually a whole day ago at
this tournament with two almost 2,000
players. Yeah, this is this day.
>> Yeah, it's uh it is kind of crazy.
Almost 2,000 players in this event and
we are we have narrowed it down to four.
We see Prismat who has, by the way, top
aided three of the last four regional
qualifiers.
>> That's a lot.
>> That's a lot. Yeah,
>> that's a lot. When you think of the
amount of players between three regional
qualifiers added up together, that's how
many people they're better than.
>> Yeah.
>> Sorry, guys.
>> Sorry about it. Yeah, this is their
second medal card. believe they got the
best of Draven in Bolognia and they got
best of Annie
>> here today which is really great. So uh
you know kudos to them but we've also
seen this Azir deck Pedro play it at the
absolute pinnacle of what it can be
played as. I mean we saw it throughout
the Swiss here. We saw it in that last
round as well taking down Barek who
played that master gee very well but
Azir was able to take it down. I'm sad
to see a Master E get knocked out, but
I'm just pleased they were here for the
ride. And we do have another in top
eight. Uh we did have another in top
eight, I should say. And honestly, I'm
just so pleased that we were able to see
that diversity and how the deck runs now
cuz it hasn't
>> it hasn't kind of been in favor for a
long time. It seems to have just sprung
back at us all of a sudden. And I feel
like any deck can do that,
>> right? I feel like there's some secret
ye enjoyers that have been out there. I
interviewed uh Shawn earlier on who won
a feature match earlier on in the day
and they've been on Yi the whole time.
But yeah, for the most part I think the
general consensus has been oh yeah that
remember remember that Origin deck back
in the day
>> we ran Master Ye and there was uh there
were Porros that for some reason yeah
Kaisa there poros that for some reason
had five might and were two drops. Yeah,
those were the days. But no, we're
playing a different version. when we're
playing that the Stellicorn Herder makes
makes me shake in fear when I hear that
name. Just how many cards if you shake
too hard the cards fall out of your hand
and you don't care because there's so
many for the Stellicorn Herder.
>> It's interesting when we compare how
only two sets of Rift Pound have come
out so far, but we've had entirely
different feeling events all the way
from Origin all the way down to here in
Le right now. And those decks have come
a long way with some staying pretty
consistent in what they have been trying
to achieve and what they have achieved
like Kaiser who's always been somewhere
around the top whether people are
considering her to be best deck and
format or whether people are just
bringing her to tournaments and still
doing well. We still have seen Kaiser in
the tippity top almost this entire time
but then we've got some that have
fluctuated in and out. Draven, you know,
was incredibly strong at the beginning
of Spirit Forge. Now we've got, like
you've been saying, this kind of 2.5
meta where we have that extra chance to
go back and revise decks with this new
ban list. It's an interesting it's an
interesting paradigm,
>> right? For sure. I mean, we saw the
addition by subtraction. We are we
subtracted some cards with the ban list.
We are adding other decks that are
playable. But that doesn't mean that
Draven, just because Draven is not the
absolute S tier unbeatable deck,
>> doesn't mean that it's not still
>> good,
>> a perfectly fine deck to play. And it
also doesn't need to be that doesn't
need to be an absolute defined best
unbeatable deck. I think people have
that expectation from other games and
from other metas potentially. That's
just not been the case in this uh in
this meta. It's really not been the case
too much. I think maybe you can make
some arguments in some metas, but for
the most part, it's not been the case in
Riftbound. It's certainly not the case
here at this regional qualifier where we
are seeing a ton of diversity and a lot
of new decks coming up in this event.
>> Honestly, so pleased as well. It's one
of the reasons I really love Riftbound
and one of the reasons that I have, you
know, quite so avidly been a fan from
the beginning was because actually this
game has so much more to give. I feel
like I can play what I want. Mhm.
>> I'm not being stripped of my choices
>> because a card is bad. Like you can make
anything work if you try and even if
you're not going to win the tournament,
you can go for that best off as long as
you dedicate yourself to your chosen
champion and legend, then you know
you're you're going to come out on top
eventually,
>> right? So, what I'm hearing is I can
make Lucian Aurora work. That's that's
what I'm hearing.
>> No, I know. I said you can make Lucian
work.
>> Lucian Aurora can work. Confirmed here.
>> Is we heard it here first, folks. Lucian
Aurora has been confirmed. It's going to
work and has to work.
>> It's a chosen champion and legend
doesn't Aurora is not one of those
cards.
>> Okay. Well, I'm still going to try to
make it work at least one time. Maybe
I'm at least maybe going to make it
work. Try to some. Anyway, we don't need
to worry about that because there is no
Lucian in the top eight. Unfortunately,
no dazzling Aurora in the top eight
either. But there is an Annie, there is
an Azir, and there's two other decks
that we're not quite sure of yet here.
But we are uh diligently and patiently
waiting for the players to get ready as
we get into our top four. And
>> it'll be worth the wait.
>> Yeah,
>> we're almost there.
>> We're almost there. Let's just We can
just patiently wait for that to happen.
And but no, it is going to be coming
here soon. And uh I'm again we are
already seeing two decks in the top four
that we did not see either of in I'm
just going back in my mental catalog
here. Don't think we saw any in Bolognia
or in Vegas. No Azir for sure. Noir and
I don't believe that there was an Annie
in Vegas or Bolognia if I recall
correctly. So
>> it definitely wasn't in Bologna.
>> You're right.
>> But I'm not sure about Vegas because my
memory is poor. I know that the top four
of Vegas was Draven. So, at the very
least, there was definitely not one in
the top four. Neither of those are in
the top four of Vegas for sure. We're
seeing that here. The addition of new
decks by the subtraction of cards from
the ban list here. And it really is
interesting cuz Azir is a deck that I
think really really very focusedly and
overtly
benefits from the lack of fighter
flight. Being able to fight orflight a
sand soldier or any unit back when it
has three or four equipment on it is
worse than killing it in in almost every
scenario where you're just stranding it
back there. Now, a lot of the answers
are still fine. If that uh if that unit
dies, you're still able to use those
equipment, but Azir really good. Now, we
obviously have seen Annie. We're going
to be seeing more Annie and Azir here in
just a bit, but before that, let's toss
it over to Barcode.
Thank you guys. Yeah, indeed. I'm in
front of the crowd and I can tell you
something. The atmosphere is special.
There is something in the air. We are
close to the ending of this journey and
we will soon know who will get crowned.
This is something absolutely incredible.
Think about it. Such a tournament. Two
days of competition and it will all
revolves around those two last rounds.
Who will get the title? Who will get
crown? We shall know that very soon. But
for now, let's get some more content.
Thank you, barcode, though. I don't
know. I don't know where the content is
here. I'm just Oh, here we go. We've got
Amy here as well for the content. Yes,
we are absolutely just brimming with
anticipation for this top four because
like I said, you know, if you we're
coming from Vegas, if we're coming from
Bolognia, it was really it was Draven
time, which is not the case in this
event. And actually, we get a little bit
of a peak of what the bracket looks
like. So, let's take a look at what
we've got here. Here's our top eight and
our top four. We've got Pedro we saw on
Azir and Annie in the top. And there it
is. Your Master Y versus Draven on the
bottom.
>> Aurelia has been stripped of the
potential title of grand finalist.
You're hearing it here first. Aelia is
out for the count. Our top four decks
are Azir, Annie, Draven, and Master Ye.
Glad to see not only a variety of decks,
but entirely different builds, and we're
going different colors into different
colors on both sides of the bracket.
Will those ferocious purple red decks be
able to be taken down or are we going to
see that Annie Draven finals instead?
Now, I don't have an encyclopedic
knowledge of every Riftbound regional
event in the in English and in China.
>> Why not?
>> Because I'm old and my brain doesn't
work as good as it used to.
>> However, I do think this may be the
first time that we've ever had four
different decks in the top four.
>> You know what?
>> I don't specifically remember it ever
happening before this.
>> I mean, it's definitely the case for
Europe. Yes,
>> we can say that.
>> We can definitely say that.
>> We can say that. We're going to stick
with it. That's going to be our final
answer.
>> I think it may actually be the first
time that this has ever happened at an
event of this level. But regardless, we
are here. We can see the players sitting
down getting ready to play. Pedro on the
left with Azir. Prismaticism
on the right with the Annie.
Here we are looking at that Azir deck
list one more time. We've seen them
before, but we're seeing it again. It
was a fantastic list that we've seen
work to perfection. It's all about
timing. It's all about those gear, and
it's all about managing resources, not
units.
>> Now, I think we've certainly had enough
time for production to make that sand
counter at this point, right?
>> Yeah. Come on, guys.
>> I know it's not a real thing. Anyway,
we've got Brismat's Annie deck here. We
see the Rex Eye. We see the Rengar. I
mean, cards that we haven't necessarily,
we certainly have not seen in the
limelight, but they work so well with
Annie being such a hyper aggressive
deck. And Rengar working particularly
good with Annie because you can
effectively play it for one energy and
one power if you're able to use that
extra energy on your turn and ready
those runes with Annie. So, very, very
strong deck. looks reminiscent of course
of the mid-range Draven but with a lot
of additional and different tools that
people are just not ready for because
it's Annie
>> bringing the unexpected can be such a
powerful utilization in this game and
we're absolutely seeing that right now.
>> Absolutely. I mean it is running so many
chew drops. It's running the Noxis
hopefuls. It's of course got stack deck
rebukes. I mean, it has all of that
interaction that you would expect to see
in a Chaos Fury deck, but it also has,
you know, I think the number of times
that I saw in scrims and in testing
Prismat play that Rengar and people
like, "Oh, yeah, that's right. There's
just a there's just a plus five that can
come out of nowhere. I forgot about
that. I know that now." I have to
imagave
many wins that people just weren't
expecting because I can play around a
plus three and a plus two or I'm not
playing around
with that also has a body there. It's
just such a good card. Also, don't
bother rebuking the Rengar cuz it will
come right back down.
>> Rengar pouncing is quite right.
>> Absolutely.
>> The name is very apt. When you are
unprepared, it will pounce. And
unfortunately, that clearly has happened
a lot in this event. And we saw it
earlier today and I'm sure we might get
a chance to see it again.
>> Yeah. I mean, we even saw it in the
little clips. We saw it in the little
clips right before this the the the
clips of Prismat's game where
>> setting up these combats where they have
a lot of energy up and usually that's
that's a reelious game plan to have a
lot of energy up and have these combat
decks and and he's like, "No, I've got a
bunch as well. I've got Longard. I've
got I've got Hard Bargain. I've got
Rengar. got all of these cards that are
just so so good and are able to be
played in combat in a in a deck that's
not usually doing a lot of combat
manipulation like that. Not anymore. It
used to have fighter flights. It's it
does have rebuke, but that it's not the
same, right? You're not expecting that
angle of attack like Rengar and like
Cleave can because that kind of fell out
of favor a lot.
>> Yeah. And I think that's the thing.
these these unforgotten cards gone by
that actually are still really powerful.
And you know, in this instance,
this Annie Aggro deck isn't going to
have the surprise element as much
>> as we've known before because obviously
um Patriot is going to know what's in
this deck this time round. So actually
they do have that opportunity to look at
the deck lists. So they are going to
know what could come up. But it's all
well and good seeing something written
on a page. But do you remember what it
does? Because I don't know about you
guys, but I have a poor memory. And I do
not remember the differences between the
different Rengar cards. Like I wouldn't
know off the top of my head if I was
reading it just on a piece of paper.
Because it had been that long before
this event before I was like, "Oh my
gosh, look at this Annie list. Wowza."
>> I didn't remember what it did. I'm going
to be honest.
>> Yeah. Well, no. And it it really hasn't
seen a lot of play. Even though spear
forge card has not seen a ton of play. I
think a lot of people have looked at it
and considered it and it is a really
cool card. We did see it played a little
bit in China, but honestly not much
outside of that and there's just it's
not necessarily hitting the break points
or is efficient enough to be played in a
lot of decks. But Annie, it makes so
much sense. You can spend your energy on
your turn. As long as you have one left
up, you'll ready two runes and that's
three. Rengar's a reaction. you can play
it on your opponent's turn and you're
effectively gaining that extra two
energy and you can actually put it into
stats that impact the board that is
really really strong
>> as if Annie didn't need another excuse
to be more aggressive with their play
style. And here we are giving them
another good reason to be. And I'm
honestly pleasantly surprised by this
deck list. But I'm also
>> uh I'm also surprised. I'm surprised I
haven't seen this before. I'm surprised
this took me by surprise and I'm happy
about it. I got to say I'm really
excited to see how this matchup plays
out because I haven't seen this Annie
before now,
>> I haven't seen how it might interact
with Sea.
>> Is it aggressive enough to deal with
that many units? Because although we
have lots of aggression, we have lots of
ways to defeat,
>> we're equally going up against a
potentially lots of sand soldiers which
have adaptable stance,
>> right? Yeah. And certainly this is a
matchup that
I if I didn't know Prismat personally
and didn't know just how extensive their
testing can be, I would say probably
both of these players have not played
against this their respective matchups
very much. However, I do know Chris Matt
and I do know how extensive their
testing is. I would almost guarantee
that they have reps into Azir. Now, was
it a player of Pedro's caliber playing
Azir? Was it their build? I mean, almost
impossible to say.
>> So, they do get the list. Like you said,
it's one thing seeing it on a piece of
paper. It's another thing seeing it in
the hands of a top four level
competitor. So, I mean, at the end of
the day, it's going to come down to
their fundamentals. It's going to come
down to what preparation they've had.
Obviously, both of these players have
played absolutely spectacularly so far.
They've both got best of metal cards
that they can take home regardless, but
they want to win. I know Prismat, I've
prismat for a long time across many
games. Prismat does not care about
consolation prizes. Prismat was bummed
when they were handed the best of
Draven. I know this for a fact. We were
talking about it backstage. They were
bummed when they were handed the best of
Draven because they had just lost in the
top eightst means everything to both of
these players as we are getting into our
top four. Prismaticism on the Annie
Pedro on the Azir.
>> They're just having a last little look
at those lists. It's an important time
for both of them from trying to remember
what counts are in each other's decks so
that they can play around them. And this
is another skill in and of itself that
we don't get a lot of time to practice
quite often.
>> Yeah, absolutely. It it is uh you don't
really have to prep open deck list a lot
because unless you're toping in RQ or
above, you're probably not playing open
deck list. However, it is a very
important thing to do when you are at
that point. But we're jumping on into
game number one. Hall of Legends on the
side of Pedro. The seat of power over
for Annie. Now, we saw seat of power
actually on the side of both players.
So, this is one that is certainly going
to benefit Pedro as well.
>> Let's see if we get set up in the way
that we want. Going for those mulligans.
Incredibly important to Mulligan. If you
don't have the ideal start, we can
mulligan up to two cards. And yep. Well,
Azir doing what Azir does best. We've
made a gear and a sand soldier on your
first turn. I say that's pretty good.
>> Yeah, that's the way you want to do it
for sure. Get those sand soldiers ready
to roll. And of course, being able to
get that initial tempo going, get that
might on the board, get those
battlefields conquered. where especially
with the seed of power cuz if you're
able to start conquering faster you're
going to be able to draw those extra
cards. This is a you know this has
certainly been a reveal party for seed
of power. I think I don't know if I saw
the card played very much at all before
this event but with the opening up of
Battlefields we've seen such a diversity
>> and honestly I'm all for it. I don't
know about you, but I'm so pleased that
we've been able to see diversity in the
battlefields that everyone's choosing.
And obviously, there there are a lot
more out there than I think a lot of
people give them credit for. There's a
lot that kind of they have this
reputation for being good and or bad,
but actually I think that a lot more
have uh kind of potential, more
potential than we think.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And there's certainly
ones that I think we're still as a
community really figuring out the really
the formula for how to utilize
Battlefields best. There's a lot that
are that are definitely more playable
than we think. But it's also, you know,
how are we actually choosing to use
these battlefields? Do we have one that
we always lead on? Do we have one that
we use when we go first? Do we have one
that we use when we go second? That was
sort of my basic playbook for how I
started to understand choosing
battlefields. But I think that there it
even goes matchup to matchup like it's
this is my lead against this deck. This
is my going first if XYZ has happened.
So I think there is a lot there's a
absolutely massive amount that can go
into Battlefield choice and uh really
we're just beginning to scratch the
surface of it.
>> Absolutely. You're absolutely correct.
That is the the be all and end all
really is that battlefields are strong,
but are they going to benefit our
opponent too much? In this instance,
both battlefields are good for both
players. So, I'd say that's pretty even.
Our stack deck choice has been made and
we've been able to once again cherrypick
a Noxus hopeful and we get that nice
legion effect. So, it only costs two.
>> Yeah, one of the uh really one of the
best starts that you can have as Annie
that stack deck as a one cost card. Of
course, that Nox Hopeful being the most
amount of might that you can get for two
energy for the most part, at least out
of a single card right now. So, you
really want to have that to be able to
contest what Azir is going to be doing
here.
>> We got another gear. We got another sand
soldier. Azir doing what Azir does best.
And now we're going to be looking at
whether it's worthwhile dipping our toe
into the Hall of Legends, which it is.
You can actually uh when you conquer
there, you can pay one to ready the
legend and then you can jump back out if
you want to be safe. Um which is I
really like that effect for uh for Pedro
here. So it feels pretty strong.
>> Yeah, if you're able to actually uh have
the energy for it, you can make two sand
soldiers on a turn if you've played a
gear there. But obviously did not have
the energy to do it in this case. But
now Prismat going to see are they going
to go for that open battlefield or are
they going to try to contest? Nope. Just
going to take the seed of power there.
Go for that first point and take it from
there.
>> Got to try and keep toe in toe. The
pressure is on. Kaiser is coming in. Is
she accelerated? Yeah. Oh no. No. Just
being accelerated. Just played to the
battlefield. Yeah.
>> Yeah. in with that is hopeful.
>> These are the types of things where, you
know, if I picked up this deck and just
played it without talking or testing,
the chances I make that play are near
zero. And maybe that's a reflection of
me, but the my brain does not function
in the way that I'm thinking, oh, I want
to play this defensive Kai'Sa on a
battlefield without accelerating it and
not drawing a card. That is just
practice and knowing the matchup,
knowing the deck at such a level. And
that's what Prismaticism is doing here.
>> Prismaticism has been through every
single scenario. And you can tell this
is top level play. They know exactly
what they're doing. They know exactly
what they're doing into Pedro's deck.
And they're making this big defensive
wall on this one battlefield for
hopefully some consistent hold points.
>> Absolutely. looking to take it down
here. Wanting to protect that seed of
power. You know, you don't want Azir to
be drawing a bunch of cards. That is
really not a place you want to be. And
oh, the aggressive hold Annie deck. Is
this what is this the world that we're
living in right now? It looks like it
might just be as the fairest forerunner
comes down and is really defending that
seat of power or at least allowing the
Kaiser to potentially back out here.
>> 14 currently on that seat of power. They
want that seat. That's their seat.
>> This is where I'm sitting.
>> No one else will take it from me. My
first forunner, Kaiser and Noxus hopeful
say so. And for at least now everyone is
staying in there, making sure that we're
building that right up. No sand soldiers
are going to be able to touch that in a
while. And Prismat really just deciding
whether or not they want to move the
Kaiso. They say no, we're going to ready
the two runes there and pass it back
over to Pedro who is got a nice little
uh nice little sand soldier army down
there. Three equipment in play. A lot of
energy as well and three points to boot.
>> And here we go. We're starting the frey.
First sand soldier goes to challenge
that seat of power. Going to just trade
with the Kaiser. Obviously, the BF sword
goes back into base. We get to keep that
around. And that's a nice thing about
these sand soldiers is that they're
expendable. You can just throw them into
a situation to allow yourselves to
soften up the aggression from your
opponent.
>> Absolutely. you're able to, you know,
especially when you can cascade these
equipment, that really gets to be a
strong play. And there we go. Desert's
call. That's not one, but two more sand
soldiers coming in with Bladem if you so
choose.
>> Ring ring. Who's there? Desert's
calling.
And Prismat is trying to put them on
hold, but unfortunately not something
that they're able to do. Just allowing
those sand soldiers to come into play in
the backline and uh pick up a piece of
equipment if they so desire.
>> And adding another one into Hall of
Legends.
Just adding extras in there. Kind of
feels like they've both gone, "No, I
want this one. I want this one." are
sharing right now, which isn't really
what we do in Riftbound. We don't we
don't share the battlefield. So, uh, at
some point we're going to have to start
making some aggressive plays. Who will
be the aggressor? You naturally would
think Annie. So, we have hidden a card
there for Pedro.
>> Yeah, this is the the really funny thing
that can happen when in high level
where, you know, both players are are
trying to jockey for position. They're
trying to not overcommit and the game
really slows down for both players where
oh, I don't really want to conquer. I'm
giving my opponent enough credit here to
not uh to to have an answer. So, I'm
going to just I'm just going to set up
here. I'm going to hold. Pedro says this
is fine. I'm technically ahead on point
tempo right now. If we just keep passing
the turn, I'm going to win before you
are. So, you need to do something first.
>> Exactly. You're forcing your opponent's
hand. You've got to at some point you
there has to be more than this. You
can't just carry on with this pace of us
sharing these battlefields. But for now,
we're going to continue building that
wall. Kais is in base and booting it
back over to Pedro.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, both players really just Okay,
how much might can I get into play
without spending any power? How many
resources can I develop to have at my
disposal when the ultimate turn happens
that we need to make that that first
move?
>> There's going to be an explosive
showdown.
>> It's going to be a crazy It's almost
certainly going to be an absolutely
crazy turn when that happens because you
know both players I think see the
writing on the wall. We're going to keep
passing. No player sees a good
opportunity necessarily. Maybe I speak
too soon. When a sand soldier is going
in, that is an onguard as well.
>> Okay.
>> To try to get some material off of the
board of Prismat.
>> Is this just an attempt at softening up
that battlefield again or are we going
all the way? That's what Prismaticism is
going to be thinking about in whether
they try any tricks to keep all of their
units around or whether they just kind
of let the Azia just soften this up a
little bit with the sand soldier. But it
looks like we're considering jumping
back at that defy.
Is it worth the resources? That's the
that begs the question. Yeah, it's it's
really what is your endgame plan here?
What are you trying to do here? We do
see a flash on the side of Prismat. They
may want to get their nonForrunner units
out of the out of harm's way, trade the
first half of 4Runner for a sand
soldier, get the two mechs, go from
there. Or, you know, they may just say,
"Okay, let this happen. You know, let
Pedro take out a couple of these units
and then see what happens from there."
there. But looks like we may be
committing a card here.
>> We're 7 to 12 power currently on seat of
power.
>> The pressure is intense.
>> Yeah, I was I was the the might trackers
are amazing, but only if you look at the
right one. I was looking at the Hall of
Legends. Actually, yes. This this flash
potentially could just be getting the
could just be getting two units out and
just throwing away, not even killing a
sand soldier, which is going to cause a
conquer point up to five, which is going
to draw a card from the seed of power.
So, these are all things that are being
considered right now by Prismat. And the
implications of any one of these plays
needs to be thought of.
>> That's the problem. The damage is too
much. So actually it does then become a
problem. So we are going to go for the
flash.
Seeing if Pedra has an answer or whether
yeah we're going to bring the Nox as
hopeful.
>> Okay looks like chose to flash just the
>> We're going to on guard again just to
take out both but we will get the two
mech tokens and Pedro goes up to five
points from the conquer. Yeah, that is a
conquer. That's going to be a draw from
the seat of power. But now we do have
quite a bit of might in the backline for
Prismat here. So they're going to be
able to put forth at least somewhat of
an attack. We'll see what they're able
to do.
>> Pedro managing to poke through all of
those huge units just using a single
Sand Soldier is incredibly impressive.
Going for another Desert's Call here.
We've got so many guys on that speed
dial. Just getting another couple of
sand soldiers in on this. One in base
and one there at the seat of power.
Doesn't really want to allow
prismaticism to take that back with
ease. So at least going to present a bit
of a tussle by allowing some sand
soldiers to remain on there. Currently
at what 3 six is at nine power on there
at the moment. We're moving a gear
across. Going to bump that up even more.
Trying to keep it kind of level on both
of the battlefields here, which begs the
question kind of which one does
Prismaticism start to try to buckle
first.
>> Yeah, it's certainly going to be tough.
And one key difference here between
Draven and Annie is that Azir is able to
make these combats happen. And even if
they happen to lose a combat, lose a
sand soldier, they're at least not
feeding a card over to the Annie. But we
are of course So we are of course seeing
Prismat with only a few cards in hand
even though they've won a few combats
here. They're going to have to try to
make something happen as there is a lot
of might on the side of the Azir. Not
only is there a lot of might, there's
gear, physical units, the bodies on the
board right now are in the troves. They
truly have made a sand soldier army to
present against the aggression that an
Annie deck presents. And now
Prismaticism is in a position where
they're going to have to split their
units potentially because their deck
doesn't have a lot of versatility when
it comes to kind of being able to gank
or being able to move from battlefield
to battlefield. So we might have to chip
away at these separately. And then
there's those pesky hidden cards. And
obviously they've seen the deck list.
They probably know what's coming. But
it's also just sometimes a bit of a mind
game.
Yeah, absolutely. The thing is is that
they can be at least it could be hidden
blade. It could also be guards.
This was also a hidden card. And yes,
again, does have the exclamation mark in
the text. So, I am legally obliged to
yell it like that. It's It's just a
rule.
>> It's true. We checked while we were
backstage.
>> We checked with the legal team and they
said the police were on their way if I
didn't scream it. So, sorry folks. Has
to happen.
So, it's just about whether he can
dismantle this board. There's a lot of
thinking going on and honestly, I
respect it because this are this is
crunch time. These are the moments that
really matter and this is what sets our
players apart from everyone else. They
are just anticipating every possible
scenario. They're going through it.
They're running through the stats in
their head. They're doing the math on
this board. We have little trackers.
They don't. They got to do it in their
heads. I wouldn't I'd be looking at this
going, "Where do I even start?"
>> Right. Well, Prismat says, "I am going
to start with an Annie from the Chosen
Champ Zone and into a stacked deck.
>> Annie stubborn. She's a familiar face
and not one that we love to see to be
honest because she can be rather a big
nuisance."
>> Yeah, she's going to be able to get a
stacked deck back.
I imagine
we did we did cast the stack deck. Not
sure what was off of the top. Maybe a
cleave. Looks like it was a cleave.
>> Yeah, looks like it.
>> So, that's going to help.
>> Yeah, we've got a Rengar and a cleave.
That is threatening up to eight here.
Now, how does that change the math?
Because it's not just eight coming in at
once. It can be staggered. It can be
across multiple battlefields. It can be
across multiple combats potentially. So
really, Prismat is figuring out what is
the best way to make it as awkward as
possible for for Pedro to do these
blocks here.
>> Right, we're cleaving on our mechs and
we're going to just poke away at that
seat of power to begin with. See if
Pedro has any reaction. See if we're
going to play that hidden card. And it's
okay. It's hidden blade on their own
unit here.
>> Ooh, okay. We saw that before. We've
seen it in uh we've seen it in combat
before. We've seen it again. It's a
great utilization of being able to take
out your own unit so you can draw some
cards and that's just going to help in
these combat situations. Prismaticism
has managed to just take that board down
a tick by poking in with the mechs. And
Pedro was like, "Yep, that's kind of
what I wanted actually. I want to draw
some more cards and further my
advancement of this game that way
instead. And now Prismaticism is having
a little poke there at Hall of Legends,
which I'm imagine is going to have a bit
more push back.
>> Yeah, it might. But also, Pedro can just
say okay at this point. Mat is not
threatening to win. uh if they can cause
some favorable trades. I think Pedro
might just be fine with it even if they
uh you know are able to use a hidden
card. Yeah, Pedro says just that. Says,
"Yeah, let's just let this happen."
>> Now, Kaiser, you can go on in next.
Everyone's forming an orderly line to go
and have a look in the Hall of Legends.
>> Yep.
>> Uh
>> and there it is. Guards.
>> And there they are. Here they come.
We're going to Yep. Weapons master
equip.
>> Yes.
>> BF sword
>> indeed.
>> That is big. And it looks like I am
imagining that was just looking at the
top cards of the deck to see what they
were going to draw. But that is going to
be it. Game number one going to Pedro
with Azir.
>> Azir showing that numbers do matter.
Every single sand soldier was so
fearsome and it is because it's like a
build your own army. It really is being
able to put those building blocks
together and make the perfect scenario
from scratch.
>> Absolutely. And we see the sideboards
here. Face Breaker, another possible
card that can come in as a sideboard
option. Salvage probably not going to be
doing it. Call the week could be decent
though. Generally not great against the
deck. We're not great against decks that
have a lot of small units. Not great
against decks that have Ferris 4runner
and well Annie has both.
>> Defy maybe. Defy, I think, definitely is
an option there as of course the a lot
more combat tricks in this deck than you
would see in others. But Thermo Beam
definitely being a big one that Prismat
might want to bring in.
>> Yeah, Thermo Beam, even Factory Recall
just putting all of that extensive gear
disruption into the deck to prevent them
from being able to continue. And I think
that's it. We could have carried on with
that game, right? Or we can say, I'm
going to look at those cards. Yeah, no,
I'm losing this. I'm going to just
forfeit that side now.
I'm going to save my mental uh
arithmetic skills for in a minute. I
don't want to get worn out. I need a
little break. And then also, uh I'm
going to get that side decking all done
nicely. And it's it's an important
factor between these games doing your
side decking. And it's a skill that I
think makes a pro player shine. I find
think it's genuinely one of the most
tough skills to learn in Riftbound.
knowing not only what cards to put in
your sideboard, but also knowing how to
change those between matchups for which
matchup and how likely you are to see
those cards as well.
>> Right. It absolutely is. And again, we
talked about it. I don't know that both
of these players have they certainly I
can say with almost 100% certainty
neither of these players has tested
against this each other's decks as much
as they did for a lot of the other decks
in this event. These are both relative
underdogs in terms of tournaments uh in
terms of this tournament the deck at
least. So certainly uh not the most easy
Oh, yep. I know exactly I know exactly
what my Annie or my Azir matchup is.
It's not necessarily that. As we take a
look at the trophy, at that blade of the
Ruin King. Beautiful trophy card and
playmat there in the middle of the
stage. This is what these players are
playing for and it is absolutely
gorgeous.
>> I love the way they present that card as
well. It's not just giving you a little
card in a sleeve. It's No, this is the
champion card. That is a prestigious
trophy in and of itself,
>> right? It's just the one thing I found
with that card is that it's really hard
to shuffle into your deck. It is in the
case and I'm definitely not taking it
out. So,
>> no,
>> I don't know what I do. I have to like
call a judge or something or I you know,
I'll figure that out when I win a a
regional qualifier. I'll figure out what
to do with the trophy case and the card
I definitely want to play in my deck.
>> Definitely. Yes. You'll have to figure
that one out on the fly. But for now,
our competitors are both just inches
away from that trophy and those prizes,
but still in the fray of trying to earn
them for themselves as our crowd out
there. I see some familiar faces and we
are all so excited to be here. We've got
the bustling in the hall already.
Everyone is genuinely buzzed right now.
and excited to see who's going to take
the crown. We're in top four right now
at the regional qualifier in Le.
>> Yep, absolutely. As the players are
finishing up a side boarding here,
finalizing those sideboards. You know, I
think even if you had a game plan into
Azir as Prisma and even if you had a
game plan into Annie as Pedro, I don't
necessarily know that those notes that
you had from before this tournament
apply to this very game. That's because
I think both of these players are such
high level that you really can't
necessarily say that, oh, this is how I
thought this match up was going to play
out where both players sort of turn into
this pseudo control hold deck and I'm
just building up resources into one big
attack. I don't know if that's how the
matchup is drawn out. It happened in
that game and I imagine that both
players were on the same wavelength for
how that played out. But that may
actually be changing what they are
trying to do going into this next game.
>> I imagine both players were kind of
making mental notes throughout that game
to think about how the next one's going
to go based on their opponent's play
style. Because even if I'm prepared if
let's play say I'm playing Azir and I'm
like, "Oh, I know my Annie matchup." Do
I know my Annie matchup when it's Annie
aggro with Rengar with Rexi with you
know extra flash and cleaves? Like do I
know it? No. No I don't because that
isn't maybe something that I've prepared
prepared for this exact deck list but
also an incredible player playing that
deck list and also someone who can
remember how I played in game one adapt
and play in game two. And that's why
we've seen a lot of these games go to um
a third game is because people learn,
adapt, and then bring that into another
match. And that's exactly how these guys
grow is that they learn from every
single
>> showdown. Yeah. And I certainly uh only
have the downwell Annie matchup uh
sideboard notes ready. So I I I'd be in
I'd be completely out of sorts here. I I
practiced against the wrong Annie. I
practiced against the meme deck instead
of the real deck. But uh no, I certainly
even if you're of course testing against
the you know quote unquote default
Annie, I don't even know what you would
consider that. I mean at this point you
would consider it what Prismat is
playing right now. But that's because of
this event. Not necessarily going into
this event was everyone on a list like
this. So certainly new ground. Certainly
really a fun place to be in the world of
Riftbound in this this whole new set 2.5
meta.
>> It's a wonderful place to be. I'm I'm
enjoying my time here. I hope you are
too.
>> Our Annie and Azia match up. We had Hall
of Legends and Sea of Power for game
one. I'm curious of which battlefield
each player will pick next. cuz I don't
think they have any No, they don't have
any overlapping. So, we're not going to
see the same ones come out, but I'm not
seeing any kind of I don't think any of
the battlefields
for either of them feel bad for either
of them?
>> No, not at all. I think that, you know,
Arena's greatest and Zon Warren are
relatively similar depending on who is
going first. So I think if if Prismat is
going first, he's likely going to go
arena's greatest. So I would think that
he's likely on that for this game. And
then Trafarian War Camp is not bad for
Annie, but it's certainly a bit better
for
uh for Azir. And then Ceda Power of
course is in both their decks. So Ceda
Power is almost a completely neutral
battlefield as both players are bringing
it. But let's see. It looks like the
players have shuffled up and presented
as we are getting into game number two.
Azir, Emperor of Sands versus Annie
Darkchild. Pedro versus Prismaticism.
Looking like an interesting starting
hand there. We've got Seat of Power and
the Arena Greatest. Like I said, we're
not going to have a matching, but we did
have one from a previous round. We've
got that seat of power back again. I
wonder if we're going to be fighting
over who's sitting in that this time.
>> Yep, absolutely. So, the game is going
to start off with both players at one
point here
>> and guards.
>> Thank you. I was like, it wasn't I'm not
practiced enough, but they won't they
won't come if I ask.
>> We're eventually going to get the whole
crowd yelling guards when guards gets
played. I know that's going to happen.
>> Maybe I'll give it a go next time. We've
got a tide turner, of course.
Prismaticism just starting off that
rampage going up to two points. Nice and
early on.
Let's see if they can play anything
else. Just the Kaiser and passing. And
of course from that fantastic ability,
we are going to have two still standing
at the end regardless. Yeah, when you
play it in the in the way that Prismat
does, it just looks like the Kai'Sa only
costs two energy and you go, "How in the
world does this work?
>> That was so cheap. We'll throw it on."
And it's like, "No, no, no, no, no.
Don't worry."
>> So good.
>> We've got the on guard here going in to
try to take out that tide turner, get
that second point of the game. And now,
is this something that Prismat wants to
fight over? Not necessarily fight over,
wants to protect that tide turner, keep
that material alive.
And that's going to be a point there for
Pedro. That is another sand soldier from
the eye of our good friend Harold.
And looks like that might be a pass of
the turn.
>> Both players accelerating into two
points each already. Feels like we only
just started and already right into the
thick of it. Prismaticism making great
use of that timing. hopefully being able
to outpace Pedro this time. If Pedro
doesn't have enough time to build up
those sand soldiers, then prismaticisms
might will be overwhelming in
comparison.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And now needs to see
what do does Prismat think that Pedro
might have. It's a It's a lone sand
soldier at two, but does not want to
send the Kai'Sa into a battle. It just
wants to take a trade. And are we
setting up camp again? Is the 4ERunner
going to go and try to protect that
Kai'Sa?
We shall see. Looks like the answer is
yes.
>> We have a winner. Absolutely correct.
Ferris Ballrunner once again being just
the chunkiest unit you could ever
imagine. And even when it gets taken
down, then more little guys just spawn
up in your base and you get two three
power mech tokens, which basically if
you smash them together, it's another
Ferris 4runner.
>> Yeah, he's not chunky. He's just big big
mech. He's He's got big mechs.
>> We've got the BF sword. And guess what?
We're going to give that a sand soldier.
>> Yeah,
>> cuz you get a sand soldier and you get a
sand soldier, but only if you have a
gear. And then then more gear gets a
sand soldier.
>> Yeah, it's I get a sand soldier and I
get a sand soldier and and I get a sand.
Yeah, it's only it's only Pedro. There's
no sand soldiers for prismaticism in
this case.
>> Oh, that would be a twist. Yes, you
mentioned all of those gear on the side
of Pedro, but that is a thermo beam in
the hand of Prisba that may be coming
down on a key turn. But in this case, it
is just a development of a Kai'Sa in the
backline. A Noxis hopeful on that seat
of power. We are in this hold game. And
in this case, Prisman is actually ahead
on the point tempo here. Getting that
fourth point before Pedro does.
Pedro is now going to need to really amp
up the pace. We do we have the resources
to do so this early on. We do have a
fair few sand soldiers. We've got two
gear in play thus far, but not a lot
going on in the hand unfortunately. Wow,
that's not looking great. Couple of
discipline and and a rise. We've got
kind of spells that can help us in
combat, but nothing that can help us
make more sand soldiers other than our
uh champion uh unit and then our legend
ability.
>> Yeah, we I mean we could cash in the
Arise now just to make a bunch of units,
but again,
>> it's only two, right?
>> Yeah, it's it's not a lot. It's not
super great right now. I mean, this is a
uh a common issue with the Azir deck is
the other half of deck problem where it
really wants to draw a pretty even mix
of spells and equipment, but if you draw
all of one or the other, it really does
start to hurt. And it looks like that is
a little bit what Pedro has run into
here, run into in this case, but is
still able to develop the Azir and pass
the turn.
>> Still a very respectable turn. Lots of
units going on there. We managed to get
recruit. We got Azia. We have still
control of our battlefield. So, not
going bad, but there's a lot of might
going on on Prismat's board right now,
and it's going to start getting a little
fishy when we jump into combat.
>> Yeah. And I'm wondering if this is this
the turn that we fire off a thermo beam
to try to get rid of those equipment. I
think it there's a pretty you can have a
pretty good read that there aren't more
equipment in hand. almost certainly any
one that they would have had would have
been played last turn with a sand
soldier as well. It seems quite unlikely
that they would have opted not to play
that and and instead play the Azir. So,
I think you can get the read that there
aren't any equipment. So, if you're able
to resolve a thermmo beam here, that may
be the all the equipment that Azir has
for the rest of the game.
That could be genuinely terrifying
having that arise in hand and then
having your equipment burned away by a
thermo. Oh, that would be awful. But
again, it's knowing those tails and it's
it's whether the timing is right. Do we
get into combat? We're on five points,
so we've got to kind of keep pushing
ahead. We've got a little while to go
yet before we can call a win. So, we've
at least got a couple more turns of this
game to go. Yeah, we're certainly in the
tank here for Prismat deciding is this
time to to fire off the thermmo beam?
Should I wait until a later turn? What
happens if they arise next turn? Does it
matter? I think these are all the things
that we are talking about here as
Prismat and really seeing how many cards
are in hand. That's to figure out, you
know, what kind of combat tricks do they
have? What's the chance they have a
defy? What are the chance, you know,
wind wall? Something like that. is a
card that uh can certainly stop the
thermo beam and there are two in the
sideboard. So certainly in the range of
cards that could be in Pedro's hand. How
bad is it if a thermmo beam gets
windwalled.
This these are all the questions that
are being asked by Prismatu himself
right now.
>> You've got to you've got to take
everything into consideration because
the timing is key. We've got about well
two more turns before this could
potentially be all over before this
could be a victory for Prismat. So
really every single card needs to be
played with conviction.
Yeah, there needs to be a purpose for
all of them.
There is that Nox is hopeful. We've got
a gust which can be quite good. Better
off in combat though if you can use it
as a surprise and really just figuring
out what is the game plan. How do we
execute it and what tools do we need to
be able to execute it? We've got a lot
of might and base. We could go ahead and
challenge the other battlefield one.
There isn't a lot kind of going on. We
could potentially start to pick units
apart and then go for thermo beam when
the we kind of just have already
dismantled. Maybe Pedro won't worry
about sand soldiers being taken out
before thermo beam. So if you take out
some sand soldiers, Pedro might not
react and just be like, "Yeah, okay.
I'll save my resources. They can go cuz
I can arise them." Then thermo beam the
equipment and then oopsy daisy,
>> no sand,
>> right? No sand whatsoever. And no
followup sand either. But it's it's not
even just a matter of do I want to play
these cards this turn. It's a matter of
what order do I do them in? When do I do
them in relation to attacking? What can
I try to bait out? What am I looking to
bait out? Am I going to be able to?
These are all things that Prismat is
considering. And the consideration is
led to all three of the units in base at
the very least being picked up and
examined by Prismat.
>> Very methodical player.
>> Might stamp their way into the arena
greatest. But first up, we're going to
bring Annie in from our champion zone.
We're going to flash.
>> Oh,
flash to try to get the units at the
seed of power back into base. Are we
making a complete alpha attack right
now?
>> It might be. Honestly, we might be
trying to bring them back and just
overwhelm, take down as many units as
possible and keep Pedro on the back
foot. The way that Pedro won last game
was just being overwhelming with the
amount of units. And I guess if we can
limit that, then how's he going to
string together a similar win?
>> Right. This is another one of those
plays where like the chances that I make
the the line that Prismat made here, it
it's got to be close to 0% that I'm
making this play. So, it's either genius
or it is crazy or it certainly could be
both. And I think that we've got a
little bit of all categories here with
Prismat. And we're starting with the
Ferris 4Runner coming in and wanting to
trade off for some sand here.
>> This is one of the mechanics that I
really love about Riftbound. Combat
isn't a stage. Combat is whenever you
would like to invite one of your ready
units into a battlefield. You can have
multiple instances of showdowns instead
of a combat phase, which I really enjoy.
I think it's a really great way to do a
combat style where we're having a
showdown every single time a unit
chooses to go in there on a separate
occasion. discipline comes in to
chunkify the might on Azir's side and
make it a little bit tougher. But I
don't know if Warrunner necessarily
Yeah. was was going in with the
intention of taking them all out. It was
just so that they knew which sand
soldier was sticking around.
>> Yep. Absolutely. Wanted to keep the
equipment still on the battlefield, I
think, is the the biggest thing here.
And now we're probably looking to push
in with more units. Um the
pump spell that we've used will remain
the discipline. Uh but any damage done
kind of goes away. They just put a
plaster on and then they're ready for
the next time that units come on in to
say hey.
>> Absolutely. Now Prismat deciding do they
want to attack here? How much are they
going to attack? How many you know on
guards or disciplines are they willing
to play around here? They attack with
just two Kai'Sas a single pump spell
stops that if they attack with the Nox
is hopeful that covers a wide range and
if they attack with all of these units
that probably covers most of it if I had
to guess.
>> I would say so.
>> Are we going back to defend?
The choices are genuinely
the most difficult that I have seen
across our series so far this weekend
here in Le. It is top four. We got to be
playing to our best. Another discipline.
This sand soldier is humongous for for a
sand soldier. I should should say up to
9 to 14. So we're going to take both
Kaiser and then allow that sand soldier
to crumble. the little sand soldier that
could take out two Kais is the story of
that combat, but we do get to that sixth
point there for Prismat. Not a ton of
resources on the side of Pedro, but you
know, this is a bit scary. There's
there's nine might left in the back of
the battle or of the back of the base
here for Prismat. six left almost
stranded on that arena's greatest. So,
they are able to potentially threaten to
win next turn, but are they going to
have enough might to actually do so?
We'll have to see whether Pedro is going
to put up enough of a fight
with these remaining units to stop
Prismat from taking that win. We're now
playing not to lose. We need to make
sure that we're at least putting up some
units in that top battlefield.
>> Yep, absolutely. We see that arise. Now
we see a good amount of equipment here
on the side of Pedro. A lot of energy as
well. So they could potentially have
multiple equipments played plus an arise
and that is really going to put quite a
few sand soldiers into play. But yeah, I
think for the most part, Prismat is is
willing uh is willing to take this
sacrifice here. They are going to try to
win on the back swing. They don't
necessarily need to stop this attack
right here.
>> Whether they choose to stop this attack
could be the pivotal point. The thermo
beam comes down.
>> Oh, there it is. Of course, thermmo beam
coming out. But there is death grip
coming in going to be used in response
to keep that might onto a unit.
>> Transfer the might from one unit to
another.
>> So the might sticks around. The the gear
still goes. Those have been fizzled with
the thermmo beam. But this recruit did
have the extra now to take down the tide
turner that moved in.
>> Yeah. And absolutely massive. I mean
that happens before the arise that is in
hand. Now of course there are still more
equipment
>> on
we're going to have to play that eye cuz
we need to start rebuilding the board
now. Can't let Prisma just take the game
next turn. So we're going to need to
start rebuilding from here. We do have
two ready units. So you know we can just
sneak into both battlefields but is that
going to be enough? No,
>> not right now. It certainly isn't. But
it's going to be about can they get to
battlefields here and then also be able
to defend against the nine might on the
side of prison plus any other
shenanigans that they may have from
hand. Of course, we know there are
Rengars, there are cleaves, there are a
lot of other units as well potentially
or other combat tricks as well that can
be quite scary. We're going to draw a
card from the seat of power and go from
there.
see all of the options available to us
this turn. See what we can use to
further our cause, to protect our units
so that we're able to win on our next
turn. Both players at this point are
going to be trying to not only score
points themselves, but also stop one
another.
I'm
>> absolutely
looking to stop one another for sure. I
mean, again, it's it's it's about
getting to those even point swings, but
when your opponent has gotten there
first, you need to be able to stop your
opponent from winning. And now we are,
looks like we are spreading the love
here. Going to have a couple of
battlefields with some amount of
defenses on them. We've got the Azir on
the one. We've got two recruits, not
sand soldiers on the other. We're going
to make another sand soldier here. Where
is that one going? going to stay in the
base actually
>> and move the Herald on there. We had
brutalizer now. One of those recruits
just building this board. I like having
the sand soldier in base as well. It's
kind of showing the intent for Well, I
can't win right now, but if you manage
to deal with at least one of these
battlefields, then I'm going to need
something to go into another one at some
point.
>> Yep.
>> Going for a hidden card. Just debating
where. Okay, that's going to go on seat
of power. Putting a nice cushion on that
seat, but a dangerous one for your
opponent, I imagine.
>> Yep. The hidden card could be a few
things. Could be hidden blade. It could
actually be a face breaker from the
sideboard, or it could be, and say it
with me, everyone. Guards.
>> Uh, not really sure which one it is, but
you know, I always like to take the
opportunity to to scream a card if I
can. I got a few units in the hand of
Prismmet. I see a Noxis hopeful. I see a
Gust. I see what I believe is a hard
bargain and a traveling merchant. So
those units are not really helping win
the combat here. The Gust
>> maybe. And then the hard bargain is
potentially doing something, but it's
not necessarily that great against that
much open energy on the side of Pedro.
>> No, I think at this point when we're
Prismat, we're thinking, gosh, I wish I
could draw some more cards.
>> Absolutely. Nine might spread across
three units on the side of Prismatic.
Going to start with two mechs coming in.
And that is hidden blade on one of the
mechs. Now it is a risky proposition
>> to give Prismat two cards.
>> You got to draw some cards.
>> You got to draw cards. Ask and you shall
receive.
>> Which I guess one of the reasons you
might want to go in there is for exactly
that. It's like, well, if it is a hidden
blade and they do choose mine, then uh I
get some cards and that's pretty good.
>> Yeah. The problem is is it cost you it
cost you another mech to play that
unfortunately.
>> Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Absolutely. Gusting
back the recruit with the brutalizer.
>> Yeah, makes sense.
>> Get back there. Push, push, whoo.
>> Get out of here, please. And now looks
like Prismat is likely going to need to
>> might be saying a bit of a nope to that.
>> Yeah, looks like another death grip.
>> It's too big now.
>> It is too big. It's going to have to be
It would have to be a hard bargain
repeated here to stop it from happening.
Oh, we're going for it.
>> That's exactly what happened.
>> Hard bargain repeated is going to stop
that from happening, which means the
gust will go through.
>> It got big, it got smaller again. And
Gust is the gust was too strong. Put the
fan up to the next level. Crank it.
>> Yeah. The unfortunate thing for Brisbat
is that this is all done just to not
lose.
>> Yeah, that feels bad.
running really low on units right now.
And we know who is better at making
units fast.
And then name begins with P and ends in
O, not M.
>> Yes, it is going to be a salvage
actually cast just to draw the card. Did
not draw anything there. So Annie
conquers. We're going to fortify with
the Noxis hopeful and pass the turn and
hope that this is enough to hold the
line here for Prismat at seven points.
Pedro also at seven. They're going to
have to hold here. It's going to have to
be enough. Pedro in an absolutely
pivotal moment here needs to make the
right decision.
And it's going to have to be soon.
>> Pedro must take the arena greatest
to get that final point for victory to
head forth
from top four here at the regional
qualifier. And Leo, this is game two.
The pressure is on.
>> Yep. Here we go. We're going to start
with an ong guard. That is going to put
the
sand soldier up to three.
We equip a brutalizer.
>> That's a big soldier.
>> Yep, that will put it up to six, which
is not quite enough, but the seventh is
there with the soldier. And that is
Prismat drawing the cards. The fist bump
is extended and we have an Azir going to
the finals.
>> Pedro has powerfully pummeled their way
into the finals as we see an Azir topple
our top four.
>> Wow. Again, Azir absolutely
playing I mean and Pedro playing Azir to
the absolute maximum extent. I can say
as someone who tried to make Azir work
early on, I was not able to make it look
like that. Every time I played the deck,
I had no runes in play and no board
after a while. I traded everything off
and it ended up being inefficient. But
we see every single bit of value
extracted by Pedro able to take it down
there over a very strong player playing
a very strong and innovative deck in
Prismat with Annie. I'm honestly blown
away by both of these players and the
strategies they employed against each
other's very tricky decks. But seeing
the Azir go all the way in this
tournament has been a delight.
>> Yeah, it's been absolutely fantastic to
see a deck that has certainly not been
the top of the meta in Azir make it all
the way to the finals. certainly not
been a deck that has been on a lot of
people's minds uh going into or at least
pre-bands for sure. I think that the
loss of fight orflight has certainly
changed a ton here obviously for Azir
and it is paying off for Pedro in this
event.
>> Azir showing that you can build your own
army and make it work so beautifully.
And you're absolutely right. Sometimes
it takes the right player, the right
build, and not one of us trying to build
our silly deck and be like, "Oh
goodness, um ah yeah, I've got all
spells or I've got all units. Why is
this not working?" Well, uh I tell you
why it's not working. We're not Pedro.
>> Yeah, we are not playing it to the
absolute maximum. But uh Pedro has done
that and we're going to be able to see
more of that in a bit. But Amy, I've got
some good news for you. We have actually
got game three of the other match here
in our top four. So, let's see it. We
have got Master Yi versus Draven.
>> Let's see it. Boogie down with some of
the OGs. We've got Master Yi, Draven,
and here we go. Glorious Executioner
versus our Wuju Bladesman. Who's going
to come out on top? Yep. We are here. We
are going to actually I was kidding
here, Amy. We are actually in at the
beginning of this match. I thought we
were going into game three. We actually
get the full match. This is amazing.
>> Oh, what a treat. Here we go.
>> I lied. No, this is game three. I You
know what? I'm gonna Maybe I'll say the
wrong thing again. We are in game three
here at the beginning of game three. We
start here with that sand soldier on the
side of Master Ye. Now we've got Draven
going into their first turn here.
>> You gave me such the emotional roller
coaster there.
>> I gave it to myself, too. So, we're
we're on this roller coaster together
saying go.
>> Incredible. Mastery versus Draven.
Whoever goes through to the finals be
facing off against Azia. Both a
fantastically incredible player base.
And what a strategy you'd need to employ
against either of these to pull forth.
We've got our Trinity Force already on a
Sand Soldier. That's a great start if
you're Master Yi.
>> Yeah, definitely is. Of course, the
Trinity Force, a key card for Lucian,
but also in this Master Yi deck being
very, very good to be able to threaten
to score two points by holding. That is
one of the downsides of having to hold.
You can only score one point. Well, you
can score two points if you are uh a
Trinity Force holder. And there we have
it. There's two points scored.
>> Bing bing.
>> Up and up we go with the Trinity Force.
>> Yeah, we could hear those points being
added there. And we've got a charm
bringing that Kaiser that was just
played forward, bashing her into this
sand soldier. An unexpected twist that
Kaiser wasn't ready for. Only one Chaos
Rune standing on CTCG's side. So, we're
cleaving.
>> Yeah, Cleave comes in and that does work
because Kai'Sa is turned into the
attacker. But there we have it on guard.
Going to counter that. So, that is a
Kai'Sa and a cleave down. We even got
the Raven Bloom conservatory trigger
though did not actually get a card, but
that's okay. still gets to happen there
with the charm and the sand soldier
holding down the fort.
>> Holding on in there. We've just got a
palty porro going into our turn. We do
get the hold point. So the porro's done
his job and we're going to falling star.
Oh my gosh.
>> What more so fast?
>> Oh, what I'm like, what more could you
ask for than a falling star being used
on a sand soldier? And it's so important
we're actually using a not so fast. So
strong.
>> We need that sound soldier. Kaiser
coming in again. Pouty Porro going to
come back to base. Keep him safe with
Kaiser.
>> Yep. Keep him safe. Not only do we not
want him on the battlefield, we also
want Kaiser to be able to conquer that
battlefield. That aspirin climb that we
are ever so importantly on this game,
which means we are playing to nine,
>> which means it is odd point totals.
There's another Wait, hold on. Did we
just see this? Is are we
>> No, it's a different odd. It must be a
different turn.
>> Are you sure this is not deja vu? We
missed another Raven Bloom
>> conservatory figure, but that's okay. No
cleave this time. The Kai'Sa is down.
The sand soldier has
>> has killed
multiple epics worth of legends. Now, I
think I wonder if this is lore accurate.
Has there ever been one sand soldier
holding a Trinity Force that kills Kaisa
twice in the lore?
>> Does does that sand soldier get like a
promotion? Uh, when does he get to be
above soldier?
>> Well, it does get a promotion to getting
rebuked. So, now this sand soldier has
eaten two Kai'Sa. Has now also eaten
four runes on the side of the Draven. I
don't know if there's ever been a sand
soldier that has done as much as that
one right there.
>> That did a lot of damage. Not in
physical might, but just damage to our
opponent's res
>> and scored five points as well.
>> And scored five points.
>> Nah, he deserves a promotion.
>> I think so. I I would agree that sand
soldier did a lot of work there.
>> Draven showboat coming to show off some
stuff.
>> Show off some power.
>> Show off the might cuz it is Draven
time. And there we have the camel
himself,
>> the ruin runner.
>> You got to love him. You got to hate
him. But you love him if you're Sha.
>> You absolutely love him if you are Shawn
here. But Draven is going to be
conquering that aspirants climb. Pouty
porro wondering if they're going to stay
there. Is pouty porro worth a raven
bloom conservatory proc is the question.
Don't
>> porro gave us the answer. You're so
pouty.
>> Or we could also have a Ferris 4Erunner
there as well.
>> Oh, it's the alliteration squad over
there.
>> Potty poral. Ferris 4runner.
Ruin Runner also alliteration. Yeah,
it's it's all there.
>> Yeah. So, we're going there. Hiding a
card. It's not there.
>> It's not there. It can't hurt you.
>> I can't see it.
>> It definitely can hurt you. Yes.
>> No. Camouflage. So good. So good.
>> Absolutely. And we see the ruin runner
at five.
The other side, of course, we have eight
on both battlefields. God, I say
>> on guard coming in on the Ferris
4runner.
>> Put him up to seven.
>> That's not Ferris 4Runner, you silly
>> ruin runner. It's one of the runners.
>> It's a runner.
>> Runner.
>> Different runner.
Whether it's Ferris or Ruin, we're
running away from combat here if
possible. And it looks like it is no
longer Draven time as the fair. No, the
ruin runner. I almost said that. as the
ruin runner
>> is taking down the Draven. But actually
it is Tide Turner
>> there to swap over and save the Draven.
Saving the Draven.
>> Tie Turner here being like, "No, not the
showboat."
>> Oh, absolutely.
And as we see here, we can have the ruin
runner
>> up to six points if you're Sean. That is
a demanding position to be in. Now it is
our turn. If you're Draven, you got to
stop him. You got to try and deal with
that Ruin Runner. The only unit on the
other side of the board so far.
>> Yeah. And that's fine though. You You
really don't mind if that's the only
unit you have. If that's the one that
you have, it is massive. It is seven on
the base, but when it defends alone,
it's going to go up to nine. Plus,
there's a couple of cards in hand and a
lot of energy on the side here of Sha.
So, they are going to be in a pretty
decent position to try to defend here.
But, you know, Draven does not really
have much of a choice but to try to
contest this because they're going to be
getting two points and going up to eight
on this next turn.
>> Don't like that.
>> Not enough to win right now because of
Aspirin's climb, but still is a great
spot to be in. It's pretty scary when
that Trinity Force comes into play and
again just bolsters you into the
commanding position. Especially when
we're going to nine points, you've kind
of put your opponent on the back foot
because they can gain fewer points per
turn than you can.
>> Yeah, absolutely. When you are holding
and you only get one point, well, it's
not great when your opponent is also
holding and they get two points. That's
just that's just basic math that even I
can do.
>> One is bigger than two. Turns out that
is the case. We are moving Draven
Showboat back. Wonder if we're going to
be doing something this turn with him or
if we are waiting to set up a def or a
an attack for next turn. We shall see.
How much of an attack is it going to be?
Rexi in the backline
>> and a porro.
>> And a porro. So now we're going to go up
to eight. So technically we could be
threatening lethal here if we're able to
take that Raven Bloom Conservatory. We
have the Mastery Heat in the Chosen
Champion zone. What do we have? And is
it going to be enough or are we just
going to play defense here?
>> Up to eight points using that two is
greater than one. Trinity Force giving
us an extra hold point there. Now we
just need to take that top battlefield.
But wait a minute, there's no units in
base.
There are no units in base, but we do
have a Ruin Runner in base now. And
there's a first mate.
>> Incredible. Readying the Ruin Runner so
they can dash right in.
>> Yep, they can dash right in. That is
going to be a discipline. Going up 9 to
eight. We see one energy spent. It is a
stack deck. I don't know what we can
see.
>> There was two Ferris 4Runner. So,
they're not going to be very helpful.
>> That's going to be it. The handshake is
extended. We have Master Ye in the
finals. No Draven. That is absolutely
insane.
>> This is not the League of Draven as
Shaun strikes gold for victory with
Master Yi. Our finals will be Master Yi
versus Azir. Azir has already taken down
a Master Yi in our top eight.
>> Can they repeat that or will it be a
Master Yi victory this time round?
>> Yeah, and I mean not all Master Yis are
built the same. I know I uh talked to
both of these players in the finals.
Actually, weirdly enough, these are two
of the players that I interviewed in the
finals here, and they both had different
uh different opinions necessarily on
this matchup. So, again, this is
certainly not the finals that we were
expecting. I don't think anyone predict
I did not see a single person predict
this finals. Master Yi versus Azir. Show
me the receipts if you did. I will like
your comment at the very least uh and
say, "Great Photoshop skills, buddy." Uh
but cuz I do not believe that. But this
is absolutely spectacular. I'm so happy
that we got the chance to see this. Amy,
>> I'm so overjoyed. Not only that we got
to see this, but we got to feature that
last game there. We got to feature that
winning moment. We got to see the joy
that came from finally defeating Draven
and putting them in the top four, not
the finals of this event.
>> Yeah, Aurelia. There were three Aurelia
in this top eight.
zero in the top four. They all flopped.
No, no offense to the players. I know.
Did very well. Long day, but very much
very much. Here we can see here is the
final bracket. The road of Bedro, the
road of Sha. Here, Azir versus Master
Yi. No Aelia is here. No more Dravens.
We have got the calm legends in the
finals.
>> They're calm and collected and they have
earned their spot by battling so
tremendously throughout this event.
>> Yeah, absolutely insane top four there.
But Amy, we've got so much more here.
We've got the finals coming up, but
before that, we've got a video with
barcode
>> Domino who just won the best of set
medal cards. Congratulations. How do you
feel?
>> I feel amazing. I was waiting if I'm
going to get it or no because at the end
it came down to tiebreers and I managed
to stay on top.
>> But that's absolutely incredible to be
honest. I was walking down the alleys
and I saw you during the entire
tournament. you are in the top tables
and I was like, "Wow, he's doing that
with set." You're a true set master.
>> Yeah. I started the tournament very
well. I went 9-1 and then I said I lost
all my last three games, but hope
luckily it was enough.
>> Exactly. I mean, in the end, you still
had the medal card, which is great. What
does it mean for you to have this card
because in the end we are the best set
of the room.
>> Yeah, I mean it feels amazing. It's my
second set after Bologna.
That is absolutely insane. I mean, right
now you are literally the best set of
the world.
>> We could say that.
>> So, what's next now? Do you plan on
still playing set for the next
tournaments or do you want to put your
eyes on another champion, another
legend?
>> I'll probably play set for as long as
it's possible.
>> That is the mindset actually. Once
again, congratulations. Back to you
guys.
It's time for the finals. Loar, we are
ready. Ready for our second ever RQ
finals in Europe. And these are not the
decks. I think for a finals we would
have put money on uh to begin the
weekend, but as we've seen play
progress, I think ever so slightly
people have thought, okay, ye definitely
up there. Azia starting to to get up the
wins as well.
>> I think we have to start a uncomfortable
conversation about
>> is green the best color in the game in
the game.
>> So what you're saying is we need bands.
We need to get rid of
>> That's what I meant. I I I think I will
say though that um through a lot of
Spirit Forge uh many people were saying,
"Well, Chaos is clearly clearly the best
uh single domain." Um
>> it was the most popular color in this
event.
>> It was it was and certainly has had a
lot of impact and and that's not to say
that the bands have completely removed
Chaos from the the the the trophy uh you
know the
>> we had five that incorporated purple
color in the top eight. And that's why
it's a surprise not to have a chaos deck
in the finals.
>> Mhm. It is. But at the same time, if you
were an avid, let's say, uh, uh, viewer
of people's content or opinions for pro
players, you could see that many people
are were leaning towards either yellow
color decks, you know, or mid-range
Master E was something that was under
radar a little bit. But if you are
knower, you knew that mid-range Master E
might actually perform in the
tournament, and it did. Having two of
them in the top is actually quite
incredible. And now we're going to have
an Azir. This is a mastery final. That
is that is probably the least
I would expect from another final when
it come to this regional.
>> That's a a very fair statement when you
come to as we said number of decks
played in the room there. Both of these
were not within the top three decks
represented but definitely uh very
strong performances throughout uh the
tournament so far. But we can talk a
little bit about both players roads to
the final. Uh Pedro, the uh the top seed
coming out of Swiss uh was able to take
their road through the top eight and uh
you know side selection has been key. We
saw that first matchup for them uh
really put the pressure on. Actually
winning this exact matchup earlier,
right? It was the the Az having side
selection really punished his opponent.
So we can draw a little bit of like
parallels between those matchups that we
already seen. Like for example, what you
mentioned because he's a higher seed, he
will choose to go first in the first
game, right? And then will most likely
go if will he win the first one, loses
the second one, then he will go first
again in the first the third match. But
what we already established if you were
not watching the top eight match uh for
um for Pedro over here there are two
locations two battlefields that are just
so pivotal for uh the for the Azir
legend when they especially put it
against the Master Yi and one of them is
Trifaran War camp which will allow the
Azir to stack that battlefield and deal
an insane amount of might on that one
battlefield that the Masti will have
problem into conquering Right. And the
other one is Hall of Legends which Azir
can use to create more might essentially
by creating more tokens while the Master
Yi can like essentially only use it if
the other battlefield is going to be
forge of the fluff and that's still like
very clunky to like and almost
improbable to use actually twice in one
turn.
>> Both of those battlefields uh were
really quite oppressive in the the wins
for uh Pedro on Azir over on the other
side of the table. Um, you know, coming
into this on the master, we obviously
saw
the game where basically like turn two
was Trinity Force off um Forge of the
Fluff that his opponent had played,
which was crazy, and then playing like
double Trinity Force jumping up through
the points. So um yeah it's been quite a
battlefield dependent day in a way which
sounds really strange but you know we
were a little bit stuck in a rut of
seeing a lot of dreaming tree obes
like every single game you seeing
multiple that that sure they have impact
on the game but not quite in the way
that that we've seen asymmetrical impact
with some of these battlefields.
>> Yeah, you could say that for example the
dreaming tree in most games would have
been symmetrical because both of the
decks have spells that are targeting a
unit, right? and it can be done during
one showdown which is not something that
for example uh seed of power is a good
example. State of Power only is
triggerable when concurring and not many
decks can actually concur or like hold
and conquer the two battlefields at the
same time or it is happening in like
more pivotal moments of the game rather
than just during every turn. And while
some decks are actually capable of doing
that almost every turn like Rexi, like
Azir, typically like yellow decks,
right? So then you have those kind of
more asymmetrical effects like you said
and they can have a bigger impact on the
game which I feel like is neat as well
because it it gives um deck building a
little bit more depth as well but at the
same time it creates more uneven
situations on the board which might not
be the best for like the viewer
experience or like the chance of like
specifically the disparity between going
first and going second gets even bigger
when the battlefields have bigger effect
on the game as as well. Yeah, we are
only a few minutes away from our finals.
Of course, have to give the players a
moment or two in between rounds here.
They are the final two people in the
room playing Riftbound within the main
tournament. I I actually saw some people
still out playing Riftbound. We've got a
great audience as well in in the hall. A
couple people just jamming games.
They're like, I've got the stream on.
I'm going to jam some games. That is uh
like a good evening.
>> Exactly. The atmosphere here in the
venue has been great all weekend. And if
you haven't been able to make it to RQ
Leal, please try and join us in RQ Utre
coming up next for Europe or if you're
across the pond. Uh see you next weekend
RQ Atlanta. Sadly, I won't see you there
in person, but I know our our colleagues
over on the broadcast team there will
walk you through all of the action for
sure what is sure to be a great event.
And we'll have to see whether the meta
read is the same over in North America
as it has been here in Europe. I'm not
starting that banter. We're not going
there. I mean, we could talk about the
potential impact of this meta game for
Atlanta because I feel like
>> because of the aspect that equipment
equipment is getting so much traction,
uh, I think it could be something that
will affect the meta game.
>> Could very well. Well, there is a big
question on which deck is the best this
weekend. Let's get in to our finals.
All right, this is it. After two days of
competition, of heated battles and
clutch moments, it all comes down to
this. Two players, one stage, one title
on the line for the two players. This is
more than just a game. This is real
competition. This is legacy. This is
everything they've worked for. The first
player coming from Spain playing Azir
Pedro
and his opponent coming from Germany and
playing Mastery Se.
And for the last time of the
competition, I'm going to hand it over
to our wonderful commentators, James
Luthther. take it away.
>> Thank you so much, Barcode, for bringing
us into the finals here in Leil. That's
everything on the road to the finals out
of the way. We've got all of the
housekeeping done. The players are on
stage. They are ready to get into the
game. And so am I. I'm so ready to go.
>> Yeah, I'm actually kind of like, you
know, pacing in my chair cuz I cannot
wait to watch the match. It's going to
be, you know, maybe not going to be the
fastest because I'll be honest with you,
if I will be sitting in that chair and I
know that I have no time limit to play
the game and I'm playing for the first
place in a regional qualifier, I will be
taking my time when it comes to taking
every single decision. But of course,
>> there's not going to be a slow play. You
still have to make a reasonable decision
in time even when there's no, you know,
time limit in general. But one thing I
will tell you though, I feel like
there's a very high ceiling with the
Azir deck and it seems like the players
who are actually putting the hours and
the reps and they have the planning in
their heads like ahead of time, like two
turns ahead, three turns ahead. It the
deck completely works in a different
manner than what we typically would
expect from an Azir deck. And it's
showcasing how complex and beautiful
this can this game can be when you have
masters of the decks. and and that is
now the second tournament in a row for
Europe that we're having where it has
been a deck that requires expertise and
reps. Uh Allan on Ezreal last event over
in Bolognia showed us that you know
playing however many hundreds to
thousands of games on on Ezreal and
drilling that strategy again and again
can lead you to a win compared to here
now with Azir being the uh the deck
we're looking at with that of course has
some complexity to it but Master Yi as
well is not one to uh count out as this
is the deck list here for Pedro Azia
Emperor of the Sand hands based mainly
around equipment and generating sand
soldiers and very small units in order
to actually control the battlefields and
win. Of course, very unit light. Uh just
the chosen champion really coming into
this from the main board at least.
>> Yeah. And then we have also the Vu
Bladesman. A very classic deck coming in
from even set one when mid-range E was
also an option in addition to the Aurora
E, but now establishing it himself in
the metag game as the prime choice when
it comes to the overall deck archetype
that comes into the metag game. So we're
going to have just, you know, some
amount of units that try to conquer and
hold a battlefield after that. So kind
of similar to what um Azir wants to
achieve as well. But the stark contrast
here is that Azir has explosive turns
has really like a lot of possibilities
when it comes to the swapping the might
between units by equipping it and then
juggling the equipping the equipment
between two units going one by one into
battle but also death gripping a unit to
then transfer the same might that you
will double from the equipment on the
same unit in the same turn. So
potentially creating a really powerful
unit at the same time, you know. So
there is the difference. I also like the
um the change in game plan for Pedro
that he presented in the previous time
when he played against Master Yi. It was
one of the theories that we we talked
about where Azir typically wants to play
wide and use the sand soldiers weapon
masters to not pay for the equip cost.
But at the same time, when you play
against a master, you're going to have
to have a bigger unit. Yes,
>> that will go over the top over the
defenses and make sure that you can
utilize your equipment to the max by
stacking it on one soldier. But then you
have to pay the rune cost which will
keep you down on potential like
explosive turns with Arise as well. So
there is there is payoff and there's but
there's also the cost. So that's one of
these skills that you have to have when
you play a deck that is a little bit
more complex like Azir. And also just
wanted to point out Pedro didn't lose a
game yet,
>> a whole match. He's undefeated.
>> Undefeated in matches. Sha has only lost
the one match and tied one as well. We
are into game one of our finals. It is
Hall of Legends for Pedro. Sha will be
on Vilemore layer. Vilemore's layer. So
we are in a situation where, you know,
that does remove some of Azir's potency
of being able to move battlefield to
battlefield as we see the opening
mulligans here. Mhm. Now the the mulan
for year has a guardian angel and aas
and if I'm not mist was that also a
discipline. Let's see what air will
start with desert call to open the game.
So no equipment this time.
>> Yeah it's not quite the uh the eye of
the herald
>> but that's for war camp. That's like
that's open for trfan war camp for hall
of legends going to be important to have
an equipment next to him to trigger the
hall of legends. untap your legend and
get two sand soldiers.
>> And I feel like you got to feel okay
about this when your opponent just plays
a something to do with uh the energy
early on in turn one.
>> Mhm.
>> Again, not too versed in the master
matchup, but that definitely feels like
a card where you're like, well, I'm just
kind of making sure I'm using my
resources that I can if I haven't got a
two drop or a turn one play.
>> Correct. And now we're going to have a
brutalizer being played. We are going to
equip it to one of the scent soldiers is
in the base. So that's the weapon master
use without any power cost. Now for
mastery and let's take a look. I don't
think um we established that there are
no
>> cool the weeks in the main for Azir.
Yep.
>> So you don't have to worry about a cool
week when you have one big unit on the
board till it gets to game two and
three. And that's still a question if
even is being sideboarded in. um that
changes the patterns with how you play.
Like if you're not certain what the
opponent's deck has and we have full
knowledge of the deck list when you're
playing in the fate, it will change with
how you perceive the matchup and how you
play the matchup. You can take
completely different um completely
different ideas on how to execute a game
plan. So the move to Hall of Legends to
score the second point uh the third
point sorry I should say from Pedro and
that will be the Azir just played into
the base. I mean you always have to to
look at is that something that can be
charmed away? Is there enough
potentially if the Nav'ori scout moves
over to one battlefield? Is it enough to
uh to be able to pull that Azir away?
because we've seen the Azir be a big
finish for the uh at least the Azia
sovereign be the big finish for the Azir
deck.
>> If if you can remove that, that may very
well take out some of the potency to
close. So, right now, Sha is in a
position where he has to choose which
battlefield he wants to attack. Even if
he wants to attack, maybe he wants to
like reinforce his base and then move at
the same time when the opponent might be
a little bit lower on runes. that I feel
like that moment might pass very soon
because right now Pedro has only two
runes open which essentially gives it
like a potential death grip a discipline
so maybe an ending guard double guard is
possible but it's very unlikely because
only two
>> it is a discipline
>> so there's a discipline is now 5 to4 and
the ball is in Sha's court to decide if
he has away and he has
>> discipline against discipline and we're
hoping for a very disciplined and finals
from both players. And so far so good on
that. That is going to be uh the Novori
scout conquering. Now where do we go? I
think there was a charm in hand and
having used the discipline. This could
be an opportunity. You've burned the
remaining resources available from the
Azir. So the shields are down uh
compared to other times. Here comes the
charm. Going to remove the Azir. Very
clear move here. Moving Azia sovereign
guards comes out
>> and that is going to
>> be played in response because it can be
at reaction speed.
>> Can be a reaction speed
>> cuz it was from hidden.
>> It was the charm was targeting the Azir
though in the correct correct.
>> Yes. But Azir of course will be declared
as an attacker here.
>> Mhm.
>> So is there a way of overcoming the Nvi
because the Nvari is also going to get
plus two right. I'm just wondering it
was there any way cuz the brutalizer
would get weapon mastered onto the new
sand soldier that would come from guards
be brought with the Azir in the attack
because of the attack trigger and would
overwhelm the novori. Defy says no get
out of here with that. So that was the
line of thinking from Pedro there to try
and
>> it could have been a very good attempt
at breaking this charm but unfortunately
the defy puts a dot at that eye.
>> It does indeed. find your center being
found early on in the game just to uh
advance the economy here from Sha to
just say, "Yep, I just going to stay
high up on runes the further we go."
Again, Sha is trying to just use every
single rune that he can in this early
game to just say, "Okay, later I will
have better cards to use with my
economy."
>> Mhm. But it was a very nice attempt with
the gods play and the possible movement
with the Azir So Rain. Unfortunately,
didn't work out. It would It would be a
cool clip as well. I know the shria
shuffle would have been kind of like
really surprised you bring him with
bring the army with him. So that was a
significant moment in this game.
>> Yeah. Uh now it would actually break the
tempo completely for Sha as well if that
would happen. So not only it would
achieve the hold as well. So we it could
have been a huge swing but that's not
the case. And now Pedro needs to rebuild
his board. We have seen an arise in his
hand. So, his game plan right now is
going to be to do what he would
typically like to do anyway. So, play as
many equipment and just
>> play him out.
>> Play him out and then go with uh with
the rides. And we know that there's no
wind wall in game one because that can
only be sideboarded by Sha and No, no,
sorry. Sh doesn't even play um the wind
wall. The wind is actually in
>> Azir.
Yeah, we actually uh we have him
backwards on our deck on on our desk. Uh
so, some big power units here for Sha.
And that will be the master from the
chosen champion zone. Only one rune
available for a follow-up here if this
mastery does go aggressive. And it's a
one-way trip into Vmore Vilemore's layer
here.
>> Well, not exactly. He does have ganking.
>> Oh yeah, that is such an important part
of this card that is there. If you have
to move over to Hall of Legends, that is
absolutely not a defy. Oh my,
>> another defy.
>> Those two defies are just absolutely
backbreaking. Face breaker, more like
back breaker from Sha as the defy on two
key cards. And in the matchup earlier,
Pedro on the play was able to dictate
the pace against Master Yi. And in this
game, Sha has been able to control the
entire game around these show uh
showdowns on his own terms.
>> Yeah, it's really huge influence here on
this those defies. Those two plays were
establishing control for Pedrol, but
were completely denied. And not going to
lie, the guards play was also very cool.
But now we have to probably use the uh
uh reinforcements as soon as possible
because otherwise we're going to have a
problem with this ganking E. The reason
why the Navaris card went back to base
is because it's not needed anymore.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> You have the ganking E that is a little
bit stronger, right? And it will have
your unit in base for reinforcements as
well. that ZAS is still active as well.
Remember, uh so when this guardian angel
is played, the Arise is likely to
follow. There's a question mark in in
the way that I'm saying this cuz it's
are you going to just overwhelm the Yei
alone with one unit, which you probably
can with the brutalizer if you want to
equip that.
>> To be fair, I wouldn't be surprised if
Pedro doesn't maybe wants to slow down
the game. There was also a possibility
like he's ahead on points. he might give
his opponent like the possibility of
going to five if he just doesn't concur
and then builds up in the back and just
waits for the next turn.
>> But in this case, we are putting one of
the sand soldiers to get the points.
We're ahead on five. And now we're going
to maybe reposition the BF from the
battlefield. But it's still I think it's
still valid to keep it because five
versus four on the
>> would be nice. But the problem is that
the master actually has six. So that
would force you to interact with it
first.
>> Yeah. So Massi, do you get the BF sword
back anyway with Massi having to kill
this unit,
>> but you would have to pay the cost then?
>> Yeah, that that is fair.
>> And here we're just building a huge unit
that is going to attack into the master
Yi. This is going to be 9 to eight.
>> And Sha has nothing available, no uh no
energy available to play around that. So
this is what you said earlier about
stacking all of the equipment on one
soldier. They are now in Vmor's layer.
So depending on how this how long this
sand soldier stays around here from all
of this equipment is now stuck.
>> Well, there is one out that is death
grip that can the unit
>> transfer all of this might to someone
else and then re-equip it. So when you
think about it, we I don't think we have
the death grip in hand unfortunately.
But if you have the death grip, that's
plus seven on another sand soldier.
Reaction speed, by the way, which is
very important in in general. Not maybe
in this matchup, but overall in many
match matchups, the buff on reaction
speed actually matters a lot because it
can save you from removal as well that
is dam damage based or like play around
ghast and stuff like that. But also,
this plus five from this equipment can
be then utilized on someone else. It's
actually going to be plus seven because
brutalizer re-equipped gives you another
plus two. So, you're going to be able to
transfer essentially 12 might with one
death grip to someone else.
>> There's a white flame protector in hand
for Sha.
>> First time we actually see it being
drawn for on stream.
>> How in in the games we've cast, yeah, we
didn't actually see it. Um, and of
course, that is a big swing of might for
the turn that it is played. But is is
that enough? cuz you know as much as the
the the micro decisions perhaps went to
Sha with some cool defies and plays it
hasn't broken the tempo that Pedro has
had. You mentioned it earlier like Pedro
was ahead on points and is now at six
and we are going to eight in this game.
There is no reason to be playing longer
than that. No aspirants climb or
anything like that. So really Pedro is
representing Lethal with what is on
board. Of course, Sha will be able to at
least break the sand soldier that is on
its own at Hall of Legends. As
>> you can see how important was the Arise
to actually bring in back possibility of
attacking and being proactive in the
same turn.
>> Yeah, exactly. The follow-up turn does
have three sand soldiers even if Pedro
loses both battlefields. So, that isn't
avore scout conquering. Shan goes to
four. So, Pedro does know he has another
turn at least
>> save for a Trinity Force shenanigan
which
to stick in this match,
>> but it is in the deck. So, we've always
got to always got to keep that in mind.
>> Typically, you would like to keep that
protector in hand when you gank with the
E
>> to potentially finish a game, you know,
like but it sometimes has to be used
just as a discipline essentially in this
scenario. That is a really big
discipline.
>> There is the white flame protector
>> which is a big unit on its own. White
flame protector of course eight might.
You're paying a lot for it but it is
going to give plus eight might to
another unit the turn that it enters.
And I wonder where that eight might is
going. Surprise. It goes on the master
and master now very very big.
>> 14 to7 seems like a
pretty easy matchup for the master. Now,
how much might do we have? Oh, right.
There was a guardian angel.
>> Yeah, guardian angel. So, uh it does get
recalled back to base. We called the
sand soldier, right?
>> And all the equipment does stay on it.
That is the other point.
>> Now, let's take a look at the hand. We
Is that death grip?
>> It is a death grip. It is.
>> It is a death grip.
>> At least one. I think it might be two
actually. Yeah, it is two death grips in
hand. So, that is significant, right?
cuz you can
>> that you can quad quad triple the amount
of might essentially
>> and Sha is tapped out.
>> There's no interaction over here. Yeah.
>> So, death grip from one is going to put
all of that might onto the second and
then you can equip the brutalizer and
the BF sword and cuz you don't need
runes cuz this game could end this.
>> We need we need eight for breaking
violair. Right now this sand soldier has
plus five plus eight. Yeah, he he can do
it. How much is this? Is this is 3 five
six?
>> I'm going to let the judge add the the
mic over here.
>> It's enough. And that means wealth is
going to be transferred now with the
second death
>> just to another unit. And Shan has
nothing to do about it. Sean nods his
head knows exactly what is coming next.
And that means it is likely to be game
one. Now going over to Pedro.
>> We re-equipped the BF suit. We
re-equipped the the uh um brutalizer.
That's another plus six. And it's
attacks in its attack for million. It's
over 9,000 over here going into holes of
legend and close out closes out this
game.
>> Shan had two defies that seemed
clutched, but they weren't enough to
deny Pedro game one. And Pedro from
being our top player from Swiss. Has not
lost a series yet. Is now one game away
from being crowned a Q leal champion.
>> You can see how insane death group is.
But when you get two of that and you
essentially just
you just get so much value out of the
equipment, it's bonkers. Now, when it
comes to game two, we're going to have
reinforcements. Sha can side in the
actions. The actions can foil your plans
with like stealing a G8, which is
actually very impactful. Uh, stealing a
BF sword is also pretty huge because now
you're staring at a seven might action
that is most likely not an easy target
to kill to then reposition repos
repossess the the BF sword that was
stolen. And you've mentioned a couple of
times while we watched the Master E
games. Thonk is another thing from the
sideboard where where you're playing
games against somebody that is stacking
one big unit. Thw kind of just
>> is fight or flight at home in a way
where it just says, "Yeah, get out of
the the combat. No, you can't re-equip
everything because sure you you're not
going to lose the unit, but you can't
get those equipment on anything else to
utilize the might. And that is what our
players are playing for. This is what is
on the line, the trophy from RQ Leil,
the Blade of the Ruin King, first place
champion promo and playmat.
>> And wanted to a little bit go back to
the sideboard things that you were
mentioning. Tw is actually an
interesting card that you mentioned
because typically when you're playing
with closed closed deck list, you would
not consider maybe starting in Twunk
against an Azir against a in theory a
white deck. But you see how Pedro is
actually playing the game. how he's
swapping his game plan against the
Master here and Twank seems to be now
enticing because you know that that that
Pedro will try to create this monster
soldier and one Tonk can also negate any
value of the death grips that are going
to be used on on like a particular push.
So Tonk might be a good sided side um
card to go in action and defy is
something as well. pirate um sorry first
maid um can actually be also implemented
into this game plan because you will
need a little bit more proactiveness
with how aggressive the Azir is and you
have to be a little bit more on your
toes when it comes to just not letting
go of the battlefields.
>> Yes, thank you to everybody joining us
here in the venue. They are giving round
of applause over to our competitors or
themselves you know you deserve it too.
any of the competitors there joining us
in the hall as it is Pedro against Sha
at this point. Pedro is one game away
from being crowned RQ Leal champion. Sha
is going to have to go back to back on
these games, which uh again,
>> not easy.
>> Not easy, especially when even if you
level up the series to one-on-one, you
then have to overcome
Pedro's advantage of going first
>> on Trafarian War Cap.
>> Yeah, which is what we're expecting. We
would expect that is what we saw Pedro
do earlier in um a best of three against
the market.
>> It makes so much sense.
>> That means his second uh choice was seed
of power, right?
And that's still a another battlefield
that will benefit more the Azir player
than the master most likely.
>> Uh normally I I think we do have a
little bit of delay, but uh Pedro at
this moment has his headset off. So
not that our sideboarding is
particularly compared to them.
>> Yeah, if you've got to the the finals,
you probably are not caring about our
sideboard opinions. Um,
>> yeah, but there's a delay on on the
stage.
>> There is a delay on on the stage just
for integrity reasons, but those of you
at home that may be wondering, I think
it is worth us addressing it while it is
uh the elephant in the room on stream.
It has been a wonderful weekend though
of Rift Band. We had the bands come in a
couple weeks back uh really shake things
up. We uh were not sure exactly what to
expect, but we had a good read on the
top six decks, I think I would say, in
the meta. Some have not necessarily
lived up to the the hype, but Azia is
one of them, and Master is the other as
they find their place in the finals. I
feel like Europe, we're get starting to
get these unorthodox finals like Ezreal
in the last uh Bolognia. Now we've got
uh Yei and Azir and we're on to game two
>> and it's going to have we're going to be
having Raven Bloom Conservatory which is
a deck sorry which is a battlefield that
can benefit both of those decks because
we know that Azir doesn't have a lot of
units. It's just equipment and spells.
So potentially holding the Raven Bloom
Sanctuary can be
>> a big target. That is not what Shawn
wanted to see in the Tasty Fay folk for
the opening hand. I think
>> still can draw one more card.
>> Yes, still gets one more. I think Shawn
was looking for a a turn one play from
that mulligan. A find your center and
another card. Okay, the turn one play is
Guardian Angel. So again, utilizing just
what you can at the beginning of the
game, but it is not ideal. Death Grip,
Hidden Blade, Eye of the Herald is the
one. Ah, this is exactly what Pedro
would be looking for is an early unit
and will end up passing.
>> Yeah. And now he can control the Raven
Bloom Conservatory. And because of that,
he's going to be able to potentially
draw more cards whenever being duled by
Shaun's unit. So, this is actually quite
significant tempo loss in case of of
Sha's opening hand. And you can see it's
desperation as well a little bit because
this kind of play when action is just
being played as a two drop. Of course,
the weapon master has a slight
advantage. Yeah. But the thing is
>> um Azir Pedro over here can read two
things from a play like this. Either one
is his opponent has multiple actions in
hand and he just feels like he needs to
play some one of them to just play
something that is on curve this turn,
right? Or this hand is just so bad that
there are no absolutely no other units.
Yeah.
>> And the only thing that is going to be
there is pure interaction. that goes
that gives you informations that you can
then implement into your own game plan.
And for Petro, that is definitely
something that he's thinking about over
here.
>> So, where does Sha go from this moment?
Two disciplines. Ah, it's a lot of
combat tricks and not really enough way
of playing them. Axan's going to go into
the Raven Bloom. Raven Bloom
>> got a draw and it goes to the bottom.
>> Okay. Is that how much information does
that give over that a BF sword is
getting moved out of the way? Okay, here
comes the discipline.
>> We're buffing the sand soldier. Goes up
to four and we
>> discipline in return.
>> We have five to seven. There's one more
energy open for Pedro, but Enard is only
going to give us plus one because of the
recruit.
So, not even an option.
>> Yeah, that is the moment where it is
less effective. So, Ashan will
successfully conquer the Raven Bloom
Conservatory. Now, four up for Sha. And
uh now the question is where does that
go? First mate comes in radies up
>> doesn't ready.
>> No no yeah I that is fair.
>> Maybe in the future that would actually
matter if the unit is ready or not.
>> I believe it's a mandatory trigger but
uh that is it. If you're not choosing to
move Axan back that is fine. I I you
know these players are right in the
middle of a finals. But anyway that is
not the uh important point of this game.
So now the big question is do you ever
want to give your opponent potential
draws on this action and Raven Bloom
Conservatory or are we just taking over
the seed of power and making sure that
we are ahead on on point?
That is going to be interesting
development. I'm not sure what is
exactly in the hand apart from I feel
like one Doran shield.
There's the equip of the eye.
>> Going to take over the seat of power.
No, Kadra. You have to control the other
battlefield to um to have a draw from
the seed of power.
Yeah. And uh
there will be Azir played from the
chosen champion zone.
We're equipping the order eye. And now
we're going to have a potential charm
play because it's only one energy open,
right? So if there's a defy, that defy
will be drawn out as soon as possible.
Oh, a hidden card also being placed
already on seat of power to prevent a
potential push from the first. And
again, I wanted to reiterate um the hand
read from Pedro. Yeah. Could be really
big because he knows
>> because of the turn one play, because of
the turn two play being action, you are
most likely expecting a lot of potential
pushes with sorry, a lot of potential um
combat tricks that could affect this
decision when it comes to hiding a card
because this is a pure tempo play right
now and it's helping against a first um
punch first, first mate. And if it's a
face breaker, it will just absolutely
demolish that kind of play. Remember
though that all of those hidden cards,
so hidden blade, face breaker um can be
still defied.
>> Yes. Yeah, they can. So, here comes a
Trinity Force from Sha as uh that will
look to have that hold strategy
and see whether you can jump leapfrog
the way up from two points past Pedro
and potentially
take this game two of the series as uh
now Axan of course will need to remain
on that battlefield in order to uh uh
utilize that Trinity
correct, but it's bringing it to a very
respectable hold. Seven by default and
plus two from the passive is actually a
very very big amount of might. Now, the
thing is Pedro has the Azir Soverine
that is capable of bringing all of the
tokens if he wishes to attack the other
battle. Of course, that hidden blade,
sorry, not hidden blade, that hidden
card would have to be also played in
this case. Uh, if you choose to bring
all of the units there, but now we see
reinforcements swapping the positions of
the sand soldiers essentially and
bringing in more recruits to make the um
hold on of power a little bit bigger.
We're counting the might, so a potential
push into the Raven Moon Conservatory.
Nine on defense
for the action. And I'm not going to
lie, I'm not certain actually how much
Pedro has. It's four, six, eight. No,
that's an I. So that's seven, eight.
Eight with the recruit, nine with
another recruit being spawned. Okay. Uh
so should be able,
in fact, because of the the Master Yi
defensive uh
ability, that will mean that Axan is
holding on nine, right? Um,
>> it's kind of very interesting situation
because Pedro is ahead of points. Yeah.
>> And he's establishing his control over
seat of power. So, if we just
keep this board in check and we're just
not allowing the uh Master Yi player to
just push over the seed of power, we do
have an advantage of a Pedro's position,
but he needs to think about the
potential play from Master in the
upcoming one where he can just play the
Master from Champion zone which is ready
and then push with it as well. Now
because of the action in turn two, you
might account for like multiple uh
disciplines, multiple uh punch first and
if you have two punch first most likely
available next turn that is plus 10 if
that hidden card is not phase breaker
>> right there's so many interactions by
the way because if it's a face breaker
but if there's a defy and if there's
other interaction here like it there's
so many complex interactions over here
that you have to go through because not
only Petro needs to plan out his own
turn now he needs to set up a plan for
the followup from the master. So, he
needs to think about how those energy
points will going to be used this turn.
How this amount of energy will be
affecting the amount of energy that
Shaun will have access to in the
follow-up. And how will that affect the
amount of pumps that can be utilized as
well?
>> You're the meme with like all of the the
lines drawn on the the board of of all
the lines of information,
>> every option. Yeah, there there are so
so many options on this Azia deck and
being able to determine exactly which
one is the correct one has been key for
Pedro throughout this tournament. Of
course, has not lost a series so far.
Will go
aggressively into the battlefield. Of
course, all of those recruits do have to
be uh spawned onto the battlefield that
is attacking or you are attacking with
the
>> 14 to 9 14 to 9 which is by the way
perfectly to draw the might
>> with one punch first right so one punch
first is enough to draw but then we have
still a lot of energy from Pedro to play
a pump
>> the other option are there are two
disciplines and an on guard I think in
hand didn't see is there a punch first
at all I It might just be those three.
There is a fourth card. Oh, there is one
I think in the in the back of the hand.
>> So, we start with the discipline
potentially
>> giving a new information. Sorry, rather
hiding information from Pedro,
>> right? Saying, "Oh, I don't have a
punch. There's a hidden blade."
>> So, he wants to do that probably before
the discipline is being resolved to not
be defi potentially for a defy. Yeah, I
that would be what you would be looking
nods and says, "Yep, you can have the
discipline, have the draw, have the plus
two."
>> Small triggers, but they actually do
matter because one card less in the hand
is a smaller chance for having a defy.
>> There is first. Uh so there's a few key
things here that can be used. There is
uh salvage. Double death grip is uh
>> potentially huge as well to transfer
over that might. remember that um action
speed punch first is not something that
we can stop with like you know with like
salvages and then digging for potent
like you cannot even defy it anyway.
>> Exactly.
>> Um I'm not sure if we would see wind
wall being sided in.
>> Yeah, I was wondering about that because
that is a card that potentially could
affect cards like punch first, but it
would be in like meaningful moments at
the end of the game and not in the
midst. You're both dramping for that
right. So, you know, it feels like
economically it's bad, but maybe it's
like the last twist of the knife to get
over the line.
>> Literally, what happens with hidden
blades? Typically, you just don't care
about the card draw because it's just to
finish up the game.
>> Salvage comes out. That'll take care of
the Trinity Force.
>> Mhm. Brings down the might
to wait, it was discipline and punch.
That's seven. 11 with the status from uh
um might of action. And then we have G8.
So, that's 12. That's 14.
>> Tied at 14. We know there's an on guard
in hand for Sha. Haven't seen Pedro's
hand for for a couple of moments and we
know there has been new information put
into the hand. So Sha basically has to
commit that on guard, right? You you you
have to say, "Yeah, I'm I'm all in on
this.
>> Nothing out.
>> This is your tournament life in this
game. If you don't win this game, you
are out. It's a lonely power was the
other." And that Tasty Fay folk still in
hand. That's going to be an on guard.
Um, looks like Pedro lets it resolve.
Hit the blade directly onto the axan
says, "Yeah, you can have two cards
because I want the tournament."
>> That's so many cards that were just
completely like negated with that hidden
blade. It he does replenish the hand
with two cards, but losing the Riven
boom sanctuary uh sorry, conservatory
will potentially also give card draw to
Pedro. Although I will tell you one
thing, this is not an ideal scenario for
Pedro because the plan was different.
The plan was to destroy the GA.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And then essentially winning this
way and having a a way to clear the
action. But once he committed because of
the might differential to destroy the
Trinity Force, that plan was gone. So
definitely not ideal on what happened
here. Uh but it does cost Shan a lot
when it comes to potential tempo. punch
first was two two power, right? So, he's
setting up himself to again uh how many
runes right now? Three, six, seven.
So, now we have a hold for 12 on board.
We have seven potentially Mastery goes
to 13. And you you know that it's only
one
orange rune as well. So, you know,
there's no punch first represented for
the next turn until Sha's uh next
channel phase.
>> What a roll. That was such a complex
board state.
>> Yeah,
>> truly
>> lovely. Love, really lovely.
>> Love thinking board state.
>> And now we also have the hidden card,
which I I'll be honest with you, I can't
remember what it might be.
>> Axan's going to go in. I'm just checking
the board state before we confirm that
showdown begins.
>> And it will trigger first the Brave.
>> The Raven Bloom. Exactly. That's what
we're we're waiting on before that
happens before we know that this
completes. You can see Shan doesn't
actually complete the beginning of the
showdown. Um
doesn't actually
end up converting into a combat phase.
though this is going to be just the
first mate going over to the seed power
for now.
>> Still ahead on points from Pedro and
he's going to go most likely five.
Seeing this kind of play, it will tell
me that it's going to be a pass. And
there is the um there is ruin runner.
>> Yeah. So this is likely setting up. Is
it even do you even play the tasty fay
folk accelerated on the next turn and
just try and go over the top of this
giant board stack? Although if you're
Pedro, do you just happily go to six if
possible here? uh looking at if there
was an arise in hand I believe right so
>> there was an arise in hand and you can
break of power you can draw a card bring
everything back the question is
>> is it worth to use the heat of power in
this moment how important what is the
closing of this game condition
>> you bring everything back from the Raven
Bloom conservatory you use
>> well you leave one recruit with that
hidden card I guess to my information
and still get the trigger from Raven
Bloom Yeah. And get everything else
back.
Maybe you arise here. If you have a unit
that you can get an equipment on, uh,
like to weapon master something, take
out the first mate and then next turn go
from six to eight because the likelihood
of Shawn being able to hold both
battlefields through Pedro's next turn
is very slim.
>> Well, we also have to count how many
cars Sh has. I think it's four.
>> It's four. One of them is a tasty fo
>> and he's going to have access to how
many runes? Seven. Nine. All right. So,
nine runes is like master y and to open
or
accelerated and uh one
>> will you even need it? Would you you
will not need it if the units are coming
to base because you can just take over
control.
>> Oh, yeah. Cuz you can just play it to
the battlefield. You're exactly right.
So, it would be fa folk plus two open.
Uh you don't necessarily need to
accelerate. Again, one of the decisions.
It all it all depends on what Pedro does
first. So Pedro needs to plan out this
round uh this turn and we'll see what's
going to be the potential follow-up for
it.
>> Yeah, we are Azia games do tend to have
some uh
>> there's a small army over here
>> wide board states at this point
>> and a pass. So just chas was was a pass?
It was a pass. So we're not also
concurring conquering seed of power.
>> I can understand Pedro wanting to be
cautious in this moment,
>> but is it more pressure to say I'm at
six?
>> Mhm.
>> I am in a position to overwhelm you.
Yeah, I I very much realize that. Uh, so
it is now up to Sha to say, "Okay, how
can I again put as much presence on the
board in order to try and get myself
back in this game?"
>> Remember, there were two death grips
again.
>> Yeah, that's a key point as well. So, if
maybe that's Pedro's strategy is say, I
can absorb your best shot.
>> I can take whatever you're going to give
this turn and then I'm fully in control.
Yeah, you you might actually see a a
turn without sorry a complete game with
an unrise if there will be just turns
when he will just deploy another piece
of equipment, go for death grips, easily
break the uh easily break the the
battlefields, but at the same time
because he didn't go to six, this game
is extended.
>> Yes. So it there's probably just another
one point concur with like minimal
impact on on his runes um for the next
turn. Setting up a alpha strike for um
the turn after that when he's going to
be able Oh, there's a discipline draw
from the Raven Boom. That actually
changes a lot because now
>> we get two and it's another draw. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> And the the runes are there to play it.
So Ong Guard comes through.
Looks like it
resolves. Although I'm I'm sure Pedro
will probably want to take a moment if
that discipline is likely to be played
or not.
>> We have guards which can re-equip one of
the equipments that is in the base. What
is it in the base? I think that's a
brutalizer.
>> It has a brutalizer which is plus five.
>> This is a huge swing. Typically when you
like calculate like how much might
someone can get from a a a card is not
plus five.
>> An extra plus five is uh is a lot.
Although Sha did have that information
that there was a hidden card there, so
it was a possibility. You knew the
Brutalizer was there. If you're
accounting for that, then uh you're a a
very uh you know, fidious player at that
point of uh making sure you are doing
your due diligence on the board. What
does Shan have in hand in order to uh
pump this Ruin Runner potentially?
>> Well, the thing is above
>> what what do you do? Do you punch first?
You know, there's a discipline in hand.
>> Yeah. So you go to 12, your opponent
goes to 13. Just by default, you will
need to have another card after that.
>> Are we just assigning damage and attack
this point? Yeah, just assigning damage.
>> Oh, I I was wondering if
Yeah, at the the the showdown as well.
>> And that brutalizer still active for
this turn. So that sand soldier is uh
five might currently. You can see our
might trackers at the bottom. Thank you
to the team that are controlling that
for our broadcast this weekend.
>> It's actually working very smooth. I
have to admit
>> it's been good with these confusing
board states as well. Um, Trinity Force
played at this point,
>> but still the discipline is there,
right? The discipline is there.
>> Yeah, the discipline is there. So,
Trinity Force goes to the first mate. So
trying to build one big hold
potentially.
>> So that's five might. So goes up to
seven with the the Masi's passive.
We have deserts call setting up
potentially a base reinforcements.
Yeah. Is there any
>> for two for two? Uh yeah. is taking the
defy.
>> Doesn't find it.
>> Desert's call will resolve.
>> You can see how important was the defy
for Pedro here for his game plan. He's
like saying, "Look, if I can defy this,
this is probably game instantly on."
>> Yeah. Whereas now, this is the the thing
he holds to six. This is where the
question of was going to six on the last
turn
it to like more pressure than than Sha
could cope with. He's still in control.
Pedro is still in control of this game.
>> I I really love I have to go back to
that discipline in response this desert
code. This is really heads up play
because it also shows how he's managing
his energy because he has the arise to
death grips in hand. He knows that the
death crypts are going to be the things
that he's going to be using the most,
right? So potentially arise and two
death crys if he wants to finish that
way. That is 10 energy. So he's not
going to have a use for the discipline.
>> So use it now. get a card just
>> or potentially get the Defy and do
something else. It's really nice
planning. I really love that.
>> Yeah, now we'll see Pedro continue to
work the line out for what is the way
out. So, Death Grip will unlock the
brutalizer for this turn.
>> Mhm. Transfer three might.
>> Transfer the might. Now, you get to
re-equip if you're able to either weapon
master or just uh do it the oldfashioned
way of
>> remember that the seed of power is seven
might.
>> Yes. uh at least it will be on the the
showdown on on the defense trigger
coming through.
>> So that brutalizer is now going to pump
up that sand soldier as there was a a
brutalizer equipped by the the rune
floated.
Okay, we're going back
to the Raven Boom Conservatory. And now
we're setting up an attack which should
be for eight 83.
I was uh
>> at this point I feel like full control
of the game has gone over to Pedro.
Another unit will join from the
equipment being played. The Azir Emperor
the Sands Legend ability used to create
another sand soldier and another problem
for Sha to deal with. We are at the
winning point next turn for Pedro
>> and it's 7 to4. That is such a big gap
to close. You're going to have to set up
now for Sha from Shaun's perspective.
You're going to have to set up a
efficient enough attack to break the
hold from Pedro to deny him the win. But
not only that, then you have to set up
your own defenses in the same turn
>> against the potential arise double
conquer.
This is a very hard task ahead of Sha.
Let's see what are the options for him.
>> Yeah. What does Shawn drawn into? Didn't
quite get a glimpse, but that is a bit
of a shake of the head. It doesn't look
>> positive for Sha in the reaction. We
know there's a Tasty Fay folk there.
That's not going to be enough to dig Sha
out of this permanently uh and take us
to a game three. It does feel like Pedro
>> is on the verge
>> of becoming RQ Le champion. We don't
have full information on Sha's hand.
>> If he's going to pull it this off, this
is going to be a comeback. Like that
would I definitely remember.
>> I think that is starting to enter the
realms of cope as Sha
>> Well, let's think about it.
>> It's not done. This is where untimed
both players can go deep into the tank.
>> Yeah. If there's any potential card draw
that Sha has in his in his hand that can
also alter the decision making. So a
discipline pre-attack could also be a
thing.
Four energy split eight energy split
>> and you have to take out both
battlefields. So even justice sand
soldier at three. Tasty Fay folk comes
in acceleration
only two energy for the defense
>> which is almost nothing
>> that is looking rough right
>> that's equip on a trinity force
>> eight might potentially going into the
seed of power I would say although the
wave and boom conservator is probably
the better
>> you have to clear both so do do you have
and I mean there's four runes available
for Pedro in this situation. So, there
are a number of of abilities that can
dig Pedro out of even just a combat
where you're only exceeding by one might
or two. We know that there's disciplines
on guards. There's multiple things
available. And here we go. This is the
attack from Sha. It's going to send the
FA folk with one sand soldier leaving
two units remaining. Raven Bloom is
going to reveal a rise off the top. And
that is another nail in the coffin. Sha
knows that even if everything gets
completed this turn, even if Sha can
turn the corner for now, Pedro has
options the following turn and that has
to be it.
Pedro's thinking
5 to 10. It would have to be quite a lot
of cards now being used to actually
defend this position, but I don't think
it's even worth it. Doesn't matter.
There's a death grip.
>> A death grip. death grip on the
defending unit and it reinforces the
seed of power to reinforce the potential
hold for the win. We're getting plus two
for the other soldier going up to five
>> which means Axan and the the sand
soldier can break through. So Sha has
broken the Raven Bloom Conservatory. Two
runes available for each player. And now
for Pedro and Sha, it comes down to if
Sha goes in with both units and does not
have
equal
combat spells, it's a death grip
>> plus three on the unit.
That brings up
>> is it enough? Because Sean it would be
like discipline or yeah, punch first
would do it. If there was a discipline,
it would only even it. It's not enough
because a rise would likely be enough to
conquer and break through the tasty fay
folk with the Azia. On the next turn, we
know there's I think a Stellicorn or a
Parro in hand. That's not enough. Sha is
going to sweep his units from the board
and that means Pedro
>> is about to hold.
>> Is there anything that you can do for
two energy over here? Charmed to No,
that's
>> fist bump comes out. Perro undefeated
at RQ Leil on Azia.
Congratulations Pedro on an impressive
win through the tournament on one of the
decks that we were wondering if it's
>> would it rise to the top? Would the
Emperor of the Sands become the Emperor
of Le?
>> That is for now. A quite amazing one.
Undefeated completely
devastating like this entire tournament
and not losing a single match in this
entire round.
Very impressive run through the
tournament. A new champion of Europe has
been crowned for Pedro. Uh we will have
of course we will of course have a uh
championship crowning ceremony coming up
uh soon. We have to uh we we we can't
just end it there.
>> Winning the trophy. He's winning the
medal foil legend
>> and the playmat.
>> He's winning the playmat. He's winning
the champion uh blade of the wood king.
>> Can you imagine? You you turn up to your
Nexus Knights
and
>> you sit down and you're like, "What do
you mean? My opponent has like all of
the like the collectible items."
>> He has the trophy in his like pocket
over here.
>> Stands it. That's actually how he's
counting his uh his mat. Yeah, exactly.
of the side. Uh I mean if I could I
would but uh never that that is not
going to be the case as Pedro a force to
be reckoned with this weekend. We will
of course give Pedro his flowers as we
go through the the crowning ceremony.
But you know Sean I want to talk about a
second place finish on the master
respectable as well
>> will secure of course the best of Yei uh
metal cards. No, very respectable, very,
very well played to top, not only top
eight, but top two in one of these RQ
events means you are absolutely one of
the top tier players here in Europe.
>> Correct. Exactly. When you think about
it, you're the second place out of
almost 2,000 players competing in in in
Riftbound regional qualifier. Li, it's
an amazing achievement for everyone
who's competing here, but specifically
also for people who went into the A2,
finished top 64, finished top eight. All
those are bet like thresholds that you
go go and cross and you add to your
resume as a COD game player and it's an
incredible achievement to be in the
finals of such a huge tournament.
>> Absolutely. And an honor to be in a
finals alongside you as well.
>> Hey, we made it.
>> We Yeah, we made it. I was saying to
people earlier, 100% uh conversion rate
for for this tournament. So, I'll take
that. I told you before the the weekend,
you're you're going to make day two. You
got it. You made finals.
Congratulations.
Um, it has been a wonderful weekend. It
has really truly been uh our honor to
bring you the Rift Band action here from
RQ Leil. I mean, we've shaken up the
meta with bands. I think it is fair to
say that there is a variance to the meta
now. Even though some of the faces are
the same, the decks are quite different.
>> I would say that the top eight was wide,
surprising as well to some degree and
very enjoyable to watch. The game play
is so different as well. Like it
changed. Everything changed.
>> There's more, let's say, combat tricks
being used in general
>> and more combat in general. Like we had
a a long phase where Draven was like, I
don't really want to fight against it.
>> It's not even Draven. It's like a
reversal.
>> Yeah.
>> Like not without the reverse ro there's
no more interaction like going back and
reattacking
>> fight or flight. similar re rationale
there where you know a lot of the early
games of Spirit Forge were saying how do
we avoid combat avoid uh decks from
actually getting themselves stuck in and
scoring points and now now we have all
of those uh tasty combat phases to work
through Lothar. Uh any final words from
you on Arculio?
>> It was a pleasure to cast. It was a
pleasure to watch as well when I was not
casting and the overall atmosphere of
this event was phenomenal. It has been
our pleasure, my pleasure and
everybody's pleasure here at RQ Leil.
That's it from the casted desk. It is
time to crown our champion.
It has been an incredible journey and a
wonderful tournament, but in the end,
only one player could get crowned.
Please welcome your rebound regional
champion here, Elil Pedro.
Congratulations, Pedro. What a wonderful
game it was. It was absolutely insane,
to be honest. And I see that on your
face. Please tell us how you feel right
now. How does it feel to be crowned as a
champion?
>> I don't know. It's a feeling I I have
never had before. Yeah, it's insane to
go to undefeated now to be here. I don't
know.
>> It actually feels insane when I watch
you. You're always smiling and it makes
sense. You were undefeated all the way
with